this course will teach you to build real
world apps with react router 6. you will
Master essential react router features
such as layout and index routes nested
routes search parameters route
protection and the new remix inspired
data router apis Bob's role teaches this
course he is one of the most popular
react instructors ever and is also the
head of education at scrimba hi there
free code campers and welcome to this
interactive scrimba course where you are
going to learn how to use the react
router library to build single page
applications in react since this is a
course dedicated to a specific
third-party react package it's going to
be pretty important that you already
know react if you haven't yet learned to
react or you just need a refresher I've
got you covered I've got another free
course here on free code camp and on
scrimba that's a complete introduction
to react you can check the video
description below for a link to that
course and then when you're ready you
can come back to this course it'll still
be here for you I promise now the
special thing about this course is that
it is fully challenge based which means
you as a student are going to get your
hands on the keyboard again and again to
really practice the topics that we're
learning and if you're feeling a little
bit concerned at all about following the
challenges of this course on your local
development environment don't worry
that's why we've created an interactive
version of this course over on
scribba.com there you can solve all of
the challenges directly in your browser
without having to worry about anything
with your local environment If instead
you do want to follow all of the
challenges on your own local environment
that's great too I've got a GitHub
repository with all of the code that
you'll need in order to follow any of
the challenges that we have throughout
the course again check the video
description below in order to get links
to that GitHub repository one final
thing if you are enjoying this course I
ask that you please give it a thumbs up
here on YouTube and if you have any
feedback for me you can always reach me
on Twitter at bobserol so with all that
said let's get started
welcome to this course on react router
6. I am so excited to guide you through
one of the most popular and impactful
libraries that exists in the react
ecosystem now react router is a library
used for enabling something called
client-side routing and understanding
what client-side routing even means is
just one of the many things that we're
going to learn in this course from a
really high level we're going to be
learning about the basics of using
routes and routing we're going to learn
about how to navigate between our routes
we'll learn about layout and index
routes nested routes we'll dive pretty
deep into learning about search params
and how to filter results and we'll be
creating protected routes so that you
can allow only authenticated users to
visit certain parts of your page along
with those there's a ton more that we're
going to be learning and of course in
the typical scrimba fashion we'll be
doing tons of Hands-On practice in order
to drive the curriculum forward we're
going to be building a really cool app
called van life which is a way for
people to rent out camp Vans for their
next road trip adventure this app will
have over 10 routes we'll be able to
filter the Vans by their type we'll
learn about active nav link styling so
we can very easily tell in the user
interface where we are in the current
APP as I mentioned we'll be including
protected routes so that certain pages
will only be accessible if you're logged
in and will be hitting hard the concept
of nested routes because this app goes
multiple levels deep into nested routes
then towards the end of the course we're
going to be shifting Focus briefly to
learn about how we can migrate our fake
data into a real database using Firebase
and periodically throughout the course
we're going to update a live version of
our site by deploying it to netlify here
on the scrim I do have the final version
of the code for the app that we'll be
building so you're welcome to poke
around the app get a feel for it you of
course are also welcome to look around
the code don't let it be intimidating
because jumping into a new code base is
always a bit intimidating instead be
excited that you're going to be learning
everything you see here now this should
be really relatively self-explanatory
but the things you should know before
starting this course are of course react
I would expect before you start this
course that you have a pretty solid
foundation in react if you are feeling
Rusty or you have not yet had a chance
to really learn react this course will
not be a good starting point for that it
will assume that you already have the
basics in your tool belt so if you do
need to spend some time learning react
or just brushing up on certain topics I
have a free course here on scrimba it's
over 12 hours long it's got tons of
practice tons of projects and is
completely free you can click the
screenshot here which will take you to
that course on scrimba if you'd like my
name is Bob zerol I'm going to be the
course instructor for this entire course
the most active place you can find me
online these days is on Twitter you can
click this little Twitter icon to go to
my profile page on Twitter and without
any further delay let's jump in and
start learning about react router
version 6.
I mentioned that react router enables us
to do something called client-side
routing however that might not make a
whole lot of sense on its face if you're
not familiar with the history of
multi-page applications versus single
page applications so let's spend a
second talking about the difference
between these two in a more traditional
website you have multi-page applications
or mpas on the left side of this diagram
we have a client it's showing a computer
but more accurately the client is really
the browser in our case and on the right
side we have a server which really is
just a computer that lives off-site
usually somewhere else so when you go to
your browser and you navigate to a
website let's say mysite.com a
simplified version of what happens is a
request is made to the server that's
associated with the domain of my
site.com and it's requesting the HTML
page that is needed to display the web
page at that point the server will do
some processing it will grab the HTML
page but it also might be evaluating
some CSS or some JavaScript it could
potentially be reaching out to a
database or making API calls to other
servers in the end with the ultimate
goal of putting together a completed
home page to send back to the browser in
the form of an HTML file that HTML file
is then sent back as a response from the
server to your browser and your browser
then loads that page for you to view so
then once you're looking at that home
page you might go ahead and click on the
about page the URL for this would be my
site.com about which would then perform
another request to the server the server
again would go through similar processes
where it would be searching for the
about page to then deliver up to the
browser your browser would then replace
the old home page with the new about
page from the browser's point of view it
might look something more or less like
this not including this actual animation
when you're on the home page you can see
all of the homepage content including a
header let's say and a footer and when
you click on the about page the entirety
of that page is disk carded and replaced
with the entirety of the new page of
course it's usually not a sliding motion
like this instead it will appear more
like a Flicker and that Telltale flicker
is a good way to know that you are
currently looking at a multi-page
application so how does a single page
application differ well don't be
confused by the name single page
application it doesn't actually mean you
can only have one page on your website
but instead it means that your browser
is only loading a single web document
one time and then your app will make
incremental updates to that existing
document through different methods like
internal react State changes or fetch
requests to an API it all starts in a
very similar fashion in your browser you
navigate to mysite.com that makes a
request to the server the server will
then process a few things but this time
instead of its job being to process and
build an HTML file it's going to send
back an entire react application so that
application is sent back to the browser
it's loaded into the browser and when
new requests like going to the about
page are made oftentimes portions of
that new page are able to load directly
inside of the react app without any new
requests being made out to the server
that said the about page might still
need some extra information or data from
a server or an API and so a request
could still be made out to a server at
which point it would do its job and this
time instead of sending a new page back
because remember that view already
exists inside of the react app itself
it's likely only going to be handling
sending back something like Json data
that Json data gets sent back to your
react app which then loads into the
react app gets consumed by it and
changes whatever view you're looking at
to include the new Json data that you
just loaded from the server all that
said on the client side the real
difference that you'll see is there
won't be the same flicker of the entire
page when you're going from one page to
the next because remember we're not
reloading the entire document it's just
one document one page but the content on
that page might change in essence what
that does is it might swap out the home
page content for the about page content
because the react app was loaded on the
initial render of your website it
already knew what content the about page
was going to contain and it may or may
not have had to reach out to a server to
get some additional data in fact in our
van Life app we're going to see this
where we can transition to the about
page without any delay without any of
that flicker that happens with the
multi-page application and the about
page doesn't request any additional
resources or Json data from the server
instead it's already loaded on the
initial render of our site however when
we go to the Vans list page the
beginnings of that page will load in
sort of a skeleton UI you could say
while in the background a request is
being made to the server to ask for the
specific data about the vans that we
need to list then once that data comes
in it will update the page to display
the Vans this will make a bunch more
sense once we actually start developing
it so that's a very high level overview
of what will be happening as we're
building a single page application using
react router now it's time for us to
actually dive in and start learning the
code
hey free code campers this is a special
message just for those of you that are
taking this course on YouTube when
you're following this course on YouTube
you likely will want to complete the
challenges and write the code alongside
me in your own local environment and so
I wanted to make a quick note about
developing through this course locally
at this point in your Learning Journey I
assume you're already familiar with some
kind of editor like vs code and at least
know your way around the program in
order to create new files and open a new
project and so forth well the code for
every lesson in this course exists
inside of a GitHub repository that I
really want to encourage you to go
follow using this GitHub repository will
give you the starting code for every
single lesson in this course not only
that but it will have a really important
readme down here that will give you
specific instructions for how to set
this up on your local machine and any
gotchas that you might run into while
you're developing locally as well as any
updates to this course that you might
need to be aware of of inside of scrimba
I have the power to record new lessons
and insert them anywhere inside the
course that I want but with the course
being here on YouTube I don't have that
same capability so this GitHub
repository and the readme therein is
going to be a really important tool for
you as you work through this course to
make sure that you're getting the most
up-to-date information so even if you
don't plan to use the code from this
GitHub repo and you just are going to
start the project up completely from
scratch on your own still make sure that
you come to this GitHub repository start
it watch it bookmark it whatever you
need to do and make sure to check it
regularly in case there are any updates
that will be important to you as you
learn react router in this course the
link to this GitHub repository should be
readily available in the description
down below if for whatever reason you
get stuck developing locally while it is
a great experience to debug those local
development issues I don't want that to
become a demotivator for you and stop
you from your progress in the course so
if at any point you do feel like you're
getting stuck you are of course is
always welcome to head over to the
scrimba platform and just pick up where
you left off in the react router 6
course okay that's all I have to say
about this for now let's keep moving
forward in the course
okay we're gonna start this app from the
almost bare bones we have a very basic
react project here you can see that all
we really have is a simple hello world
there's one thing I do want to point out
and that's something that I haven't
really talked much about before and you
might have noticed it real quick over
here in the index.html you'll see that
our script tag is pointing to
index.jsx when you're working in a react
project you can specify any files that
have react components in them
specifically ones that are using the jsx
syntax as having a DOT jsx extension now
under the hood in scrimba we've made it
so that it's using Veet in order to
compile the language if you were to
download this onto your local machine
and run it and Veet expects any
components you make in the jsx syntax
are using the dot jsx file extension now
here on scrimba it's going to work just
fine if you decide to make these as dot
JS files but I did want to introduce you
to that in case you had never seen it
before so throughout this section and
this project we are going to be using
jsx files when there's a react component
involved okay let's move on to react
router setup you can see I have react
and react Dom included as dependencies I
need to include another module called
react router Dom and that's react Dash
router Dash Dom so I'll add that here
you can see the current version is 6.4.3
now for a little extra information react
router Dom 6.4 introduced a whole new
set of tools that you can use in react
router I'm planning on touching on those
new additions to 6.4 a bit later in the
course however in this section I'm only
going to be focusing on the basics that
come with version 6. we will not be
going into the data layer apis that come
with 6.4 okay let's start out with the
most basic thing in order to set our
project up as a single page application
with routing using react router we need
to import a few things and in this
screencast the only thing we're going to
be worried about is importing something
called browser router and that comes
from react router Dom
now we just learned about context
recently in this course so I think this
will be interesting to you what browser
router is doing under the hood is it is
a context provider and so in order to
give our app the power to include
routing in its functionality we need to
wrap our entire app with this browser
router so I'm going to put browser
router around the app like this we'll
hit save and nothing much should have
changed we should still get our hello
world text right there but by simply
adding browser router we now have a
whole Suite of tools that come with
react router Dom that we can use to
control our app now just in case you see
this in the wild sometimes people will
rename browser router since it's a bit
of a mouthful and so they'll import
browser router but then rename it to
something like router now we're also
going to be seeing that there is a
routes component and a route component
so I'm not going to rename it as router
because those are all very similar so
we'll just call it browser router for
now awesome this is a great start like I
mentioned there's a few other components
we're going to be importing so that's
what we'll be working on next
as we mentioned browser router is a
context provider and it provides context
to all of its children components very
similar to what we were doing in our
reusability section so browser router is
the provider we need to set up a way to
define the routes that we want in our
application we're going to start with a
really simple Home Route and an about
route and there's two components I need
to pull in in order to start setting
that up the first one is one called
routes the routes component goes as the
first child inside the browser router so
I'll set up routes here and I think to
avoid confusion I'm actually going to
stop rendering our app component so we
just have the browser router and this
empty routes element notice here it has
a separate closing tag and that's
because inside of routes will need to go
a series of new components that is just
called route now just in case you don't
know a route is just part of your url
that specifies where on your website you
are so let's say you have a website like
example.com example.com would be your
home page and oftentimes it has a
trailing slash so that route might just
be called the slash route but if you
wanted to create an about page on
example.com you would maybe have a route
called slash about and then this part of
your url is the route for your site
maybe you have a contact page that would
be slash contact or maybe you have a
Blog Page slash blog now routes can be
nested and we're going to cover nested
routes later but if you had a Blog you
might want to specify that you have
another route as part of this URL that
leads you to blog article one you
hopefully have more interesting titles
than that oftentimes blogs will use the
title of the blog as this part of the
URL although you might see sometimes
it's just an ID number where it
specifies for the database under the
hood which blog ID number it should be
looking for currently over here in the
mini browser you can see that it says
slash index.html and when we're just
serving up a single HTML file that might
be true but once we set up our routes
we're going to just see the route
portion of our mini browser it's not
going to say something like example.com
it's just going to say slash or in our
case slash about it'll also say in the
app we're building it'll be slash Vans
it'll be a Vans route and then we're
also going to have Vans slash and then
some ID number for the van okay we're
getting a little ahead of ourselves we
don't have any routes to find so now we
have a place to put our routes we need
to start using this route component to
actually Define our routes and actually
we've covered enough material I want to
get your hands on the keyboard so we're
going to have a quick challenge before
we move on
before we get too far I want to make
sure that you are practicing some of
this so you're basically starting from
scratch I've actually removed the app
component because in this case we're not
actually going to render anything to the
page yet and I've already included the
react router Dom dependency over here so
all you need to do is to render our
browser router with a routes component
inside of it so pause here and work on
this challenge
okay first things first let's make sure
we import the browser router and the
routes components from react router Dom
again the browser router is a context
provider so we are going to wrap
everything that we have Below in the
browser router and for now we're just
going to put one nested child component
in there and that's going to be the
routes component all of the rest of our
work with react router is going to
happen inside of this routes component
okay hopefully everything has made sense
so far we haven't gotten too deep yet so
when you're comfortable with what we've
done here we'll move on next to creating
our route definitions
the next component we'll talk about is
the route component which we also need
to import from react router Dom and this
is really where the meat of what you'll
be working on will happen it's within
these route components the most basic
way to use a route component is to
render it as a self-closing element here
and the route component can take a few
different props the most common of which
are the two that we're going to learn
now and that is path which is where we
specify what the path to this route
should be remember I mentioned that the
Home Route is going to be called just
slash well that's what we're talking
about here we're talking about the route
path if I wanted to create an about page
I would make this slash about or a
contact page slash contact for now let's
create a home page and secondly we need
to tell it which react element we want
to render if the path in the URL bar
matches the path that is defined here on
this route component now you'll see that
I put a set of curly braces that's
because inside the curly braces I need
to render some kind of jsx in this case
we'll say when the home page is loaded
or rather when the path is just a plain
old slash we want to render our app
component that we have up here now I
haven't quite shown you this yet but I
want you to see if you can figure out
what we need to put here I mentioned
that we need to render our app component
see if you can read between the lines
and figure out what it is that's going
to happen inside my curly braces here
this is the kind of thing that's fun
just to play around if it doesn't work
that's completely fine you're not
breaking anything that can't be undone
so notice that our mini browser is
currently at slash see if you can make
it so that when you fill in this element
and then hit save that your hello react
router H1 will show up here on the page
pause now and see if you can get that to
work
one thing you may have tried was to pass
a component as a function like this and
actually in past versions of react
router you actually could do something
very similar to that however I did
mention that we need to render the app
so I'm going to surround it with the
angle brackets like we see here okay
let's hit save
and there we go we are at the slash
route and we're rendering the app
component when we're at the slash route
out of curiosity let's see what happens
if I add a slash about here and hit
enter okay it sends us to the slash
about page but there is no slash about
path and so nothing is showing up this
seems like a great place for another
challenge
okay your task is to create an about
component just right here underneath our
app component and it can render whatever
you want I mentioned an H1 that says
about page but then I realize that's
probably pretty boring so choose
whatever you want to render there and
then you need to create a new route so
that it will render the about component
when the path is slash about I've
already put it here at slash about so
you will know that this worked when you
hit save or refresh over here and your
H1 or whatever it is you render in your
about component is rendered to the page
pause now and work on this challenge
I'm feeling a little bit boring so I'm
not going to be super creative and I'm
just going to copy my app component and
we'll put this as an about component and
we'll just say about page goes here okay
maybe we can make it a little more
interesting we'll put a little Tada
symbol there okay now down here where my
route definitions live I'm going to just
copy my route this path will be slash
about and the element will be the about
component getting rendered I'm already
at slash about let's hit save and there
we go about page goes here and if I get
rid of Slash about in the mini browser
URL bar and hit enter it sends us back
to the home page or maybe more
specifically the slash route let's clean
this up so we can see a little bit more
awesome work now you might have noticed
it's quite annoying to have to click up
into the URL bar in the mini browser and
type out slash about usually that's not
how navigating around the website's
going to work so in the next lesson
we're going to briefly cover another
component from react router Dom called
link that will help us navigate through
our routes in a much easier way
okay before moving on I actually want to
do a very quick reorganization I didn't
just want to do it behind the scenes
because I was worried that you might get
a little Jarred by me having changed the
code so quickly but right now it's I
guess a little wonky maybe it's just me
but I have this app function or app
component that's being rendered as the
home page but I have an about component
that's being rendered as the about page
I feel like I'd rather keep the names a
little bit different and then instead of
rendering the entire browser router
inside of this render method I think
what I'm going to do is treat the app
like the top level so I'll just render
app and that means I'm going to take
this entire browser router put it inside
of app and then I'll create a separate
component just called home that
represents the home page
then instead of rendering the app as the
home page will render the home component
that we just made and down here we need
to render our app and maybe let's move
this onto its own line
okay that feels a little better to me
let's move on
like I mentioned it's a bit annoying to
have to go up to our menu bar just to
change which route we're in so if I want
to go back to the home page I have to
hit slash and then if I want to go back
to the about page I have to type in
slash about we also can see that when I
do that the page is actually blinking
which means it's refreshing it's doing a
complete full page refresh it's not that
big of a deal when you only consider
about the blink but if you have any kind
of state living in your app that needs
to be passed to the about page or well
really any state at all doing that page
refresh is going to completely wipe out
any state that you were maintaining if
you really think about it a react app is
a little bit delicate when it comes to
State because if that page refresh
happens then all your state just
completely disappears unless you're
saving it in local storage or something
like that it will just completely reset
now the way to solve this problem in
HTML is to have an anchor tag the
problem with an anchor tag is when you
click it it will do another page refresh
so we need some way to navigate between
our different routes within the
ecosystem of react router Dom
Unfortunately they give us a component
to do that and it's called link so I'm
going to import the link component
capital L link and if you actually look
at your Dev tools when you render a link
it's just rendering an anchor tag but
it's intercepting the path that the
anchor is sending you to and making sure
it doesn't do that page refresh so you
can maintain your state now this isn't
the real way that you would do this but
to avoid having to put links in both the
home and about Pages I'm just going to
stick a link element right here and the
way that link works is very similar to
an anchor tag so it will have an opening
and a closing portion to it whatever you
put inside is what will be the text that
shows up on the page but instead of an
href property a link takes a two
property and this is actually kind of
nice because it reads like English this
is a link to the following route and so
I'll say equals slash to go to home
we'll duplicate that and we'll say it
goes to slash about to go to the about
route again you aren't going to usually
stick your links just inside your
browser router like this we're going to
see a more robust way to have this
navigation element that will appear on
every page later but let me hit save
it's going to be poorly styled it's just
kind of shoved together because they're
inline elements but when I click the
home button it takes me to the slash
route and when I click about it takes me
to the about route and if you look
closely you'll see that there's no page
refresh happening between the two if I
were to create some state in my app and
pass that as props to my home and about
components whatever state I created even
if I decided to change it maybe like a
counter that I had a button that said
incremented and it counted up to 10 when
I go back and forth between the about
page and the home page both of those
will still have that state of 10 as
opposed to using an anchor tag or typing
into the URL bar because that would
refresh the page and refresh my counter
State back to zero because it would take
quite a bit of code I'm not going to
bother actually showing that example
hopefully it makes sense if not that's
okay the main thing to take away is that
if you want to link from one place to
another or navigate from one place to
another inside your react app using
react router you have to use the link
element now if I want to style these
links I could either give each one of
them a class name and select that class
name in my CSS or if I need to use the
element selector then I can go into my
CSS I can say select my nav or maybe if
I had some kind of class on my nav then
I would put it there but to select the
element of the link remember it's
rendering an anchor tag so I need to
select the anchor so maybe I don't like
the underline we would say text
decoration none and there goes the
underline we are going to be revisiting
the links a little bit later in this
section but for now this is good enough
for us to more easily navigate around
our app without having to type into the
navigation bar or use these little back
buttons and lose our state in the
meantime as always feel free to play
around with everything we've learned
here and when you're ready we'll move
forward
before we move on we're going to apply
what we've learned so far by creating
the first two pages of our van life
project so your challenge is to do
exactly that I do have the react router
Dom dependency already installed in this
project so you don't have to worry about
adding the dependency but you'll see
that I have no Imports I'm not using
anything with react router yet and so
that's going to be your task as a part
of that I want to make sure that you
also include a navigation bar so that
you can at least get to the home page by
clicking this van life logo or the about
Page by clicking the about route if you
want you can add a Vans route but we're
not going to be dealing with that quite
yet as a part of that you'll notice that
both the home page and the about page
have the same navigation bar we haven't
learned sort of the official way to
handle this but I did show you one
example in a recent scrim so I wouldn't
worry too much about it if you want to
copy and paste the code you use for the
navbar on the two pages that's totally
fine if you find a way to use the same
code on both Pages that's fine too we're
going to learn learn a more official way
to handle that situation in an upcoming
lesson now this isn't something I'll say
super often but I do trust you to know
where your strengths and your weaknesses
lie if you do feel like you struggle
with CSS then I would encourage you to
actually do all of the CSS by yourself
it's not an insignificant amount that
you would be spending trying to get this
designed this way so I just wanted to
give you a heads up since I have already
designed this on the side we're not
going to be spending our time actually
thinking through and writing all the CSS
I'm just going to copy and paste what I
already have but since this isn't school
I'm not going to be giving you a grade
so if you have a weakness in CSS then
practice it exercise it actually do this
yourself you can click on either of
these screenshots which will take you to
the figment design where you can grab
all of the spacing and fonts and colors
and everything you need however if you
do feel pretty confident in CSS and you
really are just here for the react then
I totally understand if you just want to
make a Bare Bones white background black
text page that will link you between the
home and about page to practice react
router specifically and not necessarily
to practice the CSS so I'll leave it up
to you just do whichever will be best
for your own education okay that's
enough of an intro pause now and work on
this challenge
okay let's import some of the things
that we already know we are going to
need we know we need browser router
that's going to be the context provider
that will set up everything with router
we'll need the routes component and some
routes inside using the route component
the naming is a little confusing and
we're going to need the link component
and all of this will come from react
route or Dom there's a few different
ways that we can set this up let me buy
myself some space here we could either
put all of our react router stuff here
inside of app or we could put all of the
react router stuff right here in the
render I'm going to prefer that my app
act almost like a table of contents for
my react router stuff and so I'm going
to render the browser router right here
in my app we'll create our set of routes
and inside there we will have a route
we'll have two routes and these are both
going to have a path and the second one
is going to be about but we'll handle
that in a second and then it will be
rendering an element
and let's have the first one do a home
element the second one do an about
element this will be slash about and
then that is going to lead us to some
errors where we don't have a home or
about element so let's import those even
though they don't exist yet and actually
you know what I think I'm going to put
all of my pages into a folder called
pages so we'll say that I'm importing
this from dot slash Pages slash home and
about okay that means I'm going to have
to create those so we'll create a Pages
directory and I'll create a home dot j
let's see jsx because I'm going to use
jsx in this project
and we'll also create an about.jsx
okay import react from react
hopefully by now this has become kind of
second nature just being able to spin up
a quick react opponent like this
let's do our classic H1 that says home
page and then I'm just going to copy
this whole thing and put it in the about
we'll change this to say about page okay
this is good it's now displaying home
page here so let's go back to index and
I guess let's test to see if we have our
different routes so for now because I
don't have any links we'll have to type
in slash about okay we got to our about
page cool now like I mentioned in the
challenge I didn't want you to spend too
much time looking into how you would
include the navigation bar only because
there's a sort of this designated real
way to do this in react router and we
haven't learned about that yet obviously
when we have a site with a lot of
different pages it's not very
maintainable to copy and paste the
navigation bar into every one of our
Pages if that's the way you solved this
challenge of getting the navigation bar
up there that's completely okay I
specifically mentioned that that could
be something that you do but one other
thing we could do is before we start
rendering our routes I could stick the
navigate education bar right here under
my browser router above my routes so
that's what I'm going to do for now but
we'll be learning the real way to do
this very soon so let's maybe put this
all inside of a header element and
that's where we will have our navigation
and let's see to be honest I'm not sure
if the logo that is clickable and sent
you to the home page should be a part of
this nav element because it's also kind
of serving as the site logo for now I
think I'm going to just consider what's
on the right here part of the navigation
and I'll call this maybe its own link so
in the nav I'm not going to use an a tag
because that is not how we transition
from one page to the next in react
router I'm going to use a link element
but I need to import this so oh I
already did import it okay awesome this
one will lead us to the about page I
need a two prop that goes to slash about
and then as part of the header but not
part of this nav we'll say that we have
another link
this is the one that will say hashtag
van life and this is going to send us to
the home page or slash okay I'm sure
this isn't going to be pretty but let's
see if it works that takes us home that
takes us to about okay now this is kind
of what I was talking about the rest of
our efforts would really just be into
putting some content on the page and
then dealing with CSS however because
we're learning about react router I'm
not going to spend our precious time
making you watch me do CSS so I'm going
to snap my fingers
and just like that we have a project
that is designed now don't be thrown off
this is basically what we had before
just with a few changes and I'll walk
you through them so it's not so
disorienting our home page and about
page I've really just put in some CSS
classes and some content same with the
about page over here one thing you can
see is that I also added these images I
put them inside of a folder called
assets and then images so we have the
two Heroes on the two pages I have some
styles that I plan to use throughout
like this button right here I called a
link button just because it is actually
a link but I wanted it to look like a
button and there's a few places where
that exists I think over on our home
page we also have this one I think right
now this might be sending to the slash
Vans route yeah but we don't have that
yet we're going to get there soon so
feel free to poke around the CSS if
you'd like it's really just 145 lines on
top of what we already had so it's
really not too bad so the next thing
we're going to start learning about is
something called nested routes so once
you feel good about what we have here
let's move on
you know it may not look like much but
darn it it is worth sharing so let's
talk about continuous deployment using
netlify the terminology may sound
complex but I promise it's easier than
it sounds in this lesson we're going to
walk through every step that you'll need
to accomplish in order to get your
project deployed up on netlify and have
an Associated repository on GitHub but
once you go through all of these steps
as you'll see at the end of this lesson
it is dead simple to update your app and
have that change automatically deploy to
netlify so the idea behind continuous
deployment is that as you make changes
to your code you will push those changes
to GitHub which is an online place to
hold your code and when you push
something to GitHub it will
automatically deploy to netlify and
netlify being a web host makes it so
that people around the world can access
your website from their browser in the
end the idea is we will be able to have
an actual URL that you could send to a
friend family member or post in a tweet
and that person could go see the actual
site that you have built in deploy again
this will happen in three easy steps
first we're going to push our project up
to GitHub then we're going to tell
netlify which GitHub repository we want
it to deploy and it will automatically
watch for changes to that repository and
the truth is it's only two steps then
you're done now there's a few things we
need to take care of before we begin and
actually I'm going to walk us through
creating a netlify account so in reality
you just need to make sure that you have
a GitHub account and that you install
GitHub desktop there's a bunch of
different ways to use git and GitHub of
course I've found that for somebody
first learning git and GitHub it's
easiest just to use GitHub desktop if
you are already familiar with using git
then you don't have to do that at all
you can use command line git or whatever
method you feel like using so before
moving on ensure that you have a GitHub
account make sure that you have GitHub
desktop installed or you are already
familiar with how you're going to push
your code up to GitHub so for creating a
netify account you can click netlify
account here and that will take you to
the account page or you can even click
this logo here and you'll go through the
steps of setting up an account just like
you would anywhere else it'll ask for
your email and password you can hit sign
up that should send you a verification
email you'll go and you'll click that
link clicking that link will take you to
a sort of getting started page for me I
chose that this would be primarily used
as a personal account and I identified
myself as a hobby developer I don't
think it matters much what you say your
first project will be I just put a
personal portfolio site and for naming
your team because this is a completely
personal account I just put my own first
name as my team name then I hit setup
and continue we get to this page for now
I'm going to skip this step because
we're going to come back to this later
that said if you're already familiar
with Git and GitHub and you've already
pushed your code to GitHub then you can
skip the next number of slides and at
this point just say that you're going to
import an existing project for the sake
of completeness I'm going to go through
those steps and just skip this part for
now so that brings us over to GitHub
desktop I'm going to open GitHub desktop
and in the upper left I see a drop down
for adding a new repository and I'm
going to create a new repository
clicking create new repository will
bring up a modal I can give it a
repository name everything else I'm just
going to leave the same and for now I'm
going to put it on my desktop but I
would recommend organizing it somewhere
that you actually want to keep it then
click create repository that will bring
you to the main page for your repository
that you just created and next we need
to actually put some files inside of
this folder now depending on how you're
following along this next step will look
a little bit different for you I'm going
to show you how you could do it directly
from scrimba in the current scrimba
interface there's a little gear icon in
the lower right that you can click and
choose download as zip and in fact you
can do that right from the scrim here it
basically has everything that we just
saw where we left off in the last lesson
do be aware that in the future as the
scrimp interface changes the location
for this option to download the project
as a zip may change so just search
around until you can find the option to
download this project as a zip now that
will create a zip file you'll have to
unzip it which will have a folder with
your project files in it and because
we've already created a new folder that
is a git repository I've found that the
simplest thing is just to take all of
the files from the project that we just
downloaded from scrimba and drag them
over to the new folder that we just
created with GitHub desktop then you can
take that van life folder and open it in
vs code now this next step is going to
be pretty important we haven't yet run
an npm install on this project as you
can see we don't have a folder called
node modules but it's pretty imperative
that we don't commit our node modules
along with a few other things that are
really good to never commit to your
GitHub repository so I would highly
recommend at this point immediately
before doing anything else to create a
DOT get ignore file in this file each
line will contain a folder or a file or
some kind of naming structure that you
are telling Git You don't want to ever
include in any commits that you make if
that doesn't make a lot of sense that's
okay just know that it's important to
have a DOT git ignore file and to
include at least a few basic items now
if you were just following along and you
downloaded this project I did create a
DOT get ignore file already mostly so
that anybody who isn't downloading this
can actually come in here and copy the
items that I have listed here and paste
them into your dot get ignore file that
you just created I also made this a
little bit larger so it's a bit easier
to see now that we've made a change to
our project we can go over to GitHub
desktop and we will see that it is
already tracking the changes that we've
made including dragging all those new
files over and creating a new git ignore
file manually so let's go ahead and
commit these changes we can do that by
adding a summary down here in the lower
left I'm just saying adding files and
git ignore and then I can say I want to
commit these changes to the main branch
so I can click that button and after a
few seconds that will be done if you're
relatively new to git and GitHub it
might be important to note at this point
that you have only committed to your
local git repository but you have not
yet pushed anything up to your online
GitHub account so that's what this
published repository button is for we'll
go ahead and click this at this time
we'll get a modal here it should already
have a name filled out you don't
necessarily need to change anything else
unless you feel like adding a
description or making this a private
repository and you can click publish
repository and once that is done it will
send us back here to the GitHub desktop
dashboard at this point you can click
the button to view on GitHub which will
show you that your code is now live
online the stock readme that we get from
scrimpa is a little bit ugly but that's
okay for now okay now that our project
is live up on GitHub we are primed to go
back to netlify and sync up our
repository with our netlify account so
back on netlify we are greeted with this
dashboard page and we can click this
button down here that says we want to
import an existing project from git when
you click that button it will ask you to
connect your git provider in our case
we're using GitHub so I'll click the
GitHub link which will send me to an
oauth page where I can authorize netlify
to access information on my GitHub page
and when I do that I'll have the ability
to search through my entire list of
repositories I've here searched for Van
Dash life that pulled up my new van life
repository so I'll select that
repository doing that netlify will try
to figure out the best way that it can
deploy this project and it usually does
a pretty good job so for me I was able
to keep all of the stock options here
exactly the way that they were the most
important thing is that we run npm run
build as the build command and that the
publish directory is dist unless you
have gone out of your way to change the
Veet config settings for the
package.json so that this is different
so this is what popped up for me I'm
just going to keep it that way and hit
deploy site doing that sends me back to
a dashboard page for this specific site
and we can see that it says it's
building a new production build after a
pretty short wait we'll see that board
building change to published and at this
point it's just chosen a random URL
which is going to be good enough for us
for now that we can click on and see our
site live on the web super cool now oops
it does look like we have a little bit
of an issue here on scrimba of course we
pretty much develop everything as a
mobile style but even when I turn on the
mobile view in my developer tools we can
see that the styles are not really
looking like a mobile styled site to be
honest this is something I almost always
forget to include when I'm spinning up a
new project completely from scratch and
that is to include this line of code
which is a viewport meta tag so the
reason I'm showing you this process is
not because I actually forgot to do this
but because because I want to show you
how once you have deployed your site
live you can make changes and update the
live version really really easily this
is where the benefits of having
continuous deployment setup really shine
now if you are actually following along
and you want to add this line of code
you can actually click this screenshot
it will take you to a page on mdn which
has a quick way to copy this line of
code and you can paste it into your
index.html page right below the start of
the head tag like I did here now once I
paste this in we can go back to GitHub
desktop and see that it is tracking some
changes here I think my formatter might
have changed the way that things were
lining up which is why it's showing a
little bit more green than what we
actually added and just like before I
can add a little summary up here if I
want I can also add a description and
hit commit to main again this is only
committing to my local repository and
doesn't automatically make changes to my
GitHub repository in order to do that I
do need to remember to push these
changes this commit up to my origin
which is the Repository that lives on
GitHub and from GitHub desktop I can do
that by just clicking push origin then
without doing anything else I can go
over to netlify and see that it has
noticed a new commit to my main branch
on my GitHub repository and so it starts
rebuilding my site and after a few
seconds again it will have a new
published site that includes my changes
awesome so again the process for
updating the deployed site in just three
easy steps one we change our code to we
commit and push those changes to GitHub
again it's just two steps that's how
simple it is now that you have a live
site that you could share with family
and friends I'd recommend jumping in
both feet with the build in public
mentality if you have a Twitter account
you can click this screenshot which will
pre-populate a tweet that you could send
out to the world and really show off the
work that you're doing on your projects
of course make sure to add your actual
Netflix link here at the bottom one last
important thing to mention is that even
though you've downloaded your code code
to your local machine and push it up to
GitHub it will still be pretty important
for you to follow here on scrimba
scrimba isn't intended to be the
ultimate place that your code lives
you're not going to open scrimba in
order to write production level code for
example but for the sake of learning
scrimbab makes a lot of other things
easier it lowers the barrier to get your
hands on the keyboard and follow along
so in the future when we talk about
deployment again we'll cover the steps
on how to update the code that you just
downloaded to your local machine so that
you can deploy the most updated stuff
but for the best learning experience
just remember to keep following the
course here on scrimba okay that's
everything we have to touch on right now
for continuous deployment using
netlifice so let's keep pushing forward
and building our van Life app
in these upcoming sections we are going
to be working on a Vans list page and a
van detail page and as you can see
there's some data here that needs to be
coming from somewhere in the past what
I've done is created just a simple
data.js file and kind of pushed all the
data in there but that meant that we
were just importing that file instead of
actually doing a fetch request to a
server and a database like you would in
the real world however I also didn't
want to create a real server and
database just because of the maintenance
problems that can happen Over time
however I found a solution that I think
will be a really good compromise and
we're going to try it out in this
project there's an npm package called
mirage.js you can click on the
screenshot here to go to their website
if you want to learn more about it and
it's a way to create a mock server that
will intercept any API requests you make
and it will return the data from your
mock server instead of having to worry
about reaching out to the real world
this isn't something you have to worry
about but if you want to look in this
server.js file that I I created you can
see there's the data for our vans and
down here at the bottom there's a simple
routes section which you can think of
like the server code that will run
whenever you make a request to slash
fans or to slash Vans slash the ID
number of the van again this doesn't
have to make sense in fact you can think
of it more like you are the front-end
developer on this project and a back-end
developer one of your co-workers has
already created the server and some
endpoints for you to get data from
what's nice about this is I don't have
to pollute my code too much the only
thing I need to do is say import server
so import dot slash server and
everything else will work out just fine
we'll get to see this in action in a
little bit but I just wanted to show you
what I'm doing there with server.js so
that didn't become confusing okay that
sets us up perfectly to Now work on our
vans page so that's what we'll do next
okay the next thing we're going to do is
create the Vans list page and this won't
really require you to do anything that
you haven't learned yet so I'm going to
make this into a two-part challenge the
first part is going to help you practice
creating a new route modifying the
header creating a new page and the
second part is going to require you to
use a fetch request to get some data and
use a map method to map over the data
all of this is kind of the introductory
level react stuff that you should
already know by now but let's not get
too far ahead of ourselves let's start
with part one again your challenge is to
create the Vans list page that's going
to be over in the Pages directory the
route which is what will happen down
here and a link in the header so that
you can actually navigate to it now even
though this is something that you have
done recently I really want you to
practice this before just skipping ahead
and watching me do it however if you get
stuck of course we will be going over
this together so pause now and work on
this challenge
let's start by creating the page so I'll
create a new file called vans.jsx and
we'll just do some of the regular setup
stuff
nothing fancy quite yet we're going to
get to that in the next challenge then
over here we need to import the Vans
page
we'll create a new route so I'll just
duplicate this line and change this to
Vans and this will render the Vans
element
and then we will link to vans so this
will lead to slash fans bands and I
think that should be it let's hit save
okay we have our vans here and if we
click it man's page goes here awesome
now comes the fun part in the next
challenge we are going to actually pull
in our data so that we can display the
actual Vans and the van information
however before plowing ahead if you did
struggle with this challenge then just
revert back to the beginning of this
video and try it again if you're
confused about these parts then it will
be more important that you kind of drill
them in before you just pow ahead okay
getting off my soapbox let's work on
part two of The Challenge
okay this is the fun part of the
challenge this Vans page goes here is
nice and all but we want to get the
actual van showing up on the page as per
usual you can click the design
screenshots here to send you to the
figma design in case you feel like
spending the time to actually put the
CSS together yourself but like I did
before I'm not going to necessarily make
you do that I'm just going to do a magic
snap of my fingers and we'll have the
design already implemented for us so
your challenge is written out here
you're going to use the fetch API from
the web and you're going to fetch API
slash Vans let me put some quotes here
just to make sure that that's clear that
that's a string you're going to use the
fetch API and you're going to fetch to
slash API slash fans this might look a
little strange if you're used to only
doing your fetch requests to another
server or another URL somewhere because
usually you have something like https
colon slash example.com API slash fans
but when you're fetching something on
the same domain as what your site is
running on then usually you only have to
provide the relative path now remember
we have our kind of fake server running
here with mirage.js and you can see it
says this dot namespace is API that
means that all the requests are going to
start with Slash API and then this
function here is going to handle a get
request to the slash API slash Vans
endpoint and all it does is return all
the Vans again you don't need to
understand this this is not an important
part for this course but sometimes it's
nice to poke around and see an inside
look and hopefully that helps make sense
of why this URL or what it doesn't
really look like URL but why this URL
looks a little unique so you'll kick off
that request you'll need to parse that
Json and turn it into Data you need to
think about what react hook you would
want to use to fetch the data as soon as
the page loads and how you would make it
so that it only fetches it the one time
and actually you know what number three
is no longer an issue so I'm just going
to get rid of that now parts of this
challenge are going to require you to
have prior knowledge in things like how
to use the fetch API and where in react
you can kick off a request when the
component mounts if you're feeling a
little rusty on that that's completely
okay I've tried to include a couple
helpful resources here this is a link to
the fetching data in react scrim that I
taught in my introductory course and the
second one is how to take an array and
to map over it using the dot map method
and then how to actually display each of
those as elements on the page so feel
free to check out those resources brush
up on some of those topics before trying
to start this challenge here okay I
think I've given you everything you need
again if you don't necessarily feel like
doing the CSS to make it all beautiful
I'm actually okay with that this time
just try to get each of the pieces of
data displayed and if CSS is something
that you feel Rusty on or you want a
little more practice with then I would
encourage you to do it okay enough of me
talking pause now and work on this
challenge
I think I'm actually going to do these
in backwards order I'm going to start
with number two and the answer to this
question is to use the use effect hook
in react now the truth is and this is
something we're going to explore later
on down the road or possibly in a
different course there's a bit of a
movement away from trying to do your
fetch requests for the data of a
component in a use effect hook but for
now let's go ahead and use a react.use
effect this takes two parameters the
first one is a function and the second
parameter is an array of dependencies in
this case we have no dependencies but
it's important that I put this array
here otherwise our effect will run every
single time any State updates on our
page at all inside the body of our
function we will kick off our fetch
request so I'm going to say fetch slash
API Vans and again what our server is
going to do this fake server it's going
to intercept this fetch request instead
of trying to actually make a fetch
request out to some endpoint probably
here on scrima.com it's going to
intercept it and give back fake data
this fetch function it returns a promise
and so I'm going to unpack that promise
which will come with a response and
we'll turn that into a JavaScript object
or just regular JavaScript by taking the
Json part out of it that returns a
promise so we will resolve that promise
as well and that is where we will
finally have access to our data I
usually just like to console log our
data for one just to make sure things
are working we haven't made any mistakes
along the way but also to see the
structure of the data so we know what
it's going to look like how we're going
to access all the pieces of it so let's
hit save and okay well we got something
console logging looks like it's an
object with a Vans property now in this
case because we're choosing to kick off
our request inside of a use effect and
we're only kicking that request off one
time when the component first mounts we
need a place to save the data that we're
pulling in just so that if anything were
to change and this component got
re-rendered the data wouldn't just
disappear and you might remember that
state is a place where data can survive
the re-render cycle of a component so
we're going to create some State let's
call it maybe Vans and set Vans is
react.use State I'll start this as an
empty array and then instead of console
logging our data we will use set Vans
and we don't really care what it used to
be so I don't need the Callback function
I'm just going to set it to data and
then remember there's a property called
dot Vans that's the one that actually
has the array that we want so if I
console log Vans we'll hit save and
first we get an empty array that happens
when the state is set as an empty rate
in the beginning and then it turns into
our array of Van information from our
fake server awesome actually you know
what while we have this still console
logging I'm going to grab one of the
objects of our vans just so we know what
properties it has let me get rid of our
challenge text instead I'm going to put
in the properties of our van okay so our
van has an ID a name a price a
description an image URL and a type so
I'm going to turn our array of raw data
into an array of elements that we can
display on the Page by using the map
methods so maybe I'll call this van
elements is equal to vans.map and for
each van we are going to render and you
know what this is where normally we
would just start creating one van
element that we want to show on the page
so one of these little sections here for
the sake of time I'm going to paste in
what I've already created since it won't
provide a whole lot to this lesson or
challenge to have you watch me go
through each little piece like that okay
so what you can see is just a div that
has the elements that we see in the tile
of one of these Vans and since we're
doing a map it will end up being a tile
for each one of the the vans in our
database and there's a couple class
names that are not here yet let's
actually put van elements onto our page
first and then we will fix the CSS so
instead of our H1 that says Vans page
goes here we'll have in fact let's use a
fragment just because we don't need to
necessarily add a bunch of more elements
and we will just put our van elements
here and let's see where we end up okay
well that's a huge picture but we've got
our picture and it's got the name of the
van the price and this is the style or
rather the type I think is what it was
called yeah type is simple and okay we
have our vans awesome let me go ahead
and just use the magic of editing to
make this look a little nicer
and just like that our CSS is applied I
had forgotten that we wanted a list
container and then we have our list
itself just for styling purposes so I
got rid of our fragment and actually put
in a div so that it could have a class
name and actually we're missing
something from the well we're missing a
few things from the design but one
that's really easy right now is this
looks like maybe an H1 that says explore
our van options so I'm gonna stuff that
just right inside of our tile here we'll
have our H1 that says explore our van
options to hit save okay cool a little
step closer we still have some other
work to do like these buttons the footer
and so forth but we'll get to that okay
man that was a lot of work but hopefully
this is mostly just review from previous
lessons that you have learned about
react but this does lead us to what
we're going to learn next and that has
to do with nested routes because what I
want to have happen is I want each one
of these tiles to be clickable basically
anywhere on this tile and I want
clicking each one of these tiles to take
me to a nested route so it will be slash
Vans slash and in our case we're going
to keep it simple and just use the ID of
the van so slash one will send us to a
detail page of this modest Explorer man
because that's the one with the idea of
one slash two would take us to a detail
page of the beach bum van and so forth
there's a couple fun considerations to
keep in mind when we're going to do that
so that is what we're going to tackle
next
everything we've learned so far about
react router you could say is like the
meat of react router what with the
browser router the routes these
individual routes that we have and the
link that allows you to navigate between
one and the other everything else that
we'll learn is sort of the I guess you
could call it the vegetables of this
plate they're really going to round out
our experience and they're going to
allow us to do some pretty cool things
with react router we'll spend the next
couple lessons learning about nested
routes but to do that we're going to
first see maybe the harder way to do
this so in order for us to understand
nested routes we're first going to learn
about parameters or route params now we
know that we have our van list page here
and the list page is showing us all of
our vans we want to be able to click on
one of them and be navigated to a detail
page for the specific van that we
clicked on you can see in the design
here we have the list page clicking on
one of them sends us to the detail page
and in our case we decided we want this
detail page to have a route of Slash
Vans slash Flash and then the ID number
of the van but we don't want to go
through and create a new route for every
one of the vans in our data and have
something like slash Vans slash and then
slash one slash two slash three slash
four we wouldn't want to manually create
that because well it's just not
maintainable if we were to add more Vans
to our list then we wouldn't also want
to have to come in here and create new
routes create separate elements and so
forth so this is where route params come
in when we're defining our routes let me
get rid of all these extra ones when
we're defining our routes I'm going to
copy this one just as a starting point
and then instead of saying slash Vans
slash and then a specific dedicated ID
number or some other kind of text we're
going to use a colon and then we're
going to give it sort of a variable name
in this case let's call it ID we get to
choose whatever we want but let's call
it ID because we will put the ID of the
van in this spot because the colon sort
of turns this into a variable it means
that we can reuse this one route
definition for every detail page that we
want to create no matter what the ID is
going to be now we need to change Vans
because this right now is just leading
us to the same Vans list page so instead
we're going to create a van detail page
so I'll Whip that together really fast
we'll go to Pages create a new file call
it van
detail.jsx and I'll just set this up
really quick
okay like we did before just an H1 that
says the van detail page goes here we
will go back to our index page import it
and instead of rendering the Vans here
we will render band detail and we don't
have a link yet to send us there so let
me hit refresh and I'll just start by
typing in in the URL slash one and hit
enter and cool that sent us to the van
detail page now we'll notice that this
doesn't say anything about one it just
says colon ID so I could change this to
slash 42 even though we don't really
have a van with an idea 42 I could
change this to whatever I want and hit
enter and it really doesn't care the
colon is just saying there's going to be
something here I don't know what it is
but it's going to be something so
there's two more things that we need to
hook together in order for this to work
the first is from my Vans page I want to
have each of these Vans send the user
when it gets clicked to slash Vans slash
and then the ID of that specific van and
then in the van detail page we want some
way that we can access the ID that is in
the URL after slash vans in that way
from the van detail page we can grab
whatever the ID is from the URL make a
get request to our server to grab the
detailed information for that one
specific van and then go through the
process of displaying the detailed
information for that one specific van
like you see here really I think the
only information missing from the list
page is this description down here but
still for now what we'll do is whole
extra get request to get the detailed
information for this van so for the sake
of breaking this up a little bit let's
tackle those two different parts in
separate scrims so that's what we'll
start with next
the first part of this involves a
challenge that you should already be
able to complete without learning
anything new each one of our vans is
listed in what we're calling a van tile
here on this div and we want to make it
so that if the user clicks anywhere at
all within the contents of this div that
they'll be sent to the Vans slash and
then the ID of the van so your challenge
is to wrap all of the contents of this
div in a link from react router Dom and
have it send the user to that page
you'll know that you've completed it
when it sends them to that then detail
page goes here page so pause now and
work on this challenge
okay first we need to import link from
react router Dom
and then we will just wrap everything in
a link
we'll indent that and then the last
thing is we need to send them to and I'm
going to use string interpolation here
so I can say slash bands slash and then
because we're inside of the loop where
we're mapping over the Vans we have
access to each individual van and we'll
say van dot ID okay let's hit save let's
click on reliable red and of course it
really doesn't matter but we can see in
the URL in the mini browser that it sent
us to slash Vans slash three because
reliable red had an ID of three we can
go back to Beach Bum which should be two
and there it is now of course this van
detail page is not very descriptive it's
not really doing anything important next
we need to make it so that the detail
page can grab information about that
specific van that they clicked on so we
can display everything we need to
display here to do that we need to learn
about something called use params so
that's what we'll learn next
let's take a second to look back at what
we've done just as a reminder before we
move on in our app component where we
have our route definitions we created a
route that has a parameter as part of
its path that's identified by the colon
in front of this part of the path by
putting a colon here it tells react
router that this isn't going to be the
literal text colon ID but instead
there's going to be something here in
its place I like to think of it as a
variable inside of our path so whenever
slash Vans slash anything is in the URL
then it will load the van detail element
here then we set it up so that in our
vans page we link to the slash Vans
slash and then whatever the ID of that
specific van that we clicked on in the
Vans Page by doing that it takes us over
to slash Vans slash two in this case
because we clicked the van with the ID
of two and our next task is to make it
so that in the van detail page it's able
to grab the two out of the URL and then
go and get the specific information
about this one van that we're supposed
to be looking at there's a bunch of
different ways that we could do this and
we're going to see some optimization
that we can do for example right now if
we go to the Vans page you'll see it
delays for a second because it's doing
another fetch request going to get all
of the van information so really we
should be caching that somewhere so that
we can get that information much quicker
and then there's probably a better way
that we can handle getting the detail
information rather than always doing
another get request since we have all
the information when we get all the vans
in the first place the point is there's
a lot of different ways to organize
things to make it have better
performance but for the sake of focusing
on our learning with react router we're
going to keep it simple react router
provides us a tool called use params
which allows us to grab any of the
parameters that we have in our URL and
that's a tool we will need to import so
I'm going to import use params from
react router Dom and inside the body of
my component I'm going to grab the
params so we'll call it const params
equals and then we'll call use params
and let's go ahead and just console log
the params
this function will run whenever the van
detail component is mounted so I'll open
up the console we'll hit save and cool
we see that we get an object that has an
ID property I want you to pause and
think for a second where did ID come
from
remember over in our index.js after the
colon we put this colon ID react router
will look at any sections of the path
that have a colon before it and it will
add that as the key in the key value
pair in the object that we get from use
params so if I were to change ID to blah
blah and hit save we'll see that now our
object has a key of blah blah that's too
silly let's go back to ID also it's
important to note that the reason that
react router chose an object instead of
just giving you the value of what's
there because you can have multiple
params there's nothing stopping me from
using slash Vans slash ID slash rent
maybe like a rent page that's nested
inside of the detail page now if I do
this my URL currently isn't going to
match anymore so I need to update it
we'll say slash van one slash rent one
really quick side note is there's
nothing stopping us from having multiple
params inside of our URL so I could
after slash colon ID I could add another
slash and say colon I don't know maybe
type and when I hit save of course this
path that we currently see isn't going
to match anything on here so it's going
to disappear but let's say we add to our
URL slash rugged and hit enter and now
we can see the van detail Pages back up
because this path is now matching again
and also the params that we're pulling
in the van detail page and we're console
logging over here is now including both
vid and the type parameter for our needs
we won't be needing multiple parameters
but I just wanted to make that clear so
let's go back we'll go to well let's hit
save we'll go to Vans go back to our
vans we'll do number two this time and
cool our parameters are coming through
as we saw before and now I think it's a
good time to get your hands on the
keyboard instead of building a whole
separate app to have you get practice
with this I'm actually just going to
delete what we've done and have you do
it from scratch so I will write up part
one of this two-part challenge that
we're going to video
okay this will test if you were paying
attention of course you can rewind to
see exactly what it looks like but I
want you to be the one who's writing
this out so I want you to reroute what
we did and I want you to console log the
params object like we still see in the
console from before in fact I'll hit
save and that'll disappear and now it's
your turn pause and work on this
challenge
so we need to First import the use
params Hook from
react router Dom and then we will grab
the params object by calling use params
and then simply console log params and
that needs to be lowercase hit save and
there we are back to where we were okay
so now we're ready for part two and this
lesson is getting a little bit long so
we are going to do part two in the next
scrim
okay so in part two of The Challenge I
want you to make a fetch request to get
the data for the van that we're looking
at on the van detail page based on the
params.id that comes in we're using the
mirage.js server fake server again to
get the data and the endpoint you will
make a fetch request to is slash API
slash Vans slash and then the ID that
comes from params in this case I'm just
making this as a comment van ID has no
significant meaning or anything I'm just
saying that the ID of the van needs to
go at this point in the URL for now you
can just console log the data we won't
be worrying about designing up the page
I'm just going to give you all of the
markup that I use for that okay pause
now and work on this challenge
okay let's get ourselves some room by
closing the console and like we've done
before we're going to use react.use
effect to make a request when this
component first loads so let's go ahead
and do that maybe down here below this
text we'll do react dot use effect the
first parameter is the function the
effect function that we want to run the
second parameter is the array of
dependencies now before what we did was
we used an empty array of dependencies
and that's because well the fetch
request didn't rely on any other
external piece of data to stay in sync
with what we currently want to fetch
however this time around we do want to
rerun our effect if somehow this
component were still loaded but the
params ID were to change in our case
this probably isn't going to happen the
only way I can really think of this
happening is if we had some link on this
van detail page that linked to another
van detail page in which case what would
happen is the ID would change but but
the component would not unmount and
remount it would just re-run the
function with a new params.id I suppose
down the road maybe some feature that
says here's some vans that are similar
to the one that you're looking at could
be implemented in which case this would
make a difference if we left this as an
empty array it would not refetch when we
moved to another van like van 3 instead
of Van slash two it wouldn't run the
effect therefore it wouldn't run the
Fetch and therefore the page wouldn't
change that's not a feature we're
worried about now but since we know it
could happen we might as well put it in
here so I'm going to say I want you to
rerun this effect if params.id were to
ever change okay so then we'll do our
fetch request and we're fetching out to
slash Vans no slash API slash Vans slash
and then the van ID which we're getting
from params.id so I'm going to use some
string interpolation here
and we'll say params.id
then we will get the response and parse
the Json out of it click this res dot
Json that returns a promise that we will
also resolve that will have the data and
let's just console log our data
and at this point I'll get rid of this
console log and let's get rid of all the
challenge text here just to clean things
up a little bit we'll hit save and check
our console okay it took a second
because it's doing a fetch request going
out to the quote unquote database but it
pulled in the van with the ID of two in
this case we can see that there's this
object that has a Vans property and
that's the only thing in here and the
only thing we care about and awesome it
has everything that we need at this
point all of the next steps to get this
page up and running actually looking
good with the data that we need is
really something that you should be very
familiar with by now so once again I'm
going to snap my fingers
really all the changes that I made are
instead of console logging the data I
set that data into some localized State
you can see we used data.vans because we
had that Vans property in the data that
was coming in up here we're initializing
that state the rest of it is mostly just
some markup you can see there's a little
bit of conditional rendering happening
here because we're initializing our van
State as null if I try to access things
like the image URL on null then that's
going to be a problem so what I did was
conditionally render if there's a van
then I rendered all the markup and if
there isn't a van then we just have this
H2 that says loading when I refresh the
page you can see it briefly it'll say
loading and then it'll show the data
everything else is really just some
styling there's nothing too special here
clicking the button at the bottom
doesn't actually do anything but what's
awesome about this is because we're
using a dynamic parameter in the path we
can go back to Vans we can click the
modest Explorer and it's going to load
the the data from the van with the ID of
one we can go back to Vans and choose
something like reliable red and we have
net data as a separate piece of data so
once again as a quick recap over in
index we created a route parameter that
was Dynamic by using the colon and part
of the path that we have for our route
definition by using that colon we're
setting it up so that react router will
save whatever value gets put in the URL
when this page loads into a variable
called ID in the Vans page we are
linking to slash Vans slash and then the
ID of that van it's important that that
matches up because when we come to the
van detail page which we're coming there
because the element is set to go to the
van detail page when we get to the van
detail page the very first thing we do
is grab the parameters from the URL so
that we can make a fetch request to then
get the van with that specific ID again
we could definitely increase the
performance of this app for example over
here instead of doing a fetch request
every time this component loads or or
the Vans component loads we could
probably save that maybe in local
storage or do some kind of caching so
that it can not have to make a request
across the internet first but can just
check our local cache and then because
this data that's coming in has all of
the information for each van we could
theoretically just grab the piece of
data that we need based on the URL
instead of making a whole extra fetch
request like we're doing in our van
detail page but at this point with us
learning react router that's not really
our intent here is to make this a very
performant app and just like that we
have a majority of our app built at
least the skeleton is all there there's
a few little details that we still need
to fill in so that's what we'll start
working on next as always though if
there's anything that was confusing
about this Challenge Series that we just
completed I don't want you to push
forward I want you to go back I want you
to practice practice practice what we've
done that's going to be what helps you
internalize what we've learned If This
Were School you might be cramming for a
test just so you could pass the test and
move on but this isn't school I want you
to actually learn the stuff of course
it's always okay to use whatever
resources you have using Google is
something that even the most senior
developers do every single day but
getting the muscle memory by practicing
this is what's going to help you truly
deeply understand what's going on at
least well enough to start building your
own projects so spend as much time as
you need reach out to the scrimba
community and ask any questions that you
might have and then once you feel
confident with the things that we've
been learning let's move on and we'll
start learning some of the nuances about
react router
let's run through a quick quiz on Route
parameters just to make sure that you
are understanding everything we've been
talking about again I'll remind you that
this isn't school I'm not going to be
giving you a grade on this it will have
no effect on how you do in this course
really this quiz is a tool for you to
assess your own understanding of what
you've done as such I recommend you
don't just skip ahead if you were to
struggle with any of the questions here
but rather to maybe open a separate tab
review the lesson that's associated with
each of these questions and then come
back and see if you can answer them for
yourself skipping ahead and just
watching me answer it will maybe help
you understand it a little better but
the understanding will be so much
stronger if you're able to answer it by
yourself okay that's enough of a guilt
trip now with these quizzes on scrimba I
do expect that you pause the screencast
just like we do with any other Challenge
and physically type your answer down I
know when you hit play it's just going
to erase your answers but that's not the
point the point is to have that muscle
memory that's included when you actually
type on your keyboard it will really
help you retain the amp answers that
you're writing down okay pause now and
work on answering the quiz questions
okay number one what is a route or
sometimes called a URL parameter in our
route definitions we are able to tell it
exactly what we want the URL to say when
a certain component is loaded or more
accurately when a certain element is
loaded however it's pretty common for us
to not know ahead of time as the
creators or the developers of these
route definitions what the actual URL
will be this is most common when you
have some kind of detail page that
displays specific information for one
specific item in a whole group of items
that sounds super specific but if you
think of basically any web app that
you've been to there's probably
something like this for example any blog
will probably have something like a
slash blog route but then after that you
might want the detail for a specific
blog entry in which case it would be
slash blog slash and then probably some
kind of slug of the title of the blog
why I love react router for example the
second portion would be a route param
instead of copying and pasting our route
pads a billion times every time we want
to add a new blog entry instead we can
create a parameter inside of our route
path that makes it a sort of placeholder
for any part of the path that might be
put in there so let me try to summarize
that in an answer here
this sounds a bit wordy but I landed on
a portion of our route path that is just
a placeholder for what will eventually
be the actual segment in the URL of the
page so let me clean this up I'm already
bleeding over into number two here and
let's work on number two we need to add
a route parameter called product ID I'm
going to copy that to the path below we
have a path that says slash products but
we are going to add a slash representing
a new segment of our URL and then
instead of just putting product ID I'm
going to put a colon in front of product
ID if I just had product ID then it
would be the literal Text slash product
slash product ID with no deviation
whatsoever in this however with the
colon it says by the way this is just a
placeholder for some other text that
will actually be the segment in the URL
of our page okay and then for number
three we need to add some code below so
that we can actually display whatever
product ID gets put in the URL when it's
displaying our product detail component
in this case we would need to First
import use params from react router Dom
and then we can grab the specific
parameter that we want in our case
there's going to be the one called
product ID and that will equal a call to
use params and now with product ID in
tow we could say something like product
ID is and then stick in our product ID
okay since this is just a markdown file
we can't really save this and double
check that it works but I feel pretty
confident with my syntax here and more
important than the specific syntax is an
understanding of the concepts behind it
once again if you feel like you need to
review these things then now is the time
to do that before we plow ahead and when
you are ready we'll keep moving forward
we are about to dive into what at least
for me was one of the more complex
topics about react router but that's
okay we're going to walk through it very
much step by step and hopefully we can
get to the end and you'll just
completely understand it perfectly and
that topic is nested routes when we're
talking about nested routes we're
oftentimes talking about actually a
couple different things first of all
we're talking about nesting pieces of
the URL so for example we've already
seen something like this we have the
slash van route and a nested route that
we have is the slash van slash and then
the ID or the name of the van or
whatever it is you want to be in the URL
but the URL is only a part of the story
because when we're talking about nested
routes we're also talking about some
shared user interface or parts of your
page that need to remain on the page
when you transition from one route to a
child route or a nested route and that
might happen more than you think with
the example with the slash van and the
slash van ID over here we're are not
doing much of that because if I come to
Vans I mean we're sharing our navigation
bar across the entire site but slash
Vans doesn't really have any shared UI
with its child route of Slash Vans slash
and then the ID of the van slash van one
even that little explore our van options
wasn't part of this next page and so
this page isn't really sharing any user
interface but oftentimes you will want
to do that a really great visualization
of this is over on the remix website I
included a link here if you wanted to
see the live demo of this and the reason
it's over on remix is because react
router is actually now a part of the
remix package remix is just a full stack
framework for the web it uses react
right now on the front end although I
think in the future they'll be
supporting whatever front-end framework
you want to use but a major part of
remix is the way that it handles routes
so here we see an example app they call
it fake books and we'll notice a few
different things first of all we're
inside of a nested route here we have
exam sample.com sales slash invoices and
then slash the number of one of the
invoices and if we break this down
you'll see that example.com is rendering
everything that you see on the page that
includes the navigation bar over here on
the left the logo everything else as you
might expect as you navigate with this
navigation bar on the left it will
probably go to example.com maybe
dashboard slash accounts we happen to be
here at slash sales and so that's the
next part of our URL sales now we still
have some shared UI here because we are
maintaining the navigation bar on the
left the slash sales part of this URL is
going to render everything else that you
see here in this teal color now here we
have yet another navigation bar inside
the sales portion of our website we have
an overview of our sales subscriptions
invoices customers and deposits again
presumably if we click on overview well
that might just be the slash sales
endpoint by itself or maybe it's slash
sales overview we click on subscriptions
that's going to be slash sales
subscriptions we're here at invoices so
we have sales invoices this top portion
is going to be a shared UI for those
other routes so if we go to the next
image we see that invoices is rendering
this part down here but it's keeping
everything from this kind of secondary
navigation bar and then of course
everything from the first navigation bar
still exists too over here we have a
list of invoices and presumably this is
one of those invoices in fact it's the
second one here so the last part of our
URL which is the ID is going to be
rendered in this little portion over
here on the right so in this example we
see not just a nesting of the portions
of our URL but that Those portions of
the URL are mapping to nested content on
our site or another way to think of it
is that there's quite a bit of shared
user interface pieces on this site even
if you navigate to another route so how
do you actually create these nested
routes well we know about the route
component but up until now we've just
been using it as a a self-closing
component if we look at the code that
we've written so far let's go to our
index page every one of our routes is
closing itself nothing is being nested
however we can use route as a
non-self-closing element or rather
something that has an opening and a
closing tag we're going to see exactly
how that looks a little bit later but
it's one of the most crucial
capabilities of the route component that
allows us to Nest our routes now we
talked about there being a couple
different reasons to do nested routing
and I would like to propose that the
primary reason that you would want to do
it is whenever you want to keep some of
the UI on your page but you also want to
display more so you're linking to a new
part of your website but maybe that new
part of your website is really just
changing one small part on the page or
it could be a big part too the point is
you have some things that you want to
keep displaying kind of like we showed
with the navigation bar or both of the
navigation bars in that example but you
also want to display some new stuff too
another reason that you might want to do
this is just so that you can avoid some
repetition inside of your route
definitions I put a little Caution sign
here because sometimes that may end up
being more work than it's really worth
in the end for example over here we have
a little bit of repetition where we're
saying slash Vans and slash Vans slash
colonid but as we mentioned we're really
not sharing that much user interface
actually we're not sharing any user
interface between the Vans component and
the van detail component and so in this
case you could choose to Nest or you
could choose not to Nest again we're
going to see what that actually looks
like in a different scrim but I wanted
to lay the groundwork and say that the
primary reason that I would suggest you
actually consider nesting routes is when
you have parts of your page that you
want to keep but also that you want to
display some more stuff to so this is
really going to crack open our website
because we have a lot of pages that
we're going to build so that we can
really practice with nested routing and
hopefully really solidify our
understanding of nested routing so let's
take a quick look at what we will be
adding to our site as of right now we
are only can consumers of our van life
site we can see the list of Vans we can
see the details about one van we can
click this button that does nothing to
rent the van but on the other side of
this equation are people who are renting
out their vans so we are going to be
adding an entire host section to our
website hopefully it's not too small
you'll see in the navigation bar we're
adding a host link there and going to
the host route is going to render a new
navigation bar that we see here that
navigation bar will have a dashboard
which displays kind of a quick overview
of the details the van host might want
to know and also a list of the other
information that the host would want to
know like a detailed view of the income
notice that it's also going to have this
navigation bar that's going to be a
shared user interface the reviews that
their Vans are receiving again sharing
the same user interface with that
navigation bar and then we have this
section for Vans now I'm keeping this
separate because this is going to go
even another level deep on the slash
host slash Vans route we'll see a list
of all the vans that this host is
hosting on our van life website clicking
on one of those vans will take you and
again it's got the shared interface here
by clicking on one of those is going to
take you to a new page there's still
some shared interface but this time we
have yet another little navigation bar
down here this allows the host of this
van to see the details the pricing and
the photos for this fan so the details
will be kind of the default and when you
go to the pricing it will have both of
those shared user interfaces too and
then some new information that displays
same with the photos we'll have the
photos of this van down here
theoretically it would be where the host
could then edit the photos so to get an
overview of the routes that we'll be
adding we will have the slash host route
that's going to send us to the dashboard
then we'll have slash host slash income
slash hosts slash reviews and then we'll
dive into the slash host slash Vans this
is going to be the list page but then we
have yet another level of nesting where
we'll have slash host slash van slash
the ID of the van that was clicked on in
slash host slash vans and then yet again
we'll go down to slash host slash fans
slash ID and then slash pricing and
slash photos so this one here where it
just ends in slash ID that's going to
sort of default to The Details page we
also could choose to name this slash
host slash fan slash ID slash details if
we really wanted to but just making the
executive decision to have that be the
default view okay that is a lot we have
a lot on our plates fortunately kind of
like before because I really want to
focus this course on react router and
not necessarily on making a beautiful
design I will do you the student a solid
and I will Implement all of the styling
and everything for you I know that's not
usually my style but I do want to stay
focused here on react router and of
course that's not to say that you
couldn't take the reins and actually
design it yourself if that's what you
want to practice so let's Center
ourselves let's take some deep breaths
if you need to and we will Jump Right In
the first thing that I'd like to do to
get our feet wet with this nested
routing idea is to really fix what we
have going on with our header right now
we stuffed our header into our browser
router just because it was outside of
our routes which means that it will
display on every page however this
really doesn't feel clean to me in fact
if we had a header that was more complex
maybe it would take up 50 lines of code
it feels like a weird place to just
stuff it into our browser router like
this I guess we could abstract it to a
header component and then it would just
say header but still it doesn't feel
good to me to put something that's
unrelated to our routes inside of our
browser router like this so our
introduction to nested routes is going
to be through something called a layout
route and I wanted to remind you that
the primary reason we are nesting our
routes is so that we can hit this second
bullet point here when you want to keep
displaying some information or some UI
on the page but you also want to display
more stuff that's exactly what we're
doing with our navbar we're keeping our
navbar on the page and I think our
design has a footer too yeah we've got a
footer that we haven't implemented yet
but that would also be something that
would just be on every page but we also
want the changing of our URL to display
other things as well so I added another
slide to the end of this presentation
let's bump forward a little bit this is
an image taken from the documentation
for react router it's specifically the
spot that talks about layout routes you
can click the image you see here to go
to the documentation if you'd like you
can read through this whole main concept
section or at least parts of it or skim
through it maybe it might be a little
hard to grasp if you haven't done react
router before but it honestly has great
information there you might need to read
it a couple times to make it stick so
feel free to pause and go look at the
documentation if you'd like but I'm
going to be talking about these layout
routes the idea of a layout route is
that it doesn't have a path of its own
per se but instead its purpose is to lay
out your page we know that we want every
one of our pages to have a header and a
footer if you go to that documentation
one of the things that they'll mention
is how the concept of a route can be a
little bit stretched I guess because in
the case of a layout route you don't
necessarily need to have a path if you
look really closely it's a little bit
small in this image but it says this is
a bad example and it says danger
basically don't do this what they talk
about is how if I didn't want my header
here inside my browser router but I did
want to wrap all of my pages without
using what we're about to talk about
with layout routes I would have to do
something like take my home component
and maybe wrap it in a fragment or a div
and then start stuffing in all my header
code just right here and I would have to
repeat that for every one of the
elements that I want to have my header
and I would have to do that with my
footer as well this is obviously not a
good example like it says in the
documentation don't do this there's a
much better way and that is by using a
layout route so let me back this up to a
reasonable spot now we do have a little
bit of work before we throw the layout
wrap together so I'm actually going to
make a challenge I'm going to give you
the chance to do this hard work for me
and then we will actually implement the
layout route in the next scrim so let me
type up a challenge for you okay I'm
sorry this is a bit administrative but I
want you to create a new folder called
components it's going to sit as a
sibling to our assets and our Pages
folders so not nested inside of them and
in that components folder I want you to
create two new component files
layout.jsx and header.jsx and then you
will simply move the header code here
into the header.jsx file but I don't
want you to necessarily go beyond that
because we will actually not end up
importing it here and using it at all
inside of our index file so pause now
and work on this challenge
gosh you know I wish there were actually
a way that I could just steal the code
that you just wrote and use it in my
recording here but alas that's not
exactly how it works so I will be doing
this work let's go ahead and create a
new folder called components and inside
I will create those two new files header
and layout
and then we will just steal our header
from the index page we can actually just
cut it we're going to lose our header
for a little while so in the header
we'll import
react and we'll create our file
or rather our function
and we will return the header that we
just copied all right let's hit refresh
there and okay so yeah our header is
gone which is a little bit inconvenient
because we can't navigate our site
anymore but that's okay we're going to
fix that soon actually we're going to
fix that now because we've done the
administrative stuff we're ready to now
just jump in and learn about how we can
implement this layout component so that
we don't have to repeat ourselves by
putting the header on every one of the
elements that we're rendering at every
path
okay so we mentioned how route is a
self-closing element but it also can be
an element that wraps around other
elements and in fact when the route
component does take children it needs to
be other route components as its
children what I mean by that is if I
want to create another route up here and
I want it to wrap around other elements
I can't just go ahead and start putting
other things like an H1 in here it needs
it to be other route components as its
children so I'm going to move this
closing tag down here I want it to
envelop or wrap around every part of my
website that I want to contain my
navigation bar which is everything now
assuming that you have dealt with react
children before you might start
recognizing this pattern this route
component is going to essentially take
whatever element we pass to it so I can
say an element and this is where we're
going to put our layout component
and it's going to render the layout
component and then it will also render
whatever child route matches the URL
that we're currently at let's fix some
of the bugs we have here first of all
we're not importing layout so let's go
ahead and import
layout from our components folder slash
layout and then we need to actually
create that so we will get that set up
okay easy enough this is obviously just
a placeholder now I'm going to hit save
we're going to see what happens and then
well yeah let's just do that I'm going
to hit save okay it's done loading this
is everything that our site is now
displaying at slash fan2 or if I go to
slash fans also the same thing now
assuming you do have some experience
using react children I want you to think
why is it that this layout component has
now completely taken over our app it's
the only thing being rendered here if
you'd like you can pause for a minute to
think about that I wouldn't necessarily
try to fix it quite yet because we
haven't learned what we need to learn in
order to fix it
if we were doing something like this say
creating a layout component or actually
rendering the layout component ourselves
and wrapping it around everything here
like this then we would have access to
our route components inside of our
layout through the children prop however
this isn't the right way to do it
because react router is not going to be
able to render correctly if we do that
so when we have our layout as an element
that we're passing to this route
definition there's a special tool that
react router has provided us so that we
can render the layout but then also tell
it exactly where to render whichever
route we're currently matching on the
URL for example we're at the slash Vans
route right now so it should render the
layout and then we want it to render the
Vans component that we're rendering here
the element that we're rendering here or
the element that we're passing to this
route here so let's go over to layout
and the tool that we're going to use is
a component from react router called
Outlet foreign we have to spell it
correctly so we'll import that from
react router Dom and the outlet is
basically our way to create a hole in
whatever our component is where the
matching route that is a child of the
route that we're nesting here or the
parent route like this the outlet
creates a hole where the matching route
can render this took me a long time to
wrap my head around so don't feel bad if
that doesn't make sense playing around
with this is going to be the only way
that it makes sense if it didn't already
let's actually implement it and then
we'll go over it once again so right now
I'm just rendering this H1 let's um
maybe put some fragments around this
just so we can actually render two
things and below my H1 I'm going to
render the outlet as a component so now
I want you to think when I hit save what
is going to happen
well when I hit save I should get my H1
just like it is but then I should also
get the content that is supposed to
display at slash fans
and sure enough there we go so this is
the layout route H1 up here is replacing
our header so we're going to fix that in
just a second but now we have the rest
of the slash Vans page rendering below
so let's look at that once again because
we are nesting these routes inside of
this parent route react router is going
to notice that this route doesn't have a
path so it's always going to match
whatever URL we're currently at and it's
going to render our layout component so
when it renders our layout component if
we don't have some way to tell it where
to put the rest of the matching child
routes like we have currently slash vans
so this route path is going to match and
we want to render this Vans element we
need to tell react router inside the
layout component where that Vans
component should go just like the
children prop Works in react children
where we get to tell it where the
children should be rendered so I want
you to think what is going to happen if
I were to switch these two I put the
outlet on top and my H1 on bottom you
can pause if you want to think through
it or if you want to run it and actually
see what it does
well if I tell it that the content
should be rendered first and then the H1
second I'll hit save we'll see that my
content is first and way down at the
bottom we get our this is the layout
route H1 okay now it's your time to
shine let's do a challenge
I'll be a little bit vague I want you to
get the header working again you'll know
that it works when you can go to the top
of the page you'll see our header and
you can actually navigate between the
pages again pause now and fix our header
well everything should be set up for us
I'm going to move this Outlet to the
bottom and then instead of using an H1
I'm going to Simply import our header
from and let's see it's inside the same
folder so I can just say dot slash
header and then I can render the header
component and let's get rid of this
challenge text we'll cross our fingers
and hit save
ah so close over in our header we're
using the link component in a few places
and I forgot to import that
some of you were probably shouting at me
about that and I apologize so react
router Dom okay let's hit save again
awesome I'm currently at the Vans page
we see the list of Vans I can go into
the van's detail page go back to Vans
about the van lamp home page now I know
we're not working on nested routes in
the URL per se quite yet but we are
definitely going to get there I think
this is a great way to introduce the
concept of nested routes and most
importantly understanding how this
Outlet works if it didn't totally make
sense that's okay we're going to get a
lot of practice with it but I've been
blabbing on for a while we've done a lot
of good work here we've got that ugly
nav bar pulled out of our browser router
the nephr wasn't ugly but it felt ugly
to have it here in the browser router
now if for some reason I didn't want
let's say the about page to have access
to the same navigation bar and I wanted
it to be completely different I would
need to move it outside of the children
of this layout route so that would just
have to move down here and then I hit
save everything's working but when I go
to about we lose our navigation bar
hopefully that jives with your
understanding of what we've been doing
so far let's put it back in there so we
can actually navigate back okay with
that under our belts we're going to be
bootstrapping out all of the host pages
and remember there's a lot of different
cool shared user interface things that
we're going to have to deal with with
nesting so we will get lots of practice
with what we've talked about here so
when you're ready that's what we'll
start working on next
okay before we can dive into actually
doing the nesting that we want to do
we're going to bootstrap out some of the
pages that we need and so that's going
to be one of your first tasks first of
all I want you to add a host link to the
navbar it should be before the about
Advanced just over here to the left and
when it gets clicked it should take you
to the slash host path and of course
that won't happen until we set up the
rest of this but I want you to also
create the following components that we
see here dashboard income and reviews
I've organized things a little bit I
moved our van detail and vans pages into
a dedicated fans folder and so I've also
created this host folder currently it's
empty and so you'll need to add these
components there I've also included the
routes here just in case you wanted a
quick reference to them I also pulled up
the slide here in case for some reason
this is better for visualizing it and
keep in mind I don't need you to build
the pages right now I just want you to
have maybe an H1 that says like host
dashboard here and then once you have
those components ready you'll need to
import them and you'll set up the routes
for each of the those now because we're
just bootstrapping things I don't want
you to worry yet about doing any kind of
nesting you can just put everything as
additional routes here right on the same
level as these other ones all right now
it's your turn to get your hands on the
keyboard pause now and work on the
challenge
all right let's get this done so we'll
first go to our header which is where
our links are We'll add another one that
will take us to slash host host
awesome okay easy start if I go there
nothing's going to show up because we
don't have any route that matches that
and oh no I broke it
okay there we go we're back okay that's
nice a quick easy win we'll get rid of
that okay let's create some components
dashboard income and reviews I won't
Bore You by making you watch me do all
of this so I just created a basic
dashboard component and I'm going to do
the exact same thing in fact I'm just
going to copy this and paste it to some
new components for the income and the
reviews okay so now we have the income
and reviews done let's go to our index
here and we will import those
we'll bring in the dashboard this is
going to be in the host folder and it's
the dashboard component and then we'll
just do that for the other two
okay so challenge part number two is
done and next we need to set up our
routes so I'm just going to take this
Vans route and let's see we need one two
three of them so we'll change Vans to oh
this is well that's okay we'll change it
to host and then I'm going to change
this to the dashboard I guess I could
call this host dashboard or something if
I wanted to be extra clear and then this
will be slash host slash income that
will be the income component and slash
host slash reviews and that will be the
reviews component okay let's hit save
we're not broken that's good news I'm
gonna go to the host and we'll see
dashboard goes here that's good now
currently we don't have any kind of
navigation that will be able to take us
to the income and reviews routes so I'm
just going to type it up here into the
URL we'll hit enter okay income page
goes here we'll do slash reviews reviews
page goes here awesome okay that was all
just some bootstrapping work nothing too
groundbreaking but next we're going to
see how we can actually on our host page
have another navigation bar that will
allow us to be a little more deeply
nested so that we can navigate just
through the different host Pages if
anything that we did in this
bootstrapping challenge here was
difficult then that's probably a good
sign that it's time to go back just
review what you've learned maybe it's
been a little while since you've done it
but it really will be in your best
interest to review what we've learned up
until this point and try to catch
yourself up so without further Ado let's
start turning this into some more nested
routes
okay we are going to work on nesting
these other routes inside of our slash
host route and we're just going to take
it one little step at a time so your
first challenge is to take this route
that is for slash host and turn it into
a parent route that surrounds the host
income and host reviews routes now
because we don't have a navigation bar
to get to these other paths here once
you've done that you'll go to the URL
and you'll type slash host slash income
or reviews it doesn't matter hit enter
and see what happens once you've done
that I want you to pause and I want you
to see if you can figure out why it did
what it did okay so pause now and work
on this challenge
okay well let's simply take this closing
slash away so that we can turn this into
a parent route here we'll close it with
a separate tag and move that down we'll
indent these nested ones now okay let's
hit save again we don't have any kind of
navigation happening so I'm going to
type in slash income and hit enter and
okay well here we are it says we're at
slash host slash income but we're seeing
that the dashboard goes here and we're
not seeing anything else so maybe you
figured it out kudos to you if you did
remember when we learned about layout
routes we learned that this route as a
parent to the other routes needs to have
some kind of hole inside of that layout
so that react router can know where to
put the route that actually matches the
URL in this case this dashboard element
is acting like a layout route and if we
go to our dashboard page we don't have
the outlet component here anywhere so
okay let's say we go ahead and we import
the Outlet component from react router
Dom and let's just do a really quick
fragment so that we can add our Outlet
we'll hit save and look at that we have
our dashboard goes here that's from this
dashboard page that's this H1 and then
we have the outlet which is the sort of
placeholder for the route that's
actually matching best to go I guess the
important thing to learn from this
lesson is that the way react router is
working is it's matching multiple routes
and deciding that multiple things can go
on the page at one time in this case
this route with the path of Slash host
is matching and so it's displaying the
dashboard and because our dashboard has
an outlet it's also matching this route
here and by matching I just mean that
it's comparing our path in this route to
what's actually in the URL and because
this route is matching it's also
displaying this income and it's putting
it inside the outlet from its parent
route that should have been reviewed but
maybe seeing it in this slightly
different context is helping clarify
that now there's one major problem here
and that is that our dashboard is
actually a different view altogether
it's going to have a summary of our
earnings our reviews a quick summary of
the vans that we're renting so the
dashboard isn't the shared user
interface that we want to share between
these three routes so think for a second
what is the shared interface that we
want to share between these three routes
well it's this tiny little navigation
bar at the top so in reality what we
need to create is another layout route
that is specific to the slash host route
and this layout route is still going to
be nested inside of our main layout
route up here because we still want the
top navigation and the footer we don't
have a footer but eventually the footer
to exist so in the next scrim we'll have
another challenge where we create
another layout route we'll call it the
host layout and thankfully we'll create
that little navigation so that we can
actually navigate around this slash host
nested routes without having to type
anything in the URL so that's what's
coming up next
before we jump into this challenge we
are going to backtrack on what we did on
the dashboard file really quick as you
might remember the dashboard itself is
going to be the view that has sort of
these summary stats and we also want it
to include the navigation bar but the
navigation bar isn't really the
dashboard because if we navigate to
another route like the income or the
reviews route we want the navigation to
stay but we don't want the summary to
stay we want to switch to those other
routes currently we set up our dashboard
with this Outlet so we're just going to
undo the changes that we made there so
that we are all set to start now on the
challenge for this script so let me type
that out
okay your challenge is to make the host
layout component it's just going to have
the navigation bar for the dashboard the
income and the reviews like it mentions
here and once you have created that host
layout component you'll need to replace
the dashboard being rendered here for
our host route as a caveat to this it's
going to make the dashboard disappear
but don't worry too much about that
we're going to fix that in the next
lesson so your navigation will include
something called dashboard but clicking
it won't exactly show dashboard goes
here the way that you might think I've
left out a couple of the steps that
you'll need to take so this is going to
be a good challenge for you and it will
really test your knowledge and make sure
that you've been following along with
the challenges and understanding what
we've been doing so far especially
regarding layout routes so now it's your
turn pause now and work on the challenge
okay let's go over to components I'm
going to create my host layout in the
components folder not the pages folder
maybe there's an argument for doing it
in the pages folder to me because first
of all we have the layout component in
the components folder it makes sense to
put the host layout component there but
secondly this isn't really a full page
per se it's just this navigation bar
that's going to be shared between the
pages so let's go ahead and create a new
component we'll call it host
layout.jsx and we'll just kind of get it
set up like normal
for now we will just return an H1 just
kind of do it one step at a time
and we'll say host layout then we need
to make sure that we import that so
let's import it at the top of this file
host layout that was kind of a cool
shortcut I could do there and we'll
replace the dashboard with host
layout
we're at the slash host route so going
to that path should render the host
layout
and sure enough there we are okay let's
go to the host layout we know we need
our navigation here and to navigate
around we're going to use the link
component from react router Dom and
let's use a nav element since this is a
navigation on the site
and we will create our links so this is
going to go to slash host oh not slash
host slash link there we go this will
say dashboard again this one's not going
to be working the way that we think but
we'll fix that soon then we will create
our other two we're going to have slash
actually just here let's see Slash
income slash reviews this will say
income and this will say reviews as a
quick aside for anybody who may be
already familiar a little bit with react
router you might be screaming at me that
I don't need these absolute paths even
over here in our index we have some
repetition happening with Slash host
slash host slash host so don't worry if
you know that there's a better way I'd
also know that there's a better way
we're going to learn about that very
soon if you have no idea what I'm
talking about with relative paths or
anything like that don't worry about it
we will talk about it okay let's go back
to host layout and well let's go ahead
and hit save
okay it's pretty ugly so I'm going to
call on my magic snap
and here we are perfect it's a little
basic but the styling is there so let's
see if the functionality is there now we
already talked about this dashboard well
we're at the dashboard I'm clicking it
it's taking us to slash host but nothing
else is showing up and well actually I'm
getting ahead of myself these will take
us to slash reviews and slash income but
the part that I kind of left out was the
fact that we would need the outlet if we
want to show any of the other parts of
the page so that's the next thing we
need let's go ahead and import our
outlet and I will need to turn this into
something a little different so let's
just wrap it in a fragment for now so
that we can put more than one thing here
and below our nav bar we will render our
Outlet let's hit save okay awesome we
were at the slash host slash income
income page goes here that's of course
where we would design the actual income
page okay let's try reviews reviews page
goes here awesome dashboard uh oh
nothing's there let's go look at our
index and I'm going to clean up this
challenge here I want you to look at
this nested route setup and see if you
can figure out why it is that when we go
to slash dashboard our dashboard page is
not actually showing up in fact you can
even pause here if you need a little
extra time
well one thing that might be obvious is
that we are currently importing the
dashboard but we're not using it
anywhere so the program has absolutely
no idea that we want the dashboard to be
a part of this app we had it right here
with the host layout but we needed to
dedicate this parent route because the
shared UI needs to be on the parent
route to The Host layout so our
dashboard is gone well there's one way
to fix this but it's going to highlight
what I was kind of alluding to a moment
ago where I was saying that we have this
kind of crazy nested repetition
happening and we're going to eventually
use relative routes to kind of fix this
so the workaround is I could just repeat
another path and say this one is also
slash host and the element should be
dashboard I want to make it very clear
that you would never see this in
production react router 6 code so I just
want to make sure nobody takes this as
their takeaway and decides This Is How
They want to do it so let's hit save
technically our dashboard is showing up
react router is matching this route and
it says the element is the host layout
and then it looks at this child route
and it says well yeah I already matched
it but I guess I can display this
element too in the parents Outlet so we
have the host layout giving us this
navigation bar and then the child route
here displaying the dashboard as well so
technically this is working but that
leads us perfectly into the next topic
which is all about using relative routes
so that's what we'll learn about next
the way react router works under the
hood is when it is looking at a child
route like the ones we have here and
here and technically this one here as
well inside of the context of that route
it knows that this route is a child of
the slash host route up until now we've
included a slash at the beginning of
every one of our paths but the truth is
we don't need to do that all the time
and in fact it's going to end up making
our lives a lot easier to not have to
have an absolute path like this every
time that gives us the complete view of
the path from the very home page at
slash all the way to the end that might
not seem like a huge deal here when we
just have kind of two portions of our
URL or of our path but if we look back
at one of the pages we're going to be
creating we have slash host slash Vans
slash the ID of the van pricing and
slash photos and that is going to start
to get tedious plus if this were to grow
into a much bigger site that might even
get more and more and more nested and
just become a little bit unmaintainable
fortunately there is a better way and
like I mentioned before for anybody who
already knows a thing or two about react
router we can clean up what we have here
and make it better and the way we're
going to make it better is through the
use of relative routes Now Fair Warning
by switching things to relative routes
it is going to lead us into the next
topic because we're going to break a
thing or two here but that's okay that's
how progress is made right the idea
behind this is that the slash really
should mean and should be dedicated for
the very initial home page if I start my
path with a slash then react router is
going to treat it like an absolute path
and technically as we've seen I can use
that and I could just use that for the
foreseeable future for my entire app and
things would work if I do not use a
slash at the beginning then it treats it
as a relative route and what is it
relative to well it's relative to its
parent route in this case the parent
route is not really determined we have
this path of Slash which is our home
page and the parent has no path it's
called a pathless route because well
there's no path there so it assumes
because there is no parent that this is
one of the first Pages like the first
section of the URL here slash about
Slash fans slash fan slash ID so I can
do the same thing with my host here and
just remove my slash and maybe we decide
we get a little carried away and we're
going to just remove all of these
initial slashes well let's hit save and
we'll see what happens okay I'm at the
slash host route but suddenly my
dashboard is gone but here it says that
the host is the path well what's
happening is because I don't have a
slash here it is now relative to the
parent route and the parent route is at
slash host it doesn't say slash but
that's because it's on the top level of
our routes so think for a second if this
host is relative to the parent and the
parent is host what could I type into my
navigation here my URL in order to get
to the dashboard view you can pause now
and kind of play around with that or
think about it if you want
well what I'd have to type in is slash
host slash host hit enter and now I'm
back to my dashboard so that's not ideal
I go to income well that route doesn't
even exist anymore and you can see
actually none of it is matching because
really we're defining slash host slash
host slash income and now we're back to
where we want it to be of course we set
up these links as absolute paths to
slash host slash income slash host slash
reviews and so that's taking us to this
unmatched blank page which we should
actually put on our backlog because we
probably want some kind of 404 not found
page to really soak up any routes that
are not being matched in our route
definitions over here but that's for a
future lesson let's go back okay well
how could I fix this well if these
routes are relative to the parent then I
don't need to specify host again I can
just say this is the path of income this
is the path of reviews because in the
context of these nested routes it
already knows that the parent is host
slash host so that should fix income and
reviews let's hit save go to income and
awesome our income page is back reviews
Pages back the dashboard is still broken
now at this point there's a couple small
caveats that I want to talk about and I
think that will probably be best served
by doing it in the next lesson so before
just moving on if you want you can play
around with everything we've done here
you can scrub back to the beginning of
the video and see if you can recreate
this relative path setup that I have
here and when you're ready let's go to
the next lesson we'll learn how to fix
dashboard and a couple other minor
things as well
okay let's fix this weird conundrum
where we have slash host slash host and
that's where our dashboard lives we've
already seen that the income and reviews
are working because we do want them to
be at slash host slash income and slash
host slash reviews it's pretty common
when you're creating a nested route
scenario like we have here to put some
sort of layout element at the parent of
that nested Route Series that you're
creating this layout element is of
course as we've learned the one where
all of the shared user interface in our
case just this simple little navigation
bar where that's going to be exposed and
then everything else that matches more
nested inside of it we'll just go into
the outlet of the parent layout
component because this is a pretty
common setup in react router there's a
way for us to say okay this is the
layout element and this layout should
exist on every route that starts with
host or slash host but when you go there
I also have a component that I want to
render in the outlet of the this host
layout component and not at some further
nested URL path like slash host slash
host just at slash host and the way that
you do that is with something called an
index route you can click this
screenshot which will take you to the
react router docs which talks a little
bit more in detail about index routes
but the main takeaway to remember that
was at least most helpful for me is to
know that if I have an element that I
want to display in the outlet of the
layout component but I want it to be at
the same route as what the layout
component is defined at then I can
simply replace my path with the prop
called index a way that I tried to
understand this for a long time was to
imagine it being like path equals slash
but the problem is when a path starts
with a slash it's an absolute path so
doing this means that this would only
display at the top level slash path up
here it's like it would be the home page
so the slash isn't going to work for us
because that's an indicator to react
router that it's an absolute path so
their work around for that is to say
index now there's a nuanced difference
between the layout route that we have
here that does include a path and the
layout route we have above that does not
include a path in this case the layout
component will apply to well everything
because everything is a child of that
layout route and that's why we still see
a navigation bar even though we're
inside of our more deeply nested routes
here now in fact I could switch this
definition here so that it does include
a path and the path would be path equals
slash but if I do that I want you to
think to yourself what tool did we just
learn about that I would then have to
use in order to maybe update my route so
that they looked a little bit more
consistent and clean well let me hit
save let's go to our home page and
everything seems to be working just fine
that's very specific because of the way
that the slash works and this being an
absolute path but the point is we could
also replace this path equal slash with
index because once again index is saying
I want you to put this element the home
component inside the outlet of my parent
route when it matches so when the path
is just slash then first render the
layout and then inside the outlet stick
in the home element when it changes to
slash about then I don't want you to
render the home anymore because it's not
the index anymore it's slash about and
so you should render this element inside
of the outlet of the parent I think for
the sake of more closely matching what
the documentation shows I'm going to
leave it this way but it's helpful to
point out that it was working before and
it would continue to work the other way
as well okay there's one other little
caveat that you might be asking yourself
about and that's right here we have this
Vans path and then we're explicitly
saying fan slash colon ID so what gives
with that how come we're not using
nested routing there well that's a great
question if you were asking that and
we're going to talk about it in the next
lesson
okay so what gives with having this van
colon ID here if we were just talking
about how we can Nest the routes so that
we don't have to include these nested
route definitions in our paths well I
want to refer you back to when we first
started talking about nesting the route
component the primary reason you would
want to do that is when you want to keep
displaying some user interface on the
page some part of your page will stay
the same while other parts will display
differently or new things will display
on the page when you're changing from
one route to the next and then we talked
about how there's kind of this caution
sign when the only reason you want to
Nest routes is because you want to avoid
some kind of repetition in your route
paths let's take a look at that so the
Vans and Vans ID we have this slash Vans
page
and it starts with explore our vans and
then we click on one of these and
nothing has remained the same I mean our
navigation bar and our eventual footer
will remain the same but that's outside
the purview of these paths here these
routes here so looking at these two
pages because none of it is sharing the
same UI there isn't necessarily a reason
for us to Nest a route for just the
colon ID portion inside of a nested
route for vans in fact doing so would
make us create a route that has a path
but no element because as soon as we put
an element in a parent route we have to
include an outlet for that parent route
and because we're not sharing any UI
that parent component would be a layout
route that only has an outlet in it and
we end up with a whole extra component
that's not really doing anything in fact
Maybe Just for kicks and Giggles it
could be fun for you as part of a
challenge to see what that would look
like so we can Nest this van colon ID
route inside of a Van's route let me
actually type that up as a challenge
okay I'm gonna call this one a thought
experiment because I personally don't
believe that the way we're going to
write this is going to be an improvement
per se but it could be a good way to
practice what we have recently learned
and kind of better understand how these
routes and these paths work with each
other so I want you to rewrite the Vans
route let me actually put this as a
little separation so you know what
you're working with you're working with
these two routes here I want you to
rewrite them so that they are nested in
this case because there's no shared user
interface between the slash Vans and the
slash van ID route the parent Vans route
that you create won't have its own
element prop it's only going to have a
path prop and that does mean that as
part of this thought experiment you're
going to have to figure out how to
render something at the slash Vans route
if the parent route here in the
definition won't have its own element
you can read the hint here which should
help a little bit so pause now and work
on well it's not a challenge let's maybe
say work through this thought experiment
okay let's go ahead and create a parent
route that's actually wrapping these
other routes
go like that and in this case we need to
move our path of Vans up to the parent
route but because there's no shared user
interface I'm not going to put an
element here again putting an element at
the parent route would mean that I would
need some kind of Outlet inside that
element so that it had a place to
display the children routes but because
we have no shared user interface I would
just be creating a layout route that had
nothing but an outlet in it which is
totally extraneous that's not necessary
at all so for this first child the Vans
page I do want that to render when it's
at the slash Vans route well we just
learned about the index prop where I
tell this route to render this element
at the parents path technically speaking
it usually wants some kind of Outlet in
the parent element but in this case
because we have no parent element it's
just going to render the Vans page with
no shared user interface between all of
these children routes and that's exactly
what we want so that should work out
okay then the only other thing I need to
change because we're already nested
inside of this path equals Vans is I
don't need to repeat the Vans and the
slash here I can just say that the path
is colon ID so let's hit save and things
seem to be working the way that they
were which is good that's what we'd
expect again we're now using four lines
instead of two lines which of course
isn't that big of a deal but it is doing
some weird things like we have a route
which has no element and now we have to
specify another child route using the
index route so again as a thought
experiment I wouldn't necessarily
recommend doing this maybe there's a
scenario where it makes sense but when
there's no shared user interface between
these routes there's really no reason to
do a nested route setup like this so
while that was fun to play around and
get some practice under our belts let's
go ahead and undo everything we just did
honestly that's a really great part
about practicing especially in an
environment like we have here on scrimba
you can mess with the code and maybe
even get something completely completely
wrong and it's not going to break
anything if you're anything like me I
suffer from some severe perfectionism
sometimes and it can be really
liberating to realize that it's okay
when I'm just practicing I can mess
everything up and then just go back to
where I was before I think that's pretty
cool but now it's time for us to move
forward
we've talked quite a bit about nested
routes so let's pause for a minute on
the curriculum and let's go over a quick
quiz dealing with nested routes just
like before I do actually want you to
click into the editor here and type down
your actual answers to this quiz and
again of course I'm not going to give
you any kind of grade or anything like
that the purpose is to help you reflect
on what we just talked about and
hopefully wake you up a little bit just
in case you've been in a bit of a dream
state I know sometimes when I'm watching
a course I will tune out a little bit
and I'm hoping this will help combat
that so pause now answer the questions
in this quiz and then we'll go through
it together
okay what is the primary reason that we
would ever want to use a nested route we
saw two possible reasons but one of them
is much preferable or rather one of them
is much more important than the other
one and that is whenever we want to use
some kind of shared user interface
amongst multiple different routes so
I'll type that down for a reference
if you have a larger app and there are a
lot of nested routes that are all
sharing the same name in its path I
suppose there could be an argument made
that using a nested route could help
avoid some of that more often than not
we'll focus on this primary reason which
is when we want to share user interface
between the routes so what is the layout
route well a layout route is the actual
route that hosts or contains the shared
user interface portion of the nested
routes so its job isn't to display the
primary content from the nested routes
or the routes from which you're trying
to display content its primary job is to
display just the shared portion that you
don't want changing when you go from one
nested route to another nested route
as a segue into the next question
another important aspect of a layout
route is that it will use an outlet
component
I'm not going to go too much more into
detail about that in this question
because that is what the next question
is so what does the outlet component do
and when do you use it well to answer
the when do you use it part first you
use it inside of some kind of layout
route where that route is the parent to
some nested routes so maybe even more
specifically rather than referring to
the term layout route we would say that
we use it anytime we have a parent route
that's I guess by definition wrapping
children routes and what does the outlet
component do well it's an outlet or a
placeholder that represents the place in
your parent route where the matching
child route will render its contents so
the parent route will oftentimes have
the shared user interface like we talked
about with a layout route so that parent
route element will contain the contents
that you want shared across every child
route and then the outlet is sort of
like the concept of children if you have
you compound components in react before
where it's a placeholder where the
children route elements will render I
think I just said the same thing two
times so hopefully it's starting to sink
in let me write up a summary
this is worded a little bit differently
but it renders the matching child routes
element prop and we'll say prop given in
its wrap definition okay so then what is
an index route well an index route is a
child route that will match the path of
the parent route if the parent route has
a path defined that definition might be
something you have to really think about
a lot but I promise the more you use it
the more it'll make sense but remember
we might have a layout route as a parent
which is containing any shared user
interface you want amongst all the
children routes but you might also want
another element Beyond just the layout
component to be rendered when the path
of the parent route is matching or is
rendered so a good way to think of an
index route is like the default element
that should render in the parents Outlet
when the path matches the parent and
nothing else I think that's a good one
that we could write down
I don't have the slides for the van Life
app right now but a good example of this
is how on our host page we have the
route host and we want it to display
both the little navigation bar for just
the hosts that navigates us between the
dashboard reviews Vans and income but we
also want to display all of the
information from the dashboard we could
have made the dashboard display at slash
host slash dashboard but just to keep
things simple we wanted slash host to
display both the shared user interface
of that little secondary navigation bar
but also all of the information from the
dashboard okay that wraps up this quiz
feel free to go back and review some of
these answers if you'd like you can of
course go back and re-answer them from
scratch might be a good way to really
help it sink in and as always when
you're ready we'll keep moving forward
with our van Life app
this challenge is a bit off the beaten
path for what we've just been working on
but I wanted to put a little bit of
space between when we added the header
from before and now what your challenge
is to add the footer that's just a way
to test yourself and your abilities from
what we learned prior so your challenge
is to add the footer to the site I've
even given you the markup here so you
can use that in a new footer component
that you create in the components folder
and mostly I'm wanting to test your
ability to see if you know where the
footer would be added so I don't care
too much about you getting the styling
just right however you'll be the best
judge for your abilities in CSS if it's
been a little while you're feeling Rusty
or you just want a little extra practice
you're more than welcome to add the
styled footer you can click on any of
these multiple screenshots to take you
to the figma design file for that if you
wanted to get the details on it but
otherwise I will just be handling the
styling behind the scenes and mostly
what I'm looking for is that on your app
any page you go to will have the footer
just tacked to the bottom of the page so
if you're not going to be doing The
Styling it will just appear maybe on
this really short page like this right
here below dashboard goes here on a
longer page it would show up at the
bottom you'd have to scroll down to see
it if you are working on the styling
then the idea is that the footer will
always be at the bottom of the content
even if you have to scroll to see the
bottom then you would have an extra
section where the footer sits if it's a
small section like this then the footer
would still be at the bottom of the page
okay I think that should all make sense
pause now and add the footer to our site
okay you might remember that the layout
component is where we are including our
header and because this route that's
using the layout component is wrapping
every single route in our route
definitions here inside of our router
that means that the header is going to
show up on every single page and since
that's what we want to do with the
footer that's what we're going to do
we're going to put the footer inside of
our layout route here or rather our
layout component so below our Outlet
remember the outlet represents whatever
content will go below the header we're
going to say we also want a footer in
here and that's going to be at the
bottom of the outlet to import our
footer even though we don't have it yet
created
footer
we'll hit save okay unknown error that's
because footer is undefined so let's go
ahead and create footer.jsx and we'll
set this up like normal
and fortunately for you I was so kind as
to just give you the markup that you
need to include let's hit save and great
there's our footer as basic as it is and
it should be showing up at the bottom of
every page there we go like I said I'm
going to handle the styling for you so
I'll use the magic snap of my fingers
and there we are so we can see that if
we go to a shorter page here we have our
van life footer down at the bottom the
main point isn't about the CSS the main
point is about this layout file you can
see I've made a few changes here to make
it so that everything laid out correctly
great work hopefully that wasn't too
much of a challenge I think the CSS was
a lot harder than actually getting the
footer to show up on every page and
hopefully that was the same case for you
okay it's time for us to jump back into
some new material so let's do that next
let's bring things back to a much
simpler time than the more complicated
app that we've been working on this is
actually the current default react and
react router scrim that scrimba produces
when you tell it to create a new scrim
with react router I've made a couple
styling changes but that's about it
currently I have it set up so that when
you hover over one of these links it
makes the link bold and underlines it
this is actually going to be pretty
similar to what we do in the van Life
app however navigating around there
really isn't any visual feedback as to
where I am other than what's actually on
the URL bar and of course the actual
content on the page a really common
practice is to have the navigation bar
highlight the item that represents the
page that we're currently on so if I
click about and hover off of it maybe I
want to keep this hover style to be
always applied to this link here
fortunately react router makes this
fairly easy and it uses something called
render props which if you're taking this
course as part of the full Advanced
react course you have already learned
about so let's see how the this is done
I'm going to replace the link import
with something called nav link nav link
is basically the same as link except the
style prop and the class name prop can
both take a function as its value let me
show you what I mean first of all I'm
going to change link to nav link
everywhere and of course I have to do
that here as well and as it stands I can
hit save everything will work exactly
the same as it was before and it's of
course not working the way that we want
it to yet where it keeps some visual
feedback about what page we're currently
on but that's where the difference comes
with nav link let me actually put each
one of these on their own lines okay
this might look like Overkill since it's
got so few characters in each one
spreading them across five different
lines is a little bit crazy but we're
going to add to this this will help make
it look a little more visually distinct
from one another let's start with this
slash about link here as I mentioned the
nav link can take a regular class name
just like you might expect and I could
give this a string value like I don't
know my link then I can save that I can
go into my CSS I can Target my Dash link
and I can maybe say the color is red of
course that's going to add that class
name no matter what route I'm currently
on you'll see I'm at the slash contact
route but just like we would expect in
regular CSS this is styling my about
text here my about link as read well
with nav link we can do this
programmatically let's go over to where
we're using our nav link and instead of
providing a string as my class name nav
link allows us to pass a function
because I'm going into JavaScript I need
to use my curly braces and then I can
provide a function and whatever that
function returns will be the class name
that gets applied to my nav link the
reason this is beneficial is because
react router will pass this function an
object and that object will have a
property called is active so right in
line here I'm just going to destructure
it this looks a little bit crazy with
the curly braces parentheses curly
braces but just know this is getting me
into JavaScript this is my function and
it's an arrow function so it's just
parentheses Arrow curly braces and then
inside of that function parameter I'm
immediately destructuring it I guess I
could say something like object and then
I would have to use the object dot
syntax in order to access the property
in this case I'm just going to
destructure it and the property that I
care about in this object is called is
active the is active property will be a
Boolean and it describes whether or not
this route the slash about route is the
current active route so this is nice
because I can use it to determine what
my class name should be so inside my
function I'm just going to use an
implicit return so instead of using
curly braces and then having to use the
return keyword I'm going to implicitly
return it's only that last curly brace
there and we're going to say if is
active is true so it's a Boolean I'll
just say if is active then I want it to
be the class my link but otherwise we'll
just have an empty class or an empty D
string representing the class we might
also be able to do something like null
let's see how this works so I'll hit
save okay we're on the slash contact
route remember we've only put this class
name on the about link so when I go to
about it turns red and it stays red
awesome so it's not just on Hover right
here this hover CSS rule is making it a
font weight bold and a text decoration
of underline but the my link class is
what's making it actually red so I will
make a copy of this and move it up to my
home nav link and then we'll do the same
down to
contact
and I want you to think for a second
when I hit save what is going to change
on our page
well we're on the slash contact route
and we just added this active style
class name to the link that is for slash
contact so when I hit save it should
turn red hopefully perfect okay so now
everything seems to be working you might
remember I mentioned that nav link
allows us to either use class name or
the inline style prop and that is
allowed to be a value of a function so
if I didn't want to define a separate
style in my CSS I could put an inline
style directly here let's actually
combine our hover State and our selected
or our active State into one set of
styles so inside my layout I'm just
going to create a Styles object we'll
say this is Maybe
active Style
and we will have our font weight of bold
our text decoration of underline
and we'll say our color
is red
now the only thing left we have to do is
to actually use this active style and we
will just take exactly what we had with
our class name but instead of applying
the last name of the string my link we
will include our style of active style
so we'll just say if it's active then
the style should be this object of
active style and otherwise well I think
we can just keep note let's get rid of
our class name and I will just copy
these down here and clean up our class
names there
and this should have the same effect
although now our active style includes
the underline and the Bold so it'll keep
it kind of the way that it is on Hover
State except our hover state is not red
so we would have to go over here and say
that the
color is red we can get rid of this
style here well I'll leave it there for
educational purposes I guess if you're
looking through this later okay so hit
save now the hover state is the same as
the active State and when we click over
to home that becomes the active State
there awesome
whether you use the nav link style prop
or the class name prop is completely up
to you if you're working in a team there
will probably be some kind of standard
or Norm that you should be following so
just stick to whatever makes the most
sense for that project and that team
okay now that we've got the basic idea
of nav link down we're going to back
into the van life project and apply it
over there
let's apply what we just learned about
the nav link element to our van Life app
we have a few different places
throughout our app because we have
multiple navigation bars in these nested
routes so we're going to work on those
one at a time and there's going to be an
extra thing or two that we learn along
the way to start we'll do this easiest
one and that is for us to style the main
navigation header up here I've given you
the CSS rules that you should apply to
the link if that's the currently active
route that the application is on and I
made a little note too that we don't
need to style this link that goes to the
home page mostly because that's kind of
our logo right now in fact I should
probably get rid of this underline
that's happening so only worry about
these three links here don't worry about
this link here with that said make sure
you read through the challenge I think
you should have everything that you need
to know to complete this challenge so
pause now and work on this challenge
okay well we know that we need to change
our links to nav links I do want to keep
this link here so I'm not just going to
change my import but instead I will also
bring in nav link and then I will change
all of these to navlink as it stands
everything should work exactly the same
there's nothing different about nav Link
in its functionality but it does add the
capability of adding that active class
or the active style this is going to get
a bit long vertically so I'm going to
separate things onto their own lines and
since these are going to be repeating
themselves quite a bit I'm just going to
keep my three cursors up here and as it
mentions you could either use inline
Styles or you could use a class name
maybe just for the sake of seeing both
ways I will start with a class name and
the thing that's special about the nav
link component is that I can provide not
just a string as my class name but I can
pass a function this is an example of
nav link using a render props pattern
where we pass a function and when that
function gets called by the navalink
component it's going to call it with an
is active property on an object so it's
going to call it with an object there's
also an is loading property on this
object but we're destructuring it to
just make use of the is active property
on that object and that way we know that
we can check if is active is true then I
want to provide maybe we'll call it
active link will be the class name we
haven't created that yet but we'll get
there and otherwise I don't know we
could say null or maybe empty string is
better I'm honestly not sure last but
not least let's go actually let's copy
these Styles here and we'll go over to
our CSS and actually maybe closer to the
top is where we'll Define this here
we're accessing some header anchors
let's just style all anchors that have a
class of active link
we'll give it those CSS Styles let's get
rid of these comment
Stars here and I need to make sure let's
see up in the header I hit save
and okay well host is highlighted that's
good news I click this and about is
highlighted Vans is working and this one
is not of course because we left it as a
link this is really cool because without
a whole lot of extra knowledge under our
belts just understanding this kind of
render prop pattern for a class name we
were able to add something to our app
that really does help quite a bit with
the user experience in understanding
exactly visually where they are without
having to look up in the navigation bar
especially because these days the URL
bar kind of obfuscates what path you're
actually on in a lot of browsers awesome
work hopefully you were able to complete
that challenge if not feel free to go
back and try it again next we're going
to go to this nested navigation bar that
we have inside of our host routes and
we're going to do the same thing there's
going to be a small caveat but we'll get
to that in the next challenge
okay we're gonna do more of the same
thing inside of our nested host view
dashboard here or navigation bar here we
have our dashboard our income View and
our reviews View and none of them are
really giving us a good indication as to
which one is currently selected so your
challenge is to do the same thing here
you should know that there's a little
caveat I included it in this note here
there's a little bug that you're going
to run into it's nothing to worry about
while you're doing the challenge but
we'll be fixing it right after we do the
challenge this time around I'd recommend
using an inline style and instead of
using a class name and I'll tell you why
after we do the challenge but let's get
your hands on the keyboard pause now and
add the nav links to our host layout
navigation bar here
this time around we will not be keeping
any of our links so I'm just going to
replace my link import and I'll select
all of these links while I'm at it we'll
replace it with nav link that gets a
severe amount of the way there then I'm
going to because there's some repeated
code and it's going to get a bit long
I'm going to put some of this stuff on
its own lines just like before
and let's go up to this two line and on
the next line we're going to add a style
prop instead of a class name again the
value is not going to be a string or
anything like that or even just to play
an object it's going to be a function
and that function will return the object
that we want and we will receive in that
function an object with an is active
property and we'll use that to determine
if we want the active Styles we haven't
created that yet but we will or if we
don't want any additional Styles applied
let's go ahead and create this active
Styles just put it right here say const
active Styles is an object and let's
pull in these properties now because
this is an object and not just a CSS
string
get rid of this stuff we're going to
have some syntax errors if we try to
just copy over the CSS so we will use
the regular inline Styles in react where
we need that to be camel cased these
will need to be strings and instead of
semicolons
commas easy enough I think everything is
set up let's hit save okay we can see
the bug here we have both our dashboard
and our reviews showing as the active
links but we can see that for the most
part it's working we have income and
reviews working and then if we go to
dashboard neither income nor reviews are
highlighted or have the active styles on
them so why exactly is it matching both
the dashboard and the reviews well an
important thing to understand about
react router under the hood is that it
is not just matching a single route it's
matching multiple routes whenever you
have a nested route like this what I
mean by that is under the hood react
router is matching actually I think
three routes here the first one is the
slash route if we go to our index here
as you might remember we have this
parent route that has the path of Slash
and that one is getting matched in other
words react router is considering this
an active route and that's really good
for us because we want it to render this
layout secondly it's matching the host
route and that's again really good
because we want it to render our host
layout route so when we're at slash host
it's matching both the slash route and
the host route and therefore the link
for the slash host route is being
matched or rather the nav link is
showing as this being an active route
now when we go to income at the
dashboard it was matching two of these
routes this slash and this host when
we're at income it's matching three
routes the Slash the host and the income
route because one of those matches is
the host route this one here our nav
link is considering this host link as an
active link and therefore we get the
dashboard being highlighted even when we
know that it's really the reviews page
or the income page that is the active
page we didn't see that problem up with
our main navigation bar because we
decided not to change our logo here to
the nav link we kept it as the original
link so we didn't run into this problem
but I think we would have if we had
changed this van life logo to a nav link
because it is Slash and host is slash
host
anyway I think you get the idea how do
we fix it well it's really easy there's
a prop that we can add to our nav link
that's just called end and what n does
is it tells react router to end the
matching here so if a more nested route
matches it won't also match this link on
this route so we hit save we'll go over
to income and now dashboard is no longer
highlighted this might look a little
funny if you're not terribly familiar
with it when you just provide a prop
name and not set it equal to something
it considers it a Boolean this would be
equivalent to saying end equals true or
at least it would be functionally
equivalent in the documentation they
just use end so I'm going to stick with
the way that they do it in the react
router docs awesome work let's keep
moving forward
the next thing we'll be working on is
the host Vans page this is different
than the Vans page that we have in the
navbar the main navbar up here because
that lists all the vans on our entire
van life site going into the host kind
of sub menu the Vans page here just is
supposed to list the vans that this
particular host is the owner of keep in
mind we don't have any kind of
authentication so this is all a bit
contrived but the idea is the host would
only see this host link when they're
actually logged in if they're a host and
they would only then be able to get to
this dashboard and navigation for hosts
but that's beside the point your
challenge is to start off by creating
these first two pages you'll see there's
a van list page again the vans that this
host owns clicking on one of those will
send you to the van detail page and that
van detail page has details pricing and
photos we're not going to worry about
pricing in photos we're actually not
going to worry about any of the user
interface that you see here because the
challenge is to add those routes and to
to add the Vans Link in the host navbar
right now we just have dashboard income
and reviews we need to add the Vans link
there like it says just create a stubbed
out version of the pages that return an
H1 for now and don't worry about adding
the navigation from host Vans to the
host Vans detail in other words because
you're just going to have an H1 that
says host fans page here there isn't
going to be a way to have a link to the
individual Vans quite yet don't worry
we'll get there soon as a part of this
challenge you'll need to decide whether
or not you'll be using nested routes and
I want you to keep in mind what will or
won't be shared between these two pages
you can take a look here remember that
the navigation bar is being provided by
the host layout component not the host
Vans component so I'll leave that up to
you and I think that's all the primer
you need so pause now and work on this
challenge
we already have the slash host slash
host slash income and the slash host
slash reviews pages so all we need to do
is create another route here for slash
host slash Vans when that page is
reached let's create an element that
we'll call maybe host fans and for now
we'll just create that component in our
host folder here we'll call it
hostfans.jsx and we'll set it up like
normal
as I mentioned for now it's just going
to return in H1 we'll have it say host
Vans list page let's go ahead and import
that over here so we don't get that
broken and actually let's copy this
reviews one and we'll just make the
change there we'll say host bans and
that's the same name we already chose
for our element so well we can hit save
we don't have any kind of navigation
there but I should be able to change the
url to say slash host slash Vans and
we're at the host fans list page awesome
let's add that to our host navigation
before we worry about the host Vans ID
page or the host fans detail page you
could say this navigation bar if you
remember is under host layout and I will
simply well let's look at the design the
design has dashboard income then Vans
then reviews so let's just follow that
that means I will copy this income and
put one right below it we'll change it
to slash host slash Vans and we'll
change this to say vans
save awesome now we can actually
navigate between these Pages now I
imagine the biggest struggle was trying
to figure out if you should nest the
Vans or rather host Vans slash ID as a
child of this route or if it should just
be a sibling route like this and if you
remember our decision up here in not
nesting was because they didn't share
any user interface and that's actually
the case here as well we look at these
two there's nothing that's shared
between these two that isn't already
being shared from a layout route above
in which case it would be a lot more
trouble to try and Nest these so in my
opinion I'm just going to say I'm going
to have a van slash colon ID and that
will be a sibling route to the Vance
route and we will call this host van
detail doesn't exist yet but we'll
create it we'll copy this host fans and
change it to host fan detail and then
create this component in our host pages
so will say hostfand detail.jsx
import react from react and get
everything else set up like normal
all right let's hit save no errors
that's good again we don't have a way to
link over there quite yet so in the
navigation bar I'm just going to say
host van slash one
and there we go host van detail page it
was a little bit subtle between the two
because this one says Vans list page and
this one at slash one says Vans nope
that didn't work slash one van detail
page and That Just About Does it for the
whole challenge yeah we finished
everything here awesome let's clean this
up all right this gives us a good start
the next thing we'll be working on is
getting these nested routes implemented
as well so that's what we'll jump into
next
because we need a way to get from our
van list page or rather our host van
list page to the host Vin detail page we
do need to build out this page here
however that doesn't have a whole lot to
do with react router so I'm making it an
optional challenge for anyone who wants
to really Flex their react skills and
exercise what they've learned in react
in general to build out this page to
make that a little more possible I've
added some endpoints to our server the
slash host slash Vans endpoint
specifically that will return only the
vans that are owned by this specific
host that we're pretending to be logged
in as you can see that it's searching
all the Vans where the host ID property
is equal to one two three that's not
something that used to exist but up here
I've added a host ID to a number of
these Vans some of them including one
two three I think three of them have the
host ID of one two three and the others
have just random other host ideas that
are not owned by the currently logged in
host aircraft notes around currently
logged in remember all of these requests
are implied to start with Slash API so
when you make the fetch request you'll
make it to slash API host slash Vans
what actually gets displayed will be
here in the host fans list page again
this is an optional challenge I'm not
going to be walking through the actual
creation of this because it's a fair
amount of work but this is the time to
pause if you do want to work on that
optional challenge
if you know anything about me you know I
don't do this very often making these
challenges optional so I'll nudge you
once again if you are feeling a bit
shaky on your react skills then once
again I really implore you to go back
and to do this optional challenge but
otherwise I'm just going to pull out my
magic wand to snap my fingers
and just like that we have our vans list
page built as I mentioned there were
three that had the ID of this particular
host or the host ID of one two three and
that is these three vans that you see
here we have not yet built out the
detail page we're going to work on that
next if you click it it does take us
successfully to the host van detail page
but of course there's nothing specific
to this one band here a few key things
to note is that when we're mapping over
our list events we're creating a link to
the host Vans slash colon ID and we make
sure to dynamically fill in the ID of
the currently looping over van or the
van that we're currently looping over in
our use effect you're seeing that we are
creating our fetch request to slash API
fans we're setting that into the van
State and because we're initializing our
state with an empty array we're checking
if the van's length is greater than zero
and if it is then we're displaying the
van elements that we created above but
otherwise we're just creating this
loading element here now that I look at
this this isn't going to be a problem
but there could be a little bug where if
the currently logged in host has no Vans
it's just going to say loading forever
so I've used kind of a cheater's method
here of getting whether or not it's
loading usually we would look for some
kind of loading state but that's a topic
for a completely different lesson okay
if you did this challenge hopefully it
wasn't too hard if you didn't do this
challenge I know for a fact that it
wasn't too hard for you but now we're
primed to work on the detail page so
that's what we'll be doing next
this challenge marks the start of
embarking on I think the most
complicated part of this app so we're
just going to take it one little step at
a time that said most of the things that
we'll be covering should be things that
you already know we're going to add some
new knowledge along the way but in the
meantime most of this should be doable
and if it is a really big struggle for
you that's a good indication that it's
time to go back and just to review some
of the things that we've learned already
the challenge here is to start building
out the shared UI portion of the host
van detail page so that's this section
right here at the top and if you
remember from let's see one of these
past slides here these last three pages
are really all we have left to build
this one it's a little hard to see
because it's so small but this one is
the detail page that we're working on in
this challenge or rather just this top
portion and that top portion is what's
going to remain constant through the
host fans ID pricing and the host fans
ID photos page as well let's go back
here to a little bit better of a view
hopefully it rings a bell that because
this is going to be some shared user
interface between those pages the
pricing and the photos page and The
Details page you'll remember that we
will end up using a layout route for
this So eventually we'll have an outlet
that we need to use for this challenge
don't really worry too much about that
you'll make it so that this appears when
you're on the what is it host Vans and
then the ID of the van so building this
page out is not the optional part of
this challenge but there is an optional
portion and that's to style it so that
it looks just like this if you don't
feel like you need to practice your CSS
at this time then you can just get all
of this information displaying on the
page and then I'm going to handle the
CSS part on my end we're going to fine
tune how the data gets into this page
but for now just make a request to slash
API host slash Vans slash and then
whatever the ID is in the URL so the ID
of this van the server is hard coded
just to only pull when the ID is equal
to the ID you pass in and the host ID is
one two three so that's really already
handled for you this is obviously not
exactly how it would work in the real
world but it's close enough for our
purposes in learning react router so
again you will just be building this top
portion don't worry about changing the
routes we have in our index or anything
to set up for this bottom portion that's
what we'll be working on in the next
challenge okay it's your turn to get
your hands on the keyboard pause now and
work on the challenge
okay let's set up some state for holding
the current van so we'll say current van
and Set current van is react.use State
and until that data comes in we could
initialize it as null or I suppose we
could initialize it as an empty object
let's go ahead and do null for now then
we will do a use effect which is where
we will grab our data we'll set up the
dependency array and we'll leave it
empty for now just saying if this
component ever loads then we want you to
run this effect and we will send out our
fetch request so this will be to let's
see I'm going to use a template string
because I know that I need a dynamic
access to the ID on the current URL so
that's going to be actually let me just
copy this part right here okay and then
I will use a template string to inject
some JavaScript now I need to figure out
what the current URL is and if you
remember way back we can get that from
the params so I need to import use
params from react effect router Dom and
then I can grab the params by calling
use params and let's see in our index.js
I think we've called Everything ID yep
so whatever I guess you could call it
variable name we put here if I said this
were colon whatever then over in our
host and detail page params would have a
property called whatever so it'd be
params.whatever that's too silly so
let's take that back and this will be
params.id or if I wanted to I could just
destructure it when I pull it in and say
I only care about the ID property so
then we could just say ID here okay and
then we will get the response and get
the Json turned into a JavaScript object
and then we will have access to the data
and if you know me I'm going to console
log this data before we get too far down
this Rabbit Hole so let's hit save open
up our console not Json parentheses we
need res dot Json cool okay so we get an
object with a Vans property and oh this
is interesting thing I guess this is the
way that the server is returning the
data the Vans property is an array but
because of the way that I wrote This
Server endpoint it's always going to
return only one item just because the
IDS are unique and especially when you
take into regard the host ID so in that
case I guess I could just always console
log let's say data oops at no that's
zero dot Vans at the index of zero which
would always be the first object because
I just know that it's always going to be
one object let's just see what that
looks like okay so that is the van that
we care about and hopefully you were
able to figure that part out because I
am the creator of this server and I'm
just going to cheat so I'm just going to
put my index of 0 on the server because
to be frank I probably should have done
that in the first place so let's take
off the index of zero here because now
data dot Vans oops nope that's going to
be let's see it's going to be that dot
Vans at the index of zero okay let's see
if this even works this might not even
work let's say the data uh nope that's
not gonna work okay bear with me here
I'm actually going to change this from
dot where to something called find buy
and then we'll take this out the find by
Method allows me to pass in an object
with a bunch of key value pairs that it
will find and return the first instance
in our quote unquote database that
matches these parameters so let's go
back to host van detail and now let's
see what comes in okay cool that's
pretty much what we wanted it's still
got a Vans property so we'll just say
dot Vans cool okay again because I
hadn't made that change before you did
the challenge this is I guess outside of
the purview of what we did for the
challenge this makes a little more sense
to me though okay well we don't want to
console log data.vans we want to set the
current van to data.vans and then in our
markup the challenge just says that we
need to display all the data so let's
just stuff it into a div for now and
then I'm just going to paste in the CSS
and the markup that I used in creating
this myself to speed up our process here
so let's get an image we'll set the
source equal to currentvan dot image URL
and I can already see that there's going
to be a problem here because we're
initializing our current van State as
null and so null dot image URL are
trying to access the image URL property
on null is going to throw an error so
again hit save and we'll see I cannot
read properties of null a quick kind of
Band-Aid for this would be to
conditionally render everything or maybe
even better is just to say if there
isn't a current van then will early
return and we'll say return H1 that just
says loading like I mentioned before we
probably would want a real loading state
to include here instead of just assuming
that if there isn't a current van it's
because it's loading and not because
there's some kind of network error or
some other problem but we're taking a
few happy path shortcuts here so this
will work for now okay let's try this
again loading and then we get this Mass
of image okay we're going to fix that in
fact I'll just throw a Band-Aid on it
and say that the width is equal to I
don't know 150. okay let's see what else
it said display the van image name price
and type so we should be able to just
kind of throw those in we'll say current
fan dot let's see is it name yeah there
it is okay name and let's just stuff
these into a paragraph for now current
band.price and we'll say currentvan dot
type okay it's obviously not the form
factor that we want but that is a great
start for us if you weren't able to get
to this point then I would recommend
pausing and going back reviewing what
we've done here honestly everything
we've done so far except for the use
params should not really be too new to
you in react this might be a good time
to mention that there's kind of a shift
away from using use effects to do your
fetches these days there's other methods
that we're actually going to cover a
little bit later in this course and some
new really cool react apis that are
coming out in the near future that will
make this a lot easier to write and to
reason about and you know what because
this has actually been a bit of a
challenge already it's taken a fair
amount of time I think this last portion
what we'll do right here is actually
going to be something we work on in the
next challenge if you were able to do
this little navigation bar then that's
perfect that's really really good we're
going to do that in the next challenge
if again you already did it then you can
skip doing that challenge and you can
just watch me do it over there in that
lesson okay great work hopefully that
went okay and if not you know what to do
let's move on
Okay I lied before we get to doing this
nested navigation bar we need to spend a
minute to talk about relative links
we've covered relative route paths for
example here we have our main route
which is the path of Slash which enables
us to put all of its nested routes as
just about instead of specifying slash
about because its parent is Slash the
slash is sort of assumed a more obvious
version of this is when we come down to
the host ones where we have the path
just as income but this is not slash
income it's slash host slash income
these are relative paths because this is
a nested route inside of its parent
route it assumes a known path leading to
all of the parents above it or rather
it's assumed that when we say income
here it's referring to the absolute path
of Slash host slash income down here we
had to specify Vans and not just colon
ID because we did not Nest this route as
a child of this route and therefore we
need to be a little bit more explicit in
the path leading up to it however it's
still relative because the URL is not
slash Vans slash ID it's slash host
slash Vans slash ID so that brings me to
what I actually wanted to talk about and
that's over in our host layout when we
created these nav links we created them
as absolute paths we said that this path
this nav link goes to slash host slash
host slash income slash host slash Vans
and so forth however the truth is we
actually don't need to do this and
that's because this host layout is
getting rendered right here in this
route and this route is already a child
of the slash route because our element
is part of the route for path of host
the element can assume the path of host
in all of its links so if I come back to
my host layout element this one that's
being rendered on the slash host route I
can change these to just say income fans
and reviews going to talk about this top
one in just a second but let's go ahead
and hit save and I can see that this is
going to take me to well this is the one
that we didn't change because that's our
dashboard let's go to income okay the
link is still working slash host slash
income slash host slash fans slash host
slash reviews and once again the reason
that's working is because this host
layout is rendered or nested inside of
the slash host path this means that if
we have links inside of the income
component here we don't need to specify
the whole path leading up to income
slash host slash income in fact let's
see that just for the sake of learning
I'm going to import a link from react
router Dom and let's say that we are
rendering both an H1 and a link let's
see what happens if we put I don't know
just something here let's hit save we
have our click me I want you to think
for a second where is this route
actually going to take me to in the URL
again if we look at the route hierarchy
we have this income is is nested inside
of Slash also inside of host and it's
already rendering on the income sub
route so slash host slash income so if I
just say that the link is going to take
me to this string of something it's
going to take me to slash host slash
income something so that's the idea
behind relative routes let's get rid of
these changes okay and we'll come back
to our index file actually let's come
back to our host layout file so this is
why all of these relative paths are
working something that's pretty
pertinent to what we're about to work on
is how to handle this nav link here that
takes us to the dashboard because our
route is not slash host slash dashboard
it's just slash host whereas these other
ones the routes are actually nested as
one layer deeper in the URL we need to
do something different well I guess we
don't need to I could just leave this as
slash host but one of the benefits of
using relative routes and relative links
is if for whatever reason I decide
decided I wanted to change what this was
called maybe I don't want it to say host
I want it to say admin let me navigate
to maybe the about page and then hit
save I'll click on host well actually
that one we didn't fix let me fix that
in the header this one is oh these are
also using absolute paths so let's say
this is going to admin and this will say
admin okay so I click admin and now when
I click income my link isn't broken
because it's a relative path I only had
to make a couple small changes I didn't
have to make a change on every link that
leads to slash admin slash something
else however my dashboard is still
broken because it's linked to an
absolute path of Slash host so let's
undo these changes because I don't want
to name it slash admin and we'll come
back to our host layout these nav links
are all fine so what exactly should we
put here when basically what we want to
say is I want to link to this route the
route you're currently on just slash
host well if you've had a chance to
practice using your terminal on your
computer if you want to reference the
prior directory you can use something
like dot dot it's a shorthand for The
Parent Directory of the directory you're
currently in using your terminal for
example if I wanted to change directory
to the previous directory I would say CD
space and then dot dot which represents
the Parent Directory well in a Unix
terminal you also can say CD space Dot
and that represents the current
directory CD space dot does absolutely
nothing it changes directory into your
current directory but that little
history can hopefully help you
understand what I'm about to teach which
is if we just want to link to the route
that we're currently inside of I can
just say dot this isn't by mistake or
really has anything to do with the
directory hierarchy it's just something
that react router has implemented into
the react router package and as a sneak
peek very soon we're going to see when
we might want to use dot dot but that's
for the next lesson so for now we're
going to say I want the dashboard to
link me to the current route where the
host layout out is being rendered and
again a host layout is being rendered on
the path of Slash host so let's go ahead
and hit refresh I can hit income that
takes me to host income let me come back
out here to the host layout so income is
a relative path Vans is a relative path
reviews is a relative path and now
dashboard is a relative path to slash
host if I were to go back and change
host to say admin I would really just
have to change it here in this top
navigation and in the path right here
other than that all of my relative links
would still be working hopefully you can
see that there's a benefit in doing that
and I've spent a lot longer talking
about this than I originally planned but
hopefully that gives us a quick primer
into the next thing we're going to work
on which I know I said would be this
navigation bar but it's actually going
to be this back to all Vans button I
purposefully didn't teach this when we
were doing these Vans list here because
there's a little bit more we need to
learn but when it comes to these fans
right here adding a little back to all
Vans button is something we now are
capable of doing so buckle up that's
where we're going next
okay I even did some heavy lifting here
and added this link for you and of
course you can tell that I added all the
styling to our van list detail page at
least the beginnings of it so we have
this back to all Vans link and this is
supposed to take us back to this page
slash host slash fans so let me click on
this we have a quick mini challenge for
you I want you to change the two so that
it goes back to all Vans a major hint is
how we just talked about the difference
between saying CD space Dot and CD space
dot dot in a Unix terminal or in a
terminal and we mentioned how dot
represents the current route when we're
talking about react router relative
links but before you get started a major
caveat on this is that it's probably not
going to do what you think it'll do but
I do want you to give it a shot see if
you can figure out what I want you to
put here and then we're gonna learn one
little extra tweak so that it will fix
the problem that you're about to see
okay pause now and work on this mini
challenge
hopefully your thought was to say well
if I don't want the current route in
fact let's see what happens I'll hit
save I'll click back to all Vans and
well nothing changes and that's because
dot means the current route which is
slash host slash fan slash one so
theoretically I should be able to say
well let's go back a route dot dot I'll
hit save and what happens is well it
takes us too far back we go to slash
host we want it to be at slash host
slash Vans this page here so why did it
do that well something that I mentioned
but didn't really dive deep into is the
fact that when we're using relative
links what it's relative to is the route
hierarchy here it's not necessarily
relative to the path that we currently
see in the URL why does that matter well
when we're here in this route slash fan
slash ID or in this case slash band
slash one sorry slash host slash van one
to be more specific when I use the dot
dot relative path the default in react
router is not to go back exactly exactly
one route which would be slash Vans but
it's to go up one level into the parent
route and our parent route is host or
slash host which is why currently
clicking back to all Vans takes us to
slash host remember we realized that the
Vans list page and the Vans detail page
here didn't share any user interface and
so we chose not to have a nested route
for Vans like we might have otherwise in
fact just for fun I'm going to show you
what it might look like and we'll see
how it's a little bit ridiculous if we
were to Nest this route so I'll create a
closing element rather for the route
we'll stick our vans colon ID in there
and now because we want this host Vans
to show up on the index of Slash fans
we'll have to create another route
that's going to be actually you know
what let me put some space around this
just so we can see it a little easier
this one is going to be the index in
other words the host Vans is what we
want to show up in the outlet of the
parent route here well we don't have an
outlet in host fans so we would need to
just render an outlet let's bring in
outlet from react router Dom now because
I'm nested I don't need to specify Vans
slash colon ID in fact it would be wrong
to specify van colonid because that
would mean slash host slash Vans slash
Vans slash ID so let's get rid of the
van slash part okay that was a bit of
work and we have this kind of ridiculous
just rendering an outlet in the parent
here but let's hit save everything seems
to be working and now that the parent of
my slash ID route is slash fans the dot
dot should work let's cross our fingers
we'll hit back to all Vans and sure
enough that takes us back there now the
reason I was mentioning this is a bit
ridiculous is because this is a lot of
work just to get that back button to
work so I'm going to undo all of that go
back to the way we were we have no
shared user interface between these two
so there's not a really compelling
reason to have a nested route scenario
like we just saw so how do we fix this
problem well react router has us covered
if we go to the host layout no the host
van detail our link one option for a
prop that we can pass is something
called relative and what we can tell it
is to be relative to the path not the
routes this means that when we say we're
going back a route we mean that we're
going back one level in our routing
structure in our path structure not up a
level in our routing hierarchy with this
setup react router knows that there's a
slash here and it knows that we're just
going to go back one little path segment
which would be this host Vans path so
let me put my money where my mouth is
let's hit save back to all Vans now
successfully takes us just back to the
parent path not the parent route that
might have been a lot to take in I know
we went kind of quickly if you need to
watch this again that's okay
understanding this relative path thing
took me a while to fully a grasp but I
am grateful that react router introduced
this relative equals path prop because
that wasn't always there and it really
helps us out in scenarios like this okay
I promise we're done talking about
relative links let's get back to what we
were working on which is getting this
navigation bar working
all right this challenge is going to be
a little bit of a doozy so I've tried to
give you the hints and the preparation
you might need just to make this a
little bit easier for you that being
said just because it's a more difficult
challenge it doesn't mean that you're
not prepared for it assuming you've been
following along and doing all the
challenges you should have all the tools
and knowledge you need to complete this
challenge so what exactly are we doing
we're not yet working on the navigation
bar instead we're going to create a
route or the routes that we need for
these views underneath what we've
already created to display so this view
over here shows you the three different
views that we're creating side by side
up at top you can see the three
different routes that we're expecting to
use in order to see these views and so
that's what your challenge is it's to
set up the routes that you need here in
our index file that are necessary so
that we can access the host Vans ID
pricing and the host fans ID photos
views part of this challenge will be for
you to add some stubbed out components
in separate files I've already created
these files for you we have the host van
info the host van photos and the host
van pricing components they're just
empty files right now so that's part of
your challenge just to fill those out
but they can just be subbed out like I
said you just maybe add an H2 that says
pricing view goes here or whatever my
first hint that I'll give you is that
you need to use a special tool from
react router so that we can keep all of
this top info that you see over here in
view while we navigate between the
different sub views or sub routes that
we are going to be creating this is
going to require some slight changes in
the host van detail page and I've tried
to indicate where that will be exactly
in that component now since we don't
have the navbar yet you can test them
manually by navigating in the URL bar by
actually just typing in the path that
you want to go to and actually as you
might have noticed the slash host van ID
view or path will display the
information down here at the bottom
currently we're not doing that but we
are at that path so you should be able
to start out by just adding what you
need in order to display the information
or more importantly for this challenge
just a stubbed out version of that
because this is a little bit more of an
involved challenge I did include a
hints.md file I'm not going to click on
it here because it'll give away the
first hint try not to go there if you
don't need it but if you do start
feeling stuck then feel free to go to
the hints I have two hints that are
separated by a lot of space so you have
to scroll to see hint number two okay
Lean On Your Instinct remember what
you've learned rely on the community if
you're really feeling stuck turn to the
hints if you need them but I believe in
you you've got this pause now and work
on this challenge
okay well the first thing I'm going to
do is take this route here and turn it
into a parent route to other routes
currently it's self-closing let's go
ahead and not make it self-closing and
we will add a closing route element or
tag here now the reason I'm doing that
here again is because this van ID or
rather slash host slash van ID is going
to essentially become a layout route for
the children routes that I'm going to
create we're starting to sort of
conflate what we're actually referring
to when we talk about a page because if
you think about it we're not really
creating new pages here per se we're
just swapping out a small portion of our
UI but for the time being we're calling
it Pages maybe this is where a good
refactor of our folder structure would
make a lot of sense I'm not going to do
that now because it's outside the scope
of what this challenge is but by doing
this I'm turning this element this host
van detail element what we see here into
sort of a layout route or a layout
component and when I have a layout
component where I have child routes that
need to be displayed I need to use the
outlet component so before we even work
on creating these nested routes let's go
over to the host then detail component
and my changes are going to go here this
is where I'm going to include an outlet
component I need to make sure that I
import that from react router Dom so
we'll import the outlet I think hitting
save should change nothing at this point
now let's go back to our index and let's
create our child route this one will be
self-closing for the time being we're
not going to have any more children
nested which hopefully makes you a
little bit happy about getting closer to
the end here we're going to say that the
path is equal to and actually you know
what this is not going to have a path
instead this is going to be the index
route as I mentioned the slash host
slash fan ID route should automatically
and by default display this information
so we're not saying it's slash host
slash ID slash details or anything like
like that it's just what will
automatically be displayed on this route
so that's what I would use an index
we'll say the element is going to be
well you know what instead of going down
the whole path of creating the stubbed
out version here and importing it let me
just kind of skip that for just a second
and we will just render let's say an H2
that says the detailed info goes here
assuming we have this set up correctly
it's not probably going to be pretty but
let's hit save and look at that we have
inside of the layout here the detailed
info goes here perfect but if I navigate
to slash host slash van one slash photos
well because that route doesn't exist
it's just going to give us a blank page
so we're not quite there fortunately I
can just make copies of this we'll
change this one to have a path of
pricing and let's say the pricing goes
here and we'll change this to a path of
photos or Foods nope photos and we'll
say that the photos that'll be go here
all right let's cross our fingers hit
save detailed info goes here we'll
manually go to slash photos hit enter oh
and for some reason the URL did not
listen to me sometimes this can be a
little bit tricky I don't know let's try
refresh okay that took a minute but here
we go we have photos go here this has
been quite a bit the rest of this is
just kind of procedural so I'm going to
import let's see I'll just copy this one
since that's most closely related let me
the third one so we'll bring in the host
van info host van pricing and host van
what is it photos components okay and
then I'll just uh let's just copy this
and replace each one of these okay those
components have nothing in them so we
need to fill them out okay so I created
this one for the hostman info and we
will cheat and copy copy this over to
the host van what is this one photos
photos go here and pricing say pricing
info goes here and I think we should
essentially be where we were before so
let's go ahead and hit save okay photos
go yeah because we're at the photos
route we'll see if this even works
pricing hit enter okay that takes me to
the pricing page and then if I just go
back to slash one and hit enter detailed
info goes here now because I'm entering
this in the URL bar and hitting enter
it's actually doing a full page refresh
but in the next challenge where we add
our navigation bar that will take us
from one page to the next without the
whole full page refresh and flicker
happening okay take a deep breath
hopefully that was okay I completely
understand if it wasn't even if you have
been doing all the challenges I think
this is probably the most involved
challenge that we've had so far if you
were able to do it pat yourself on the
back that's a big congratulations if not
again that's completely okay at this
point I would scrub back to the
beginning of this scrim and try doing it
again from scratch as always that muscle
memory is only going to set in if you
are actually typing with your hands on
the keyboard working through it in your
mind trying your very best to get it
done no matter what happened great job
or good effort and now it's time to
really tidy everything up by putting
this navigation bar in and next we'll be
working on adding the navigation bar and
then figuring out how to make the actual
information show up instead of these
silly little stubbed Out versions
before we even jump into the real
Challenge on this scrim I want you to
think for just a second we have here our
host van detail page where on this page
are we going to start writing our navbar
code take a look at what we currently
have where the outlet currently sits and
what it's supposed to look like here we
have the navbar and then the information
so if you need to you can pause and
think about it otherwise I'm just going
to be quiet for five or seven seconds
and let you answer the question
will the outlet represents the switching
out views or the user interface that
will be changing from one route to the
next and we show that our navigation bar
is above that switching out view so
we're going to add our navbar code above
our Outlet here right here okay that
sets us up for the challenge let me type
that out okay this is fun the challenge
text is actually here below where you're
going to be writing your code now I did
add the nav element with the correct
class name and the CSS styles that you
need just to make sure that everything
looks okay so you should be able to just
add your links as part of the challenge
and this style should kind of work out
okay so the challenge is to add the
links to the navbar that's going to be
above this information that's showing up
below here that swaps out from one view
to the next and if you need to check it
out I mean it just says details pricing
and photos so that's really what I mean
by check out the figma design to see
what the text of the links should be we
also as you might notice want to make it
so that there's a clear indication as to
which route we're currently on so you'll
have to remember how you can do that and
of course you can look at the other
parts of the code base where we're doing
that we're already doing that in the
snap bar and the snapbar and remember
the details link here is just leading
you back to host Vans ID it doesn't go
to host fans ID details or anything like
that so you'll have to remember the
little trick we recently learned so that
clicking the details link will take you
to that route instead of one of the
other nested routes okay that's enough
of me talking pause now and add our
final navbar to our app
thank goodness it's our final nav bar am
I right okay let's go to add our links
here now because we want to indicate
based on the current route a different
kind of style for each link we're not
just going to use the link we're going
to which we're already importing we're
going to also use nav link so we need to
make sure we import that then we'll get
rid of this and we'll say we're going to
add a nav link and we're going to have
three of them for details pricing and
photos so let's just type in that text
here details pricing photos now I do
know that I'm going to be adding a few
other things here so I'm just going to
split things out onto their own lines
right now and we'll put a little space
just so it's a little easier to
understand what's going on here okay
first of all I need the two path so
we'll say two equals and let's work on
getting these right so hopefully the
pricing and the photos was fairly easy
because I'm inside of my nested route I
can just say pricing and photos I don't
need to specify the entire absolute path
leading up to this this one is the
tricky one because the details should
lead us kind of back to the route where
we're currently writing this code in
other words all this code is living at
Host slash fan slash and then the ID I'm
going to use just a DOT and that
represents the current path remember
this host van detail is being rendered
at the ID path or endpoint here host
man's ID and so when I say to dot that
means just go back to host fans ID and
actually I think this is a majority of
what we're trying to do so let's hit
save we're going to see a little bug
here oh actually we're not going to see
that little bug till we get the styling
in but I hopefully can navigate let's
hit pricing awesome this is so cool
photos details that takes us back to
detailed info goes here perfect now
let's add the actual active class that
we need by using the style and again
this is going to be a function that
takes and is active prop or parameter
and we want it to return if is active is
true we'll return we haven't created
this yet but we'll create some active
Styles and yikes this is starting to
bleed off the page here so active Styles
or null okay sorry that that's being
covered up there because I can scroll up
and we can see that's the same I could
make this a little bit smaller it's a
little too small okay oh that wasn't me
there we go good enough for now okay
these are working no I have to hit save
and we have to create active Styles so
let's go up here maybe just before our
use effect we'll create an active style
so that's an object and you know what
I'm going to steal it from my other ones
so we'll just come back so in detail put
it right there oops let's replace this
whole thing and hit save okay this is
where we see the little bug remember we
have both of these matching because
details is not a sibling route per se to
pricing and photos we look here once
again the host van info is being
displayed at as an index route which
means it's at this path and that means
that this is matching currently even
when I'm in pricing so to fix that I
simply need to add let's go back down
the end prop so I can say end we'll hit
save and there we go okay so now details
is the only nav link being displayed or
being highlighted rather pricing photos
perfect I hope everything went well one
of the final major pieces that we're
going to be working on is actually
getting the correct information
displaying here inside of our nested
routes at first glance it might seem
like it's easy because well we've
already got this information why not be
able to display it down there but
remember we only have an outlet here
we're not actually coding out the
detailed info or the pricing or the
photos here in this file where we have
the information from our fetch request
so we have a little bit of work to pass
the information that we've gathered to
the chat child routes so that they have
access to that information in order to
display it correctly fortunately react
router has made this fairly easy so
we'll be able to do that pretty quickly
for now start to get excited we're
almost done with the majority of our app
we have a couple loose ends to tie off
but those things are fairly minor in
comparison to all the amazing work that
you've done so far on this project once
you're done with your little happy dance
and maybe doing a lap around your house
or something let's get back to work and
we will figure out how to get the
information into our child routes
okay so here we are we have our
navigation bar we have our outlet and
the place where our navigation bar lives
is also the place where we're getting
our information from the server it's
saved into State locally on this
component and if we were just rendering
a child component we could pass this
information down through props to that
component in this case we're not
rendering the host bin info photos or
pricing because we don't know which one
of those is going to appear in the place
of this Outlet fortunately react router
makes it really easy for us to get
information into the components that are
rendered as part of this outlet and so
this challenge is actually going to be a
bit different than what I usually do let
me go ahead and type it out the reason
this is different is because I'm not
going to teach you how to do this before
I ask you to try and do it as part of
the challenge instead I've linked the
documentation to something called use
Outlet context this goes directly to the
react router docs on Outlet context and
it will show you both how to set it up
on this side of the equation as well as
how to write the code on the receiving
end in other words in the host man info
photos in host van pricing components
over there so go over to the
documentation read through what they
have it talks a little bit about
typescript we're not using typescript so
at this point you don't need to follow
the advice that they have for typescript
users okay pause now go to the docs and
work on this challenge
this makes a lot more sense if you
already have some experience using
context in react because in this case
essentially Outlet is just a context
provider in react if I were creating
this I would create a value prop but the
way that they've defined it I create a
context prop and whatever value I pass
to my context prop will be receivable in
my other components using a hook called
use Outlet context so we'll just go
ahead and import that here for now and I
guess while I'm at it I'll put this into
my other components as well since I'm
going to need the outlet context in each
one of these okay let's actually pass
something to our context before we go
too far down that route as I mentioned
we have the information in state called
current van so let's go ahead and just
pass the current van as the value of our
context in this case we're passing the
van object as the entire context value I
guess what I could do is surround this
in another set of curly braces which in
the this case means I'm going to pass an
object and it will have a current van
property whose value is the current van
object so this is the shorthand of
saying this I do tend to see something
like this a little more frequently than
just passing the entire object by itself
with nothing else so I think just for
the sake of sticking with the example
that the documentation gave I'll do it
this way which means when I'm receiving
it in the host van info we'll go ahead
and say my const and I can't just say
the current van is equal to use Outlet
context because current van is an object
that has the current van property so I
can just destructure that right in line
while I'm doing that again we'll go
ahead and copy this into our other
components and now I should have access
to my current van so I can render let's
go ahead and create a section and let's
I don't know maybe render this as an H4
since we're pretty far down this nested
route that we have going here and we're
going to display the name and I can
access that with currentvan.name and
actually these are all kind of the same
if you look at the design they're the
same level of typography so we'll just
use h4s for everything we'll say the
category is current fan dot I guess type
this probably should say type instead of
category that's all right we'll say the
description is currentvan dot
description and well the design has
let's go back here visibility public
that's not actually part of our current
van so we'll just kind of hard code that
one visibility public hopefully that
didn't throw anybody off too much
looking for the visibility information
inside the current van I'm really sorry
if it did okay well the route we're in
is the detailed info so let's hit save
scroll down and awesome okay we have
some styling work to do I'm just going
to handle that for you okay easy enough
now I should be able to just go to the
photos and the pricing and do exactly
the same thing so I won't make you sit
and watch me do all that okay and just
like that we're rendering in the image
where we're pulling in the current van
dot image URL we'll hit save and go over
to photos perfect of course if this were
a real site we'd probably have multiple
photos but we're not going to worry
about that because it doesn't pertain
strictly to react router okay and I will
just do the same thing for the pricing
okay let's hit save we'll go over to
pricing and perfect we have covered a
ton of ground here I mean look at the
app that we've been building we have
three different levels of navigation
we've learned about relative routes
relative navigation links and well
there's just too much to list assuming
you've been able to follow along and do
all of these challenges you really
should be super proud of yourself now we
still have a couple features that I
think would really be beneficial for us
to add and it's going to teach us a
couple more aspects about react router
along the way but this would be a great
time to take a break congratulate
yourself maybe show off all that you've
been learning to a friend and when
you're ready we'll move on to learning
just a few more pieces about react
router
this would be a great point in your
progress to update the deployment that
you did to netlify earlier in the course
we've got some great new features to
show off and maybe you want to put it
out on Twitter or share it to some
family or friends so if you already feel
comfortable deploying the updated
version of your site to netlify then you
can just skip this entire lesson if on
the other hand you have not yet deployed
anything to netlify I have a link here
to the original scrim back from the
beginning of this course that talks
about how to set up your netlify account
how to push everything using git and
GitHub with GitHub desktop and
everything you need in order to get your
site live you can click the screenshot
here which will take you back to that
other scrim showing you exactly how to
do that process and what we're going to
do is going to be very similar to that
first we're going to commit our local
code to git then we're going to push our
code up to GitHub and netlify will just
automatically handle the rest and
assuming that you already have an
existing netlify project that's
connected to the same GitHub repository
and you haven't deleted that full folder
or the GitHub repository from before
then netlify will just automatically
update everything for you now because
we're here on scrimba when you first
downloaded the code in the earlier part
of the course we have diverged since
then with our code by writing a bunch of
new code just here on scrimba so the
first thing we need to do is download
this entire project again in the current
design of scrimba you can find that with
the gear icon in the lower right a menu
will pop up and you can click download
as zip once you download that zip file
and unzip it you will have all of your
files from the project that we have and
what I'm doing here in this GIF is just
dragging everything over to my existing
van life folder and replacing all of the
files from before now something that's
important to note that doesn't happen in
this process is we are not deleting a
hidden file called dot git ignore so if
you open the van Life app with all of
the new files that just replace the old
files you should still see a file called
dot get ignore with the contents that
you see here I've made sure that it's
included here in the project in case you
downloaded the zip directly from this
project so hopefully that is still there
for you and doesn't cause any issues if
not you can manually add this and that
will work just as well then if we open
up GitHub desktop and we make sure that
we're looking at our van life repository
we'll see the list of changes that
happened we can commit those changes by
adding a message down here and clicking
commit to main which will then send us
back to this state where we have no
local changes and we can push our
changes up to our GitHub repository by
clicking this push origin Button as soon
as you do that netlify is going to see
that there has been a change on your
repository and it's going to upload the
new version build it and deploy your
site so that it's live for anyone to see
you can click on the link up here which
will then take you to your site and
voila everything is ready to share just
like before if you'd like to share it
out to Twitter I think it's a great idea
to build in public and to share your
wins with the world so if you're active
on Twitter you can click this screenshot
which will pre-populate a tweet for you
of course you can change it however you
want especially make sure that you add
your custom netlify link right here at
the bottom of that tweet and that's it
now we're ready to continue working on
our van Life app
you may have noticed that we completely
skipped adding this filtering section on
our vans page this is the list of all
Vans not just the host vans in fact you
can even see this screenshot doesn't yet
include the little host link up at the
top in fact you can even see that this
screenshot doesn't include the host link
that we added to our navigation bar but
don't worry we didn't forget to do it
and now it's our time to tackle this
feature the reason we put it off till
now is because it will require us to
learn about something called search
parameters or query parameters I pretty
commonly hear it called both of these
things so I just put search query
parameters because you'll hear spoken
both ways let's talk for just a minute
about what query parameters are the idea
of a query parameter is that it can
represent some kind of change in your
user interface what you actually see on
the page in your app probably the most
common tasks for query parameters are
whenever you need to do any kind of
sorting of your list or filtering of
something on the page or if you have a
ton of results and you need to do
pagination we have a pretty limited
selection of hands on our site but if we
had say 2 000 vans that were listed we
might want some kind of pagination that
said we only show 10 results at a time
and the user can click through the pages
to see more pagination like that and the
kind of filtering that we're going to be
working on in this app usually happens
within a query parameter we're gonna see
in just a second what that actually
looks like and how you implement it but
for now we're just talking about the
theory a really helpful way that I have
found to think about query parameters is
to think of them as a single source of
Truth for some of our application State
I've talked about this before in another
react course that I've created and the
idea is that it can be really important
to ensure that the state you're
maintaining in your app no matter where
that actually is happening has a sort of
central Hub that we call the source of
Truth so that everything else just
derives the way that it looks based on
that single source of Truth some
examples of this might be something like
react state or local storage or as we're
seeing here the query parameters that
are in your url or you might be using a
third-party Library like Redux where
that single source of Truth is
maintained in memory in a Redux store
for example so like I mentioned
sometimes query parameters which will
exist in the URL can be used as a single
source of Truth for parts of your
application State a really helpful
metric that I have used is to ask myself
should a user be able to revisit or
share this page exactly like it is and
have the experience be the same or
rather have the results be the same if
the answer is yes then it might be worth
considering raising the state of our
filtering or sorting or pagination or
whatever it might be up to the URL in a
query parameter so you might be thinking
well what about react State maybe you've
even done some filtering or sorting or
maybe even pagination using react State
as the single source of Truth something
you've probably noticed about react
state is what happens when you refresh
your page in fact I want you to think
for a second what does happen when you
refresh your page say you're maintaining
a counter and you've clicked the button
seven times so the count is currently
seven and then you hit refresh what
happens the counter resets to whatever
you initialize to your state as hitting
Refresh on your browser is akin to
loading the app up for the first time so
assuming you initialized your counter at
maybe zero when you hit refresh your
counter is gone your state is wiped away
and everything starts fresh as such can
you share the current state using react
state of your app with a friend well no
if I had a counter app and for some
reason I wanted to share the current
count with a friend and I copied the URL
and sent it to them when they load it up
it's going to be fresh state for them in
their browser so it won't include my
account that I saw in my end maybe a
more realistic example using our van
Life app if we maybe had four different
filters and some kind of text search or
maybe even a location search like if we
wanted to only see the Vans that were in
our vicinity so that we could easily go
pick them up that might be part of the
filtering that we're doing on our list
of vans so then let's say I want to take
that list that I've created through my
filters text search location search
whatever it might be and share it with a
friend well if I'm holding all of that
state in react State I really can't do
that in a meaningful way at least not
without some kind of crazy work around
so this would be a great example where
the state of my filters and text search
and whatever else it might be might be
better to raise out of react and up into
the URL in reality react router is
handling our URL but under the hood it's
using the native browser apis that are
dealing with the URL now one thing that
I've noticed over the last year maybe
two years is that the best practices
about using react State and actually
about using other parts of react like
use effect they're always changing in
fact later in this course we are going
to see an example of how we're not even
going to be doing our fetching of our
let's see where do we have our vans here
we're not even going to be doing our
fetching inside of a use effect and
saving the results in state which might
seem crazy that might be the only way
you've ever done fetching but there's
some serious drawbacks to the way that
this is happening anyway we're getting
down to Rabbit Hole so let me bring us
back we'll see really quickly how query
parameters are actually structured as I
mentioned it's part of your URL and it
represents key value pairs of
information that can live directly in
your url I'm almost certain you will
recognize this pattern you create query
parameters by first starting with the
question mark So in our app if we have
slash Vans we would include in the URL a
question mark and then we would
associate some information like the key
of type and we would set it equal to a
value of in the system sample rugged
remember all our vans have this kind of
type here that's simple rugged and
luxury well if we only wanted to see all
of the rugged vans that were available
then we might include a query parameter
where the type is equal to rugged and
there's nothing that stops us from
having multiple query parameters you may
have seen URLs that were extremely long
I think if you go to Amazon any product
page that you find will have a really
long URL and if you look at it it will
have a number of different query
parameters theoretically there should
only be one question mark in the URL
that begins the query parameter segment
of the URL but you can have multiples
that are separated by an ampersand so
for example if we wanted to be able to
filter by the type of rugged but also
filter by Price or maybe even more
common is to do something like sort by
price if we wanted to see prices low to
high for example then we simply include
multiple key value pairs in our query
parameters by separating them with an
ampersand and you would just do do more
and more ampersands with key value pairs
in between if you wanted more query
parameters okay I promise I'm done
talking about Theory let's work on now
implementing some query parameters and
some filtering into our app by including
the little filters that we have so far
been neglecting from our design
in order to handle search parameters in
a react router app we're going to use a
hook called use search params you can
click on the screenshot here to go
directly to the documentation and one
thing that's really nice about used
search params is that it is very similar
to the signature of use State let me
show you what I mean so here we have a
very simple app that has a list of Star
Wars characters they're either Jedi type
or Sith type we have some conditional
styling happening where they're either
blue or red depending on their type and
our goal is to make a couple buttons so
one will say Jedi one will say Sith
clicking them will add a search
parameter to the URL which will then
make it so that it filters this list and
only shows either the Jedi or the Sith
to start out we can use the hook for use
search params we'll just do it here at
the top of our component we can say
const and then we will destructure an
array that comes back by calling use
search params just like in use State we
will get back the the value of the
params we're creating so we'll call it
search params and that's in the first
index of the array that we're
destructuring and the second thing we'll
get back is a Setter function just like
in you state so we'll call it set search
params let's go ahead and console Log
search params and let's see what we get
okay so this is not just a regular
object or a string or anything like that
it's actually an instance of the browser
native URL search params object because
of this the search params object that we
have here actually has a whole set of
methods that we can make use of when we
need to and if you're interested you can
go look at all of the methods in the URL
search params documentation on mdn you
can click the screenshot here to go
there one of the methods that is very
useful is one called dot get and we can
provide the name of a key in a key value
pair for our search parameters and it
will return the value of that parameter
so for example we are going to be using
a parameter called type and so if we say
searchprams.get type it will return that
and then we are going to console log
Whatever Gets returned or rather it will
return the value of that so I'm going to
hit save but I want you to take a look
at what is currently in our URL and
determine what you think the console log
is going to return well we currently
don't have a query string in here so
let's go ahead and hit save and it looks
like from the search params object when
we try to get the parameter of type the
value is null so let's go ahead and
actually put a question mark and we'll
say type equals Sif we'll hit enter it
should re-render our component and we'll
see if our search parameters are working
okay look at that when we console log
the search params I get type we get the
value of Sith if we want a more full
picture of what our search params are
actually containing at any given time we
can use a method on the search params
called Dot tostring and I'll hit save
you can see what that does so we get
type equals if remember we can separate
the parameters with an Ampersand so if I
had another one like and scrimba equals
awesome and that needs to be equals okay
we can see that the search params.2
string will return the entire query
string it doesn't include the question
mark in the beginning though so that's
something to keep in mind okay so we
have a way to get let me change this
back we'll say we want to get the type
and I'll go ahead and get rid of even
though scrim is awesome I'm going to get
rid of this other parameter here okay we
have a way to get the value of type
which currently is Sif soon we're going
to learn how we can actually set our
search parameters so that we can change
it on the click of a button but before
we even do that I think it would be
useful for us to use the value in the
search parameter to filter down our list
of Star Wars characters so that it only
displays the type that is in the search
parameters at any given time so that's
going to be the next thing that we learn
but actually at this point let's get
your hands on the keyboard let's take
the small portion that we've learned so
far we'll apply it to the van life app
and then we'll come back to this and
learn how to do the filtering
you know sometimes when I'm watching a
tutorial with somebody else doing all
the work I find myself getting lost a
little bit in their code base so this is
a silly kind of intro challenge but the
first thing I want you to do is to try
and figure out where it is we're going
to be implementing this search params
challenge remember the idea is
eventually we're going to add buttons
here to our vans page so that when we
click them it will alter the search
params and filter our list so that it
only shows Vans of a specific type like
we have the Vans for the simple the
rugged and the luxury types so if you
need to pause and find the correct file
you can do that or you can just maybe
say it out loud or something to show
that you know where it is we're going to
be implementing this so go ahead and do
that now
because we are doing this work on the
Vans page we are going over to the Vans
component here and hopefully you were
able to find that or at least understand
that that's where we would be doing the
work again the only reason I had you do
that is because I know that for me
personally sometimes I realize I've
gotten this far in a code base while
watching a tutorial and then kind of
realize I actually get lost in it pretty
easily because I wasn't the one doing
all the work I guess that's a little
different in this course because
hopefully you've been typing along okay
so we have our real challenge here and
that is to access the search params
inside of this component I guess an
important distinction to make between
what we're doing here with search params
and what we have done in the past with
state is to understand that state just
lives inside of this component whereas
the search parameters there's something
that lives up in the URL so even though
we are going to be accessing the search
params here in this component we're not
actually instantiating or initializing
search params here instead the search
params variable is simply going to read
the per parameters that are up in the
URL we can modify the URL and we will be
modifying the URL from this component
but it's a little bit different than
State since state is just living in
memory for this component only anyway I
don't know if that clears anything up or
makes it worse but hopefully that helps
so I've laid out some steps for the
challenge you need to use the hook that
we just learned about from react rat or
Dom set a variable and use it to set a
variable called search params that
search params object will have a
property you can use to grab the value
of the type parameter and I want you to
save that to a variable that we call
type filter and then simply log the
value of type filter to the console now
remember currently as it stands right
now in this recording we don't have a
query up here so don't be surprised if
you get to the third step and you log
the value of type filter and it isn't
what you might think it would be to test
it out you can simply type up into the
URL question mark type equals and then
whatever you want all right you should
have every thing you need pause now and
work on the challenge
all right let's get started we will just
do this right above our state
declaration and we'll create a new
search params object here so search
params and we're not yet at the point of
using set search params but we might as
well do it now because we know we are
going to use it in the future so we will
call use search params and I need to
import that from react router Dom then
maybe right below our state let's buy
some space here and we'll say type
filter is equal to search params and
remember this is an instance of the
Native Constructor URL search params
that comes with a number of methods that
we just get for free like dot get dot
get is where we specify as a string the
name of the key in the key value pairs
of our search params and it should
return the value at that key of type so
I'll go ahead and console.log type
filter and again because we don't have a
query string in our URL this I think
will be null is what we discovered yeah
so it's null and now I can test it out
by putting in the URL question mark type
equals and it really doesn't matter I'll
just say blah blah blah hit enter and
there it is in our case notice that
we're getting it twice and that's
because we are rendering the component
we're grabbing the search param of type
we're console logging it and then our
use effect is running it's going and
getting the data and then it's setting
state so it's re-rendering this
component which is then running our code
again that's nothing to be concerned
about right now okay great work the next
thing we'll be doing is going back to
our silly Little Star Wars characters
app and we will apply the search
parameter to filtering the array
a notable thing that we are doing here
is we are not using state in order to
maintain the information about the
filter or the filtered down list of
characters or eventually the Vans but
instead the filtering and the getting of
the parameter and everything this is all
happening right here at the top of our
component notice it's also not happening
inside of a use effect or anything like
that the process of getting a search
param is really fast and the process of
filtering down in this example the list
of characters is also really fast and so
this isn't something that necessarily
needs to happen as a side effect inside
of a use effect in react instead if we
just put it here at the top level then
every time this component re-renders it
will redo this work and that's not that
big of a deal we don't need to worry at
this point in over optimizing this
because it's not showing us any
performance problems so here we're
creating our character elements which is
what Char LS is short for and it's
simply taking the full list of Star Wars
characters up here and and mapping over
it to create the jsx elements that we
want to display right here so actually I
want to type out just a quick challenge
for you I want you to think how we might
approach solving this problem of
filtering our list of Star Wars
characters Down based on the type filter
that we just grabbed from the search
params if you want a little extra credit
there's not really extra credit but if
you want to I guess feel extra good
about yourself then you could actually
try to do this for yourself right now we
can see that there is a query in our URL
it says type equals Sith so if you're
able to successfully do this then it
should grab Sith from the URL or from
the search parameters and it should only
show the two Sith characters that we
have one kind of gotcha here is notice
that the type in the object has a
capital s in it whereas the parameter
has a lowercase s that's something that
you will need to take into account when
you're working on this okay pause now
and either just think through how you
might approach solving this problem or
if you're feeling extra confident try
doing it yourself
I'm sure that there are a number of
different ways to solve this problem the
first way that comes to mind for me is
to Simply chain a DOT filter on our Star
Wars characters before we then map over
the array dot filter returns an array
but it will be a more limited array than
what the full array of Star Wars
characters has dot filter returns an
array and then we can just chain the dot
map on top of the array that gets
returned from dot filter if it's easier
to understand you also could just set up
a completely separate array variable
like maybe you call this displayed
characters and that would be equal to
Starwars characters dot filter and then
you could just change this to say we'd
get rid of this filter and we would say
displayed characters so that would also
be a legitimate way to do that actually
in fact you know what I think I am going
to do it this way just because there is
a chance that we have no filter in fact
we know that there will be cases where
we don't have a filter and so I may want
displayed characters to 2 sometimes
equal the full list of Star Wars
characters so that might look something
like this if I say do we have a type
filter first of all so I'll put a
question mark let's actually move it
down to this line if type filter is a
value in other words it's in our case
either Sith or Jedi then displayed
characters will be equal to the full
list of Starwars characters dot filter
and we'll figure this part out in just a
second but otherwise it will just equal
Star Wars characters okay let's figure
out our filter that filter takes a
function we're going to have access to
each one of the characters in this
function we need to return true or false
if we return true then it will keep this
current character in the new array and
if we return false it won't and so we
can say if the character DOT type and
remember these have capital letters so
I'm actually going to say character.type
dot to lowercase if that is equal to our
type filter then this will evaluate to
true and therefore this character will
get saved into the new array of
displayed characters and we already
switched this to say displayed
characters so let me clear up this
challenge text add a little space here
and we already have type equals Sith
let's see if this works I'll hit refresh
cool look at that okay we have just the
two Sith Star Wars characters in our
list I should be able to change Sif or
type equals if to type equals Jedi and
hit enter and awesome okay everything is
filtering down just like we'd think
let's test it out without a search
parameter so I'll delete the search
parameter up there and we have everybody
awesome work I really hope that went
okay of course as always if it didn't
just go back and try it again and
actually even if you were able to do it
try scrubbing back to the beginning
before we had any of this code and try
doing it again anyway next up is for us
to apply this concept of filtering based
on the search parameters to our van Life
app
okay your challenge for this one is to
well basically do exactly what we just
did but here in our van Life app in fact
it's very very similar so hopefully you
grasped what we just worked on because
now it's your turn to get your hands on
the keyboard pause now and work on this
challenge
well let's just do exactly what we just
did we'll create a const displayed bands
and that's going to check if type filter
is a thing and if it is then we will use
Vans this is the full array of Vans dot
filter we'll look at each van and if the
van DOT type is equal to the type filter
then it will return true and that will
become part of the array in displayed
Vans otherwise if type filter is null in
other words there is no type equals
whatever up there then we just want to
have the full list of Vans and then when
we're mapping over it we will just put
our displayed Vans again sometimes this
will be the full array of Vans and
sometimes it will be a filter down array
we'll just use displayed bands to map
over that and create our van elements
don't think anything else needs to
change let's clear this up
and I already have type equals simple so
let's hit save I'll scroll down a little
so we can see that there's more than
just the simple ones cool so I think the
next logical thing for us to do is not
have to actually type it up into the URL
but have a way that we can click some
buttons and have that change the query
that's in the URL there's actually a
couple different ways we can handle this
so that's what we'll be learning about
next
the simplest way that I can think of to
add search parameters is to Simply use a
link element at this point we're pretty
familiar with using link to send us to a
specific path like if we were going to
the slash about page or something like
that but we also can use a link to not
specify A New Path that we're going to
but instead to specify a query so I can
simply say question mark type equals
Jedi and have this link be when it gets
clicked the way that we add the query to
the top I'll just create a duplicate of
this we'll say Sith Sith
let's hit save ah and we do need to
import link so we will import link right
here let's try that again okay it's not
much to look at but we do have these
links here and when I click Jedi well
everything's just kind of working we can
see that it put the question mark type
equals Jedi in the URL and because it
started with a question mark react
router knew that it wasn't changing
routes per se it's still the slash
characters route but it is adding some
search params and because these search
parameters changed the component
re-rendered it re-ran our code that got
the type and it did the filtering and
everything like that so again it's just
kind of working out of the box by adding
question mark type equals Jedi or type
equals let's hit Sith and we can see
that's working as well now let me throw
in a quick challenge here
okay your challenge is to see if you can
add another link just right here next to
the other ones that clears out the
search params so in other words right
now I'm filtered down by type equals
Sith I should be able to press a button
or a link that says clear and have it
show me everything in the list again I
haven't specifically taught how to do
this but I'm hoping that your intuition
will kick in and you'll be able to
figure it out so pause now and give this
a shot
I found actually two different ways to
do this and I'm sure there's plenty more
but I'm just going to duplicate the link
we'll change this to say clear and one
way I found that works is just to say
that the 2 is equal to an empty string
we'll hit save I click clear and that
clears out the search parameters and
shows everything again the other way
that I thought about doing this is to
say that I want this to go to Dot and if
you remember dot represents the current
path or the current route so let's hit
save I'll hit Sith to filter down and
then we'll hit clear again and sure
enough that seems to work as well I'm
honestly not sure which one I prefer so
I think either way is going to be fine
I'll probably just leave it here as a
DOT because I suppose you could argue
that it's a little more explicit as to
what we're doing we're saying just go to
the current path without anything else
attached to it okay that was fairly
straightforward but there are a couple
caveats that I want to talk about with
this method of using the link so that's
what we'll be doing in the next scrim
okay let's learn what we just applied by
adding some links to our van Life app so
that we can filter the Vans by their
type for now the Links are just going to
have a hard-coded two string like we
just practiced and the different types
are going to be simple luxury and rugged
I've given you some class names to use
because we're not focusing on the CSS
here so I've already written some CSS so
for each of those links add a class name
of Van Dash type and then the type of
that link so if it's the simple link
it'll say simple if it's the luxury link
it'll say luxury and so forth for the
link that will clear all the filters its
class name should be van type space
clear Dash filters give this your best
shot I'm sure you can do it if you do
get stuck we're going to walk through it
in just a minute but of course as always
you can reach out to the community for
help too oh and one last thing is you'll
add your links right here between this
div that I created so right where I'm
putting my cursor okay pause now and add
those filtering links to our van Life
app
okay I can see that we already have link
imported so we should just be able to
create some links and while I'm at it
I'll just add the class names now so our
class name is going to be equal to
van Dash type space and then this is the
one we'll change here we're saying
simple
let's move this onto its own lines and
we'll just leave it like that and we'll
give it a two property of question mark
type equals simple and let's just start
out there let's see what it looks like
okay and let's see if it works so I
click looks like some styling needs to
be fixed uh we'll click that okay we get
type equals simple and we only show the
simple Vans awesome let's go ahead and
copy this link we'll create one for
luxury and one for rugged and I guess
one for clearing the filters and we'll
just make some of these little changes
like this
and then for clearing out the search
parameters we will just hit that the 2
is the current route and this will be
clear
filters
and this will say clear filters or
filter okay let's hit save
okay yeah The Styling is uh still
needing some work but we can see that
everything is working okay sometimes
when you're developing it feels a little
bit like a gamble you think you've done
everything right and then you find some
major bugs something still a little off
by The Styling let me take a look at it
ah okay there was a couple Styles so I
forgot to copy over hopefully that
didn't throw anybody off too much but
the styles are one thing the
functionality is another and the
functionality is on point it's working
great okay so now we've learned how to
set a query string using a link element
in react router but you might have
noticed that we created this Setter
function when we're initializing our
search params we have this set search
params function but we're not actually
using it anywhere if we're just going to
link directly to a hard-coded version of
our search params then we don't
necessarily need that search param
Setter function however there are
instances where you may need to use it
so we are going to refactor what we have
and learn about using the set search
params function that we have here
let's take a look at another way that we
can set the search parameters in our app
the way we have our link set up is a
really really simple way to do this
there's some caveats with it that we're
going to talk about soon but first I
want to comment these out actually I'll
move them outside of my components so I
can comment them out and I'm going to
show you another way instead of linking
to the query parameter that we want we
can use the state Setter function that
we received when we initialized our
search params so this function here set
search params just like in use state is
a Setter where we can tell it what the
new search params are going to be so let
me create a couple buttons here
okay the form factor is going to be a
little bit different so I'll hit save
and we have buttons instead of links of
course we could style these however we
want so this time around because buttons
are not part of the react router
ecosystem like link is we are simply
going to use an on click event handler
in order to call our set search params
function so I'll create an on click for
each of these and these will have a
callback function and that function is
going to run set search params just like
with use State the setter function can
either take a new value for the search
params which will completely replace the
old value or it can take a callback
function first we'll look at just
passing in a new value one thing I've
learned with set search params is that
it's very flexible we can pass any value
into here that the URL search params
this object here can take and if you
look at the documentation here I think
there's four different types of
parameters that you could pass in for it
to generate search params one of the
ways that you can initialize new search
params is by passing in a string that
represents the new search params you
want so this is actually almost
identical to what we had with our links
in the URL search params object is smart
enough to figure out if there's a
question mark at the beginning so it
actually doesn't matter you can either
say type equals and then we'll say Jedi
this one will say Sith and then this one
will actually just say we want to set
the search params to an empty string or
I could put question marks here and it's
smart enough to figure it out so let's
see with the question marks
Jedi shows Jedi we see in the URL type
equals Jedi Sith is the same Clear
clears them out and without the question
marks it does the same
okay so yes this works to pass in a
string like this however I don't
oftentimes see this string
initialization used very often more
commonly I will see a record
initialization or what you could just
think of it as being an object
initialization and this is very similar
where the object has keys and values
just like our search parameters have
keys and values and so I can say that
the type is going to be and then I can
pass in my Jedi Sith and then here we're
just going to pass in an empty object
which says I don't want any search
parameters
okay we'll hit save
Jedi we see that that translated into
the query string just like we would have
expected and that's happening by the URL
search params object under the hood
Sith does the same thing and clear clear
smell now truth be told there's actually
other ways that we can initialize this
exact same thing each one has their own
use case but more often than not if
you're typing it in you're probably
going to see people using an object like
this so that's what we're going to stick
with okay time to practice this let's go
over to the van Life app and you'll get
your chance to practice
okay challenge time again your task is
to change the links that we have into
buttons and to use these set search
params function which remember we
instantiated up here to set the search
params for the filtering of our vans
make sure you keep all the class names
exactly the way they are pause now and
work on the challenge
okay this should be pretty
straightforward let's go ahead and
select all of our links we'll select the
link to the clear filter option as well
and we will change these two buttons and
then instead of having a to property
we'll select all those we're going to
actually let's leave the string there
for now we'll say that when this button
is
clicked so on click is going to be equal
to a function we'll need to run that
inside of curly braces and I can't just
say set search params right here because
I would need to call it and that means
it will get called as soon as the page
loads not as soon as the button is
clicked we need to pass a function and
let's go ahead and move looks like my
strings are a little off that's okay
we'll make it so that
this string goes inside here and then
we'll move this string inside actually
this is just going to be an empty string
remember the dot string like this like
we had with the link before that's
something specific to react router that
it's doing under the hood so set search
params is actually using the URL search
params Constructor and that won't I
don't think know what to do with having
a string of a dot in there so we'll just
have it be an empty string again when
we're passing in a string we can include
or not include the question mark let's
just leave it there because we're
actually going to change this in just a
second anyway so let's hit save and type
simple type luxury type rugged and gone
perfect now like we learned the string
is not probably the most common way to
do this although it works just great
instead a little more commonly you'll
see an object passed in here we'll
actually just manipulate the string that
we had and turn this into an object
like this and then for here
we'll pass in an empty object which
means that we have no search parameters
when we set the search parameters all
right let's hit save
and yet again it's working like we would
expect great work
now there's actually a major caveat to
the way that we've been doing our query
parameters so far and let me show you
what I mean so up here I'm going to
create a new query parameter that has
nothing to do with what we've been doing
so far I'll say name equals Jill we'll
hit enter question mark name equals Jill
that has no impact on the filtering of
this part of the app well and we know
that it has no impact on any part of the
app at this point but it's so common to
have more than one query parameter each
one possibly having to do with a
different part of your app or a
different page in your app however the
way that we've structured this right now
because we're hard coding a question
mark type equals Jedi or Sith and over
here we're hard coding this object that
just has one key and value in it as soon
as I click one of these buttons or these
links I will lose the context of the
query parameter name equals Jill so if I
hit Sif now it's changed the query
parameter to type equals Sith because
that's what we've hard-coded and rest
assured the exact same thing would have
happened if I'd clicked the buttons
instead and the clear your buttons would
do the exact same thing it clears out
any search parameters that you might
have not just the ones that you care
about in this specific component so if
for some reason you know for a certainty
that you will not have any other query
parameters in your project then the way
that I've shown you here so far will
work perfectly however for the purposes
of education and an exercising
completeness I'm going to show you some
methods that you might use in order to
merge your query parameters with
existing query parameters instead of
completely replacing them so we'll do
that in the next scrim
the main reason I think I want to show
you how I figured out to do this is
because I actually struggled with this
for a long time and I don't even mean
when I first started coding I mean just
as I Was preparing these lessons I was
really trying to figure out the best way
to do this and I think I've come up with
a good way but a caveat to that is that
it's not the only way there are
certainly a thousand different ways that
someone could solve this problem so I'm
going to split this into two parts the
first part is how we can generate a
query string like we see here in our
links so that it will merge any existing
query parameters with the one that we're
trying to add and an important thing to
know about that is we won't even be
using the set search params for that
we'll truly just be using vanilla
JavaScript in a sort of helper utility
function that we'll create right here
and the second part is how we can do
that using these set search params
because there's some gotchas with using
the set search params method that
tripped me up for quite a bit of time so
let's start with how to generate a query
string like this this does require us to
to understand the URL search parameters
Constructor a little bit but it's not
too bad it's just vanilla JavaScript the
idea is that instead of hard coding a
string here we're going to call a
function but this time because the two
prop is not an event handler like on
click is we can't pass it a function
like this because it will just never get
called instead we are going to run a
function as soon as this component loads
and that function is going to generate a
string which will get put in its place
inside of the two prop so let's get rid
of this callback function and maybe we
call this generate or gen new search
param string it's kind of a mouthful and
I'm going to make it so that this
function will take a new key and a new
value
and in the case of the Jedi link we're
going to say that the key is type and
the value is Jedi keep in mind I haven't
written this function yet so nothing's
going to work quite yet but let's go
ahead and copy this
to this one and here
we will say what we really want to do is
change the type to null or in other
words we'll just remove the type
property from the search params entirely
okay let's actually create this function
so I'll say function gen search params
this is going to take a key and a value
like we mentioned and what we're going
to do is create a new set of search
params and I'm going to do that by using
the new URL search params Constructor
keep in mind this has nothing to do with
react router this is completely outside
of the purview of react router at this
point the only thing we will use is
we're going to initialize our new URL
search params with the value of the old
search params we didn't talk about this
before but you might remember I
mentioned that URL search params is very
flexible in how you can initialize it
and you can take another URL search
params object and use that to initialize
your new URL search params so that's
what we're doing here and then all we're
going to do is use those methods that we
briefly mentioned like dot set and Dot
delete in order to alter the search
params object that we just created now
we do have a couple different options
for Value it could either be a string or
it could be the value of null and so
we're going to check for that we'll say
if there's no value or maybe more
specifically if the value is equal to
null
then we're going to use the method dot
delete on the search params object again
this isn't something that I've taught
per se I'm just showing you one possible
way to do this maybe I'm teaching this
more to solidify it for my own
understanding since this was such a
struggle for me to grasp okay and for
the delete method we're supposed to pass
a string of the key that we're trying to
delete we know that it's going to be
type down here but since we're passing
that in as the value of key or the
parameter of key so we'll just say SP
dot delete key if the value is not null
we'll say else then we want to use a
method called set and set is going to
take two parameters it takes the key and
the value in our case this will say set
the search parameter of key equal to
whatever the value is that we passed in
so the key that we passed in will be the
key the value that we passed in will be
the value now we need to return
something from this function because
it's running as soon as the component
loads and we know that we want it to
return a string that has a question mark
at the beginning let's go ahead and
console.l log
sp.2 string this is another method that
we mentioned and we will see what that
generates for us again it should run as
soon as we refresh the page
okay we get type equals Jedi oh I forgot
to change this one to Sith let's do that
okay we get type equals Jedi or type
equals Sith now and so we want to return
that let's go ahead and return
sp.2string but we also want it to start
with a question mark so let's just go
ahead and put that into a template
literal we'll say question mark and then
we'll interpret the value of sp.2string
there okay let's hit save
let's click on the buttons are not quite
ready but let's hit well they should
still work like they were before
okay so the links are working just like
they were before but now let's go ahead
and add name equals Bob
and I'll click the link for Jedi and
look at that it actually concatenated
the Ampersand type equals Jedi on top of
the name equals Bob now let's go ahead
and hit Sith just to make sure that
that's working and then we'll hit clear
and sure enough it only got rid of the
type property on our search params okay
again this is not something specific to
react router but because it was such a
struggle for me I really want to at
least have some reference to how you
could do this in case you run into this
problem so that you don't have to spend
three or four days down a crazy Rabbit
Hole trying to figure out how to do this
in the end I guess that's a little
disappointing because this isn't a whole
lot of code to solve this problem but
that's okay sometimes in the pursuit of
Education that's just what happens okay
in the next section let's actually
tackle how we might do this using the
buttons and the set search params Setter
function
okay let's tackle doing this in our
buttons as well I mentioned a few times
how the use search params Hook is very
similar to the use statehook from react
and it's not just in that it returns an
array with two items that include the
value and a function for setting the
value but more deeply the function for
setting the value can take two different
kinds of parameters just like in use
state it can either take a replacement
value for the state or it can take a
callback function and that callback
function will receive the previous state
so that you can use it to make changes
to it let's see what that looks like
we're going to need a little bit more
room than just doing this inline so
below our gen new search param string
function we're going to create a
function that's called maybe handle
filter change
we'll just get rid of everything here
and actually we are going to need to
take a parameter we'll probably call
this the new filter or the maybe new
type and we will change everything here
yeah I think that's right and we'll say
handle
filter change parentheses and then we're
going to pass in the new type we'll say
is this one is Jedi
and then we'll just do the same for
these other ones
this time I'll remember to change this
one to Sith
and here we will pass in null
it might have been Overkill to pass in
both the type parameter and the actual
value parameter or the key and value up
here since this function is currently
living in the place where the only thing
we're changing is type I guess I wrote
it so that we could eventually move this
function out to some kind of utility
folder and theoretically use it across
the entire application in other
circumstances other than type maybe just
for the sake of being similar I'll do
the same thing here so we'll say we're
going to pass in the actual key of the
key value pair and then we will not just
take the new type but we'll take the key
as well and what the heck let's make
this more generic too we'll just call it
value okay back to what I was saying
these Setter functions so we called it
set search params we were just using it
where we just passed in a new object
that represented the replacement for the
params but we found that that completely
overwrote any other parameters that we
might have just like the state Setter
function with u State we can pass in a
function and this function will receive
a previous version of the params because
it's an arrow function and we just have
one parameter I can get rid of those
surrounding parentheses and we will do
something very similar up here we'll
check if the incoming value is equal to
null
now this is where the set search params
Setter function diverges pretty
dramatically from the state Setter
function in the state Setter function we
would never take the state that we
received here and make any direct
modifications to it instead we would
always create a copy of it somehow and
only use its old values in order to
determine the new values and we would
return a completely new state as far as
I can tell and I've confirmed this with
the way that react router has some of
their internal tests set up it's
completely okay for us to modify the
previous params object so in this case
I'm going to say if the value is null
then we'll run previous params.delete
and it'll be the key whatever key we
pass in
if the value is not null then we'll say
previous
params.set whatever key and then
whatever value and at the end because in
this case we're not trying to turn it
into a string we're trying to set it as
a URL search params object we're just
going to return the previous params
again this feels a little icky to me
because I'm used to having the state
Setter B where you never modify the
original object but as far as I can tell
this is okay and I think that's all the
code we need let's hit save again our
links were working before we still have
the question mark name Nicholas Bob up
there let's go ahead and hit Sith okay
it appended it to this string that's
great same with Jedi and clear clears
out the type but it does not clear out
the name now you could go even further
down this Rabbit Hole the truth is
search params can have the same key
multiple times so for whatever reason if
I wanted to I could say name equals Bob
and name equals Joe or type equals Jedi
and type equals if and the way that
we've written this it would would clear
out okay I just had to confirm it yeah
it would actually clear out both types
in fact let's just see it in action well
let me start out type equals Jedi we'll
get rid of name equals Bob just to buy
some space okay question mark type
equals Jedi Ampersand type equals Sith
so you can see that okay it's got both
the clear function we'll just clear both
of them out so that might not be ideal
you would have to get much more
complicated to actually search through
the params object and only delete the
type that you're trying to delete but
now we're venturing into a realm that's
much past the scope of this course in
fact we might have already done that a
little bit here but that's okay it's all
great learning and hopefully I can save
someone out there at least a few hours
trying to struggle with understanding
this with that behind us let's go back
to the van Life app I'm going to
implement some of these changes for you
since it is like I mentioned a little
bit outside the scope of this course and
you know what let's lighten it up a
little bit we'll have a pretty simple
conditional rendering challenge so
that's what we'll do in the next scrim
okay we'll actually be doing two
challenges the first one is to
conditionally render this clear filter
button only if there is a type parameter
currently being applied in the search
parameters we've been working a lot down
here at the bottom of the file and
changing the search parameters down here
but remember every time we navigate to a
new URL even if it's the same base URL
with a different search parameter this
entire component is getting re-rendered
which means we have this value up here
called type filter which will always be
up to date with the newest filter that
we've applied so understanding that
conditionally render just this button
and then we will jump into the next
challenge right after that so pause now
and work on challenge number one
because this whole component is getting
re-rendered we have this type filter
variable which will tell us if the type
is existing so it'll either be simple
luxury rugged or it will be null if
there is no type parameter in our search
parameters so I can conditionally render
this clear button by first wrapping it
in a set of curly braces
and we'll just use some shorthand here
we'll say if type filter exists it's got
a value then render this button commonly
we will put something like a set of
parentheses around the component like
that
and then we'll say otherwise render null
so just don't render anything there okay
let's clean up the formatting a little
bit I'll put a little space here too in
case that's easier to read and for some
reason I want to put this on the same
line I don't know if that's better or
worse but it should be clear either way
okay let's go ahead and hit save the
clear filter should disappear perfect
because we don't have any parameters
right now and then when I click on these
it appears awesome
okay let me type out the challenge
number two for you okay one of the
things that's added in our CSS is if
there is a filter applied then that
color that you see when we hover will
actually stay on the button as long as
that filter is applied currently it's
not doing that because it's only showing
that on Hover however there's a class
called selected that I created in the
CSS that should make it so that it will
stay that color if that filter is
applied well more specifically if that
class exists on the button so your task
is to conditionally render the selected
class name if the type filter is equal
to the value that the button wants that
filter to be I hope that makes sense I
gave you a little bit of a hint here
since it's a little bit difficult to
explain but notice here that I'm using
template strings but down here we are
not we're just using regular quotation
marks that's something that you will
need to change oops not there here okay
pause now and work on Challenge number
two
okay this line is going to get a little
bit long in case you're working on a
small screen I'm just going to squish
this which clearly I haven't optimized
my styles to handle a really really
small screen like that so because we're
going to be interpreting some JavaScript
inside of this string we're going to use
string interpolation so I'm going to
select these class names and we'll
change this to a template string and oh
I need to surround this with curly
braces awesome okay and now I'm going to
stick in my dollar sign curly braces so
I can say if type filter is equal to and
then we will just grab these values here
simple luxury or rugged
then we will apply the selected class
but otherwise we'll leave it as an empty
string you know what just in case that
is a little too wide let's go ahead and
just put this on the next line like that
okay first let's hit save
and well this is good news the simple is
already highlighted because when I hit
save we had clicked the type equals
simple before okay luxury rugged and
clear now just by way of information one
thing that I tried to do was use a nav
link to accomplish this same thing but
it turns out the nav link does not care
about your search parameter so when I
used a navalink and I accessed the is
active property on the render Prop class
name and tried to use that instead of
the type filter equals the simple it
just didn't work well what happened is
all of them were highlighted because
this route Vans is active and the two
prop was sending them to the same path
it just was changing the query string so
just a little extra information for you
as if there wasn't already enough to try
and digest in this course all right at
this point we have just a few more
little odds and ends that we need to add
to our app so we're going to start
working on those
check it out I found a loose end that I
just forgot to fix when we were learning
about relative paths because here we
have a link that still has an absolute
path I actually also found one over in
the host Vans page which you'll go check
out next so I'm going to make you make
these changes change the absolute path
in this link and the one over in
hostfans.jsx to be relative paths pause
now and work on these many challenges
we know it's an absolute path because it
starts with a slash and so we had to
give the entire route all the way up to
the ID here but we don't need to do that
because we're already living within the
context of Slash Vans and so we can just
get rid of Slash bands and then the
Slash and we can just have the van ID
however I can actually take this even
one step further if we look closely at
the server the IDS are strings already
and so rather than create a template
string and then just the only thing I'm
rendering is the value of the ID we can
just get rid of our template strings
entirely and say van dot ID like this we
can hit save and we can see that these
are working just like they were before
okay let's clean this up and let's head
over to the host Vans page we're just
doing the same thing so I'm going to
clean this up too and here we have slash
host slash Vans slash ID and we can just
do exactly what we did before and just
display the ID because again this
component is living within the context
of Slash host slash Vans already and so
the link is relative to say just append
the ID on the end of the URL we'll hit
save go over to host Vans and clicking
on any of these okay works great okay
there's at least one more loose end we
need to clean up so we'll do that next
the design did show this back to all
Vans link inside the host Vans detail
page and we already implemented that
however the design also shows that
there's supposed to be one on the
regular full list of Vans detail page
you can see it here we're supposed to
have back to all Vans now there's
actually a bunch of different ways to
implement navigation with react router
and we've already seen using the
relative let's see where is it host van
detail this relative dot dot path which
takes us up one level and we talked
about the relative equals path which
makes it so that it's a back button
relative to the path or rather it takes
us up one level on the path but not one
level in the route hierarchy as we have
here so one thing we could maybe think
to do is go here just grab this link
we'll come to our host Vans no our vans
detail page and then just right here
above where the van is supposed to go
we'll just stick our link one thing
that's I guess kind of nice about this
is we have relative paths and so I think
this should just work now we have back
to all Vans we click it and sure enough
it takes us back to slash fans okay we
could just stop there but let's try to
think of the user's workflow here maybe
they're on the list of Vans page and
they filter by let's say luxury they
click on Good Old Reliable red and they
maybe look at this and say Ah that's not
for me I'm gonna go back now when they
click back what is it going to take them
back to well let's see we click back to
all Vans and now we're back at the slash
Vans page and they have lost their
filtering of course with only one simple
filter it's not that big of a deal but
if you imagine something like Airbnb
where you set up maybe four or five or
six different filters for what you're
looking for if you were to go into one
and then click a link that said back and
it just took you back and removed all of
your filters that's not a great user
experience well it turns out there's a
number of different ways that we can
Implement how to make it so that this
takes us back to just the vans that we
had filtered already by luxury so that's
the next challenge we're going to be
working on but don't worry it won't be
too difficult that's what we're going to
start working on next
okay so we know that we want to be able
to filter the list click on one of the
Vans and then have some information that
shows us what the filter used to be on
the last page like I mentioned there's
usually a lot of different ways to do
things for example one way that we could
accomplish this is take the search
parameter directly from the current URL
and instead of linking to slash van five
in this example we could just tack on
that query string that represents the
search parameters and have it actually
lead us to slash Vans slash Five
question mark type equals luxury and
then when we're on this page we would
have that directly in the search
parameters and we could pull it from the
search parameters and go back to all
vans that said I personally don't love
the semantics of that solution and the
reason is because if I'm looking here at
slash van five I can already tell that
this is a luxury van the query string at
the top that would say type equals
luxury would feel redundant to me
because this represents a single van it
doesn't represent represent a list that
I can filter down and at this point we
could Branch into two different user
experiences let's say you found this
awesome van you're really excited about
it you grab the URL and you want to send
it to your friend if it has that query
string in there then theoretically they
could come to this page and they could
click go back to all Vans and it would
take them back to just the luxury Vans
because it's been filtered and if that's
your desired use case then that's the
best way to go the URL is the only thing
that will persist from one user to the
next however my argument would be that
that's probably not as common so for
this instance let's assume that we
really don't care about keeping the
filtering when we're sharing the URL to
another friend and by that I mean on the
detail page when we go back to all Vans
if we filter it by luxury we probably do
want to share only the list of luxury
Vans when we're trying to decide what
van we're choosing with a friend but
maybe I'm making too many assumptions we
talked about earlier how the search
parameters are great for something
that's going to persist especially like
just said from one user to the next but
I want you to pause for a second and see
if you can remember what is the
structure or maybe what is the tool that
we can use if we want to save some
information while we're still here on
our page but we don't necessarily care
if it's going to survive transferring
the URL to another person that's where
State comes in and in this case I'm not
talking about react state I'm talking
about something called history State and
don't let that be scary the truth is the
browser has the ability to save some
kind of state between one link or one
URL and the next and react router has
made it very easy for us to add things
to that link state so first what we're
going to do is add some state to our
link we're here in our vans page this is
the Vans list page and the idea is to
say we want to link to the individual
van but we want to pass some additional
information to that page so the first
thing we'll do is see how to pass that
state to the next page and in the next
scrim we'll learn how to you could say
catch that state and make use of it and
this here is actually so simple it's not
even challenge worthy when I'm linking
to a resource I can simply add another
prop to my link called State and I could
set the state to whatever I want it
could be a string I could just say
whatever and when I get to my next route
the van ID page I can grab that state
and it will be the string whatever I
don't prefer to pass raw values like
this in my state I think it reads A
little better to pass an object and so
I'm going to use my curly braces to get
into JavaScript and then I'm going to
pass in an object and the idea here is
we want to pass the information
regarding the current type filter over
to the next route so that that route
when we get to say one of these Vans can
grab that information about the type
filter knowing which type it was just
filtering from and can change the link
here so that it goes back to just the
for example luxury bands now I could
just pass a property maybe called type
and say that it's going to be equal to
whatever the current type filter is
remember type filter is coming from the
search params and so it's either going
to be just the plane string simple
luxury rugged or I guess it was null if
there are no filters but let's think one
step ahead if the idea is that I don't
lose all of my query strings when I go
into the van and then click back to all
Vans I'm going to try and future proof
this a little bit so if I do have other
query strings like we had name equals
Joe
and I go also to rugged so now I have
two parameters I have name and type we
go into an individual van when I click
back to all vins I don't just want to
have the type filter there because maybe
eventually we have this sorted by Price
or filtered by Price within a certain
range or whatever other filters or sorts
we might have so yeah let's try and
future proof this instead of just
passing the type by itself I'm going to
take the entire query string and pass
that down so let's get our object back
and maybe what I'll do is let's just
call it search params and actually I
could just leave it like this I could
just say search params is the search
params value that we have this is the
URL search params object but honestly I
don't think the van detail page needs
the entire object I think really what it
needs is just the query string this
one's just a judgment call it doesn't
really matter too much maybe I will just
call this search and then we'll say the
value is search params.tostring again
and it probably just depends on the
needs in your scenario but the point is
this should take the entire search
params in its stringified version and
pass it along to the next route that
we're linking to this is beneficial
again if we have multiple search
parameters not just one filtering by
type and just in case you forgot let's
console.log search params dot to string
so you have an idea of the value that
I'm actually passing in the state here
let's save open up the console and of
course right now there is nothing will
hit luxury okay so it's type equals
luxury if I add other ones like and name
equals Joe
now we have type equals luxury and name
equals Joe just note that it doesn't
have the question mark at the beginning
so we will need to add that manually we
could either do it here or I'm just
going to do it on the other side of the
equation in the next scrum we'll talk
about the van detail page and how we can
grab the state that we're bringing in by
adding it to the link to that page
okay so we are linking to the van detail
Page by its ID and we're passing this
state along with the link so let's go
over to Van detail and learn how we can
receive the state from the incoming link
that sent us to this page doing so will
require us to learn a new hook called
use location and I'm going to be
perfectly honest you can probably tell
from the screenshot here the
documentation on use location I think
has a little bit of work to be done but
nonetheless I link to it here just in
case it gets updated or maybe I'll
submit a PR and actually update their
documentation to have more useful
examples so I'm going to import use
location use location is more like the
the use params where it doesn't bring in
an array like we have with you state or
with use search params so I'm going to
say const location equals use location
and this location object is well it's
just that it's an object so let's go
ahead and console log it and we need to
go over to the detail page to run that
code okay and you can see it's an object
with a number of pretty helpful
properties pathname gives us the
absolute path to where we currently are
in our routes search would have a query
string there if this page had a query
string in fact I can see that by saying
question mark name equals Bob hit enter
okay so now we can see the path name is
slash van five the search is question
mark name equals Bob and that came from
the query up there of course you can
also see that the state says it's null
and that's because I navigated to a new
page by adding this query string so let
me actually go back in the browser and I
guess this brings up a really good point
you can see that just by hitting back I
was able to bring back the search state
if you look in the console there's a
property called State and it has an
object with a search property as a
reminder that's what we created we chose
to call it search this isn't something
browser specific the property State
however is something specific from react
router but the cool thing is I was able
to hit the back button and bring that
state back even though it did a refresh
of my app and in fact even if I do
refresh the app you can see the state is
maintained this is what I meant by
saying that the browser has its own
internal ability to maintain some kind
of state based on where you are in the
app and that's all react router is using
under the hood now there is a limitation
to this if I copy this URL and I send it
to a friend their browser does not have
that same state there's nothing in the
URL that's hidden or secret about the
state that I'm trying to maintain it's
something specific in our browser in
fact even if I were to open a different
browser and use the same URL that state
would just disappear in this case though
that's probably okay because if I'm in a
new browser or I send the link to my
friend they may not necessarily care to
go back to all the luxury Vans like what
I'm trying to handle here okay so by
using the use location hook we have
access to the state which is an object
that has a search property because
that's how we set it up in the Vans list
page so that sounds like a pretty good
time for a challenge now
okay your challenge is to modify the
link to prop so that it can send the
user back to the previous page with the
search parameters included if and this
is important if they exist like the
little note says here we may not have
anything in the state if there were no
filters applied maybe I came to that
page and you can see in this case it
says the state search is an empty string
or as we discovered we may not be
sending State at all if I were to add a
random parameter up here say name equals
Bob then state is null so we don't even
have a state.search keeping that in mind
you'll want to make sure that you code
defensively so that you don't run into a
bug in case that happens okay pause now
and work on this challenge
okay now I did leave you in the dark a
little bit and I'm hoping that you just
had a chance to play with the code to
figure this out yourself but when we
have a relative path like this with just
dot dot I still can say question mark
maybe type equals simple and have that
work so if I hit save I'm just hard
coding this of course for now I'll click
back to all Vans and you'll see that our
simple filter is applied so let's change
this back to luxury of course what this
did is it lost the name equals Bob but
that's because we're hard coding it this
isn't the final solution let's go luxury
we'll click on a van and we have state
DOT search now we have location dot
State actually let me open the console
again location dot state DOT search and
that's going to be the query that we
want to include don't let this be
confused with the location dot search
again that's just whatever search is in
the URL at the current time when this
loads and actually you know what I'm
seeing something now the way that react
router handle search is is including a
question mark at the beginning so for
the sake of consistency I'm going to
make a quick change over here instead of
the value just being the search
params.2string I'm going to have it
include a question mark so we'll just do
this I didn't expect you to figure that
one out that's just a choice that I'm
making okay so let's try this again
we'll go back to all Vans let's maybe
hit refresh we'll change the type to
luxury go over here okay so now our
search has the question mark in it again
not necessary but it seems a little more
consistent to me so because of that I
can just change my to prop and we could
just say this is going to be a template
string and it's going to start with a
dot dot and then include location dot
state DOT search right well not quite
because again there's a possibility that
the value of state is going to be null
if the value of state.search is an empty
string this works fine but if state is
null this is going to throw an error so
what I'm going to do is create a sort of
backup for the
location.state.search just in case it
doesn't exist let's go ahead and save it
we'll call it maybe I don't know we'll
say const search
is equal to
location.state.search and there's a
relatively new feature in JavaScript
that's called optional chaining in fact
it's new enough that scrimp is going to
complain about the syntax but I promise
you it still works and so I can say if
location dot state is a thing then check
for a search property and that value is
going to be the value of my new variable
that I'm setting up but if that doesn't
exist let's just say it's an empty
string that gives me a fallback just in
case location dot states does not exist
my value will be an empty string so I'm
going to take my search and replace well
I guess we can just delete that part and
say the search will go here let's hit
save or close my console to buy some
space let's go back to all Vans and
awesome that took us to type equals
luxury perfect rugged go into one of
them back to all Vans type equals rugged
if you didn't know about optional
chaining or you didn't want to use
optional chaining you could also simply
say something like
location.state and location dot state
DOT search this is usually how it was
done before optional chaining existed in
JavaScript but because optional chaining
does exist even though scrim is going to
complain about the syntax I'm going to
leave it in here what's nice about this
is it should work with any other filters
or queries that we have included in our
URL so if I add back my and name equals
Joe I click on one of the rug Advance
now we have type and name in our queries
we go here and then I say back to all
Vans it's going to maintain both the
type query and the name query all right
that was a lot to take in as always if
you did struggle through this challenge
now that you've seen me do it I
recommend you scrub Back to Before The
Challenge and just try it again on your
own practice really does make perfect
since that one was pretty heavy let's do
a quick challenge that's going to be a
little bit lighter and then we'll be
ready to move on
let's say a product manager comes to you
and says well when a filter is applied
we don't want it to say back to all Vans
we want it to say back to and then the
filter then so back to luxury Vans or
back to simple vans so that's what your
challenge is and I'm not going to give
you too much more information there's
certainly more than one way to do this
but I want you to put on your thinking
Gap and try to figure it out so pause
now and work on the challenge
well one way I could do this is to take
the string let me open my console I
could take the
location.state.search string and try to
just do some regular string manipulation
like split it on the ampersands and then
split it on the equal signs and grab the
one that's after the type or something
like that however because the string is
a query string one way to solve this is
I could create a new instance of URL
search params and then I have access to
the methods like dot get to get the
value of the type param so that's one
way I could solve it another way I could
solve it is in Vans I could just pass
more State through so right now we have
the search I could also say I want to
pass the type in say the type is going
to be equal to and in this case we
already have access to that with type
filter and we put these on their own
lines and then if I do that over in Van
detail I can grab that string by
location.state.type since I've already
got that typed out I might as well just
keep going down this path so we'll hit
save
let's go back to all Vans and just do a
refresh we'll say rugged
okay so now you can see the
location.state is an object that has
search and type so I'll just do
something similar here we'll say const
type is equal to location dot State
question mark DOT type and if that
doesn't exist like for example if
location dot state is null then we'll
just set the type to well actually let's
set it equal to all because we do want
it to say back to all Vans if there is
no filter applied and now I can take
this type and just conditionally render
this word here we'll just say back to
and then put type Vans okay let's see if
this works let me close the console
we'll hit save
okay it says back to rec advance so I
think it's working let's go back we'll
clear the filter we'll go back to one of
them back to all Vans that's great let's
try luxury back to luxury Vans simple
awesome
again we even talked about multiple
different ways that you can solve this
at that point it's just sort of a
JavaScript challenge as a quick recap
passing State through the links can be a
really useful thing okay hopefully that
challenge went okay again review it if
you need to and then when you're ready
we'll move on
a really important part of any
application is being able to give useful
information to people when they come to
a path that doesn't actually exist on
your site sometimes this happens if you
have outdated links within your own site
and they lead to pages that no longer
exist or it might happen if somebody
else links to your site and they either
got the link wrong or again they're
using an outdated link that no longer
exists for example if I'm here and I
type in slash blah blah blah and hit
enter you can see there's really no
useful information on our site because
react router is not handling a blah blah
blah route this is where a good 404 page
comes in and I've seen some really
creative interesting 404 pages but we're
just going to keep it pretty simple for
now so how can we handle this in react
router fortunately it's really easy
there's something called a Splat route
or a catch-all route and that has
everything to do with what you put for
your path here inside of my layout route
because you can see in our example here
we still have the navigation bar and we
still have the footer so that's the
reason I'm choosing to do this as a
nested route inside of my layout I could
if I didn't want to have the navigation
or footer I could have a completely
dedicated 404 page that didn't have
those elements in which case it would go
as a child of routes right here but
let's keep it as a child of our slash
route so I'll create a new route
and a catch-all route is going to be
very similar to if you've ever used a
universal selector or a catch Hall
selector in CSS we're going to use the
asterisk this essentially means if there
are no other routes listed then use this
route which is why it's called a
catch-all it'll catch anything that
doesn't match elsewhere let's go ahead
and put an element that just says maybe
an H1
that says page not found
we're still on the slash blah blah blah
route let's hit save and here we go we
have this is a very basic version of it
but we have a page not found sort of
catch-all here one thing that's really
cool about react router 6 is that it's a
lot more intelligent under the hood
about scoring the paths that we have
based on what the actual text of our URL
is what I mean is that even though our
catch-all path is at the top of our list
of paths I can still navigate around my
site and it's not going to prefer the
first one in the list instead it's going
to give a score under the hood about
which of these paths best matches where
I currently am in my site in the past we
did have to worry about what order we
put things in but we no longer have to
do that now it feels a little bit out of
order for me to put the page not found
first so I'm actually going to bump this
down to the very bottom that'll go right
there
and because react router is really smart
about how it prefers the different paths
that we have available it doesn't really
matter so I can still navigate around my
site just like I was before and if I
were to have a link that sent me to the
wrong place like slash blah blah we'll
get our page not found the way that we
would expect now this isn't very
exciting let's go ahead and as part of a
challenge have you create a bit more of
a polished 404 not found page let me
type that challenge out now
okay I deleted the not found that we had
before so if I hit refresh we'll be back
to a completely blank page and your
challenge is to create an actual 404
page I have the design here of course
you can click on the screenshot to go to
figma but the key components are just an
H1 and a button that will take you back
to the slash route so if you just want
to put those and you don't want to spend
time with CSS that's okay
so you'll create a new component in the
Pages directory you'll add that H1 and
that button from the design and again
you can style it if you want then you'll
need to recreate the catch-all path that
we just created and you will import and
use that not found component that you
just created as the element for that
catch-all route pause now and create our
404 page
foreign okay well let's just go through
one at a time we'll create this new page
called not found.jsx I guess you could
call it 404 as well we'll get it set up
like normal
okay and I'll go ahead and add the
message that we see in the design sorry
the page you were looking for was not
found
okay there's no Styles quite yet but
you'll notice that I also already
imported the link from react router down
because I wanted to send people back to
the home page so I set up the link there
I'll have to make it look like a button
instead of an anchor later now let's
make it so we can actually see this not
found page let's go over to our index
we will import the not found page
and this one is under pages and so I'll
actually move this to be up with the
pages
okay let's add our catch all route again
I prefer this one just a personal
preference to be at the end because that
makes a little more sense to me we'll
see that the path is the asterisk and
the element
is an instantiation of not found okay
we're still on the blah blah route so
when we hit save we should see our new
not found page awesome yeah again this
return to home is not styled at all like
we would expect but that's something
that a magic snap of the fingers can
handle for us just fine so we have our
404 page we're at the blah blah blah
route return to home takes us back to
the home page hopefully this one felt
like a quick win it's fairly easy to
understand there's also some other
things that you can do with these what
they call Splat routes or catch-all
routes but for now we're just going to
use it as our 404 page great work and
I'll see you in the next lesson
we are now basically done with the
majority of the features that we plan to
add to the van Life app but at the time
of this recording there's a relatively
new addition to react router that I want
to make sure we cover and that's
something called the data layer apis
that were introduced in react router
version 6.4 in order for us to really
understand the purpose behind the data
layer apis we need to realize that so
far at least in this app we've basically
been coding what you could call the
happy path the happy path is when you as
a developer just assume that the user is
going to do everything exactly the way
that you expect and everything just goes
perfectly according to plan coding this
way can be great for getting something
up very quickly if you need to show it
off to somebody but it doesn't account
for any errors or other problems that do
occur in the real world so although it's
maybe a little more fun to code the
happy path it's important that we as
seasoned developers will code the sad
path as well and that's where it forces
us to imagine what could possibly go
rung and makes us plan accordingly this
is where we add things like error
handling loading states form validation
and all of those other really useful
user experience things that you have
experienced when you've used real
applications of course you've also
probably used applications that didn't
code this ad path and hopefully
understand that can be a pretty
frustrating experience that we don't
want to give to our users of the van
Life app let me show you an example of
that I've actually altered the server
here to return a 400 level response
that's just a server response that means
that things are broken it's not sending
back what we'd expect the syntax of this
doesn't matter because it's specific to
mirage.js but the point is over in
vans.js when we get to our vans page
we'll click on Vans and you can see we
don't have any kind of useful
information about how the Vans struggled
to load and maybe try again later or try
refreshing the page or anything like
that instead the app just completely
crashed because it is expecting that
this fetch request will work perfectly
it's setting the van's State and then we
just assume that Vans exist and we're
mapping over them as if everything were
just fine and of course that throws a
type error as you can see in the console
which is causing our app to crash so in
the next screencast we're going to see a
little bit of the pain that is required
for us to handle the error State and the
loading state which will then bring us
back to these new data layer apis with
react router and we'll get to see that
there's a big Improvement in the way
that this can be handled so let's go
through and see how we might fix our
code to better handle the errors that
we're seeing
the first thing I'm going to do just for
the sake of best practice is to take my
fetch completely out of this component
considering I may want to fetch these
fans somewhere else instead of repeating
this code over and over it's a better
practice for me to create some kind of
library or utility where I can get the
vans that I need from a function and
then inside of my component I would just
call that function so let me create a
new file we'll just call it api.js which
is supposed to indicate that we are
going to be interfacing with the API and
I'm going to export we'll use an async
function that we call get vans
since I'm transitioning from what wasn't
an async function before to an async
function I'm going to be essentially
using this code but rewriting it using
async await so let's paste this in as a
reference but we will change up what
this looks like we'll say the response
is await fetch then we will get the data
we'll say const data equals await res
dot Json and then this function's job is
basically done it just needs to return
the data and I think it was the Vans
property on that data that we cared
about so we'll get rid of these lines of
code we're going to come back and
actually work on the sad path for this
because right now it's assuming that
this fetch request is going to work just
fine but let's refactor back here we
will import our get Vans function
and then instead of manually calling our
fetch request here I could keep using my
DOT then promise resolution syntax by
saying get Vans dot then but while we're
at it I might as well update this and
use an async function now it's important
if you remember from the introduction to
react course that I taught if you took
that that you can't just change your
function here for Muse effect into an
async function so the easiest thing is
just to create a brand new async
function inside here so we'll say async
function maybe we'll call it load Vans
just to get a different name that's
going to call get vans
and we will save that data we will just
say const data equals and then we get to
await get fans because we now are inside
of an async function and before I forget
because I do this all the time I'm going
to call my load Vans function even
though it's not quite done yet otherwise
sometimes I end up pulling my hair out
wondering why it's not working when it's
just because I forgot to call the
function okay so now I get to call my
set fans function and pass in the data
that we got from calling get Vans and
just to make sure that this is working
I'm going to get rid of this 400
response and make it so that it's
working again so let's hit refresh okay
good our vans are showing up we've made
a little bit of refactoring using this
API JS file and cool now let's start
working on actually coding up the sad
path just for the sake of
compartmentalizing the topics that we've
been learning we're going to do that in
the next lesson
one thing about the way that the code is
currently running is that we are only
initializing the fetch request to get
our vans after this component has
already been rendered to the page the
experience is a little bit jarring if I
hit refresh you'll see we get parts of
our page and then it starts to load as
the data comes in we do handle this a
little bit differently I think under
host fans we have a tiny little loading
state right there which in my opinion is
a better user experience than what we
have going on here unfortunately the way
that we are handling that in the host
Vans page I think right here is by
assuming if the van's length is not
greater than zero then we are loading
something however if we have an error
the man's length is not going to be
greater than zero it's going to be stuck
on loading forever or maybe this is a
new host on our platform they don't have
any vans listed and so when they come to
this page it's going to say loading
forever even though there are no Vans
for it to load so this approach was
pretty naive and we're going to find a
better way to do that so let's go over
to our vans page and a relatively common
way to do this is to set some loading
state so I'll go ahead and create a
loading and set loading Boolean which we
will save in react.use state we'll
initialize the loading State as false
but then as soon as we call our load
Vans function we will set the loading
state to true
and as soon as we're done setting the
vans in our state we will set the
loading State as false again
so it will only be true for a short
amount of time while it's getting the
Vans but this allows us to use this
Boolean of loading to either
conditionally render something on the
page or what I think I'm going to do
just for the sake of Simplicity is use
an early return so I'll say if loading
is true then instead of returning the
whole jsx that we see down here we'll
just do something simple like an H1 that
says we are loading it's not going to be
beautiful we could conditionally render
something maybe underneath our buttons
but for now this will get the job done
let's hit save okay we see our loading
for just a second and then our vans pop
in in fact while we're doing this just
to make it a little bit more apparent if
I go to server.js I can add this little
feature that says maybe like it will
take let's say two seconds for things to
load this isn't a syntax you need to
know again because it's specific to
mirage.js but now if I hit save it will
very clearly show loading for a lot
longer than it did before before things
actually get loaded okay that wasn't so
bad we created a loading State we set
the loading to True before we did our
fetch request and then after the fetch
request we set it back to false and we
handle the user interface case when
things are currently loading remember we
would need to then do this for every
component that is loading data like the
van detail page the host Vans page and I
think even the host man detail page has
a fetch request yep for now we're just
going to worry about the Vans page and
it's again not so much the sad path per
se because we're not throwing errors
right now but of course if we were to
throw errors like we were doing before
where we're just hard coding a error
response from the server we are not yet
fixing that problem so we're going to
have the app crash and that's not good
so in the next screencast we're going to
talk about how we can handle these
errors but remember all of this is
leading back to these new data layer
apis that we're going to be talking
about I think this buildup is important
which is why I'm taking time doing it
but this is also just good to learn
anyway okay I'll see you in the next
lesson
okay I mentioned before that we had
written our little API get Vans function
in a happy path sort of way that didn't
account for any errors that might be
happening and so behind the scenes I
went through and I added this little
check to make sure that the response has
come back okay this is something that's
built into fetch it will have a res dot
OK property and if it's a 400 level or
500 level Response Code then it will not
be okay that will be a false value so if
that happens then we're throwing an
error and currently we're not handling
that error in our vans.js page this is
still assuming a happy path now I've
changed the server again like we saw to
only respond with a 400 response so
let's go to vans.jsx and let's handle
our sad path here now you'll notice that
this says loading here and that's
because if I refresh this we'll see that
our bands never come back but our error
is successfully throwing so let's go
ahead and fix this now when I'm making
this request because I don't know for
certain that it's going to work
correctly I'm going to wrap it in a try
catch block this is the common way to do
this inside of an async function and so
I'll move my set Vans up here the try
will assume the happy path but now I
have the ability to catch any errors
that might happen and the catch block
will be the sad path now what should
happen when I get an error well first
let's just console log the error to see
what shows up and actually let's go
ahead and console log something like
there was an error open the console okay
we get there was an error and look at
that we get our error that we threw from
the server no from the API file this
object here that has a message status
text and Status we can see that that is
coming through in our console just fine
so now we are handling that error we're
not displaying anything but we no longer
show loading we just don't have any vans
to display that's not super useful for
the user so let's go back to bands jsx
we'll buy ourselves some room by closing
the console and similar to what we did
in the loading State we're going to
create another state that is for errors
so we'll say if there is an error we
will
so I have set error we'll probably start
this out as a null error and if there is
an error that happens here in my catch
block we will set the error and we'll
just pass in that object that we got
from the error that got thrown earlier
let's go ahead and get rid of our
console logs and just because it exists
I'm going to use a finally block I don't
get to use this super often so go ahead
and put our loading to false because
whether we get the Vans or we get an
error we want to set the loading back to
false okay now we can handle the case
when there is an error we have this
early return for loading we'll do the
same thing if there's an error so we'll
say if there's an error we'll return
let's just do another H1 for now and
we'll say there was an error and then
we'll go ahead and just stick the error
in there let's see what that looks like
again I'm hard coding an error in my
server.js so we know that it will error
loading and it's taking a lot longer
than before ah okay so I can't do this
whole error object here let's maybe do
error. message I think is what it was
okay there was an error failed to fetch
Vans it's not beautiful just like our
loading isn't beautiful but it is some
feedback to the user that tells them
that something happened now again we
would want to do this for our van detail
page our host Vans page our host Vans
detail page and hopefully you're
starting to see that there's a bunch of
repetition there's a lot happening just
to handle this sad path and if you think
really hard about it a major reason that
all of this is happening is because we
are only starting our fetch request
after this component loads remember when
we weren't considering the possibility
that Vans would not come back as an
actual array of Vans that's back when we
saw that when there was an error in the
server it actually crashed our app
because we were trying to map over
something that was not an array well if
we didn't load this component before we
had access to the data then we wouldn't
have to worry about that and
theoretically the same would be true of
the loading State and the error State
because we're sort of prematurely
jumping to this route and then starting
a fetch request for the data there's a
bunch of little edge cases that we need
to handle now all of this leads us back
to the data layer apis react router has
introduced us a way that we can load our
data before it ever transitions us to
the route which will allow us to get rid
of quite a bit of our boilerplate code
that we have here so let's finally dive
into these data layer apis and we have a
bit of setup to do before we can use
them so let's get started with that
the first aspect that we are going to
learn about in the new data layer apis
in react router is loaders you can click
on the screenshot here which will take
you to the loader prop in the route
component which we're going to get to in
a little bit but I think it's helpful to
know that the creators of react router
are also the creators of a framework
called remix I've had a chance to play
with remix it's an amazing framework
it's a full stack application that uses
react and it's definitely worth checking
out but the concept of a loader comes
directly from remix in fact they
introduced it into remix and then they
loved it so much that Ryan Florence and
Michael Jackson who are the creators of
react router and remix they brought the
aspects of loaders and something else
called actions directly into react
router in fact you can even see if you
look closely in the screenshot we'll see
this export async function loader and
there's this export async function
action that's the aspect that I'm
talking about loaders and actions so how
does this affect react router well as as
you saw we are currently using a use
effect in order to fetch our data and
for a really long time in react this was
kind of taught as the de facto way to
fetch data for your components let's say
that I'm currently on the slash about
route and I want to transfer over to the
Vans route so I click the link in my nav
bar which will take me to Vans and what
happens is the about page goes away it
gets swapped for the Vans page and
because we're fetching our data inside
of a use effect it immediately starts
loading the data or rather fetching the
data from some external Source
oftentimes this request is pretty fast
and once the request comes back with a
response then we get some Json from the
API that we work fetching data from and
then react does its thing where it
re-renders it takes that Json and
displays it the way that we told it to
in the code and we can certainly make
this work like I said this is how things
were done for quite a while but like I
mentioned because we're only loading the
data after we have already loaded the
page or rather mounted the component
component that represents our page we
have a lot of extra stuff that we need
to add we're saving State for the Vans
themselves the loading State the error
State we have this use effect which is
calling the data and it's got some error
handling built in we're also handling if
it's currently loading and if there's
currently an error and it's certainly
not the end of the world but let's take
a look at the paradigm shift that we're
about to learn when we use a loader for
fetching our data instead this might
seem like a small tweak but we're going
to see how it can dramatically change
our code so we're here on the about
route we click over on the Vans route
and the first thing that happens is it
delays for just a moment or two during
that delay it's starting the fetch
request to get the data for the Vans
page and that way when the data is
finished coming back from the request it
is already a part of the Vans page when
it gets loaded up again this might seem
like a small difference but we're going
to see how it's going to allow us to
send simplify quite a bit of the code
that we have now for a high level
overview of how we will end up using
loaders the first thing we need to do is
to export a function we will call it
loader it doesn't technically matter
what it's called from the page that will
fetch the data that it needs in our case
we're going to be working on the Vans
jsx page because this page needs data so
we're going to be creating another
function that isn't our component it'll
just be right here above it probably
that we'll call loader and that will be
the function that gets the data since
we're exporting it from here over in our
index.jsx where we have our route
definitions we're going to pass a loader
prop to the route and we'll pass in the
loader function that we exported from
our vans page and then back in our vans
component we'll use a new Hook from
react router called use loader data
which allows us to get whatever data was
returned from the function that is doing
the fetch request again this is a high
level overview we're going to obviously
go through each one of these steps so
don't worry if this seems a little
overwhelming there is one tiny little
problem before we can start working on
this and that is we need to opt in to
the new data layer apis and the way that
we do that will require us to make some
changes to our browser router setup that
we have here so first we're going to
tackle that and then we'll be coming
back and actually creating our loaders
and changing how the data loading
happens on our vans page
before we can take advantage of any of
the data apis in react router 6.4 and
later we need to change the way that
we're instantiating or creating our
router you can click the screenshot here
to go to this picking a router page in
the react router docs but you can see
from the screenshot that there are a
couple different ways to create routers
that do allow us to use the data apis
and then there are some other ways that
won't include the capabilities of the
data apis so you can see the top of that
list that does not allow for the use of
data apis is the browser router and
that's the one that we've been using
this is actually that silly Star Wars
app that we used when we were learning
some search params I've cleared out
anything that wasn't really relevant
actually there's a couple other things
up here let's get rid of those and you
can see that what we were doing is
importing browser router and then just
creating an instance of the browser
router component here well in order to
use these new data apis we need to
create our browser router in a little
bit of a different way so the first
thing I need to do is import something
called called create browser router and
maybe the astute amongst you would
notice that with the lowercase C that
means that this is not a component
instead it's a function that we're going
to run so I'm going to save the router
that this function returns so I'll call
create browser router and then save it
as a variable called router now what we
have always learned what we've always
done is defining our routes based on a
series of nested components but one
thing that maybe we didn't know was
happening under the hood is that this
routes component it's actually taking
every route that we have in here and
it's just turning it into a plain
JavaScript object or maybe more
accurately it's recursing through all of
the children of this routes component
and it's turning every route and every
child of those routes into an array of
Route objects and those might look
something like this let's say we have an
array in this case we only have one
route so this will be our route object
and it's going to have a path which is
just flash is going to have an element
which is
the home page component that we have
there and if this were to have any child
routes which it doesn't currently
because it's just self-closing but if it
did then there might be a property
called children and that would be
another array of nested objects and so
forth so this routes component behind
the scenes in the source code of react
router that's all it's doing with our
routes here is it's turning them into an
array of objects with nested arrays of
objects and so forth so with create
browser router we could go down the path
of basically rewriting all of our routes
in this case there's only one but
obviously in the van Life app there's a
lot more we could go through the process
of converting all of those manually into
an array of objects like this however in
order to make things a little bit
simpler for updating our code from a
version prior to 6.4 up to version 6.4
and making use of the data layer apis
they also included a utility function
called create routes from elements so
I'm also going to import that just to
make my life a little a little bit
easier since I already have my routes
defined so we'll say create routes from
elements and this is getting a little
crazy I'm going to put each of these on
their own lines
okay so what we can do is when we call
create browser router we will inside of
there also call create routes from
elements and this way I can put my route
elements directly inside of the create
routes from elements basically this
function will turn my route component
into an object and then it will pass
that object to create browser router so
basically it does all of that manual
work for me to be totally honest if I
were creating this from scratch without
some existing routes already defined I'm
not 100 sure which way I would use I'm
so used to using components like this
that I might just turn to that naturally
instead of typing out an object or an
array of objects and whatnot but I don't
know maybe the standard way will be just
writing out objects either way this
should do the trick for us there's one
last piece that we need to do and that
is to get rid of our browser router
because browser router was specific to
the non-data layer API routers that we
we could choose from we need to use
something different so there's yet
another thing we're going to import
actually maybe I'll just replace browser
router here and what I need to bring in
is something called router provider and
this is a component so I can get rid of
my browser router and I can actually get
rid of well actually I can get rid of
everything here so we're going to create
our new router and that's going to be by
using the router provider and then we're
going to pass a prop called router and
its value needs to be the browser router
that gets created from create browser
router so I've said the word router too
many times for it to make sense anymore
but router equals router and then this
can just be a self-closing element and I
guess let's cross our fingers we'll hit
save and okay home page is still working
and well that's all we have to test so
I'm going to recap what we did because
in the next lesson it will be a
challenge to create the browser router
just like we did here but for our van
Life app so I have three new Imports
router provider create browser router
and create routes from elements I
actually don't need this routes import
anymore because I'm not using routes and
then outside of the function where I'm
going to be using this router provider I
created a new variable called router the
name of this variable doesn't matter and
I'm calling create browser router and
because I already had a route defined as
a component like this I'm also using
Create routes from elements that allows
me to just copy and paste my entire
route definitions right here into the
new create browser router function that
I'm calling then with this router
variable defined I'm going to use the
router provider and pass that variable
to the router prop in my router provider
component okay that's a lot to take in
especially not having typed anything in
this lesson so look through the code if
you need to and in the next lesson I'll
have you work on it yourself
okay here we are back in the comfort of
our van Life app your challenge is to
change our router so that we can use the
newer one that supports the data apis
then we'll finally be prepared to start
actually learning about the data apis
and loaders so you'll need to import
these three things that we learned about
in the last lesson you'll need to create
a router variable and I put a little
note here just because in our example we
only had a single route that didn't have
any children but in this case you're
just going to be copying over everything
inside of our main route here and all of
its children so that will go in your
router variable which makes use of these
different functions that we are
importing and then you will replace
basically everything in our app all the
way through yeah everything with the new
router provider that we imported I think
you have plenty of hints here so I'm not
going to make it too easy on you I want
you to get your hands on the keyboard of
course and practice everything you can
practice so pause now and work on this
challenge
okay I am going to cheat and just copy
these things we'll import those let's
see there's a couple things we can get
rid of let's get rid of our browser
router and routes it will import those
and then kind of clean up my language
here
and while we're at it I'll go ahead and
put these on their own lines since we
are running out of space
okay that looks better now let's create
a variable here we'll call it router and
we will call create browser router and
then so we don't have to manually go
through and change all of these routes
into an array of objects we're going to
call create routes from elements
and then I can just take my main route
here and I'm actually just going to
slide it up that creates our router and
then I can replace our browser router
with the router provider
that will take a router prop and its
value will be the router that we created
above let's double check I'll clean up
the challenge text and
let's give it a shot I'll hit save and
sure enough everything seems like it's
working let's kind of navigate around
our app a little bit and
perfect so again we didn't change
anything that will be visibly different
on our page but fortunately we now can
finally jump into learning about loaders
which is what all of this has been a
build up toward as always if you want to
practice doing this again just to see
the two different methods of creating
routers you can scroll back to the
beginning of the lesson and try it out
again from scratch and as always when
you're ready we will keep moving forward
okay we're going to approach loaders
just one step at a time the first thing
we need to do is go to the page that
normally would use a use effect to get
data as soon as that page is mounted and
what we'll do instead is export a
separate loader function instead from
that page that will fetch the data that
we need for that page so I tried to make
this as simple as I could I did move the
home page from our previous example to a
separate component just so we could get
this even a little bit closer to what we
have in the van Life app so here I have
my home page and let's say I'm going to
be getting some really basic data
outside of the component that I have
defined I'm going to create a function
that I export called loader now with
react router the name of the function
actually doesn't matter a fun fact in
remix it does matter it has to be called
loader but since we're not using remakes
we're using react router we can really
call it whatever we want and the job of
this function is to get the data that we
want to get now to make things even
simpler to understand the truth is it
doesn't really have to be a fetch
request per se I think it almost always
would be but to keep it as simple as
possible I'm just going to return a
string that says the data is here we'll
see when this comes full circle and how
we actually get the data from our loader
into our component in a couple lessons
from now okay so it's really as simple
as that we export a function whose job
is to get the data that we want to have
access to in our component for now we're
pretending that this string is the data
that we have fetched from some API next
we're going to pass a loader prop to the
route that renders this page the home
page and we're going to pass in our
loader function so let's go over to
index in our case we only have one route
that we're defining and notice that I'm
importing home page as a default import
from my home component I can also bring
in my loader function that I exported as
a named import or a named export over
there and all I need to do now is to add
a new prop to my route that's called
loader and I will pass in the loader
that I imported with my home page
now think in the van Life app how we
have multiple page Imports many of which
will have their own loaders so I'm not
going to be able to just import a named
function called loader for every single
one of them in our case it's fine
because it's our only one but a really
common practice is to rename it as
you're importing it so I might say
import loader as and then maybe say like
home page
loader and this should probably be
lowercase and then I would change loader
equals loader to loader equals homepage
loader okay that's a great start it's
not quite done yet but let's go back to
the van Life app and give you a
challenge so that you can accomplish
those steps for the Vans page
okay you're basically going to do the
same thing that we just did but here on
our van Life app it's not going to be
exactly what we ultimately want but
we're gonna iteratively get there so
your challenge is first to export a
loader function from the file that we're
currently looking at for now we'll just
have that loader function return the
string Vans data goes here or something
along those lines then over in our
index.jsx file we need to import that
function and we will set it as the value
for the loader prop on the route that
controls this Vans page pause now and
work on the challenge
okay let's export a function that we'll
call loader and it's just going to
return the string Vans data goes here
and then over on index.jsx we will
import it now that file was right here
with the van so we will bring in the
named import loader let's call it vans
loader okay and down on our vans page
which is let's see Slash Vans we are
going to add our prop called loader and
set the value equal to bands loader okay
that's everything we are equipped to do
right now let's go back and complete the
circle so that we can actually pull in
the data from our loader into the
component where we're trying to get it
the last thing we need to do in order to
get this loader actually working is to
use the use loader data hook inside of
our component and up until now it may
not have been totally clear what
direction we're heading in because we
have this random function that's inside
of our component file and then over here
we're importing it setting it up as the
loader this seems a little bit out of
place but because we've done that little
extra work what's really nice about this
is inside of our component we can use a
hook called use loader data so I need to
import that from react router Dom use
loader data from react router Dom and I
can use that hook to grab the data that
is being returned from my loader so I
can say use loader data and I want you
to pause and just think for a second
what do you think console logging data
is going to show
first think about it and then actually
try to run it and see if what you
thought is what actually happens
well let's hit save and we get the
string the data is here so hopefully
that makes sense because whatever we are
returning from our loader is exactly
what will come back when we call use
loader data so how is this different
from using a regular use effect well
because we are not doing our data
fetching inside of the code of our
component react router can delay the
rendering of our home page component
until the loader has finished its task
so it's a slight change in the Paradigm
of how things get loaded in fact if you
look at the documentation react router
specifically says we don't care how you
fetch the data the only thing we are
doing with our data apis is changing
when the data gets fetched so how is
that useful well we're going to apply
what we've learned to the van Life app
and then we're going to start making
some major changes to our code which
hopefully will highlight how beneficial
it can be to use these data apis so
let's do that next
all right so let's do exactly what we
just did your challenge is to use the
use loader data hook to pull in the data
from our loader function and then I'll
just have you console log it inside of
your component here of course it's not
actually data yet we are eventually
going to use the get Vans function which
really gets data and use that inside of
our loader for now we'll stick with
what's here so pause now and work on
this challenge
okay let's pull in the use loader data
hook and we will now let's do it down
here we'll say const theta equals use
loader data and then we will console log
the data and if everything is connected
upright then it should give us the
Advanced Data goes here string let's
open the console hit save okay Advanced
Data goes here now notice that it logged
it three times that's actually because
we have this use effect it ran when the
code first loaded and then it set the
van State and so it had to reload the
page again and I'm not exactly sure why
the third one is happening oh because of
set loading probably so we're actually
going to address what's going on here
but for now let's do part two which I'll
type out right now
so here in our loader instead of
returning a string I want you to place a
call to the get Vans function and return
what gets returned from get Vans we're
still pulling in the data and console
logging it so really the only change
should be what happens right here pause
now and work on part two of The
Challenge
okay simply enough instead of returning
this string we're going to place a call
to get Vans which should return our list
of Vans and then from our loader we're
going to return that list events that
came back from this function call
everything else is still hooked up here
so let me buy us some space here we'll
get rid of that we'll hit save check the
console awesome look at this we have all
of our vans which came through in the
use loader data now currently we are
only pulling it in and then logging it
we're not actually rendering that
anywhere on the page we're still using
the vans that we had pulled in inside of
this use effect but this leads us to a
really exciting thing and that is we get
to delete a bunch of code we'll talk
about why and actually make those
deletions in the next scrim
okay so instead of just console logging
the data I actually removed that console
log we want to use this data in the
component so your challenge is to make
use of the data here throughout the
component instead of using our state and
our use effects to fetch and to hold the
array of Vans the first thing you'll
need to make sure that you do is just to
comment out this entire use effect block
and then you'll need to figure out what
other changes you need to make so that
things start working again as a hint I
personally would make a change up here
near the top instead of going through
and changing a bunch of different things
down here below hopefully that's not too
cryptic I'm sure you'll be able to
figure it out I'm trying to be vague so
that you have to really think about it
pause now and work on the challenge
okay let's comment out this use effect
to start and then instead of going down
and changing wherever it says Vans to
data I'm actually just going to change
here to Vans and then comment out my use
state so let's hit save
and sure enough everything is working we
can go into the Vans we can set filters
and go there this is still working
awesome now if you did have a chance to
play around with this a little bit you
might have noticed something and that's
if I go back say to the host page or the
home page then I come back to bands I'm
going to click it right now you'll see
that there was a slight delay before our
vans actually got loaded remember react
router here is making changes not to how
the fetch occurs but to when the fetch
occurs like we saw in the slides say
we're at the about page or some other
page as soon as we click to the Vans
page it's going to start the fetch
request then and only after the fetch
request has completed and the loader has
gotten the data then it will transfer us
to the Vans page and it will include as
part of the use loader data hook the
Json or whatever data it is that we
pulled in from our loader function so
what does this mean for us well that
means that we get to do one of the most
cathartic things that I think you'll
ever do as a programmer and that is to
delete a bunch of code for example we no
longer need our loading State because we
are already here at the page and the
data has already come into that page so
I can just get rid of my loading state
which means I can also I mean we saw
first of all that this whole use effect
we didn't need anymore we can get rid of
that and we have this loading State down
here that I don't need to handle anymore
so we can get rid of that so let me
clean this up too while we're in the
habit of deleting things I also can
delete my state instead of re-rendering
my component because I am setting the
state with the data that has come in
after the component was loaded I know
that the data is going to be there when
I pull it in with the use loader data
hook in the sense I get to treat this
much more synchronously instead of
having to think about how the component
needs to mount and then do a fetch
request and then update the state and
then to re-render because the state has
changed I don't have to worry about any
of that the mental model for this is
significantly simpler not only that but
I can still do my loader code right here
in the same file where I'm concerned
about the display of that data that gets
loaded from my loader I don't know maybe
you're not quite as excited about this
as I am but this is a really nice
paradigm shift
now there is something that we lost when
we deleted our use effect and that is
that we are no longer really handling
any errors remember we have that catch
Block in our try catch that would set
the error well because we deleted our
use effect we're not doing that anymore
but that wasn't a mistake because react
router has a way for us to handle errors
and it's very simple once you've had a
chance to bask in the glory of having
deleted all of that useless code let's
spend a minute to learn about error
handling when we are doing our fetch
request before the page loads instead of
after
surprise we're actually going to do a
quick quiz before we move on to handling
errors so you know the drill pause the
screencast click into each of these and
actually type your answers and then we
will go through all of these together
okay number one when does the code in a
loader function actually run unlike how
code inside of a use effect runs which
happens immediately after a component
mounts to the page a loader function
runs before react router allows the
route to change and that new component
to load so in short a loader function
runs before the component loads and the
route change happens
okay number two what are some benefits
of using a data loader function instead
of fetching our data in the use effect
in a component well one of the main
benefits is we don't have to handle
error state which again we're going to
be talking about next we don't have to
write a lengthy use effect that's part
of our component code we also don't have
to worry about loading State because we
know this component won't mount to the
page until the loader has already
completed its task or in other words
react router will delay the transition
to that new route until the loader has
finished its task we know that when we
access the data with use loader data we
will have access to the data as if it
were happening synchronously so we'll
type something like that down
okay number three what change do we need
to make to our browser router before we
can use loaders or really any of the new
data layer API features in our app I
guess the wording of this could be a
little bit like a trick question because
we just need to get rid of our browser
router and we need to use one of the
accepted data routers instead so we need
to get rid of the browser router
altogether
and we need to use the create browser
router function instead if you're really
wanting to jump both feet in to the new
system you can choose to use create
browser router with the array of objects
as we discussed in the lesson you can
find more examples of that on the react
router docs or if you already have some
pre-written code that you're trying to
transition to this new router using
create browser router you can use that
function create routes from elements to
help you make use of the code that
you've already written okay and then
lastly what are the steps we need to
take in order to use a loader on any
given route first we need to define a
new loader function and Export it
usually it's defined in the same file
that our component is being defined in
and so we can write that down we'll say
Define and Export a loader function
secondly we need to import the function
that we just exported into our route
definitions and set it up as a loader on
the route that we are trying to gather
data for
okay and lastly we need to use the use
loader data hook inside of the body of
our component so that we can get the
data that was fetched or produced or
evaluated or whatever it is inside of
our loader function okay that was a lot
of information but hopefully it sunk in
okay when you're ready let's talk about
error handling
okay let's see how we can actually
handle any errors that might happen now
this example might be a little
simplistic because we're not getting any
data that will ever fail because
javascript's probably not going to fail
just returning a string like this so
let's see what happens if I were to just
manually throw an error we'll say maybe
throw new error we'll give it a little
message that says this is an error I'll
comment out my return even though it'll
never get run because I'm throwing an
error manually let's see what happens
I'll hit save okay we have an unhandled
thrown error this is an error it tells
you some of that information about the
error and then it even has a little
message here that says hey developer you
can provide a way better user experience
than this when your app throws errors by
providing an error element prop on your
route okay so what does that mean well
if we go over to index.jsx here on my
route you can see I've put things on
their own lines to buy myself a little
bit of room we have this element prop
which is basically what element should I
under assuming everything is going well
well we can also add a prop called error
element let me just hard code something
for now maybe just an H1 it says there
was an error and let's hit save okay we
get there was an error this is our H1
that is being rendered instead of the
element that was supposed to be rendered
because our app is experiencing some
kind of error one thing that's neat
about this is it will handle more than
just an error that's happening inside of
our loader for example let's say our
loader is working just fine but for some
reason we maybe try to access a property
of an object that doesn't exist or a
function that doesn't exist or something
like that and that throws an error here
so let's say we're throwing a new error
this is a common one we'll say undefined
is not a function this is just
pretending that we're trying to call a
function that we think exists but it's
actually a value of undefined now we're
not actually using this message anywhere
but let's hit save and we get our error
element that we set up here so I guess
the point of this is the error element
will happen anytime your component that
you're trying to run has any kind of
error it could be an error that occurs
in the loader or it could be an error
That's Just Happening inside your
component just spitting out an H1 that
says there was an error isn't the best
user experience either but hopefully you
can see that you could tailor a a
well-designed and hopefully helpful
error component that will display some
really useful information in a nice way
that isn't quite so jarring as what we
have here okay so let's go back to the
van Life app and we will bring back the
ability to do some error handling by
using an error element in our route
okay let's apply what we just learned
about the error element prop and we'll
add one to the Vans route however you're
going to do a little bit more than we
just learned about this time instead of
just putting the H1 directly inside of
our error element I want you to create a
completely separate component up here in
the components folder that you can just
call error.jsx at this point we're not
going to get much more complex than just
rendering an H1 that says something like
an error occurred and then you'll want
to import and use that error component
as the error element on the Vans route
remember right now our error is coming
from the fact that we have just hard
coded an error response when we try to
get the vans from the slash Vans route
so let's go back here to where you can
see the challenge pause now and add an
error component to our vans route
all right up in our components I'm going
to create a new file called
error.jsx we will set that up and like I
mentioned we're just going to return an
H1 that says an error occurred we're
going to revisit this later and beef
this up we're going to see how we can
make this a little bit more useful but
for now this will do the trick over in
index.jsx we have done step one so let's
do step two we're going to import the
error component oh and I refreshed it so
now we have an error but let's uh call
this error and down here maybe just
right below the element we'll create an
error element
and we'll create an instance of our
error
okay so when I hit refresh react router
will see we're at the slash Vans route
that has a loader attached to it so it's
going to run the Vans loader the Vans
loader makes a fetch request to the
slash API slash Advanced endpoint that
we have on our mock server and the
loader will interpret the 400 response
as a problem let's see that's in the API
git vans so in API yep it'll be not okay
because 400 response with fetch is not
okay and so it will throw an error and
because the loader through an error it's
going to search for an error element and
that's the element that will get
rendered so let's give it a shot we'll
hit save
an error occurred awesome so it worked
as we would expect but right now just
having an H1 this is an error occurred
is not all that useful and we did take
the time to provide some additional
information in the error that we're
throwing like having a message that at
least says failed to fetch Vans that's a
bit more descriptive than just an error
occurred so how can we get the
information from the actual thrown error
to display on our page well that's what
we're going to learn next
all right let's learn how we can
actually take the information from the
error that got thrown and display that
on the error element that we have set up
at least that way we would have some
additional information to display that
ultimately would lead to a better user
experience even though they're suffering
through an error at that time when we
have an error element that is catching
an error there's a special hook in react
router we can use to display information
about that error so let's go to the
error component that we just created and
I'm going to import a utility hook
called use route error that comes from
react router Dom then just like some of
the other hooks we can just grab the
error we'll say that's equal to whatever
comes back by calling use route error
and let's go ahead also log the error to
see what we get I hit refresh open the
console okay look at what's in the
console we have an object with a message
a status text and a status properties I
want you to think where did that object
objects come from
well that's the error that we threw from
our api.js file we said try to get the
vans in this get Vans function by
fetching the data from slash API Vans
and if the response is not okay in other
words if it's not a 2 or 300 level
response then throw this object as an
error and so that object is what we're
catching inside of error.jsx if we use
error.jsx in multiple places then it's
possible that this error will come back
different so we would want to make sure
that as we're throwing errors inside of
our API that we're doing it pretty
consistently preferably with a message
status text and Status properties that
said we're just going to be doing this
in one place for now so I'm going to
give you just a really quick challenge
where you can use the information from
our error object to have a little bit
more of a descriptive error message let
me type that up now
okay so simply put use the error object
that we just got from use route error to
display something a little bit more
helpful in our H1 here in fact you don't
have to stick to Justin H1 you can go a
little beyond that and design it however
you want pause now and work on this
challenge
well the error has a message property so
why don't we just go ahead and we will
include the error.message as part of our
H1 let's see what that would look like
okay failed to fetch Vans is already
better maybe I'll say error colon just
to make it clear that that's an error
and you know what I'm going to bring
back my console log of the error here
we also have a status text property and
a status property this might be more
interesting to a developer instead of
the actual end consumer but I might want
to put something like I don't know I'm
curious what it would look like if I put
it inside of a pre-tag
so we'll say maybe we'll put the status
so this is error.status and then a dash
and we'll say error.status text see what
that looks like well the pre-tag
definitely makes it look like it's an
error it's obviously not very beautiful
but the point is we have an error and it
accurately conveys that message to the
user and to the developer okay let's get
rid of some of our extraneous things
here
and awesome now we could make this a
little more robust if we wanted to maybe
check for the fact that there's a
message property on here and if not then
we could have some kind of generic error
message and same goes for the status and
the status text maybe if those don't
exist on our error that we pulled from
use route error we can either just omit
this pre-tag completely or have some
other kind of message there at this
point I'm not going to worry about that
too much along those lines if we did
want to make our error a little bit more
generic an important thing to know is
that even though we are growing the
error inside of our loader for the Vans
path and that is the same place that we
have our error element we can actually
set up the error element to live on a
different level in the hierarchy of our
routes what I mean is we could say let's
get rid of the error element here on the
Vans path we could put it up on the main
path and let's see this needs to go
right there and by doing this any error
inside of any child route let's say it's
even the most nested child route way
down here any error that gets thrown
will bubble up to the nearest error
element in the route configuration here
so even though my error element does not
live on the same route that has the
error being thrown I can hit save and
the error element will still correctly
catch the information where the error
was being thrown now in this case
because we put it on the same level as
the layout our layout is not getting
rendered and so we no longer see our
navigation bar or our footer so you'll
want to be strategic about where you
place your error elements but the
important thing to know is that at this
point this error element would now catch
any error anywhere in my app even if it
happened way down here if instead I put
the error element down here on my what
is a slash host slash band slash photos
route any error that's thrown from this
Vans route is not going to get caught by
an air that's way down here in the
hierarchy this way you could have
multiple different error elements Each
of which can be sort of a fallback
depending on where you want that error
element to show up maybe you want most
of your page to show up and just one
little nested portion that had the
problem could show that there was some
kind of error the options are basically
endless and you have as much flexibility
as you need to make those error elements
and error boundaries work the way you
want them to work in the meantime I'm
going to move this back down here and as
always at this point play around with
the code make sure you understand what's
actually going on you can come over here
to api.js and mess with the error that
we're actually throwing and see how that
affects the rest of the app you can come
to server.js one thing I did at one
point was to choose a random number and
to half of the time have it return an
error and half of the time have it
returned correctly just play with the
code the more that you get your hands on
it and mess with it and see what breaks
and then go ahead and fix it the more
you're actually going to deeply
understand what we're learning about so
since we've moved our error elements I'm
going to hit refresh to see the updated
View and when you're ready we will move
on to the next topic
in order for us to talk about some of
the last remaining topics we have yet to
learn in react router 6. we need to
include some sort of authentication and
there's a bit of gray area here because
this isn't a course about authentication
but we need to have authentication
implemented at least in a very basic way
in order for us to talk about those
topics in react router 6. so this is a
design for the login page that we're
going to create and in fact I've already
created it for you Hallelujah and so
instead of throwing you into a bunch of
code that I just wrote for you I'm going
to walk us through it step by step so
you know what steps I had to take to
create this form and get it all set up
it doesn't do anything yet we're going
to be adding to the form but it's just a
basic form right now the handle submit
which happens when the button is pressed
you can see right here the form on
submit runs handle submit it's just
console logging this form data this form
data is just some state that we created
right now it doesn't have anything in it
it's just an empty email and password we
have a handle change function which is
going to run every time there's a change
on either of the inputs this is just so
that react is maintaining State for the
login form data on every change and
that's basically it for now with the
form because the button is here inside
of a form element it will trigger a
submit event on the form I of course
added a bunch of CSS that you can feel
free to go to index.css to look up but
the other piece is in our index.jsx I
imported the login form and I set up a
login route on the top level and then in
the header I just put this little icon
which is living up here as Avatar icon
in our image Assets Now why do we need
some form of authentication to talk
about react router 6 well the main
reason is this host route we want to
make it so that this host route is a
protected route which means you have to
be logged in before you can go to this
host route right now we sort of naively
have this host route up here and you're
able to see all the Vans whether you're
logged in or not and in fact if you
remember this is hard-coded the Vans to
be the user with the ID of one two three
I think in our user host Vans where the
host ID is one two three so it's all
pretty naive just for the sake of what
we learned already but let's learn about
protected routes so that's what we're
going to be doing next
I am coming to you from the future I've
actually already finished recording and
editing the end of this course but I did
become aware of an issue that you'll
likely come across time and again
throughout the remainder of this course
it's relatively minor it's not that big
of a deal but I did figure out what was
going on and thought it would be good to
give you a quick update on that so
you'll notice that right now I just
imported this Avatar image and
everything seems to be working fine but
if I go a couple levels nested deeper
into my URL and then hit refresh you'll
see that the image breaks now in the
past scrimba has done okay to just put
the relative path to the assets right
here inside of the source of an image
element and in the past I've had to do
that because the bundler that was
bundling this code under the hood inside
of scrimbo was webpack and I guess it
was just kind of able to make this work
however this was a constant source of
questions from students because when
you're following Along on your local
machine you'll find that this just
really doesn't work very well now a
quick fix here on scrimba that I guess I
could have done is just get rid of the
relative path and have it be absolute to
the root of the project so if I hit save
you'll see that now my avatar image
comes back that said now we are bundling
all of our projects with Veet it is much
faster and it's just overall better than
webpack and now that means that I can
inside of scrimba actually do things in
a bit more of a realistic or correct way
because when my project gets bundled up
my assets might end up moving or getting
renamed and having this hard-coded
string here really won't handle the
shifting around of our files very well
and so the real way to do this is to
import any assets that you need to use
inside of your markup and I can do that
by just saying I want to import let's
call it image URL from and then we will
just grab the absolute path to the image
and put it in there and of course this
is different than what you might be used
to seeing because we're used to
importing JavaScript functions and
components and everything like that here
we're importing from an npm package and
elsewhere we're importing from our own
JavaScript or jsx files but just know
under the hood Veet is able to handle
this and apparently I didn't know this
until recently but apparently scrimba is
also able to handle this internally so
if I just take this image URL I can now
use this as my source and that way when
it gets bundled it will just have the
correct path and file name and
everything so that it works just fine so
even though we're still in this nested
path I can hit refresh and my avatar is
still showing up so if you are following
along locally then please just do it
this way ignore the silly way that I had
it before and excuse any times in the
remainder of this course that you see
the little broken image icon up there it
doesn't happen terribly often but it
does happen sometimes okay let's keep
forging ahead
it's time for us to venture into a topic
that is often called protected routes as
a pretty important caveat to this
section it's important to know that
protected routes is not really uh
specifically created API that exists in
react router but rather it's a paradigm
or a pattern that you can use in order
to protect certain routes so what do I
mean by protected routes well the
purpose of protected routes is to stop
data fetching of sensitive information
so that only logged in users can access
their data and maybe on top of that the
users can't access other people's data
in any given website there's going to be
information that you want publicly
available and then there's going to be
user-specific data which oftentimes
needs to be protected through some kind
of authentication the user needs to be
logged in to see that data now at this
point we're at kind of an interesting
fork in this course because we have
transitioned to using a data router and
we've already started implementing
loaders in our van Life app however I
think it's going to be useful to see how
this issue of creating protected routes
is solved both with a data router like
we're using but also in a more
traditional sense when using the older
routers that existed before react router
introduced the data routers in version
6.4 unfortunately the approach to
creating protected routes is very
different between the two and so I think
it's going to be helpful for us to see
how we can do it not using a data router
first and then we're going to see how we
can use it with data routers we won't
dive very deep into the non-data router
version only because it won't apply to
us throughout the rest of this course
with our van Life app and then naturally
we will dive a bit deeper in how we can
create protected routes using the data
routers in order to help us understand
why the approaches are so different we
need to remember what is happening when
we're fetching our data if we're using a
use effect in order to fetch our data
then first what happens is we transition
to a new page and then the fetch request
is kicked off this means that the Vans
page has to take into account the fact
that there's a loading State and maybe
an error state in case the data doesn't
come back correctly and then after that
fetch request is completed the Json will
get sent to this component it will
re-render and then that re-render will
maybe set the loading state to false and
it'll set the list events into State and
therefore render the list events in
react router when you have nested routes
that are all displaying on the page at
the same time sometimes it's possible
that you end up with something called a
request waterfall this screenshot comes
from the remix homepage and if you click
it you can go to a link there and see a
much more interactive version of it that
will show you side by side what a
request waterfall looks like versus how
remix and by association react router
handles data fetching but here what you
can see is we have a side navigation
which might have some kind of loading
State and in order for the rest of the
nested a route to load this first needs
to load then when this part loads or
rather the sales nested route loads then
and only then can we start kicking off a
request to get the list of invoices once
the list of invoices loads then and
sometimes only then can we kick off
another request in order to get the
specific invoice that we're trying to
see so this is where the name request
waterfall happens because everything has
to wait for the previous one to finish
in order for the next one to start so
I'm not necessarily saying our van Life
app is set up exactly this way we're
using some workarounds to kicking off
this many requests but it's just
important to know that this is not an
uncommon thing in react apps so when we
have a series of protected routes or
routes that we only want a logged in
user to access in the more traditional
setup for react router a very common
approach to creating protected routes is
to prevent renders from happening of
those protected routes or those
components that have sensitive
information so if the user isn't logged
in then we stop the data fetching by
just blocking those components from
rendering in the first place and instead
send the user or navigate the user to
the login page and since that fetching
is happening after the components are
rendered to the page inside of a use
effect for example if those components
are prevented from rendering in the
first place then the fetching will never
happen this might look something like
this you have your home page and then
you have a series of protected routes we
only want users to get to the host page
or any of the nested routes under the
host page if they're logged in so what
this looks like is we can introduce an
auth required layout route maybe to be
clear auth required is just an arbitrary
name that I came up with but it is a
layout route that wraps all of the
protected routes and the job of that
auth required layout route is to check
if the user is currently logged in if
the user is logged in then it will allow
the nested route components to render to
the page and therefore they are then
allowed to trigger any kind of fetch
requests that they might be doing
however if the user is not logged in
then it's just not going to render those
and instead it's going to navigate them
to the login route so for the sake of
completeness we are going to take a look
at what this approach might look like in
the code but then we're going to talk
about why this doesn't work for us when
we're using loaders inside of a data
router with react router so in the next
scrim we'll take a quick look at how we
might implement this auth required
layout route
let's see one way that we could
implement this auth required layout
route in order to protect any nested
routes that we don't want an
unauthenticated user to access at this
point you should be familiar with the
concept of a layout route here we can
see that we have one route that is
wrapping all of the other routes in our
really simple app here that only has two
routes a home and a protected route and
as you know the job of this layout route
for example is just to create some
shared user interface that will be
consistent throughout any of its
children routes if we go to that layout
we can see that it just has a navigation
and then it's got this main tag and it
wraps an outlet and the job of the
outlet of course is to render any
children routes that match the current
URL and while this is how we have been
using layout routes so far there isn't
anything stopping us from creating a
layout route that can do some logic and
conditionally either render the outlet
or alternatively in the case of what
we're doing here with protected routes
instead send the person or navigate the
person to a different route entirely so
let me go in here and create a new
component I'm going to call it
authrequired.jsx and we'll go ahead and
get this initial layout component setup
then before we actually start working on
the code inside of here I'm going to go
and actually wrap my protected route
inside of this auth required layout
route so I'll need to import
auth required and then we'll set that up
as its own route which will be a parent
of our protected route
in this case we don't need to worry
about anything dealing with a path
because all we really want is for the
elements to get rendered which will then
as we'll see conditionally render either
this child route or we'll navigate the
person to the login route which we don't
have a login route here but we'll get
there soon okay so my element will be
the auth required component that we just
created we'll hit save we'll see that
nothing is going to show up if I go to
protected because I'm not rendering an
outlet over there so let's go do some
more work over here we'll import the
outlet component from react router Dom
and then just for the sake of taking
things one step at a time we'll just go
ahead and immediately return this Outlet
of course this means that this auth
required is not performing any kind of
work or creating any kind of benefit but
now I can go to protected and I can see
my protected route component here again
one thing I think could be helpful at
this point is to just start making a few
few comments as to how we're going to
implement this auth required protected
routes component because at this point
we don't have any real authentication
set up we're going to sort of fake our
authentication so we'll say first we're
going to fake our authentication that'll
make more sense in just a minute and
then we're just going to have some
simple logic we're going to say if the
user is not logged in then redirect them
to the login route and otherwise
we will return the outlet so here we are
doing a check to see if the user is
logged in and if they are already logged
in then we just return the outlet as we
normally would have expected kind of
like we were doing right here and as we
just saw in the comments if they're not
then we'll simply redirect them to the
login page like we show here
now we've already covered quite a bit of
ground in this scrim so if you feel like
playing around in the code you're more
than welcome to and when you feel ready
we'll move on to the next lesson where
we will actually Implement some of this
logic
you might be asking yourself how are we
going to fake authentication well I'm
going to take the shortest shortcut we
can and say is logged in is true because
this isn't a course about authentication
specifically in one form or another
we're going to be faking our
authentication kind of similar to this
so I hope that's not too terribly
disappointing but it should help keep
our focus on react router and how to
build something in react router like
when we're creating protected routes
okay and then simply enough with the
rest of this logic we can just use a
conditional and say if the user is not
logged in then I'll go ahead and move
this up here and we can just get rid of
this I could have an else and say Return
Outlet but because we are going to
return something from within our if I
can just consider that an early return
and then I don't actually need my else
because if I'm returning in here then
this return will never get run
okay so how are we going to redirect the
user somewhere without any kind of
interaction on their part well you
should already be familiar with the link
component the idea of the link component
is that when you render a link and the
user clicks it then it sends them to
another route in react router well react
router also has a bit more of a forceful
version of that which is called navigate
and it is a component and if the
navigate component ever gets rendered by
react then it will immediately and
automatically send the person to a new
route that you specify in the navigate
component simply enough I can just say
I'm going to return an instance of the
navigate component and just like with
link there's a prop called two there's
also a prop called to in navigate so I
can say navigate to slash login
now remember we don't have a login route
registered in our router quite yet but
we can still test this so I'll hit save
remember I have hard coded that my
authentication is currently set to true
or my is logged in variable is set to
true and so I'm able to get to my
protected route just fine let's go home
we'll change this to false I'll hit
refresh and try to go to protected and
we'll see what happens and okay this is
great although we don't have a login
page and so we get this 404 not found
but the point is it sent us to the login
page remember the approach we're taking
is to prevent renders entirely of the
protected routes and that's exactly what
our auth required component has done
here because it's wrapped as a parent
component or rather apparent route to
our children routes that are protected
it intercepted the rendering of this
route or rather this H1 here it's not
really even its own component and before
it ever allowed that to be rendered by
returning this Outlet it instead sent us
to the login page by doing this if we
did have some sensitive information that
was living inside of this component
against just an H1 but imagine that this
is a component that's doing some kind of
fetch request to some sensitive
information by stopping this from Ever
Getting rendered it's not going to kick
off that fetch request now before we
move on it's I think important to
remember that this is the approach that
you would use if you were not using the
features that come with the data layer
apis and the data routers technically
we're using a data router because we're
using this create browser router
function but we're not using any loaders
here and the fact that we're not using
any loaders means that it's okay for us
to do it this way however once you
introduce using loaders inside of any
protected routes then everything kind of
changes so as I mentioned this is about
as far down this path as we're going to
go I think it's really important to see
this because at least at the time of
recording this is the most common way
that you will see people accomplishing
protected routes and that's only because
most of them are not using these data
routers quite yet however for us we are
going to jump into the future and
actually use loaders and see how we can
accomplish protected routes when we're
using loaders
it's that time again let's run through a
quick quiz that deals with protected
routes like before I want you to
actually click into the lesson here and
type down your answers and when you're
done you can hit play and we'll go
through the answers together so pause
now and work on the quiz
okay so how did we change our route
definitions in order to protect certain
routes from an unlogged in user well the
first thing we did was to wrap all of
our protected routes in a layout route
that has some logic inside of it that
will protect those routes if the user is
not logged in with the next two
questions we'll talk about how it
actually protects those routes but for
now for answer number one that's good
enough I guess one thing we can be a
little bit more specific about is that
the way in which it protects the routes
is by redirecting the user if they are
not logged in to the login page okay
number two what component can we use to
automatically send someone to a
different route in our app well that
would be the navigate component if the
navigate component renders at any time
it will automatically forward them to
the location or the path that we specify
in the to prop so I can say navigate to
slash login for example okay and lastly
what component can we render if the user
is logged in well if they're not logged
in we will render the navigate component
but if they are logged in then because
we have wrapped a layout route around
our protected routes we want to use an
outlet in order to render the contents
of the route that they're trying to
reach okay short and sweet let's keep
moving forward
okay so let's start seeing how we can
include protected routes when we're
using these new features with the data
later apis loaders and actions and so
forth as a reminder if you're using a
loader for fetching data the fetching
actually happens before the route
transition and before the target
component the next component that you're
trying to route to actually renders to
the page this means if you were on the
about page and you wanted to go to the
Vans page when you click the link to the
Vans page it's going to kick off the
fetch request from the loader of the
Vans page first before it ever
transitions or renders the Vans page it
gets the data and it includes it
immediately inside the the Vans page A
major benefit of this is that we don't
need to check for the loading State
because this component will only ever be
rendered to the page if the loading is
complete and there are no errors which
also means that we don't have to
necessarily check for the error State we
can handle that in a more declarative
way inside of our route definitions we
saw the diagram from the remix website
of a request waterfall and if you went
to the website to look at that diagram
you would have also seen what it looks
like to load things in parallel another
benefit of having these requests
available to the data router before the
routes even load is they know how to run
your fetch requests before ever
transitioning to that route so in remix
which is what this diagram on the
website is actually referring to but
also in react router when you're using
loaders if you have some nested route
that you're trying to reach all of those
fetch requests can happen simultaneously
in other words all of the loaders that
are required for your current route to
display correctly are run in parallel
they don't run one after the other but
instead they all can run at the same
time and then whenever the final one of
the loaders finishes the entire
completed page can render to your screen
so I want to preface this by saying this
is something that oftentimes leads to
faster loading and arguably will also
improve the user experience in the end
so the reason I preface all this is to
make it known that because all of the
loaders for all of your routes will run
as soon as you start the transition to
that route it means that we can't put a
layout route to wrap our routes and stop
the fetch requests from running because
they all just start running even before
it transitions to that component we no
longer can try to prevent the components
from rendering because the fetch
requests are happening before the
opponent is rendering anyway so that
means we need a slightly different
approach to create protected routes when
we're using loaders we're going to use a
function that we are about to learn
about called redirect and it's going to
happen inside of our loader function so
the high level overview is if the user
is not currently logged in then we will
run this redirect function and we'll
send them to the login page inside of
our loaders before any route rendering
happens now at the time of recording
this there is a downside to this
approach and that is that the check for
the currently logged in in user and the
redirect has to happen in every single
protected routes loader that said there
is currently a proposal out there to
include something called middleware
inside of react router that would allow
someone to run a function before any of
the loaders happen again when I'm
currently recording this that is not yet
implemented into react router so I'm
hoping in the future I can record an
update that basically amends this and
says now we can use this middleware to
run this check instead but for now we'll
just have to do a little bit of extra
work in order to run all of our checks
inside of every loader of every
protected route okay let's see a diagram
of how this works so with parallel
loaders we might be loading something on
our home page at which point we might go
to a nested host page and all of these
are going to load at the same time like
we saw in that previous diagram and all
of these loaders are going to check if
the user is currently logged in now one
of these loaders is going to recognize
that the user is not currently logged in
and so they will call this redirect
function which will cancel any loading
that's happening and it will never kick
off a fetch request and instead it will
redirect the person to the login page
this way we still accomplish the goal of
never kicking off a fetch request to
protected data if the user is not logged
in by the way the reason it's important
not to even kick off this fetch request
is if we did and the data came back if I
were to go into my developer tools
inside of my browser and look at the
network tab I could potentially get
access to sensitive information that I'm
not supposed to have access to okay
that's enough Theory let's actually jump
into some code and see how we can
implement this
you should be familiar at this point
with the concept of adding a loader to
our routes typically we have a separate
component and in that same file of that
component we can export a function
called loader and then we set a
parameter or a prop on our route that's
called loader and we just say this is
the home loader for example for the sake
of brevity and being able to see
everything in one place instead of
having a separately defined component
and a separately defined loader function
I'm just going to inline my loaders so
let me create a loader here as well
and I'm just going to make these some
asynchronous functions for now and we'll
just use an arrow function and open up
the bodies now it's pretty important
that you return something or even if you
return null from your loaders because
otherwise react router is going to
complain we can see here you define a
loader but you didn't return anything
from your loader please return a value
or null so the first thing I'm going to
do here is just return null so we can
get rid of that error suppose the
homepage one isn't quite as important to
us at this point so we are going to
focus on our protected route loader
similar to what we were doing in our
auth required layout route which I left
here just to be able to see but you'll
notice that I've removed it from our
route definitions similar to what we
were doing over there we are just going
to fake our authentication and so over
here I'm going to say on the top line of
my loader for my protected route that
const logged in equals false for now
actually let's go ahead and start this
with true okay and then similar to what
we had before I can say if we are not
logged in if not is logged in then what
we want to do is to redirect the user so
I'll just put that as a comment here now
because this is happening inside of a
loader I don't need to then do any kind
of other redirect or anything the loader
is already the precursor to this route
loading or rather this element being
rendered to the page now how do I do
this redirect remember right now I'm not
not inside of a component I'm just
inside of a regular async function which
means I can't use the navigate component
I can't return navigate because I'm not
inside of a component that is ready to
render anything to the page because of
that react router gives us another
utility function that is called redirect
and so I can come down here and I can
simply say we're going to redirect the
user to slash login now a common
Paradigm that I have found in my
discussions with some of the core team
at react router is that many people will
actually throw this redirect instead of
just doing a return I assume it's
because it's kind of conceptually
similar to a server that would be
returning a 400 level error that says
that the current user is not
authenticated to access that endpoint
either way we're not going to see that
throwing our redirect is going to make
that big of a difference so because it
appears to be convention I'm just going
to leave it there okay let's see what
happens I'm going to hit save I'm going
to try to go to protected and well of
course that worked because we hard coded
that the user is currently logged in so
it's good to know that our protected
route Works let's go ahead and change
this to false and hopefully actually
let's go home first hit refresh and I'll
click protected and perfect that takes
us immediately to the login page now I
think this is pretty neat but I want you
to pause for a second and think about
this if I hit the back button where is
it going to take me
because the loader intercepted the
direction to the protected route and
before that could even render it sent me
to the login page if I hit back it's
going to take me back to the home page
where I was before I attempted to get to
the protected page I think the benefit
of this is going to be a bit more
obvious when we finally get back to our
van Life app and start applying what
we've been learning but conceptually I
think this is pretty neat because the
loader is running before the route
transition ever happens okay we're
almost ready to jump back into van life
and start implementing this I'm excited
to get your hands back on the keyboard I
know I've been talking for a long time
while we have this set up here I think
it would be pretty interesting to see
for just a second what we're talking
about when we talk about parallel
loaders and so I found a way that I can
demonstrate this and we're going to do
that in the next scrim
okay do you remember when I was talking
about how when you have nested routes
how the loaders for each of those nested
routes will run in parallel well we can
see this in action by kind of Faking the
concept of a fetch request but first we
need a nested route and we don't have
that per se we have this index route and
then we have a protected route let's go
ahead and turn our protected route into
a parent so we'll close this as a
separate component and then I'll create
a new route and this one will say the
path is I guess it really doesn't matter
we'll just call it nested and it'll just
say nested protected route okay I'm
going to create a loader for this one as
well so let me put these on their own
lines create a loader that looks just
like the other ones it'll be an async
function okay let me get rid of the
authentication stuff that we're doing up
here for now and instead well let me
move this return null because that's
going to be important to be down there
and we're going to do something fun in
each one of these we're going to create
a random number
and then we're going to use that random
number as part of a set timeout
so timeout takes a function to run so
we'll do this and then the second
parameter is the amount of time it's
going to wait before it runs so we'll
put that random number in there the idea
here is that we will run this function
at a random amount of time between 0 and
1 seconds so that sometimes this
protected route up here will have a
let's do we'll just say console log
protected
route and down here we'll say nested
protected route so sometimes this set
timeout will finish first and sometimes
this one will finish first and if our
loaders are truly running in parallel
instead of in sequence then we should
sometimes see this console log first and
sometimes see this console log first so
I'll open up my console and we'll hit
refresh but first we have to go to our
protected route actually that's only
going to run the protected one so let me
type in slash nested at the end and I'll
hit enter and okay so this time we got
protected route first and then nested
protected route this helps us see that
multiple loaders are running one for
this parent route and another for this
child route but now let me just keep
hitting refresh until we see something
different
well one thing I can do is make the
spread a little bit greater we'll say
maybe times two here let me hit refresh
again okay here's an instance where the
nested protected route finished first
before the protected route this really
does show us that react router is not
waiting for this loader to finish before
running this loader but instead both
loaders are running at the same time
okay that was a lot of work to get to
maybe a bit of an underwhelming result
but if you're a nerd like me it's kind
of cool to see that these are running
truly in parallel and it also helps us
better understand why we're having to
take this different approach as opposed
to just putting a parent Route Around
the other ones because if we imagine
that these loaders are instead of
console logging something they're making
a fetch request to protected data then
we can see that they're both running at
the same time and so I can't simply have
code inside of my parent route that is
trying to stop the rendering of my child
route because the loader is happening
before the rendering is happening okay
we're done with that aside let's go back
to our van Life app final and get your
hands on the keyboard with a challenge
and have you implement protected routes
as we've learned in the last few scrims
in our van Life app
actually you know what I lied I'm
feeling a bit guilty for how much
talking I've done without getting your
hands on the keyboard so before we go
into something with slightly higher
Stakes by going into the van Life app
and having you implement what we've
learned I want you to get your hands on
the keyboard now while we're still here
and simply rewrite some of the code that
we just wrote so your challenge is to if
the user isn't logged in redirect them
to the login page if you need to go back
and see how we did that that's
completely okay pause now and work on
this challenge
okay well you might have noticed that we
are already importing redirect that's
from when we did this before and all we
need to do is check if the current user
is not logged in so not is logged in
then we are going to and in this case
we're going to throw like we're throwing
an error we're going to throw a call to
the redirect function and it'll take us
to slash login we have to keep our
return null there just in case and so
we're just going to keep that let's go
ahead hit save we're currently not
logged in because of this variable we'll
hit protected and sure enough it takes
us to the login page okay let's make our
way back to Van life and it'll be your
task to do the same thing over there
okay we're going to try and take this
one step at a time and unfortunately in
this challenge you're going to get
first-hand knowledge of that downside
that I was talking about where you have
to include a loader on every one of your
protected routes in order to protect all
of the routes and that's again just
because they will always run in parallel
as a reminder at the time of recording
this there is a proposal for a
middleware that would run before any
loaders where you could instead write
this authentication check before any of
the loaders in which case you wouldn't
have to write them in every single
loader but as I'm recording this it's
not quite yet a part of the react router
API hopefully I'll be able to re-record
this in the future and update with some
good news okay so I'm sorry this will be
a little bit tedious of a challenge but
it's going to set us up to make these
protected routes for now don't worry
about checking for anything dealing with
authentication so that we can just take
it one step at a time pause now and work
on this challenge
okay I am going to make use of multiple
cursors here so first just because it
will be a little bit long I'm going to
put everything on its own lines and this
is going to get significantly longer but
that's okay
okay the only reason I did this on its
own lines is so that it would be really
easy for me to include a loader on every
one of these
okay so we'll include a loader and for
now we're just going to do an inline
function here one thing to note about
loaders is that they could either be an
asynchronous function or not an
asynchronous function I happen to know
that it's going to be useful for us to
make these asynchronous functions so I'm
going to do that and I'll open up the
bodies here and just return null okay I
guess the main way we'll know if this
worked for now is that we don't get any
errors when we load okay perfect this
was a bit procedural so in the next
lesson hopefully it'll be just a little
more exciting and will actually start
including some checks for authentication
and protecting these routes
before we continue on with protected
routes using loaders we do need to make
a few changes to our host routes because
although we have implemented the loader
for our vans.jsx file we have not done
that for our van detail page our host
events page or our host van detail page
these are all still using a use effect
in order to fetch data I think
technically we could still get things to
work but it would be a strange mashup of
these two different paradigms where
loaders really should be what's used in
order to get data for the component that
needs it especially since we've already
started creating some loaders over here
inside of our route definitions so I'm
going to walk us through a quick
refresher on how we did loaders with our
vans page and then I'm going to
implement it in Van detail and then your
challenge is going to be to also
implement it in host fans and host fans
detail so you might remember when we
were doing this what we did is we
exported a function called loader and
all it does is return the promise that
comes back from get Vans then we're
using use loader data in order to get
access to our vans so that we can then
map over them filter them and do
whatever else we need to do with them in
our file if we go to api.js you can see
that I have beefed up our API functions
here just a little bit our get Vans
function is now able to take an ID if
necessary and so we're sort of
overloading this function where we can
either not provide an ID and get a list
of all the Vans or we can provide an ID
and get the single van with the ID that
we specify and then we have a separate
get host Vans function which is almost
identical to this except it reaches out
to slash API host slash Vans instead of
just slash API fans okay so let's go to
Van detail and refactor this so that we
essentially do the same thing as we did
over in Vans I'm going to come up to the
top I'm going to export a function
called loader eventually will see that
these functions can be async if we want
them to be I'll come back later and
Implement that if we need to and all
it's going to do is return a call to get
Vans let's see let's go to Vans okay
this is basically exactly what actually
it's literally exactly what we had there
now we need to import get Vans for that
to work so we will import get vans from
the API file however at this time
because this is the van detail page we
need access to the ID of the van that
we're trying to get before what we did
is we used the use params hook which
allowed us to access params.id but since
the loader function is not a component
we can't use hooks inside of it hooks
can only be used in components that get
rendered fortunately we have immediate
access as one of the parameters to this
function to an object called perhemps
and so this is exactly what you would
think we will now have params.id so I'll
go ahead and just console params let's
refresh oh actually before that will
work we need to go to our file here and
set up the van detail to have a loader
so we'll move these on their own lines
say the loader is equal to we'll call it
the van detail loader and then we need
to import that so here we're importing
band detail we will also bring in the
loader as van detail loader
okay let's give this a shot now I will
hit refresh we'll open the console I'll
go to Vans and then go to the van detail
page and sure enough we get the object
with the ID of one it looks like we have
another errant console log hanging out
somewhere and that's right here with
console logging our location we'll go
ahead and get rid of that okay so I have
access to the params object it has a
property called ID and so I need to make
sure that I pass that in to my get Vans
function and then I'll need to use my
use loader data hook and that should get
me access to a van object I think let's
call it data we'll say use loader data
and then we'll console log the data
I'm going to comment out my use effect
here and actually I'm going to put a set
of semicolons here just so that it
relegates these squiggly lines to the
semicolon instead of making it look like
our return is broken okay let's hit save
awesome now our loading is freaking out
a little bit because our van is not
coming from State anymore because we are
no longer fetching it so let's go ahead
and call this van so that we can just
reuse that name we'll comment out our
state we shouldn't need params anymore
because we're doing that in the loader
and let's hit save
oh of course I'm still trying to console
log data we can get rid of our console
log now
okay our van is showing up so let's get
rid of this code here and then we no
longer need to check if van exists
because we can be pretty confident that
it is going to exist since we are
loading it before the route ever loads
or before this component ever mounts so
we will get that in there fix up some of
these formatting issues and let's get
rid of our console log up here while
we're at it hit save
and cool okay now that you've seen how
we can do this and how we can access the
parameters directly inside of our loader
it's going to be your turn to do this
for the host fans page and the host Vans
detail page so that's what's coming up
next
okay just like I did in the van detail
page you are going to do for the host
Vans page and the host Vans detail page
currently both of those are fetching
data from a use effect and we want to
move that to a loader instead so that's
exactly what your challenge is you can
read it here one thing to note is that
you will be using the get host Vans
function instead of the get Vans
function since we're dealing with the
host routes now and also the inline
loaders that we put let's see where are
they right here and here for our vans
page our host fans page and our host van
detail page these inline loaders you'll
just replace with the ones that you will
import up above that you are exporting
from those component files here give
this your best shot if you need to look
at the Vans or the van detail page that
should help you quite a bit and then
we'll go through it together pause now
and work on this challenge
okay we'll just clean this up because we
know what we need to do we are going to
export a function called loader we're
going to return get host Vans and then
we need to make sure we import that
and this is coming from the API file
okay we will also need use loader data
while we're in this same file and we'll
go ahead and grab the list of Vans we'll
call it Vans just like our state so we
don't have to make other changes down
below at least not too many and that's
going to be equal to use loader data we
can get rid of our state we can get rid
of our use effect always feels really
good we're using the same variable name
so that can stay the same and then here
we were sort of naively doing a
vans.length check to see if it was
loading or not this of course just
assumes that the host has fans in their
array so we can get rid of that
completely now and get rid of this
completely we'll do a little reformat so
much simpler and I don't need that curly
brace either that feels really good to
clean up that code okay we're not quite
done of course let's go over to our
index file and we will come up to the
top and right here host Vans we're going
to import the loader as as host Vans
loader and then come down to our route
which was this one and again like I
mentioned we'll just replace the inline
one with a named function okay that was
a lot of work without checking how we
were doing so let's go ahead and refresh
and we can test this by going to the
host page and vans okay our vans are
coming in perfect so now we will just do
the exact same thing for our host van
detail and I'm going to fly through this
pretty quickly we know we need use
loader data from react router Dom we
need our get host Vans function from the
API file we're going to export a loader
function we will need access to the
params this time and so we are going to
return get host Vans by passing in
params.id we don't need use params but
we do need we'll just keep calling it
current van
and that will be from use loader data we
don't need our use effect we don't need
to worry if there isn't a current van
and everything else I think should be
the same so let's go back to our index
file we will import see where is our
right here host fan detail will import
our loader as host and detail loader and
once again we will replace we can find
it right here we have our inline we will
replace it with the host van detail
loader function we'll hit save and oh it
looks like I got close but not quite
there we'll see if we can figure this
out
oh you know what uh we are still using
the current van State I forgot to get
rid of my state we need to get rid of
that because there is a duplicate
declaration for it okay let's try again
those fans click on one of them perfect
okay hopefully that was good practice
it's a good example of space learning
and repetition that's been a minute
since we've dealt with the loaders so
this is kind of good to get the practice
back in and now we're perfectly set up
to finally go back to implementing the
protected routes now that we're doing
things a little bit more in line with
how it should be done with using loaders
okay so we have a task now that we're
finally back to including protected
routes in our loaders and those tasks
include checking for the user's
authenticated status which we're just
going to fake it like we did before and
if they're not logged in we want to call
that redirect function that comes from
react router Dom to the slash login page
and I was about to write step three and
realize that that's it I know that it
seems like we're doing a lot of work
here because of the way that our loaders
are but we are going to see how we can
simplify it a bit now rather than inside
of every loader doing some kind of const
is logged in equals false or true and
then trying to duplicate that for every
loader it makes a ton more sense for us
to create a utility function whose
entire job is to do these tasks so I'm
going to create a new file that I call
utils.js that's just down here at the
bottom and we're going to create a
function that's just called require auth
because this is a custom function you
could call it whatever you want and
inside this function I'm going to use my
fake login status so I'll say is logged
in equals false and then I'll do my
check that says if not is logged in then
we're going to throw that call to
redirect to the slash login page and
redirect is not a global function we
need to import it so I will import
redirect from react router Dom and
eventually we're going to do a bit more
work in here but for now I think this
should be good so let's come back to our
index we're going to import our function
that we just created that's require off
from the API no from the utils file and
then we do have the tedious task of
including it in each one of our loaders
now this brings me back to a point I
made earlier about how our loader can be
an async function what we currently have
in our utils as this hard-coded is
logged in value and this conditional
check none of this is is an asynchronous
operation in JavaScript this will just
run line by line and it will run very
very quickly however much more commonly
in require auth we might be reaching out
to a database of some sort or a server
rather in order to ensure that the user
is currently logged in and doing that
may be an asynchronous operation and so
we don't want require auth to kick off a
request and then continue doing fetches
in the loaders if the person is not
allowed to access that information so
although what we currently have is all
synchronous we are going to pretend like
it could potentially be asynchronous in
turn require auth into an async function
which means that it's going to by
default return a promise and then we'll
go over here and we will make use of all
of our async functions by using a weight
we're going to await require auth again
even though we currently are doing
synchronous operations with require auth
at some point in the future we may not
anymore and so it will be important that
we wait for require auth to kind of
authenticate the user before we do any
kind of fetching requests inside of our
loaders now most of these loaders are
not doing any fetches and if they were
doing fetches and if they are doing
fetches we are importing them as
functions that come from the components
like this one right here so that leaves
us with two different ways that we can
make sure that we include this await
require auth everywhere that needs it as
a protected route and I actually think I
want this to be a challenge because it
is going to take just a little bit of
critical thinking so let me type out
this challenge
your challenge is to include this await
require auth everywhere that it is
needed in order to protect all of our
host routes and the nested routes
they're in now one thing we can do just
to simplify our code a little bit this
return null is a little bit extraneous I
can just say return await require auth
and that should get the job done as well
so I won't need two extra lines in which
case because I'm using an arrow function
I could simplify this by just having it
do the implicit return on one line which
would then look more like this okay so
let me go to the home page in our utils
we are hard coding that we are not
logged in and so I'll hit refresh and
try to get to the dashboard and sure
enough it's taking us to the login page
let's see if I go to slash host slash
vans
okay and we can see that I'm able to get
to host Vans because we haven't yet
completed those protected routes so that
is your challenge include await require
auth everywhere it's needed and it
should make it because we're hard coded
as being logged out it should make it so
that you can't get to any of these host
routes and you're probably going to have
to type a bunch of them out just to test
so one last thing when it does come to
the loaders that we're importing things
will have to change a little bit as
opposed to just tacking it onto the
inline loader like we've done here but I
think you probably figured that out okay
pause Now work on this challenge
okay well I should be able to just copy
this loader and put it on every line
that is still using an inline loader so
fortunately that covers a majority of
our loaders here okay and then for the
remaining two with our host fans loader
and our host van detail loader we can go
over to host Vans and we need to import
our require auth
from the utils file I'm going to copy
this and just put it right over in host
van detail while I'm doing this okay and
then I'm going to make this an async
function this might have been one of the
trickier things but we did not make this
async originally but now we want to make
it async so that we can await require
off alternatively we could just say
require auth dot then and do promise
resolution that way but I like the await
keyword so we'll say await require auth
that ensures that this function can run
completely before it ever tries to get a
list of the host fans okay and then I
should be able to go to my host van
detail make this an async function and
do the exact same thing okay Moment of
Truth we were able to get to slash host
slash fans before because we did not
have a protected route there we'll go
ahead and refresh
and sure enough that took us to the
login page so if I try to go to slash
host login page slash host slash Vans
let's say slash one slash photos
awesome login page also I feel like once
again it's important that I point out
that there currently is talks on better
ways to handle this where we can include
middleware to the loaders that will run
before any of the loaders so that we
will only have to do this in one place
but for now this is what we have to work
with and even though there is quite a
bit of repetition here I still really
like the way that loaders will run
before the route Transitions and gives
us a more synchronous feel to our
components no longer do we need to
remember about render cycles and what
will cause and what won't cause a
re-render in our component then having
to set up error States and loading
States and all these other things that
were really just about managing the
react render cycle and not about
managing our actual data that we care to
use so yes you might be thinking to
yourself this is so much harder than
just including an auth required
component that wraps everything else but
for one the benefits of using loaders in
the correct way I think outweigh any of
the costs that we have here and secondly
we very likely might be getting a
middleware solution to this problem okay
we've been staring at this login form
for a while now and we haven't been able
to make any use of it now that we are
set up correctly it's time for us to go
in and actually make use of our form and
I can promise you you are going to fall
in love with the way that forms can be
handled with react router using the data
routers that we're learning about so
that's what we get to look forward to
next
here we are back in our simplified app
and what we want to work on next is have
it so that when someone tries to go to a
protected route that there's some kind
of feedback that says here's why I sent
you to the login page for example they
tried to get to protected it sent them
to login we should probably display some
kind of message that says You must log
in first we don't want that message to
show up when they just go directly to
the login page but if they try to go
through a protected route and they are
not logged in we do want to display that
message now over in our auth required
this is the layout component when we
were doing that before we were using
loaders you might remember that we have
this navigate component when you're not
using loaders you can just pass State
similar to how we did with links earlier
in the course you can pass State and
that state could have a message that
says You must log in first this works
because when you get to the login page
you can check the location to see if
there's a state.mess message variable
and you do that with the use location
hook but now that we're not using the
auth required layout route but instead
we're using this utils JS in order to
navigate or redirect people to the login
page we don't have the option to pass a
state message through this navigate
component like we did before so how can
we accomplish this when we are
redirecting to the new location instead
of using this navigate component well
the most common thing that I have seen
is to include a search program that
includes the message that you want to
send along to the page that you're about
to load so in the require auth function
here that's as simple as saying question
mark maybe something like message equals
and then we can include the message that
we want to send so you must log in first
okay let's see what this looks like we
should be able to see that in our
browser so I'll click protected and now
if you look in the URL it says not just
slash login but slash login question
mark message equals you must log in
first you might notice that it's not URL
encoded if I hit refresh it
automatically gets URL encoded where we
have the percent 20 that's representing
the spaces between the words but even if
we didn't have that it would work just
fine so let's go over to the login page
and that is not a dedicated login page
here it's just this H1 which means at
this point it might be worth just
throwing together a quick login
component so I'll do that really quick
okay so now I have this login component
and then instead of rendering an H1 I'm
just going to render my login component
and now I should essentially have the
same thing so I'll hit refresh login
page goes here awesome okay now that we
have a dedicated login component in the
next scrim we're going to see how we can
actually pull in the query string that's
saved in the search param of message so
that we can display it on our login page
then once we've done that we'll go back
to Van life and you'll have a challenge
where you get to implement this in the
van Life app
let's see how our login component can
consume the query string that exists up
in the URL if it exists when it gets to
the login page and actually what I want
to do is have just a quick thought
experiment for you
I want you to think about this in our
login component how should we grab the
search param from the URL on the login
page in the login component in order to
display that message if it exists I'm
not asking how we should display the
message I'm asking how should we get the
value from the search param of message
so I'd actually like you to pause and
think through this try to come up with
an answer if you want you can even click
into here and type down your answer so
pause now and see if you can come up
with an answer to this question
well the first thought that you may have
had if you remembered way back at the
beginning of this course we learned
about the use search for Rams hook which
we can use inside of our component and
then that gives us access to the search
params and a function to set the search
params
and that's equal to use search params
I'm mostly going down this path to show
you that it should work just fine
I can console Log search params and
remember this search params is actually
the native web search params Constructor
or object and so it has a parameter
called dot get and I can ask it to get
the message and we'll go ahead and
console log that so let's just give it a
shot I'll hit refresh open the console
and sure enough we get access to our
search params that are in the URL
however now that we're using the data
router it can be really beneficial for
us to just go all in both feet into
really working with those apis that we
get with the data router including using
a loader so another way that we could
get the search params let me comment
this out is to include a loader so I
will have a loader function and in this
case I don't need to export it because
I'm just kind of stuffing everything
into one file here maybe just for the
sake of keeping our names similar we'll
call this the login loader and the login
loader just like we saw before where it
can have access to a params object it
also will have access to the full
request object this request object is a
native web request object that you could
just go to mdn and learn more about so
let's go ahead and console log this
request and I need to set my login
loader up on my login page so we'll say
that this has a loader that's equal to
the login loader and just so we don't
get that error we will just return null
for now go ahead and hit refresh okay we
can see in the scrimba console that it's
a request object capital r request
object which represents an object that
has a request Constructor and in this
case like I mentioned it's coming from
the web this is not something specific
to react router this request object has
a URL property so I can console log that
and we can see the full URL that does
include the search params at the end if
you look in the console there's the
question mark message equals and then
the HTML encoded you must log in first
so what we can do with that request URL
L is create again another native
Constructor called URL and so I can use
the capital's URL instructor which will
give us a URL object and as I mentioned
this again is just a native web
interface that's one of the things that
if you get involved with the new react
router and the remix team they will
constantly be telling you that they're
just using the platform there's no need
to reinvent the wheel when these tools
are really amazing and they've been at
our fingertips in JavaScript for many
many years if you were to go to mdn and
learn about URL you would also learn
that you can access the search params
object on top of that and that object is
an instance of the search params
Constructor also from the Native web so
if I were to let's go ahead and console
log this whole thing and we can see that
I get an instance of URL search params
this is exactly what we had down here
where we can run this dot get message on
top of it and so let's go ahead and add
that on dot get message and we'll just
console log that whole thing and sure
enough we are back to a place where we
have our message and I know that this
looks a bit more verbose than what we
had before but I would argue that what
you're writing here is much more akin to
Native JavaScript for the web as opposed
to something that has been created by a
third-party Library obviously loaders
and the whole concept here this request
object is being passed in by that third
party library but in the meantime you
have just become more knowledgeable on
the native web so I think that's pretty
cool again I'm probably just nerding out
about this so I'm going to go ahead and
well this is all chained together so I'm
just going to return the message that
comes back from this search params we
can get rid of this return null and now
I want you to think how can I grab the
information from my loader inside of my
login component in fact I'll just go
ahead and make that a challenge
okay so the challenge is to grab the
message that's being returned from the
loader right here and display it on the
login page I'll go ahead and just erase
these two lines and you can display it
either I guess you only have two options
it's either above the H1 or below the H1
and just go ahead and make it in H2 on
the page pause now and work on this
challenge
in order to get information from the
loader we need to use use loader data I
don't need this use search params
anymore so I will grab use loader data
instead and down here I can grab the
message from use loader data and let's
go ahead and console log that message
just to make sure that it came through
okay
okay we successfully got you must log in
first but I am curious before we finish
this up what happens if I just go to
slash login instead okay we do get null
okay so getting a value of null is not
too big of a deal if I try to render an
H2 that has the JavaScript value of null
in it then it simply doesn't display
anything but if you go into the
developer tools it will show a
completely empty H2 which feels a little
bit extraneous to me plus I think it's
informative to do a conditional render
here so that other developers might see
this and know that it's possible that
this message will be null and so I am
going to do that I'm going to instead of
having just an H2 I'll go ahead and do a
conditional rendering that says if
there's a message then I will display an
H2 that has the value of that message in
it and this isn't long enough to be on
its own line let's go ahead and just put
this all in one place okay we're on the
login page we'll hit refresh there's no
message there because we didn't come
from a protected route and then I'll
click protected and awesome we get our
message you must log in first now I know
we spent a lot of time talking about
this message but in the end all we did
was we added this message inside of our
require auth function we added a loader
to our login page in order to load
whatever data might be necessary to
correctly display this page and then we
did a conditional render if that message
exists then display it in an H2
obviously we'd probably want to make it
red or something that will stand out a
little more okay let's go take all of
this new information and apply it to the
van Life app
okay let's put together what we just
learned by passing a message from the
require auth function which is down here
in the utilsjs file that says You must
log in first and display that message in
an H2 below the H1 that says sign into
your account I wrote some CSS that just
has a simple red class and so you can
just add a class name of red to get some
quick styling and yeah that's it I'm not
going to go too much more into detail to
give you a chance to think critically
and actually write all the code you need
so pause now and work on the challenge
well we could start from pretty much
anywhere but let's go to utilsjs and
I'll just say we'll throw the redirect
to slash login question mark message
equals you must log in first okay easy
enough
then I could make a decision if I wanted
to use the use search params hook I
could do that and it would probably work
just fine but again in an effort to
really keep with the theme of loading
any data that we need for our login
component inside of a loader that's
associated with this component I'm going
to go ahead and Export a function
called loader and I already know that
I'm going to need access to the request
and we'll just go ahead and chain
everything kind of like we did before if
it makes more sense to you to split it
out where you get the URL and that's
equal to the new URL of request.url and
then you get the search params and then
you return the value of message that's
totally fine I'm just going to do it all
in one so we'll say new URL of
request.url that will give me an object
of search params which I can use the
method of get on and get the message
okay I'm exporting this loader and
before I can do any kind of use loader
data I need to make sure that I go over
to my route definitions and let's import
it let's see here's our login so we'll
import the loader as login loader and
then add it to my login page which is
right here near the top so my loader is
equal to the login loader okay that
means here I can grab use loader data
and actually you know what I think this
is a Remnant from when I was testing
something before we don't need the used
navigate hook right now so I'm going to
get my used loader data we will do it
right here after state which as a sneak
peek I'm really excited to get rid of
we're going to clean up this form quite
a bit with the abilities that come from
the new data routers so get excited
about that now I can get the message by
accessing use loader data and then just
like I did before I will conditionally
render it and we'll say if there's a
message then we want to display an H2
that contains the text of that message
and has a class name of red okay let's
see how we did we're at the login page
so we shouldn't have any kind of message
when we refresh but now if I go to the
host page which is protected by our
require auth function I get that message
in my URL and sure enough it shows up on
my page I'm going to make a quick
judgment call the H2 looks a little
imposing maybe I'll bump this down just
a tiny bit to an H3 okay that's a little
less intense hopefully all that went
okay I know that was quite a number of
scrims just to pass this message here
but we are going to be coming back and
passing additional things as we are
doing our redirect which will make the
user experience even better but that's
going to happen a little bit in the
future for now it's finally time for us
to come back to our forum and actually
start learning about how forms are made
so much simpler in react router if we
use something called an action which is
kind of a sibling to loaders so get
excited that's what's coming up next
I've got a bit of a hot take to add to
this course and that is the fact that
forms in react are just bad there's a
number of libraries out there that
attempt to make forms in react a little
more bearable but the truth is they're
just a really difficult thing to work
with in react you can get used to it and
you can get good at them but they're
still pretty difficult and the reason is
we try to build a system over the top of
the Native input form elements that
attempts to bypass the State Management
that already happens natively internally
by forms and brings that out into react
and forces react to maintain all of that
information you can see in this form
which I copy and pasted from my learn
react for free course that we have to
create our own state that manages every
piece of data that we're trying to
maintain we also have this handle change
event which is put on every single input
and manually tracks any keystroke or
change that happens to the input in
order to update State and then we have
to control the value so we have to tell
the input that its value is what is
being held in state and all of this is
sort of extra on top of what is already
happening internally from a form you see
originally with forms you would have
your form element you would give it a
method so submitting the form would
usually do a post request or a put
request out to a server somewhere and
you would add an action attribute which
told it which endpoint to send that form
data to and then that endpoint on the
server would take that data it would
process it and it would do something
with it like log the user in or validate
that the inputs were valid or create
some new resource or anything that
normally would be handled by a form so
you've heard me talk about the full
stack framework remix which was created
by the same people who created react
router and what they decided to do is to
instead of completely subverting the
entire purpose of a native form and
overwriting it with our own logic I
decided to use the native capabilities
of an HTML form and remix in some more
abilities with modern JavaScript and
anyway all of this is to say that
there's a perfectly good native ability
for forms in HTML to maintain their own
State and to submit their information so
when the concept of actions was
introduced in react router 6.4 we gained
the ability to sort of go back to those
earlier times when we could make forms
in react a little bit easier to work
with so in the next few lessons we are
going to be refactoring the login form
so that it can use this new actions
feature from react router
we're going to see an example of what I
was talking about where forms in react
are just pretty difficult to work with
compared to Native forms which have
their own State management system and
submission abilities in HTML to do that
we are going to complete a couple of
challenges first of all I want us to
hook up our form so that it at least
kind of halfway works I've done a little
bit of work for you behind the scenes
over in our server.js file I've created
a model for users and I've entered one
user in the server the fake database
that we have once again this mirage.js
server file is not important for you to
understand the syntax of but just know
that I've created a user in our fake
database it has the email of b.com and a
password of p123 you can see of course
we're just saving this raw password here
which is never a good idea but that's
beside the point I've also created this
endpoint here for slash login which is
simply finding the user in our fake
database and if the provided credentials
which is the email and password match
the user in our fake database then it
will return the user object and a fake
token that we have here I've also
created a new function inside of our
api.js file called login user so this is
the interface that you'll be using it
makes the fetch request for you it
handles any errors that might come back
it will send those errors forward if
there are errors but otherwise it will
send that object that has a user in a
token that came from the server so that
brings us to what your challenge
actually is your challenge is to pull in
that login user function from the api.js
file and then call login user as soon as
the form is submitted passing the login
form data that we are just currently are
console logging and one thing to
remember is because login user from
api.js is an async function that means
it's going to automatically return a
promise in which case you'll either need
to create a separate asynchronous
function inside of your handle submit or
you can just use the dot then syntax and
chaining to log that data to the console
and in case that wasn't clear from the
first part in Step 2 you just need to
console log the data that comes back you
don't need to worry about setting
anything else up at this point okay I
think that's enough information for you
to get started so pause now and work on
this challenge
okay let's import our login user
function so we will import login user
from see how far back do we need to go
this is inside of the Pages directory so
we'll go back one directory and get API
I can spell it right API there we go
okay and then instead of console logging
our login form data I can just call log
in user and I'll pass that login form
data and I'm not going to bother at this
point in creating a completely separate
async function here like sign in or
something I'm not going to worry about
that I'm just going to use the dot then
syntax and let's see we will get some
data back and we'll consolid the data
there might be a mistake or two here
let's see how we're doing we'll hit save
and we will enter b.com and p123 hit log
in open the console and perfect there's
our user object and the token that we
were expecting this is the point at
which you might typically take this user
object and save it somewhere so that you
can have access to it elsewhere in your
application for example you might put it
in context so that you can I don't know
display the user's name or their email
address in multiple places you also
would likely want this token to live
preferably in some kind of cookie
although sometimes people might put it
inside of local storage or session
storage however we are going to be
bypassing all of that for now because
that's not terribly important for us
when we're learning react router and
client-side routing in general we're
going to continue opting for kind of a
fake version of authentication so we can
see the routing aspects of
authentication and then it will be up to
you to actually Implement your real
authentication in the way that you want
our next step is to not just code up the
happy path which is all we've done here
we're assuming that login end user is
going to work flawlessly so for the next
part of this challenge we are going to
code up the sad path all with the goal
of embracing actions which I mentioned
earlier is like a sibling to loaders
which will allow us to really simplify
our code and think about it in an
entirely different way which I would
argue is a much simpler way to
understand so that doesn't mean that you
can skip the next steps all of these
challenges that we're doing here are
still going to help make you a better
react developer so I really implore you
keep doing these challenges and then you
will feel even more cathartic when we
get to erase a bunch of the code in
favor of something simpler so at this
point let's move on to the next part of
this challenge
our job is never done as a developer
until we have also taken into account
the possibility of the sad path so
that's what our challenge is going to be
here you can see I even started this on
number three because that's where we
left off the job wasn't quite finished I
won't necessarily read through all of
these steps you should be able to
accomplish everything and I've tried to
specify where you might need to go to
Google in case there is something in
this challenge that you haven't quite
tried to do before but that's okay
that's the regular job of a software
developer so read through these
challenges one by one very carefully
start working on them and when you're
done with the challenge we'll come back
together and work on it so pause now and
code up the sad path for us
okay let's go ahead and add a status
State we'll default it to the string
idle and let's see we'll just do that
maybe right below our other use state so
we'll have a status set status
and that's react.use state with a
default of idle
there we go okay and then when the login
form begins submitting set it to the
string submitting and when it's done
submitting whether it's successful or
not set it to idle again okay so set it
to submitting as soon as the form starts
submitting so right here we will call
set status we'll say submitting and it
might be tempting to inside of my DOT
then to open up that function and set
the status back to idle however because
we are working on the sad path and
there's a possibility of a DOT catch
that will eventually run I'm going to
use a promise chain that you might not
be quite as familiar with and that is
Dot finally this is code that will run
whether the promise resolved or was
rejected and so in here I can set my
status back to idle and that way it will
go back to idle whether or not the login
user was successful okay let's see that
should do it for number three I'm just
going to erase these as we finish them
disable the button when the status state
is submitting so this might have been
one where you need needed to go out to
Google for some answers but on button
elements in jsx and well actually in
HTML there's a property called disabled
and in jsx I can set that equal to an
expression and if it evaluates to true
then the button will be disabled and if
it evaluates to false then the button
will not be disabled and so it says to
disable the button when the status is
submitting so we can say here if status
is equal to submitting this will
evaluate to a Boolean if status is
submitting in other words if submitting
equals submitting then that will be true
and the button will be disabled and
actually you know what this wasn't part
of the challenge but I think I want to
change the text to say logging in if
it's currently in the process of
submitting and so I can do that with
just some basic conditional rendering
I'll go ahead and separate these things
out just a little bit to buy myself some
room and then I'll open up an expression
I'll say if the status is equal to
submitting I'll use a ternary here then
we'll say logging in and we'll do dot
dot but otherwise we'll say log in here
let's put these on their own lines like
this okay and I think we should be able
to test this now I'll hit save and I
guess we can try b.com p123 we'll hit
log in okay it said logging in for just
a brief second it was a little bit hard
to see and we still got our console log
of the data back that's good if I were
to maybe not enter any values in here
that should be an error and okay we get
our object here that is console logging
with the no user with those credentials
found I think we're getting a little bit
ahead of ourselves but one thing that's
nice is because our Dot finally is
setting the status back to idle our
button now says login again if we had
only set the status to idle inside of
our DOT then then it would probably be
stuck in the submitting State because we
never set it back to idle okay let's go
back up we have done number four let's
go ahead and erase that okay let's
actually catch the error that comes back
when we are maybe not submitting
something or we have incorrect username
and password combination so number five
we need to add an error State and
default it to null again we'll just do
that with States so we'll have const
error set error and that is react.use
State and default to null when the form
is submitted reset the errors to null
okay so that's something we can probably
just do here we'll set the error to null
just in case there is an error and then
the user fixes it and hits submit again
we don't necessarily want that error to
stick around that might not make a huge
difference but we're just trying to
cover all of our bases so we'll leave it
there for now if there's an error from
login user add a DOT catch in the
promise chain then we need to set the
error to the error that comes back okay
so we have a DOT catch ready we'll catch
the error and we will simply set the
error to that error object that way we
can save it in state we can start
rendering things on the page age when
that state changes and actually that's
part number six so I'll delete five
display the error.message below the H1
if there's ever an error in state okay
so that would be right here kind of
again to our previous message that would
say you must log in so I guess we can
actually you know what I'm just going to
copy this line down and we'll say
instead if there's an error in state
then we will display oh look we're even
using the same term so I can say
error.message and we'll keep the class
name of red as an H3 and yeah let's
clean this up kind of anticipating that
we did everything perfectly but we never
know let's go ahead and hit save I'll
just click login without providing
anything and sure enough no user with
those credentials found perfect if I
were to say something like C at c.com we
don't have a user with those credentials
and put anything in for the password we
should get the same thing and I guess
one thing that's nice about clearing the
error to null is that when we logged in
it made that error message disappear
which made it much more obvious that we
are having yet another problem with no
user with those credentials found and
it's not just the same one that's from
before by the way if you're wondering
where this message is coming from in the
first place since you didn't code up the
api.js or the server.js editions that I
made that's where they're coming from
login user is making a request to fetch
the data from API login it's passing
those credentials and if there is an
error on the server then it's going to
throw this error which has a message
property with data.message and that is
coming from the server so we go to
server.js and we can see that if there
is no found user then we just return a
401 response and have a message that
says no user with those credentials
found which makes its way back to our
front end and displays to the user okay
that was a lot of work let's go check
out the login page and admire what we've
done and maybe admire isn't the right
word because what we're looking at here
is a ton of boilerplate code if you're
using a third-party form library in
react then you might be able to avoid a
bunch of this also if you're using a
fetching Library like 10 stack query
formerly known as react query or SWR or
one of those other similar libraries you
might be able to avoid some of the
spoilerplate code however we are going
to see how react router has brought back
our ability to use the native form
element its internal state that it's
already able to maintain its ability to
submit that form and then we're going to
process the data from that form and
we'll see just how much simpler our form
can get however before we jump into that
I promise only one more thing we're
going to learn and it's going to be very
quick we're going to see that there is a
programmatic way in which we can send
somebody to a new route mostly so that I
can check that off my list as something
that I've taught you the way that we'll
do this when we start using actions will
be slightly different so like I said I
just want to get it out there and
consider it taut so that we can finally
move on to actions
this last topic is so simple to grasp
that I'm actually not even going to
bother including this as part of a
challenge or an aside or anything like
that I'm just going to show it to you
because then we're going to jump into
refactoring everything anyway we've
learned about the navigate component
from react router if we ever were to
render a navigate component like this
and of course I would have to import it
from react router then it would
immediately redirect us to a different
route that we specify here so for
example if I went to the slash about
page if I hit refresh here on the login
well I need to import of course I just
talked about this let's import
navigate okay let's try again okay so
you can see it tried to load me to the
login page and it immediately navigated
me to the about page so that's just a
refresher of that which we've already
learned that is a component version of
what we're going to learn which is a
hook called use navigate if inside of
your more programmatic code not the UI
code that we have with jsx but rather
the code that's actually handling the
logic if in that code you want to
navigate somewhere you can use the use
navigate hook to get access to a
function that I'll call navigate equals
use navigate and this function when you
call it will navigate you to a new route
in fact under the hood the navigate
component I believe is just using use
navigate and calling the navigate
function so instead of console logging
our data here we might decide that we
just want to navigate someone to the
slash not about let's say maybe slash
host page okay so I'll refresh I'll go
to login and one thing that I did have
to change is over here in utilsjs I made
sure that this head is logged in is true
that way it wouldn't forever redirect me
back to the login page and let's see so
be at b.com p123 login logging in and it
redirects me to the host page there are
options to navigate for example right
now if I hit back I go back to the login
page there's an option I can include
that just says replace true and this
means it will replace my location in the
history stack with what used to be there
that might not make a ton of sense let
me hit refresh I'll log in again p123
I'll hit login but then if I hit back it
takes me to the page I was on before I
went to the login page instead of
creating a new entry in my browser
history for the login page it just
replaces it with the new one for slash
host now one thing you might be asking
yourself is what is the difference then
between using this navigate function and
using the redirect function which we
learned earlier an important thing to
keep in mind about react is that any
hooks that you have like use navigate
they must be run at the top level of
your component code however when we're
working with other functions like we
have with our loader and like we're
about to see with our action function
we're not able to use hooks like this
because this function is not a component
it's not rendering any UI it's simply
helping the component do its job so
while use navigate works if we're going
to be running it inside of a component
like this it's not going to help us when
we're working with loaders or actions
now I do want you to keep this little
nugget of information that we covered
about replacing the entry in the history
stack because we're going to come back
to that and it's also important to note
that if you're using navigate like this
inside of a component you're oftentimes
going to need a use effect in order to
avoid some kind of difficult bugs that
can happen when you're using navigate
okay that's enough delaying I promise
let's move on and finally start learning
about how we can simplify and improve
our forms using react router
we're back here at the super basic
version of our web app that we have and
I've spruced up this login form just a
little bit and our goal is to set
ourselves up so that we can use the new
actions feature with the react router
data layer apis you see natively forms
know how to handle their own State and
they know how to submit to some kind of
backend so traditionally I might have a
property or an attribute on my form that
would say action and I would provide to
it maybe a PHP file let's call it
login.php so that when I submit this
form or rather when the submit event
happens the PHP file would get called it
would serialize the information from the
form either in a query string in the URL
or it would collect it together as form
data and send it to the login.php file
which would then process the data and do
something in response well we don't have
a backend to submit to but maybe you can
see where the name for the action
function which we're about to learn
about comes from instead of submitting
into a back end react router gives us a
component that allows us to intercept
the outgoing request that normally would
happen with the native form and process
that information on the front end
instead so let's get rid of this action
and in order to use the action function
that we're about to talk about we need
to import a capital f form component
from react router which is built on top
of the Native HTML form but we'll use as
a drop-in replacement for it and because
the native HTML form is able to maintain
its own State and has its own way to
submit the data that's in the form we no
longer need to do this imperative handle
change or handle submit functions that
we had before which means I can start
the really exciting Act of deleting some
code I can get rid of my handle submit
which means I can get rid of this whole
function here that feels really good
we're no longer going to be controlling
the state of the form with our internal
state which means I don't need to
control the value and I don't need to
watch for the on change event which
means I can get rid of those four lines
of code as well because we're not using
handle change anymore I can get rid of
this whole function our on submit is
where our navigate was being used we
don't need that anymore and we're going
to let the form maintain its own state
so I can get rid of my react State and
just look at that obviously we're not
working in quite the same way that we
were before but the form is so much
simpler to understand and reason about
and on top of that as we're going to see
if we need to learn information about
the form we don't need to go to the
react documentation on how to handle
forms in the react way we can simply go
to the mdn docs and learn about the form
object and form data I'm getting a
little bit ahead of myself probably
because I'm excited to delete code so in
the next scrim let's jump in we're going
to learn about how to set up the action
function in react router
where a farm would submit typically to
some kind of back end in react router
our capital F form is going to run a
function that we tell it to run the
Syntax for setting this up is going to
look very similar to loaders where we
had a function that we exported that we
were calling loader instead we're going
to create a function called action once
again the actual name for this function
doesn't matter but there's pretty much
no reason not to stick to the Convention
of using loader and action and then in
remix if you're actually building a
remix app I think it does matter that
this is called loader and action now
it's up to you if you want this to be an
async function or not I'm going to
choose for it to be an async function
just to make the syntax a little bit
nicer to deal with
and just like we did with loaders I'm
going to go over to my index where my
route definitions are where I'm
importing my login I'm going to grab my
action and that's a named export so I
need to say action and then we'll just
rename it as login action just for the
sake of it just in case we have other
actions that we were to need at some
point
and where before we had a prop called
loader this time we're going to have a
prop called action and I'll just set up
that imported function as the action on
this route so what exactly does this
mean well if I have anything that
submits a form from my login component
on this login route it's automatically
going to call the function that I pass
into the action prop on that route so
let's go back to login and maybe for now
I'll just console log I'm the action
function
and we're going to submit this form and
we're going to see something pretty
interesting so I'll hit login and it
looks like nothing happened if you have
quite the Eagle Eye you might have
noticed that in our URL it did serialize
the information based on the names of
the form email and password and put them
up inside of the URL log in question
mark email equals nothing and password
equals nothing that might seem confusing
at first but you would quickly learn
that that's the default way that forms
work if you don't tell it that you are
performing a post request as part of
your form then it assumes that you're
doing a get request and in a get request
it serializes the inputs and it puts
them up in the URL however we are going
to be handling our login form as a post
request which means on my form I'm going
to include the by the way native
attribute called method and set it equal
to post now one last thing before we
actually submit this I'm going to get
react router complaining that I'm not
returning anything from my action
function so I'm I'm just going to add
this return null here okay now that I've
told my form that its method is post and
again this is something native to HTML
forms this is not something specific to
react router I'll go ahead and hit save
and let me click on login to get rid of
those query strings again we'll hit log
in and sure enough I get my I'm the
action function console log running now
you probably remember I was talking
about how Native forms would take an
attribute called action where you could
tell it where to submit that information
to like some kind of PHP file and
technically in the react router capital
F form you can also include an action
prop here however the react router form
does a pretty good job of having
sensible defaults where I usually don't
find myself having to include an action
prop at all generally speaking the
default is going to be wherever you set
that action up in your route definitions
so here I told it that the login action
is going to be the action that should
occur on the login path and so that
default will just automatically be
included or understood by this form so
instead of saying action equals slash
login since that's the route where the
action function will be handled I can
just omit that and it'll usually have
the correct default there okay the last
thing I want to do is see that there's
actually an object coming in from the
action function here so we'll go ahead
and console log the objects just to see
what that looks like I'll hit save and
submit and we can see that object has a
request property and a params property
that should look pretty familiar because
that's exactly what gets passed into our
loaders as well and that's where we're
going to get access to the information
that gets submitted in this form that's
what we're going to be working on very
soon but since we've covered a bit of
ground already we are going to come back
to the van Life app and apply what we've
learned over there
all right let's apply what we've learned
about action functions and start
building it into our sign in form in
this case I was pretty explicit about
the steps you'll need to take in this
challenge so just make sure to read
these steps carefully and you should
have a pretty easy time of this pause
now and work on this challenge
okay in order to replace this form with
the capital F form we will need to make
sure that we import that just because
this is getting a bit long I'm going to
go ahead and put things on their own
lines and then we'll import our capital
F form and go down and replace our form
let's see where is it right here with
the capital F form that comes from react
router okay we need to add a method prop
to the farm so right here we'll say the
method is going to be post
and this is getting a bit long I already
know I'm not going to need my on submit
so I will go ahead and get rid of that
and I'll leave this here just so I can
reference it if I need to we're just
going to worry about the form for now
okay so let's see that was number one uh
oh and that was number two okay so we
need to create an action function in
this file maybe just right here below
our loader I'll go ahead and create an
async function called action and I'll
just have it console log action function
and we'll make sure to do the return
null just so react router doesn't
complain to us too much okay that's
number three and then for number four to
register the action function on the
route okay we can do that get rid of
this we'll go over to let's see we're
already exporting it we'll come to our
index file come up to where login is we
have our loader as login loader and
we'll go ahead and bring in our action
as login action
and just like we did let's see where is
here we go loader we'll say action
equals login action
okay let's hit refresh and let's come to
login just so we can take a look at our
code we'll hit the login button and sure
enough the console log for Action
function ran okay let's go back to our
practice app and we'll learn how we can
pull in data from the form so that we
can actually do something with it
okay let's submit our form again so we
can see what gets logged to the console
again we have an object that has two
properties request and params we'll take
just a few seconds to talk about the
params and then we're going to focus
mostly on the request when you see
params inside of our loader or our
action objects that gets sent as the
parameter to the function params is
referring to Route parameters so if our
path were something like slash login
slash colon ID or colon whatever that
would mean that this path or this route
has parameters attached to it that we
could grab from our action function in
fact let me hit save our login is going
to be gone because that route doesn't
exist and we'll say login slash whatever
in the URL we get our login page back we
can go here we'll submit the form and
now we can see that the params object is
not empty it has a property called ID
and the value is whatever because that's
the parameter for this F so it's really
just good to know that in our action
function if we needed access to our
params for example if we were trying to
update one of our existing Vans we'd be
at maybe slash host slash fan one we can
grab the parameter of the URL and say
hey we need to make a request out to
slash API fans slash one which we
grabbed from this object and make
whatever change was necessary let me go
ahead and undo this because that's not
our use case here for the login page
okay now let's talk about the request
object and I think just for the sake of
compartmentalizing the different topics
into their own scrims we're actually
going to do that in the next lesson
okay let's look now at the request
portion of this object so instead of
pulling in the whole object I'm actually
going to destructure it and just grab
the request part in our case we don't
need the params part so we'll just leave
it this way now the reason this is
called request is because in a native
form when you submit it it normally
would send a request out to that backend
file for example I've been calling it
login.php or it could be some endpoint
whatever it might be and the back end
would process that request and do
something with it in our case because
we're just working entirely on the front
end react router with this action
function is basically intercepting that
request and giving you access to it here
in your action function which gives you
the chance to process the information
from the form in whatever way makes the
most sense for you essentially this
action function is replacing the handle
submit function that we had before
inside of our component so what can we
do with this request object well one of
the pieces of that request object is the
form data that's coming from our form I
can get access to that form data by
saying const form data or really
whatever you want to call it is equal to
request dot form data now calling this
form data function is actually an
asynchronous function so I can say I'm
going to await the value that comes back
when the promise is resolved and that
will give me the correct access to my
form data object and this form data
object is the native JavaScript form
data object that you could go to the
Mozilla developer Network docs and read
about in fact if you'd like you can
click the screenshot here to take you to
the mdn docs about form data instances
of form data have a property called get
and so now I can gather information from
the inputs of my form by saying form
data dot get and then I would pass the
name property of the input that I'm
trying to get information about or
rather trying to get the value from so
because this was named email I need to
make sure that I say form data.getme
Mill and for password I'm going to do
the same thing for the password so I'll
say password if this email were named
the name property were something like
blah blah then I would have to say that
get blah blah let's keep it as email for
now just getting it from the form data
is kind of useless to me unless I save
it so we will save it in a variable
called email and password and at this
point I could then just process this
info however I wanted in the case of our
van Life app this is where we would pass
the email and password to the login user
function so let's go ahead and make sure
that this is working correctly we'll
just console log both of these we'll go
ahead and hit save we will fill in
bfb.com and then I'll just do ASDF and
hit login and cool inside of our action
function we now have access to the
values of our inputs since we're here
mentioning the login user function from
our van life app that's a great segue
for us to take what we've learned here
and apply it to our van Life app however
before just jumping ahead feel free to
take some time to play around with this
code if you want you could add an input
or two and try to get the values from
your action function and try to commit
the process that we've done here to
memory because your challenge is going
to be to apply these exact same
principles to the van Life app so that's
what we'll be doing next
okay and now it's your turn to get your
hands on the keyboard you'll essentially
be doing exactly what we did before your
challenge is to pull in the form data
from our form when it gets submitted and
for now you can just log the data to the
console you'll probably notice that
we're still doing all of the more
imperative form handling stuff that we
were doing in react including saving the
form data as part of react state but for
now it should still work if you pull in
the email and password to the action
function and just log it we'll be
getting rid of a lot of stuff here soon
so pause now and work on this challenge
okay our action needs to get access to
the request and with the request we can
get access to a form data object by
saying await request dot form data this
await can be tricky to remember
hopefully that didn't trip anybody up
too much and then once we have access to
our form data we can get the email with
form data.get email and we'll just do
the exact same thing with the password
let's go ahead and console log our email
and password we'll hit save open up our
console type in b.com p123 login awesome
again our action function is slowly
starting to take shape as a replacement
for our handle submit but with a number
of really nice additional benefits that
we haven't yet talked too much about
before we start a major refactor of the
login component code we are going to
take the email password and actually log
our user in and kind of complete that
workflow and then we'll come back and
we'll start cleaning up our login
component
you might remember in our form we had an
on submit event handler that was calling
our handle submit function here this is
the function that was logging in our
user but now that we're using these
actions or this action function we're no
longer logging in our user hopefully
it's not too big of a leap to see that
really all we need to do is to take our
login user function and call it up here
in our action so we'll go ahead and call
login user this function expects an
object that has an email property and a
password property and since we chose to
name our variables email and password we
can use this shorthand to pass in an
object with these properties the login
user function is an async function we
can look here in the api.js file and see
that it's an async function and it's
going to return data but since it's an
async function it's automatically going
to wrap that data in a promise and I can
unwrap that by using the await keyword
so I'll say const data equals await the
call to login user let's move our
console log down here and change it to
log our data we'll hit save put in B at
b.com p123
and sure enough there we go we get our
user object which you might then decide
to put into some kind of authentication
context or into local storage or
wherever makes the most sense to have
information about your currently logged
in user and then we also get our token
which we could save in a number of
different ways oftentimes it's best to
put it inside of a cookie which might be
something that's actually handled by
your server because we did go out of our
way to code our sad path where we have
the different status and the error
states that we're maintaining in our
component we're not quite ready to just
delete everything but we can start down
that path for example right now we are
no longer meeting the state where we're
maintaining the values of the inputs
instead we're using the internal state
of forms to handle that so I can go
ahead and get rid of that local form
State I can come down to my forms and I
can get rid of my on change and my value
props right here we don't need those
anymore that simplifies our form quite a
bit and because we're not watching for
change just in the farm manually anymore
I don't need my entire handle change
function this is a great start we're
going to see that we can clear up even
more of this later but for now we've
made some good Headway and there's one
really small change that I want to make
just to make our app seem a little bit
more realistic even though we're still
doing fake authentication so we'll touch
on that next
in our require auth utility function we
are still hard coding the fact that the
user is logged in and although I'm not
going to suddenly insert real
authentication and dealing with
authentication context saving the user
across the entire app or anything like
that I do want to make it so that in
some form or fashion when we log in from
our form it remembers that we're logged
in and then we can also log out and see
how our app would react to that scenario
so I'm actually going to type this up as
a challenge for you
okay so we're going to be saving the
logged in state to local storage just
again as a temporary way to fake our
authentication I could have just typed
this for you but I figured this might be
a good way for you to navigate yourself
around the app and to think critically
about how this might work and play with
some of the different files that we've
created so when the user logs in I want
you to save a value that we'll just call
logged in to local storage and set the
value of logged in to True maybe instead
of saying save a value we'll say save a
key called logged in and set the value
of that key to true then over in the
require auth function you need to check
if the value of logged in in local
storage is true instead of hard coding
it like it currently is it's a fairly
straightforward challenge it shouldn't
be too difficult if you need a reminder
on how to deal with local storage you
can always do a quick Google search it's
a pretty common thing so you should be
able to find good answers out there and
I need the spell challenge right okay
pause now and work on this challenge
the user is logging in here in our
action function or rather we're calling
the login user in our action function
right now we're still only coding the
happy path but we're going to get to the
sad path later for now we'll just assume
that everything will work well and so
I'm going to say
localstorage.set item with the key of
logged in to the value of true in
reality I think this might get
stringified but that's okay it'll work
because we're just going to completely
remove the logged in value from local
storage when they log out so that's okay
for now we'll get rid of this console
log and then over in our utilsjs instead
of hard coding is logged in we're going
to set it equal to
localstorage.get item of logged in and
that should be it again when we log out
we'll make sure that we don't set it to
false because I'm not sure if that would
work I guess we can test it but we'll
just go ahead and remove the logged in
item completely okay let's hit refresh
and we should be able to test this Now
by trying to go to host so since I'm in
host it appears that I am logged in I
have something in local storage maybe
from testing this previously that says
that I am logged in and now that I think
about it unless I open my developer
tools which is probably what I should
just do I don't have a great way to
clear out my local storage so maybe what
I'll do is just go to my file here in
the index and I'll just type in
localstorage dot remove item logged in
run this code okay cool well it looks
like it sent us to the login page so I
think that worked and then I'll clear
that what we should probably do is put
just a simple button that will be
temporary that allows us to clear out
that local storage okay so we do see
that it says You must log in first
that's good we'll type in be at b.com
and p123 log in and we are presented
with what our next challenge needs to be
because before we were redirected to the
new page with this navigate function
inside of our handle submit but we are
no longer using our handle submit so
that is what we are going to be working
on next
I was realizing that you should actually
know everything you need to know in
order to complete this challenge by
yourself as a reminder the idea is once
somebody successfully logs in they
should be sent to the host route
eventually we're going to add to that to
make it an even better user experience
but I wrote this a little bit vaguely so
that you have to really critically think
you can go look at other parts of the
app if that might be helpful just a
quick hint you're not going to be able
to use the navigate function that's
because we're going to be sending the
user to this new route inside of our
action function and navigate only comes
from calling the use navigate hook which
can only be called inside of a
functional component and our action
function up here is not a component at
all so that's enough of a hint pause now
and work on this challenge
the tool that we need is the redirect
function so I'm going to pull that in
and you might remember that from our
require auth function where we are
redirecting people to another route and
in this case we're including a message
on top of it so back in login.js we will
pull in our redirect and then right here
we will call and actually I'm just going
to return a call to redirect so we'll do
redirect and for now we're going to hard
code in the slash host route we'll clean
up this challenge text and cross our
fingers we'll hit save
login bab.com p123 login and there we go
now something I did just to make our
lives a little bit easier is I included
this little admittedly very ugly button
here in our header that we can click in
order to clear out local storage or at
least to clear out this logged in value
of local storage you can see it over
here on components header if you want
there's the fake logout function and
just a simple button with absolutely no
styling that when it's clicked calls
fake logout now you'll notice that
clicking logout doesn't actually change
the user interface and that's because
react is not observing local storage to
make updates to the UI if that happens
but now if I click host it should
redirect me to the login page because it
knows that I'm no longer logged in or
rather that there's no more local
storage entry for logged in okay
hopefully that went okay for you now
with this redirect included in our
action we have a little bit of a funky
user experience that happens so let me
show you I go to the home page I'll try
to go to the host page it'll take me
immediately to the login page I'll go
ahead and log in bib.com p123 log in and
then if I as the user were to hit the
back button I'm sent to the login page
and maybe what's worse because we have
the query string that has the message
that you must log in first in the URL it
means that this page that we're seeing
makes it look like we're maybe no longer
logged in although I can get to the host
route because technically according to
local storage I'm logged in so this is
kind of a funky experience ideally we
wouldn't be able to see our little
detour to the login page at all
unfortunately in order to do that it is
very very easy we'll talk for just a
second about the history stack in the
next lesson and then see how we can
essentially avoid having the back button
take us back to this login page
as I mentioned making this little user
experience Improvement is actually a
really easy thing to do in the code in
the way that we have our code set up but
I think it's useful to understand the
concept of the history stack just in
case you don't have any previous
experience with it the idea behind the
history stack is that your browser
maintains a you could think of it as an
array of locations that your browser has
visited and under the hood when you
transition from one route to another in
react router it is automatically pushing
new entries to the history stack for you
so that you are able to use your
browsers back and forward button the way
that you would expect a regular app to
work so for example if you show up at
the home page it would enter in the
slash route to your history stack then
maybe you visit the about page so that
would enter in the about page to your
history stack if you hit the back button
it would pop that off the stack and you
would be back at the home page getting
forward again would take you to the
slash about page this is all exactly how
you would expect now let's say our user
is not currently logged in and they try
to get to the host page what exactly
happens well before the host page can
load the require auth utility function
that we set up stops the route
transition from happening and that's
because we set require auth to run
inside of the loader for this host route
and the loader will always run before
the transition to the host route happens
inside of require auth we redirect the
user to the login page and so the login
page is what actually gets entered into
the history stack so that's a good thing
for us however once the user logs in we
are routing them to the host page in the
host page and the login page are both in
our history stack this means that if the
user hits the back button they will end
up on the login page despite already
being logged in now we could change our
setup so that if the user ever gets to
the login page it will check their
logged in status to be totally honest
this is probably the best solution
because then it doesn't matter how you
get to the login page if the user were
to type slash login then it would would
automatically redirect them somewhere
else so that's definitely something you
could play with for the sake of
Simplicity we are going to take a little
bit of a different approach and while
we're at it we'll learn a cool new tool
that we can use so on our login page we
have our form which is our login form we
can add a very simple prop to that form
called replace one thing that takes a
little bit of time to get used to is
recognizing that the submission of a
form is actually considered a navigation
event and so similar to how we had this
little option that we have on our
navigate function that says replace true
this replace true says forget the
current route that you're on just
replace the current route which is the
slash login route since this is the
login component replace it with Slash
host well the exact same thing is going
to happen with our form because the
submission of the form is also
considered a navigation event we can
instruct it to replace the current entry
in the history stack with the upcoming
entry in the history stack and so what
happens is the login essentially gets
removed from the history stack and we
have sort of an amended history here
that allows the user who now is logged
in and is at the host page to click the
back button and go back to the about
page as if the little detour to the
login page never happened so this is as
simple as adding the replace prop to our
form let me put these on their own lines
and by adding the replace prop here when
we submit our login form we will see
that exactly what we saw in this diagram
will happen so I'll go ahead and hit
refresh I'm at the home page maybe I'll
go to the about page I'll make sure I'm
logged out here and then I'll go to the
host route this redirects me to the
login page notice that if I hit back
here I go to the about page I don't go
to host it didn't complete the
transition to host so that never got
entered in my history stack and then I
will go ahead and successfully log in
okay we're at the host route and now if
I hit the back button it takes me
directly to the about page which is just
what we saw in this diagram it's where I
was before I ever made that detour to
the login page the same thing should
happen if I were to clear out my logged
in entry it will go directly to the
login page not via the host route I'll
enter my credentials again log in it
takes me to the host page if I hit back
we're back at the about page just like
before again a more robust solution
would be to first of all not render a
login Link at all if the user is
currently logged in or another solution
could be to just make it so that the
loader of the login page will check if
the user is currently logged in and
redirect them somewhere meaningful if
they already are but at least now we've
learned the concept of a form submission
being considered a navigation event and
this cool new prop that we can add to
our forms if we ever want to ensure that
the history stack doesn't include the
route where we're currently rendering
this form okay we have been working on
our happy path transitioning it from
using our more imperative form
submission methods like our handle
submit function here we've got an action
function that's working fairly well
let's go ahead and start coding up the
sad path using our action function and
moving a few things out of our component
we're back here at our simplified app
and I've created this fake login user
function all it really does is it takes
an object with an email and a password
property it's just hard coding to check
if those are equal to b.com and p123 and
if that matches then it returns
something we're not actually going to be
making use of this right now I just
wanted to have something there if on the
other hand it is unable to log the user
in then it's going to throw an error
with a message of couldn't log the user
in we want to start handling some errors
where if the information that's passed
in the email and password is incorrect
we want to be able to display to the
user that something is wrong before we
started working with the action function
we had to maintain all of our error
State as react State inside of our login
component however now we're going to
have access to a little bit of a better
way now first of all it's important to
know that if I'm in my action function
and I throw some kind of error let's go
ahead and say we're 3 a new error there
was an error okay that's just hard coded
into the action which will happen when I
hit login let's see what happens I'm
going to hit login and we get an
unhandled thrown error this screen that
you might remember seeing before where
it instructs us to use an error element
when an error is thrown inside of our
action or our component or our loader
it's going to then exit out of the
regular element flow of our route
definitions and it's going to look for
the nearest error element now we don't
have an error element anywhere on here
and we've already learned about that so
if you need a refresher you can go back
to the previous part in the course where
we talk about the error elements but
that's not actually what we're concerned
with right now what we're concerned with
is not throwing an error because we
don't want to take the user away from
the login form just because they got the
information wrong instead we want to
keep them here on the login page and
simply display some information that
might help them understand that their
attempt to log in was not successful so
in our action If instead of throwing an
error we return something let me go
ahead and just hard code a string that
says
I don't know couldn't log in this gives
us a chance in our component to receive
the data that we're returning from our
action function and display a helpful
message here in the actual component in
order to grab data that has been
returned from an action function very
similar to how we did in a loader
function we can use a hook called use
action data remember when we return
something from a loader we can use use
loader data the naming convention is
very similar for an action so we will
use this use action data hook inside of
our component and let's go ahead and
just call it error because we know
that's exactly what it is and we'll get
it by calling use action data now think
for a second when I refresh this page
what is going to be the value of this
error variable
remember the action function will only
run after the form has been submitted
and so when we first render this
component we're not automatically
submitting the form and so we can see
when we console log this error that
we're going to get an undefined value so
that just means that when we are trying
to display this error we need to make
sure that we are coding a little bit
defensively which means using our good
trusty friend of conditional rendering
I'll go ahead and say if there is an
error then we'll display maybe just a
little H4 and because the error so to
speak that we're returning from our
action is just a string I'm just going
to go ahead and display that error right
here we do have a little class that we
created earlier called red that will
make this stand out a little bit more so
let's go ahead and hit save we still
have undefined but because we're now
checking if error exists first before
displaying our H4 we don't have any
problems and then I'll click login and
perfect we get the string that we
returned from our action function great
now that brings us to The Next Step
which will be to check for any errors
inside of our action function so that we
can redirect like we were doing before
if things go well or return some helpful
information back to the form so that the
user can take action accordingly so
that's what we'll be doing next
okay let's apply what we just learned
about returning values from our action
function in this challenge where I need
you to add a try catch block that tries
to log the user in with our fake login
user and we pass the email and password
to it if it's successful then you can
redirect the user to the slash protected
route but if there's an error you can
return the error message that gets
thrown from the fake login user function
I put this down here because this is
where you can start your coding you can
just put this above the try catch and
start your try catch right here okay
pause now and work on this challenge
all right so let's open up a try catch
one thing that I kind of like about try
catch is that I can put all of the code
from my happy path inside of my try and
then just catch any errors that might
occur along the way this works for a
simple task like this if it becomes more
complex you may need to either Nest a
try catch or do multiple try catches but
we're not going to worry about that here
so first thing we need to try to log the
user in so we're going to call fake
login user and we will pass the email
and the password and I'm wrapping those
together in an object because the fake
login user expects an object to come in
with an email property and a password
property and I believe this is an
asynchronous function so we will need to
await that I mean we can just come up
here and look so yeah it's an async
function and it's returning an object
that has an email and a token we're not
really using that but just for the sake
of it I'll go ahead and grab it in a
variable okay and then assuming that is
successful which we can do because we
were here inside of our try we can
redirect the user which we need to
import from react router so we'll pull
in redirect we want to redirect them to
the slash protected route and I don't
think it's strictly necessary but for
some reason it feels better to me to
return the redirect so we'll go ahead
and add that there okay now inside of
our sad path if we do have any errors in
the process of trying to log the user in
then we're going to receive that error
and we will just go ahead and return the
message portion of that error there's
more than one way to do this you could
send the whole error object down in case
you needed other properties from that
error but in our case let's just go
ahead and send the message down maybe to
make that absolutely clear inside of our
component instead of calling this error
let's go ahead and just call it error
message that way it's pretty clear that
we are talking about the string message
that comes from our action function okay
let's clean up our challenge text and
give this a shot first let's try to log
in for real we'll do bfb.com and p123
login
here we are at our super secret
information okay we'll click this to log
out try to go to protected that takes us
to the login page and then let's just
try to log in without any credentials
couldn't log the user in perfect okay
with that little bit of practice under
our belts let's go back to the van Life
app and we will implement the same thing
currently our action still only has the
happy path here and so we need to as
part of your challenge remove all of the
error handling that's currently
happening inside of our component and
the error component State and create a
try catch inside of our action so that
our action can handle errors in a better
way like we just practiced now if any of
this seems like it might be a bit
complicated for you that's probably
another good indication that it's time
to go back maybe re-watch a couple of
the last lessons as we have been
practicing doing error handling inside
of our action function because as it
stands if you've been able to follow up
until this point then you should be able
to complete this challenge without too
much difficulty so now's your time to
prove to yourself that you can do it
pause now and work on the challenge
okay so right here is where our happy
path exists so I'm just going to wrap
that code inside of my try catch and
right here we will include our catch of
the error we can actually see what this
error object is going to look like if we
look at our api.js login user function
we can see that if something doesn't go
okay then it's going to just throw an
object that has a message property in
case you weren't familiar in JavaScript
you can throw anything you can throw a
string or a Boolean or in this case an
object you don't always have to throw an
actual error object that's made by the
error Constructor so I'm in this case
throwing an object so that I can include
a message property but also include the
status text and the status just in case
that's useful it's not terribly
important at this time but mostly it's
important to know that we have this
message that is going to come from our
server file okay so in login.js we will
just return and I think we can just
stick to the message I don't know that
we necessarily need the status or the
status text to display inside of our
component so we will just return the
error.message and then we need to use
use action data so I'll go ahead and
pull that in use action data and inside
of our component we can grab the error
we'll say maybe this time we'll also say
error message like we did in our
practice just to make it really clear
that we're just pulling in a string
message and we can get rid of or update
this so it's not error.message or error
anymore we'll say if there is an error
message then we will display this H3 and
we can start getting rid of any of the
error handling that we had before so we
had some error stuff here inside of our
catch here we were dealing with errors
let's get rid of all that and I think
that should be everything we are right
on the cusp of finally getting rid of
our handle submit but we have one last
thing that we're not yet accounting for
and that is these statuses on the state
of our app if it's in the process of
submitting or if it's idle fortunately
we have a pretty easy way to update this
and so that is what we're going to be
learning and adding next
here in our practice app we don't yet
have any code that gives us a good
indication of the status of our app when
we're in the middle of submitting our
form in our van life what we're
currently doing is setting up some local
react state that has a status property
and we're setting that status manually
while we're in the process of submitting
our form however because the form
submission is now happening inside of
our action we can't update our local
component State because the action is
not part of our component it doesn't
have access to our state fortunately
react router gives us a utility that we
can pull in called use navigation this
is not to be confused with use navigate
and use navigation will give us an
object that gives us information about
the current status of navigation in our
app in other words if react router is in
the process of for example loading in a
loader that navigation object can give
us information about that or if we're in
the process of submitting a form like
we're doing here it also will give us
information about that so that's
actually pretty easy we can just grab
the navigation object by calling use
navigation and there's a property on
this navigation object well let's go
ahead and just log the entire navigation
object open up the console I'll hit save
okay and even just rendering our
component for the first time we can see
that it's an object it has a bunch of
different properties but currently the
only one that is not undefined is a
property called State and we can see
that that state is set to the string
idle maybe you can see where I'm going
with this that navigation state is going
to be our replacement for the local
component state that we had set up in
our van Life app so now that I have
access to navigation.state in fact let's
keep the console log here I'll hit
refresh we can see it's idle I'll go
ahead and click login we can see that it
changed to submitting and then it
changed back to idle in our case this is
happening very fast because our login
user function is just checking against a
hard-coded be at b.com and p123 it's not
actually reaching out to any kind of
database and so we don't even see a
delay really but it's cool to see that
we now have access to some navigation
state that we can use when we want to do
things like disable the button in fact I
wasn't planning on doing this but let's
make that a challenge because you should
be able to do this by now
okay your challenge is to disable the
button if the navigation state is set to
the string submitting and also to change
the text to say logging in instead of
just login again if the state is
submitting now because we don't have any
kind of delay in this function I added
this little sleep function which is just
right here it all it does is pause
execution of this function for 1000
milliseconds or one second so that you
actually have a chance to visually see
the change that's happening when you're
logging in okay pause now and work on
this challenge
all right so on our button we can add
the disabled prop and set it equal to if
navigation.state is equal to submitting
and that should handle the disable of
the button and the text we'll go ahead
and wrap this in a JavaScript expression
so that we can say navigation.state I'm
going to spell this right is equal to
submitting we'll go ahead and use a
ternary here it's question mark then
it's going to say logging in but
otherwise it will say login let's clean
up our challenge text and we'll get rid
of this console log while we're at it
refresh okay we'll hit login okay we get
the logging in and don't have a space
there sorry about that so we can see
that's working the button is disabled
and then if we actually log in
we get the same thing and then it
redirects us to the protected route
perfect okay that's how we can set up
navigation States or as we were calling
them in Van life these status so now
we'll go back to Van life and implement
this method for tracking our current
navigation State and that should allow
us to finally get rid of our handle
submit and the status date that we had
one thing I did forget to mention is
that I have a link to the documentation
for use navigation right here so you can
click the screenshot if you'd like to go
read more about it there is quite a bit
more to the use navigation hook and that
navigation object that we aren't
currently using in our app so it could
be fun to go read up on it but once
you're ready we have the challenge of
including use navigation to track the
current status of the form submission
and remove all of the status tracking
that we're currently handling manually
in our state once you've done that and
it's working then you should just be
able to completely finally remove our
handle submit function so let's get to
it pause now and work on the challenge
okay let us pull in use navigate
actually you know what we don't need use
navigate anymore so I'm just going to
attack on to the end of that and pull in
use navigation instead let me just
double check we're not using navigate so
we can get rid of this this is going to
go away when we get rid of our handle
submit function actually you know what
I'm impatient I can't wait I'm just
going to remove that completely wow that
looks so much cleaner okay we're broken
let's go ahead and fix what we have
broken so I'm going to pull in
navigation
is equal to use navigation and you can
probably see that I was already using
the conventions for use navigation just
because I knew that's what it was which
means I can just change status to say
navigation.state instead the idle value
and the submitting value was one that I
chose because I knew that it mirrored
this navigation state so everything else
should be able to stay the same let's
clean up our challenge text we'll hit
save
and let's give it a shot so I'll try
logging in without anything okay we did
see it say logging in although I did
forget to add a CSS rule for it I guess
I can just do that really quick
okay so let's go ahead and try it again
I'll hit refresh logging in okay perfect
no user with those credentials found
we'll log in b.com p123
login and it takes us to the host
dashboard so now we can see that our
form is doing everything that it was
doing before but we've been able to
offload a lot of that boilerplate
imperative stuff that we were doing
before with all of our local state and
we've offloaded it to react router so
that it can handle some of those very
common tasks for us if you've been able
to follow up until this point
congratulations I know that we've
covered a ton of ground we've really
refactored a lot of things including a
complete paradigm shift that you might
not be used to if you've been working in
react for a little while I've heard
someone call these new data layer apis
with react router kind of like remix
Lite and the truth is if you can grasp
what we've been doing here then you
would be really primed to jump into
remix and be able to start creating full
stack applications there's quite a bit
more to learn with remix as well but
you'll be pretty surprised to see just
how familiar remix feels once you've
become accustomed to the patterns of
using actions and loaders changing when
data fetching happens with our
components and all of the benefits that
come there in in the next few lessons
we're going to be touching on a little
bug that we have or maybe it's just a
inconvenience with the user experience
when it comes to redirecting to the
login page for example if I go to a
nested protected route like slash host
slash Vans slash one here and I'm not
actually logged in so I'll log out with
my silly button here and then I'll try
to refresh the page now that I'm logged
out we'll see that it takes me to the
login page and so I can go ahead and log
in but then what will happen is it will
automatically send me to the host route
it's not a bug per se it's just kind of
a bad user experience because what I'm
expecting is to go back to slash host
slash fans slash one one way to fix this
involves two different parts so we'll be
jumping into fixing that for moving on
to some of the last features that we
have to learn
I've made a few small updates to our
practice app here first of all I've
moved the inline protected component
that we had it's really just an H1 and
the inline loader function that it had
over to its own separate component file
here so we have the actual component
right here again it's just an H1 but
this way we have a separate loader that
lives over here I'm importing the pieces
that I need like redirect from react
router and a new require auth function
which I just put over here in its own
utility file here called require auth
also for the sake of demonstration I
added another nested route so now the
protected route is apparent to this one
that I just called nested and then I
added a link to nested here on the
navbar now I'm currently logged in just
to be able to show this if I go to
protected takes me to slash protected
and if I go to nested it takes me to
slash nested in the URL actually you
know what the nested has this H1 and the
reason it's not showing is because I
need my Outlets so I'll go ahead and put
that in here and we'll just wrap this in
a fragment
and put in our Outlets okay so now with
the nested route we have this nested
protected route H1 showing up and again
that is just here in line just for
simplicity's sake okay so those are just
some simple updates I've made and the
reason that I did that is because let me
go ahead and log out let's say we want
to get to this slash protected slash
nested route which I can get to by
clicking this nested link here so I can
go ahead and do that it takes me to the
login page I log in with bfb.com p123
and because of the way that we've
written our login component up here in
our loader we have hard coded that it
should send us to slash protected in our
case that's not terribly difficult to
then just get to the nested route by
clicking the link but the point is if we
did have some kind of complex nested
route that the user was trying to get to
and they were redirected to the login
page if we just hard code that we want
to send them to slash protected it's
kind of a weird user experience let's
say for example they tried to get to
this nested route by clicking a link
from their email and maybe it has some
kind of user ID in it that isn't
accessible by navigating somewhere on
the site but instead you have to get
there at least it's much easier to get
there by clicking the link in the email
if we hard code that we're sending them
to the slash protected route then
they're going to have to open up their
email clients again and click on the
link again now that they're logged in
hopefully it opens in the same browser
and still has the same session they
don't have to log in again so I'm hoping
that you're seeing a limitation by hard
coding the slash protected route here
when we redirect the user after logging
in so what we are going to focus on is
making it so that if the user let me log
out again and try going to the nested
route if the user is redirected to the
login page that we make it so that after
they log in they will be redirected to
that nested page instead of the
hard-coded slash protected route now in
the past we have been able to get the
path Name by using the use location hook
that comes with react router and we
could make that work however because
we're now using the data layer apis with
three act router 6.4 we have another way
that is a little more congruent with the
new paradigm that we're using you see
our loaders and our actions will both
receive access to this request object
let me go over to my protected route
loader and pull in that request object
and we will go ahead and console log the
request actually let's do request.url
well actually no let me let me do
request first we'll hit save
I'll make sure I'm logged out I'll go to
protected and we'll open the console
okay so we see that we have a request
object and this request object is the
actual native web request object it
comes from the request Constructor you
can go to the Mozilla developer Network
docs in order to learn more about
request and request objects have a
property called URL which gives us
access to the URL now we'll be able to
see that when I refresh and click
protected we get the entire URL and it's
just a string in our case because our
mini browser is running on the scrima
platform it shows our full protocol we
have https and then the cw1.scrima.com
as our base URL and then at the very end
we see Slash protected now I could go
out of my way to try and grab the slash
protected portion of the URL using some
kind of string manipulation but another
thing we can learn is that we can
construct a URL again using the native
URL Constructor so let me actually set
this as a variable I'm going to say
const URL equals new URL and this
Capital URL that comes from just web
apis so this Constructor is just
universally available as a Constructor I
can use as long as I'm writing my
JavaScript code or the front end and
when I pass the actual URL the string
URL by accessing that request.url I've
now created a URL object let's go ahead
and console log
URL
okay and I'll try to get to protect it
again okay so it's string representation
is showing up exactly the same but
what's nice about this URL object is I
can actually access properties like path
name for example you might remember when
we were using the use location hook the
location had something called path name
and that is just coming from this URL
object and so if I were to console log
url.pathname go to protected I now have
immediate access to the path name that I
was trying to get to and if I go to the
nested route I can see that it gives me
the full path name of the nested route
protected nested now I do want to
address something here I think for maybe
the untrained eye this might seem like a
lot of additional work to get to just
the path name having to pull in the
request object and create a new instance
of a URL object and then access the path
name property but to be honest having
been in the game for a while now I
didn't really take the time to learn
some of these platform apis like the URL
Constructor until this became pretty
much the right way to do this in remix
and by association react router so
honestly I actually really appreciate
that I've spent a lot more time learning
native web apis and spending time on the
Mozilla developer Network docs then
having to parse through a bunch of
Google results and stack Overflow
questions hoping that I get the most
modern answer based on the newest
version of react router but instead I
can just spend time on the Mozilla
developer Network docs and find the
information I need because it's using
the platform it's using the constructors
and the tools that already exist in the
web okay we've spent quite a bit of time
just to get to this url.pathname but
hopefully you can see in the end all I
did was pull in the request create a new
URL object and then access properties
from that object so for the sake of time
we're going to end this scrim here and
in the next scrim we will talk about how
we can make use of this so that after
the user logs in they can be redirected
back to this url.pathname so that's
what's coming up next
Okay so we've started diving into the
Weeds on how we are going to solve this
problem we now have access to a URL
which has a path name property that we
can use but what exactly is the overall
strategy I think that might be helpful
for us to look at remember it's our
require auth function that is in charge
of redirecting users to the login page
and then the login page is in charge
let's see where is the action function
right here is in charge of redirecting
users to the route that they're supposed
to go to and this is what we're trying
to fix remember we don't want this to be
hard coded to slash protected so that's
kind of the workflow that we have the
protected loader runs that calls require
auth that redirects people to the login
page and the login page once they
successfully log in redirects them to
the route that they were trying to go to
so how do we get information from our
protected route which is where we have
access to the request and easy access to
that path name to the require auth
function and then from the require
author function to the login component
well we saw very briefly when we
redirect a user using the navigate
component or the use navigate hook we're
able to pass some State through the
navigation event to the next location
and that location object can grab the
state that was passed to it however
those are Hooks and those have to happen
inside of components and mostly we are
working inside of the loaders and
actions because of that the most common
way is for us to pass information
through the URL so actually right here
in require auth when we redirect someone
to the login page I want you to think
for a second how can we pass information
using the URL
we can use search parameters or query
strings just like we did in Van life
where we said question mark message
equals
you must log in first we can use this
same strategy to pass information from
our require auth function to the login
page and then have the login page make
use of that information to redirect us
back to the correct spot so the next
question then is how do we get this path
name that we're able to access on our
URL object to the require auth function
so that we can include it in a query
string maybe this would be a query
string like redirect to we'll set that
equal to some question marks for now and
actually this seems like the perfect
opportunity for a challenge
okay so your challenge is to figure out
how you can get the path name from this
URL object from this loader into the
redirect to query parameter inside the
require auth function right here where
the question marks are so let's come
back here to the challenge text okay
pause now and work on this challenge
one approach you may have taken was to
just pass in the URL dot pathname
directly to the require auth function
and then over in require auth we would
receive the path name and just stick it
into the query string right here however
I happen to know that I'm likely going
to be calling require auth in more than
one place which means if I did it this
way I would need to run this code and
this code every time I wanted to use
require auth so instead of that I'm
going to copy this line and get rid of
it and then just pass the entire request
object down and that way require auth
can do that logic and figure out exactly
how to get the path name so we'll say
it's receiving a request object and I'll
paste in that line I'll even make a
separate one that says dot path name
actually I'm just going to tack on dot
pathname since that's all I really care
about and then we'll change our URL to
say path name and then now that I have
that value I can stick it here in inside
my string I'll make these into template
strings so I can do my interpolation
here and just say we're going to pass
the path name as the value to the
redirect to query string okay we've
covered a fair amount of ground for one
scrim so in the next scrim we're going
to see how we can from the login page
grab the redirect to Value that's right
here so that we can correctly redirect
back to the right spot when the user
logs in
so we are sending users to the login
page we're passing the information about
where we want them to redirect to after
the login is successful so I want you to
pause here and think where will I need
to write code next
okay if you said that we need to go to
our login page and our login component
you would be correct but if that was all
that you came up with I want you to
think even more specifically I'm here
inside of my login file that has the
action and the login component a couple
helper functions that are just helping
us kind of fake authentication for now
so more specifically where am I going to
receive that query string that should be
coming in through the URL remember as
long as I'm logged out and I try to get
to one of these protected routes I now
have redirect 2 equals slash protected
slash nested in my URL so again more
specifically where in this file
login.jsx am I going to receive this
redirect to Value so that I can well
redirect to the correct spot
well technically I would have access to
it inside of a loader function if I
created a loader function I would be
able to access the request object
however the loader is not when I want to
redirect to that new location it's right
up here in the action we already have
access to our request and so I can use
this request to grab the URL grab the
search params from that URL and use that
as my redirect value right here on line
31. so right here above our try we will
maybe just get our we'll say const path
name is equal to and then I can just
grab the URL I'm going to do this all
kind of chained together so I'll say I'm
going to create a new URL from
request.url that's going to give me a
URL object and then I can grab a
property on it called search params and
that is an object that has a get value
and I can grab the search param with the
redirect to key which should get me the
value in this particular other case as
we can see in the URL slash protected
nested let's go ahead and console log
that we'll cancel log the path name and
because this is inside of my action I'm
only going to see this console log if I
try to submit my form so I think I can
just hit login and sure enough there it
is slash protected slash nested so all I
need to do now is to replace this
protected with path name okay let us
give it a shot I'll refresh make sure
I'm logged out I still have my redirect
to in the URL so I don't need to change
anything there we'll go ahead and log in
bfb.com p123
log in
and oh we were so close what happened
here is our slash protected slash nested
route is running a loader as soon as it
loads and we did that inline right here
but we are missing something from this
function can you think of what it might
be
well we taught our require auth that it
will be receiving a request object and
we did that inside of our protected
loader here but we did not do that
inside of our nested loader so one thing
we could do is just grab the request and
pass it along to require auth that
should fix this problem okay here we are
on the nested route alternatively we
could go to require auth and make sure
it only does this if request exists I
think since we have it fixed right now
just by passing in the request inside of
this loader that's probably going to be
good enough for now actually now that I
think about it we might have to do it
that way since we want to be able to
redirect back to the nested route we
need to make sure that if the require
auth ever gets run here then it will
pass that request through successfully
so it's a good thing we tested that
let's just make sure again I'll make
sure we're logged out go to the nested
route that took us to the login page I
guess that was a little hard to see
because we were already on the login
page I'll go home and then nested that
take takes us to the login page be at
b.com p123 and okay here we are now one
last final thing I'm going to log out go
to my login page and log in like normal
bfb.com p123 it logging in and we get a
problem it's taking S2 slash login slash
null so this is an interesting one I
think it could be a good exercise if you
want to try and see if you can debug
that you can pause now if you'd like to
do that and then we'll be going through
it together
okay so why is this happening well let's
go through the regular workflow just to
try and debug this in the login page
this action is going to run every single
time we submit the form whether we are
coming to our login page via another
route that we're trying to redirect back
to or if the user actually clicks the
login page when they click the login
page there is no query string for
redirect to which means when this line
runs this path name is going to be null
because the URL does not have a search
param especially not of redirect to it
doesn't have any search parameters and
so calling.get on something that doesn't
exist will return null and then we're
kind of stringifying that when we put it
inside of our path name it's going to be
null and because it's a relative path
it's not setting it up as slash null for
example I mean this would be like a
string but it's not slash null then it's
using it as a relative path to the login
page which then takes us to slash login
null a really easy fix for this would be
to choose a default where we say or if
that is null let's just go to slash
protected so let's try this again we'll
get rid of that console log hit save
we're just on the login page there's no
query string there we'll type in our
username and password and great that
took us to the default route of Slash
protected and now if I log out again and
try to get to my nested page Log In
perfect our redirect is working just
like it was before okay we have covered
a ton of ground let's go back to the van
Life app and see if you are able to get
your hands on the keyboard and complete
the challenge of implementing this
redirect to pattern that we just did
over there in our van Life app
okay here time to shine your challenge
is to implement the redirect to feature
like we just did in our practice app but
here in Van life I've given you some
starter instructions just since it took
us a little while to get there in the
last app this way it can be a bit of a
refresher so make sure you read through
numbers one and two really carefully and
then for number three you are on your
own for the last part but I know that
you can do it pause now and work on this
challenge
okay we are going to pass the request
objects to every function call for
require auth that happens inside of our
protected routes of course so let's go
to maybe let's start here in our index
and we'll just see all of our inline
loaders that we have that are nested
inside of this host path we need to add
the request object here and I think
there's some more down here host and
info pricing and photos so we will go
ahead and receive that request object
and then we will pass it through to
require auth and then inside of the
other loaders that are separately
defined but only the ones that need to
be protected with require auth so that
is our host fans loader and our host van
detail loader and I think that's
everything so let's see where are we
here nope not Vance under host host Vans
okay this loader right here this needs
to receive the request object and pass
it to require auth and then the same for
our host van deta until we're already
receiving params so we will just also
pull in request asset 2 require auth
okay that is a good start let's go to
require auth and that should be
everything for one we'll go ahead and
clear that out then require auth is
going to receive the request we'll
construct a URL actually we can just do
it all in one we'll say the const path
name is equal to new URL
request dot URL and then we'll use dot
pathname to grab the path name that the
app was trying to get to when we were
first trying to get to the protected
route without being logged in okay and
in this case we already have the message
that we're passing through this is
important for us to keep so we are going
to add another one on top I'm going to
change this to template strings and I'll
just put this on this online so that it
can be a little easier to use and we
will add in with an ampersand we'll say
and redirect 2 equals and then we'll
pull in our path name
okay so this alone we should be able to
test let's clear this out and since
we're on our own for the last part we'll
clear out the rest of this challenge
let's hit save
okay and then I'll make sure I'm logged
out I'll go maybe to the home page and
then I'll go to host okay and if we look
closely we have the whole thing up there
we have slash login question mark
message equals you must log in first and
redirect to equal slash host perfect now
for the last part we need to go to our
login page receive the search params so
that we have access to this redirect to
in the URL and then use that as our
value for slash host or rather in place
of the hard-coded slash host that we
have here so actually we already have up
here where we are grabbing the search
param for message so I'm just going to
copy this because I guess I'm a cheater
and right here we will say that our path
name is equal to and then I'll just
paste that in but change this to
redirect to since that's the key that
we're trying to get the value from and
maybe I will put this on its own line
just in case that's getting a little
wide for anybody and I'm going to have a
default of Slash host that way if
someone is coming through the regular
your login workflow where they actually
manually go to slash login we're not
going to get null in its place okay so
we'll take this path name and that is
where we are going to redirect to let's
hit save
we will log in be at b.com p123 okay so
that took us to slash host that's where
we had been trying to get to before I'm
going to go somewhere more deeply nested
let's go to Vans maybe one I'm going to
log out and then try to get to pricing
okay great we can see in the URL
redirect to equals host slash fans slash
one slash pricing let's go ahead and log
in again
p123 enter and here we are perfect great
work I know that may have been a
challenge especially that last part
since I kind of took the training wheels
off and let you ride on your own if you
did struggle with it and you had to
watch me do it that's completely okay
but now is the perfect time to scrub
back and to try the challenge again
maybe from the very beginning all by
yourself great work and I'll see you in
the next grim
at this point in this course we are
really rounding the corner on the final
topics that we're going to learn about
react router and at this point we are
starting to venture into some more
advanced territory it's nothing to be
worried about we're going to go step by
step so that we can understand
everything we're learning but it also
will touch on a couple topics in react
not react router but core parts of react
that you may or may not be familiar with
I'll try to give a bit of an overview of
them but we won't be diving deep into
those topics specifically the topic of
suspense the motivation for what we are
about to learn can be seen here in this
little weather app that I created
clicking on the weather link which I'll
do in just a second will get the weather
for the current location where I'm
recording this and the API is actually
not very slow so what I've done in the
utilities.js where I'm creating this get
weather function I've added a three
second pause just to make it so that
it's as if getting the weather took a
bit longer than it actually does and
this is really to highlight one of the
things that you certainly noticed when
we first introduced the idea of a loader
see the benefit of a loader is that we
can write our code as if the data always
exists at the time of rendering this
component for example I can say that
loader data is equal to use loader data
and I don't have to do optional chaining
or any kind of ternary check to make
sure that loader data exists at the time
this is being rendered otherwise I could
get some kinds of Errors for trying to
access the property main of undefined
for example that is a nice benefit but
you might remember from Van life when we
first implemented the ability to go to
the Vans page and load up the Vans we
used react state to show that we were
currently loading the Vans and we had a
nice little loading message so that the
user when they click the link would
immediately go to that page and be
informed that the Vans are loading when
we switched to using a loader because it
does the fetching before the component
renders there's quite a bit of a pause
before you switch to the next route so
here if I click whether I will click it
right now
three seconds feels like an eternity
especially when you're not navigated
anywhere and it doesn't feel like
anything really happened so on the
developer side we get some nice benefits
by knowing that our weather component
will only load after the data has been
fetched and is ready for display but on
the user side we have a bit of a worse
experience so over the next few lessons
we're going to be learning about using
deferred data this is going to give us a
chance to bring back that user
experience where clicking the link on a
route that needs to fetch data will
transition us to that route immediately
and it will give us a nice API that
allows us to render some kind of loading
state in the meantime all of which we
will be able to do without creating any
of our own manual react state so buckle
up and get ready to dive into world of
deferred data
it's probably safe to assume that some
of you watching this might be a little
bit hazy on your understanding of
promises and how promises work I won't
have time to dive deep into promises but
one thing that I wanted us to remember
is that when a function is an async
function it will always return a promise
so when I say await get weather that's
an indication to me that get weather
returns a promise because a weight can
only be used on a function that is
returning a promise if I go over to my
utilsjs we can see that get weather is
an async function and therefore it is
always returning a promise when we say
return data what's really happening
under the hood is we are returning a
promise that if it's resolved we'll
return data it's not important that you
have that perfectly memorized or
understood the point that I'm trying to
make is that when we have our loader
function and we are calling a wait get
weather What's Happening Here is we are
waiting for the get weather call to
finish and remember get weather is
sleeping for three full seconds before
it even executes the fetch request and
then naturally the fetch request is
going to take some time to complete as
well and with loaders the code inside of
my loader needs to complete before the
component will ever get rendered by
react that's beneficial to us because we
know here that loader data will be
accessible to us no matter what unless
of course there's some kind of error in
which case this component shouldn't get
rendered anyway it will have some kind
of error element that gets rendered
instead but in order for us to bring
back the benefits of switching to the
route immediately before ever kicking
off the request in our loader function
we need to use a utility that comes from
react router Dom called defer the entire
process that we're about to go through
starts with react router knowing that
its loader function is allowed to wait
or defer the loading of our weather data
to a later point and therefore will not
block the user interface from loading or
more specifically it won't stop the
weather component from being rendered
before the data is completely gathered
from the get weather function now we're
not quite done yet because weather is
still the actual value because I'm using
this await keyword which is pausing
execution of my loader function so I
need to get rid of a weight which means
that weather is no longer the actual
resolved data from get weather I want
you to pause for a second and think what
kind of construct in JavaScript is this
weather variable now that I've removed
the await keyword
well we can actually console log this
let's console log whether I'm going to
remove my defer right here and we'll
probably get some errors here but let's
give it a shot and see if at least okay
good we can see that weather is not the
actual weather instead it's a promise
object so just for clarity I'm going to
rename this weather promise now that
we've gotten rid of a weight there we
can get rid of our console log and let's
bring back our defer call now what defer
expects is an object and the key of that
object is what I want to call the data
that eventually will get resolved
whenever the promise gets resolved and
I'm going to pass to it the promise that
eventually needs to get resolved and
become the weather data that will get
passed down to my used loader data I
understand that we jumped around a bit
so I'm going to undo everything and just
show you that we actually haven't
changed all that much
okay this is where we were before we
needed to import defer we're going to
remove our await forget weather which
means that this is not really the
weather it's a promise to get the
weather then we're going to call defer
pass to it an object give it a key of
whatever we want to call the data that
we are deferring till later and then
pass to it the promise that it should
work on resolving for us and putting at
this part in the object that's coming to
loader data the tricky thing about
learning this and partly why I call this
an advanced topic is because there's
quite a bit to put together before any
of it will work so for the sake of
practice I'm going to once again undo
everything and have you type this out
again so if you need to take a look at
what we just typed in again try to
commit it to memory because you're going
to be typing it in just a second
okay let's do it one more time start
setting up our deferred data just like
we did together and of course you can
scrub back for a reference if you need
to jog your memory again the tricky part
is we're not quite ready to have this
actually work for us so you're just
going to have to try and do it for
memory pause now and work on the
challenge
okay let's start up here again we're
going to pull in this defer utility
get rid of a weight
we will call defer we're going to pass
an object where the key is what we want
to call the data when it gets pulled
into use loader data and the value is
the promise so let's call this weather
promise this part is not strictly
required it just makes it a lot easier
for another developer to understand
what's going on here and we'll pass this
in now of course we could gain some
shorthand benefits if we just kept this
as weather because I could then just say
weather but for the sake of learning
we'll do this again I don't have a great
way to test this yet because we have
quite a bit more work to do down in our
component so that's what we'll be
jumping into next
okay let's add defer to the loader of
our vans route I added another one
second delay on our server so when I
click the van so we can see that it does
take a little bit of time to get over
there in the end I think it's important
to remember that it's just a trade-off
that you have you can simplify your
developer experience and also
parallelize all of the loaders so any
nested resources can be more easily
retrieved and as we get closer to adding
fur await and suspense we're going to
see that we can bring back some of the
snappiness that we got when we first
started using react router that way when
we click the Vans route it will take us
here immediately and we'll have some
kind of indication that the Vans are
loading okay so for now your challenge
is just to add the fur to our loader
which is up here and then there will be
more to the challenge later I have a
quick reminder here in case that is
helpful so pause now and work on the
challenge
okay let's go ahead and import defer
from react router I'll put these on
their own lines just to make it a little
easier to read okay and now I can return
a call to defer we'll wrap our get Vans
get Vans is going to return a promise
notice that this is not set up as an
async function and we're not using the
await keyword so git Vans is going to
return a promise just because that's
what it does in the API file and I need
to wrap this in an object and we'll call
the value that is going to be resolved
maybe Vans like this okay short and
sweet as I mentioned we still have some
steps to take in order for this all to
work together so let's go back learn a
little bit more and then we'll come back
here to Van life
if we try to get to our weather page now
we'll see that well we are broken and
that's because the protection that we
had before where we could be certain
that our loader data would be defined
and ready for us to use when our weather
component was mounted is no longer the
case and that's because we are allowing
the loader to defer for a later time and
we're no longer awaiting our get weather
call so the next piece in this puzzle is
to use a component from react router
called await a weight does a few
different things first of all it allows
us to surround the code that we will be
waiting for when this component first
renders and it will conditionally render
only after the data has finished loading
it'll make a little more sense if we
just do it so I will put in my await
component and this will not be a
self-closing but instead will take some
children and I'm going to move this H3
and this image out and just comment it
out for now we'll bring it back in in
just a minute and there's two major
parts to the await keyword that we need
to use the first one is a prop called
resolve our job is to pass the promise
for the data that we're trying to get to
this resolve prop and I want you to
think for a second where am I going to
get this promise from well up above we
are returning this object that has a
weather property and we're pulling in
loader data kind of like we had before
except before it was the actual data
let's go ahead and console log loader
data and we might still have this
unhandled error thrown but let's see if
it logged that to the console okay
loader data is an object that has a
weather property whose value is a
promise so that's the promise that we
need to pass to resolve in other words
we give our promise to this await
component I'll call it loaderdata dot
weather and under the hood the await
component will take that promise and
after it has been successfully resolved
it will call a render prop child
function earlier in the course when we
were talking about Dynamic class names
with the nav link component from react
router I mentioned that if you are
taking this react router course as a
part of my larger Advanced react course
we will have already talked in detail
about render props and how they work if
you're taking this as a standalone
course you may or may not be familiar
with the concept of render props but as
a quick high level overview I can can
pass a child to a component and that
child doesn't necessarily have to be
another component we're very used to
having parent-child relationships with
our HTML or our jsx elements like we
have already here but when I have a
custom component I don't necessarily
have to pass another jsx element as the
child to my component instead I could
pass a function for example and the code
of that component could take that
function and run it passing any
arguments to it that it wants to that
was a really quick rundown of render
props and probably didn't do it justice
so I'd recommend going and checking out
my Advanced react course to get a much
more in-depth look at render props that
said the await component does use render
props as a child and when our promise
finally gets resolved it will pass to
this function the loaded weather and we
can call this whatever we want but in
our case it makes sense to call it
loaded weather and loaded weather will
be the data that we used to be calling
loader data so inside of this function
is where one we can have access to our
loaded weather for example this icon is
going to be broken because loader data
is a promise and does not have a weather
property that's actually the error that
we see over here it's saying that we
can't read the property icon of
undefined and so I'm going to bring in
this URL assignment inside of my render
prop over here
and I can make the changes needed like
changing loader data to loaded weather
in fact let me move this console log
down and we will console log our loaded
weather so we can see what we're working
with and there's a chance we'll have an
error let's take a look
okay and it did take a full three
seconds plus a little bit to actually
render anything on this page but you can
see that the loaded weather is the
weather object that we were working with
before and because the await component
will only render the children inside of
the render prop or rather it will only
call this child function after it has
finished resolving our data we can again
like we had in our original setup be
sure that loaded weather will exist when
we're writing our code here so let me
get rid of my console log and I do want
real children to exist here so I'm going
to return the markup that I want to
display when the loaded weather has
finished actually loading so I'll open
this up and I'm just going to put a
fragment and then pull in
these components that we had before now
at least we're not broken let's hit save
we'll see that it will also take a bit
of time for it to load so I'll hit save
right now okay and then lastly we need
to update loader data here to be loaded
weather
and let's go ahead and hit save again
I'll hit save right now okay it's
working obviously we haven't quite fixed
the user experience issue but we were on
the weather route of course we could see
that even the navigation bar didn't
render which is a problem of its own
that we're about to fix and cool well it
might seem like we're done but once
again there's a lot of pieces to making
this work in the way that we would
expect and we can actually get some
insight into the problem that we're
still facing if we go to home and then
go back to weather we'll see that it
says a component suspended while
responding to synchronous input that
doesn't necessarily have to make sense
but it is something that we are going to
fix by using a tool that comes directly
from react not even react router this
time but from react before we plow ahead
because we have covered so much ground I
want to get your hands on the keyboard
practicing these things I know that we
covered a lot of ground here and it may
start to look a bit complicated but the
truth is all we did was we added an
await wrapper around the code that we
wanted to display after the data had
been loaded and we put that markup
inside of a child function that will
receive the successfully loaded weather
and allow us to return whatever user
interface that relies on having that
successfully loaded weather let's bring
this back over to Van life so we can
practice this and then we will come back
we'll learn about suspense and then come
back again to Van life and apply it
admittedly the code in our weather app
is significantly more simple than the
code here in our van Life app and so
I've made a note of this your challenge
is to implement a weight however it's
important to note that the code here is
more complex and so rather than maybe
spood and feed you the answer or set you
up perfectly for solving this I think
this might be a good opportunity for you
to really put on your critical thinking
hat and see if you can solve this on
your own really quick I'll highlight
what the issue that we're going to face
is and then I'll leave it up to you to
figure out a solution there's going to
be more than one way to solve this in
fact we're going to see two different
ways so the issue is before when we were
pulling in vans from use loader data we
had the Vans available to us but now
because we're using defer we just have
an object that has the ability to
resolve fans eventually the benefit that
we had before was we could just assume
Vans were available to us but because we
are deferring the loading of our vans to
after the route transition happens we
have to make some other tweaks the
reason this is a problem is because we
are making use of this Vans array for
example when we filter the Vans and
create our display Advanced variable and
then we map over that in order to create
the van elements and then at the bottom
we render our van elements way down here
at the bottom so you're going to have to
think carefully about where we use our
await component because I can't just put
it here inside of the rendered markup
near the very end because because at
this point in the code it has already
attempted to make use of the Vans array
even though it's still an object with a
promise inside so give this your very
best shot I understand this might be a
little more difficult but I also think
it's really good to stretch yourself and
push yourself in order to grow so pause
now and work on this challenge
okay so one thing that I think will help
us figure out how to organize this would
be for us to accurately name what's
going to be coming back from use loader
data because the name Vans implies that
we have access to the Vans I'm instead
going to change this to something like
data promise maybe this way I can
immediately know that I'm going to have
some problems when I try to for example
filter over the Vance Ray because I
don't have access to the Vans array
anymore so let's go down to where we're
starting to return the elements that we
have and I need to decide where I want
my await to live I think it might be
okay for us to leave our H1 as soon as
we get to this page because it's not
waiting on any data but I don't know
that I want my filtering buttons to
display if the data isn't there so maybe
right below my H1 I'm going to include
my await component
and I need to make sure to import that
and then let's just wrap everything that
we have below it that'll go down to here
and we'll format this okay and then the
await component will take a resolve prop
and we're going to pass data promise and
in our case we would just specifically
want to wait for the Vans array to
resolve then await expects a child
function so I need to enter into
JavaScript and then put in my function
here and we'll open that up and this
function is going to receive the array
of Vans as the data now that I have
access to this Vans keyword I can just
take everything above it that was
expecting to have access to Vans and
move it inside of that child function so
I want to have all of my van elements
because that relies on displayed vans so
I'll need to bring in display Advance
which relies on the Vans array so I'll
just go ahead and cut all of this and
paste it down here where to go inside of
my await render props function here so
we'll paste it and format it okay and
then I have all of this markup that I
need to be returning as the children
elements so we'll go ahead and cut that
out and right here below our van
elements we will return and then we'll
paste that back in and I think we have
an issue here because we're trying to
return two divs so let me just wrap
these in a fragment and perfect okay
that seems to fix that Let's cross our
fingers and hope for the best we'll hit
save
okay and we have an issue right now
where the entire screen shows up as
blank we're going to be fixing that very
soon but we have our vans data showing
up awesome okay as far as a weight is
concerned this is a great start we could
just leave it like this but I did want
to show just for the sake of learning
another way that we could solve this
problem it's actually only going to be
one extra Step Beyond what we've already
done and then we'll be able to learn the
final piece we need in order to get the
user experience back that we're hoping
for which we'll be able to show a little
loading State here when we get to this
component so I know this challenge might
have been a little bit difficult if it
was that's completely okay as I always
say it's important for us to get
experience by trying these difficult
things so if you weren't able to solve
it on your own that's okay as always
just scroll back and try again remember
there's nobody that's giving you any
kind of grade by completing this course
faster it's more important that you
grasp the concepts that we're learning
and reach out to the community for any
help you might need for just kind of
plowing ahead so take all the time you
need with this code try rewrite writing
it again if you'd like and when you're
ready we'll move on and see another way
we could solve this
we've seen one solution where our await
keyword is up here pretty high inside of
our return and then we just grabbed
everything that was above it everything
that was I guess preparing the elements
to be displayed and just shoved it down
here inside of our return so everything
is just happening right here in line
this isn't terrible by any means but it
is a little bit difficult to parse and
to read because everything is so deeply
nested but if we think about it what we
have here is a function that is handling
all of the preparation for what should
be ultimately displayed so one thing we
could do and again like I mentioned this
is just a minor refactor but hopefully
it will improve the readability is we
can take this whole function I'm going
to go all the way down here to right
here where the function ends and we'll
just cut this out and we can see that
was the right level because we just have
an empty set of curly braces now and
then before my return I can just Define
a new function and maybe we'll call it
render and elements and then let's paste
the fun function that we just created
and it just doesn't need to be an arrow
function per se so I'll just go ahead
and tidy this up I'll format this and so
now everything is multiple layers less
nested and I personally think is a
little bit easier to read and then we
can simply pass the reference to this
function inside of our await way down
here at the bottom so I think at least
this has simplified the level of nesting
and it's also simplified our return and
then if we really wanted to clean this
component up we could make kind of a
utility helper function where this
function render van elements might sit
inside of a different file and then just
import it if we really wanted to so
let's hit save and see if this works in
the first place okay we did get the
delay where the screen is blank again
that's what we're going to be fixing
next but everything seems to be working
and we can go into one of the nested
bands perfect now it's time for us to
solve the last little problem you can
see if I click back to all Vans we
actually get an error displaying saying
that a component suspended while
responding to synchronous input the fix
for this is not something specific to
react router but instead react itself so
next we're going to start learning about
the suspense component in react
here we are back at our trusty weather
app and you might remember that we had a
little bit of an issue I'm going to go
ahead and refresh this and we'll see
that it's blank for a couple seconds and
then all of our data gets loaded in at
once not only that but if I go to
another route and then try to come back
to whether we actually get an error that
gets thrown we can see that it says a
component suspended while responding to
a synchronous input this leads us to the
final piece in our puzzle of actually
creating the user experience that we
originally set out to create and that is
by using something that comes from react
called suspense you can click the
screenshot here to go directly to the
react documentation on suspense it's
fairly thorough so you're welcome to
read through the entire thing if you
want I'm not going to be teaching all of
the ins and outs of suspense as a part
of this course I'm simply going to be
showing you how we can use suspense to
finally get to that finished point that
we've been trying to get to this whole
time react has introduced the ability
for mostly libraries third-party
libraries to suspend and rendering of
your react application until something
has finished the benefit of this is we
can treat our components as if they were
synchronous like we see here where we're
pulling in loader data and then we are
just rendering what we need with that
loader data instead of initializing our
fetch request after the weather
component is being loaded and then
having to maintain the loading State and
the error State and all those other
things that we used to be doing suspense
allows us to wrap our suspended
component which is this await component
in another component called suspense now
I can just say react dot suspense here
or if you don't like the dot syntax you
could separately pull in suspense like
this just to be totally clear that
suspense is coming from react I'm going
to leave it as react.suspense for now
I'm going to put my closing tag down
here after a weight and we'll indent and
then the last thing that I need to do is
provide a prop called fallback the idea
of fallback is that it gives react an
element to render while it's waiting for
the other component that is suspending
to finish in this case I can just put
maybe an H2 that says loading and maybe
I'll be a little more clear and say
loading weather and with that simple
addition I can hit refresh we see
loading weather and then we get our
weather now notice that I put my
suspense boundary you could call it
underneath my weather in Salt Lake City
H1 if I were to move this up by one
let's go ahead and indent that I'll hit
save and we just get loading weather it
doesn't have that H1 displaying anywhere
and then it displays what is inside of
the suspense boundary because I have
this text hard coded it probably doesn't
need to be inside of the suspense
boundary but of course if I wanted to
pull the city from my loaded weather
which actually is part of the data that
comes in then I would just need to move
this down inside of this callback
function so it would be down here where
I'm returning the weather specific data
I think the way it currently is right
now is probably fine now that we've
added this suspense boundary we also are
handling that exception where this
component was suspending and so I can go
back to my home and let's go ahead and
refresh just for giggles and then we'll
go back to weather we get loading
weather and then we get the weather
loading in finally we're back to a point
where the user experience is a lot
smoother and sure we've had to learn a
lot along the way and make quite a few
changes to the code but in the end I
don't have to maintain all of that
error-prone react state in the meantime
it's all being handled in a very
declarative Way by other libraries okay
I've talked quite a bit let's practice
this in two phases I'm going to erase
what I did and have you do it again and
then we're going to move back to the van
Life app again and have you implement it
there as well
okay simply put your challenge is to
implement suspense pause now and work on
the challenge
maybe just to see it the other way this
time I am going to pull in suspense as a
separate component up there we'll just
clear out this challenge since that's an
easy one to remember
and we will just wrap our await in the
suspense component
okay and we can't forget I need to give
it a fallback property this is the
element that will display while it's
waiting for the suspended component to
finish and so we'll just put back our H2
that says loading weather hit save we
get loading weather and then we get the
weather okay let's jump back into van
life and Implement what we've learned
short and sweet to your challenge is to
implement suspense pause now and work on
the challenge
the error that we saw earlier was that
the component suspended while responding
to synchronous input and that component
that's suspended is our await component
way down here at the bottom so any
components that are going to suspend we
need to wrap in a call to
reacts.suspense I haven't imported it
separately so I'm just going to call it
react.suspense and we'll move this down
here in indent and then lastly we just
need to provide a fallback prop and I'll
just be a little bit boring again we'll
just say loading Vans okay let's refresh
okay we get explore our van options and
we had our loading Vans H2 there for us
while things were loading in and we're
back to a really Snappy user experience
now I do want to be totally clear it's
not that big of a deal if you don't want
to go out of your way to include a
weight suspense and defer because maybe
the transition to the new route is not
taking very long we need to remember
that I did include a delay right here
inside of our server so it's pretty much
manufactured delay I'll come back here
to Vans and then we'll click on the
vents route and we can see that it's
pretty Snappy anyway even if it were to
delay for a half second or so before
coming to the new route in the end it
really just depends on what user
experience you want there's one last
thing that I just want to touch on
really quickly and that has to do with
this defer function you can see we have
changed this to be an object and that's
because if we did want to include
additional data maybe there was
something like the user that we needed
to pull in and we say get user then we
could have different await boundaries
and suspense boundaries depending on
what data we want to display first or
what data we do or do not want to defer
on if there was some data that was
absolutely crucial for us to load before
we even transition to this route then we
do have some flexibility because we can
come to our function we can turn it back
into an async function into any pieces
of data that we want to delay
transitioning to the new route for we
can just include a weight in front of
the Promise by doing this it means that
the route transition will not start
until this get user function has
completed but if the get Vans function
takes longer than the get user function
then it will transition as soon as the
user is ready and will get our suspense
boundary while the get Vans function is
still resolving in our case we don't
have any use for this per se so I'll
just go ahead and delete this but I just
wanted to round out our experience there
by mentioning that just in case that was
useful to you at some point in the
future by the way that is actually
documented inside of the Deferred guide
in the react router documentation so if
you do want to learn more about it you
can go there for more information now
we've been working exclusively inside of
our vans component here but we still
have changes to be made in the van
detail page the host Vans page and the
host van Details page all of these are
using a loader and could potentially be
using defer like we just did in our vans
page so for the sake of some X or
exercise we are going to implement defer
and await and suspense over in our host
Vans route so that's the challenge that
we'll be doing next
practicing one little piece at a time I
think can be really helpful for grasping
the concept of something but it's also
super important to take the time to put
all of those little pieces together and
challenge Yourself by doing them all at
once it's kind of like learning a new
language you could memorize little
phrases here and there but the real
growth will happen as you practice real
conversations and put those phrases
together and also challenge your own
understanding when you're listening to
someone else speak to you maybe I'm
extending the metaphor a little bit but
it's similar with music you can practice
small sections of a piece of music but
it's a whole different experience to put
it all together and what people are
expecting is not for you to just perform
a small piece but to put the whole thing
together and it's the same with our code
here so your challenge is to implement
defer await and suspense here in the
host Vans route so pause now and work on
this challenge
okay well we know already we will need
to import defer and await so I'll just
do that now and inside of our loader we
are going to return a call to defer
let's wrap that in that function and
defer expects us to pass an object and
we'll give it the key of Vans okay so
now this should be a promise that will
get resolved eventually but we will not
wait for the route transition to happen
but instead we will defer this data for
after the route transition happens okay
so inside of our host Vans we were
calling this Vans maybe let's call this
I think we chose data promise before
let's just stick with that we'll say
data promise is coming from userloader
data and our host van elements needs
access to vans in order to successfully
complete the map so let's do what we did
before where we create a function and
that function will be in charge of all
of the rendering tasks here so we'll
create a function that we'll just call
render let's say render van elements
that's going to take the array of Vans
and we can move this host fan elements
inside of that function and I'm going to
keep my H1 like we did before but we
will return this so let's cut this out
and inside of our render van elements so
I guess it will be right here we'll
paste that in actually we need to return
that so I'll type in return and then
paste it in and now we have a function
which will be the render prop child
function that we pass to the await
component so let's render weight and as
the child of a weight we will render the
van elements and we need to tell it what
it needs to resolve that's going to be
our data promise dot bands okay and
since await will suspend rendering we
need to provide the suspense boundary so
that's with react dot suspense and
lastly we just need to provide the
fallback finally all back prop so that
it knows what to do of course this is
where you'd probably be better off
putting something a little fancier like
a fun spinner of some sort or maybe
something animated that makes it a
little more exciting than just saying
loading bands but for now this will get
the job done okay let's see how we did
we'll clean up the challenge text and
hit save
okay and it was it was pretty brief it
showed up as loading Vans for just about
a half a second while it was loading I
guess I can come back to my server and
putting this timing delay and hit save
we'll see if that makes a difference
let's hit refresh
okay we get loading Vans and then the
vans come in this way the transition to
the Vans page is really Snappy and we at
least get some kind of feedback that
says that the rest of the UI with the
Vans is still loading awesome work I
hope that went okay putting it all
together can be a really good experience
especially when we see in the end it
truly wasn't that much work to do and
instead we got to simplify quite a bit
of our code or at the very least we got
to give a little bit of a better user
experience to our users now at this
point we still have our van detail page
and our host van detail page which is
not using defer await and suspense but
for the sake of not beating a dead horse
I'm going to actually Implement those
myself for the next Grim that said if
you would like to practice this even
more you can go to the van detail page
and the host van detail page and do
exactly what we just did in the host
Vans page Implement defer await and
suspense just to get a little extra
practice I'm going to leave it up to you
I trust you to know that if you need
more practice with this you have have
some places where you can do that more
practice and if not you can move on we
have just a couple of little Loose Ends
to clean up so that's what we're going
to do in the next lesson
look at us here at the end of this
project just dotting some eyes and
Crossing some T's before we can finally
call it done one thing we can look
closely and notice is that we are still
doing a little bit of manual error
handling here we are maintaining our
error in state and down here we have an
early return for the error but a while
back we did learn about the error
element property or prop on routes let's
see let's go back to our index here and
if we go up here on our vans route we
have this error element that is handling
this for us but we haven't yet
implemented that everywhere that we
might need it as a reminder the error
element will render this error component
anytime there is a thrown error either
inside of this route or inside of any of
its children routes if you've ever
created an error boundary component
using class components this essentially
gives us a really declarative way to
create those error boundaries on the
route level but we have only done it
here on the Vans path so let's open up
our vans page again where our challenge
text is your job is to remove any menu
manual error handling code which I
believe is only in this component this
Vans component right here and also to
set up an error element for error
handling on the following routes that I
have listed here as I mentioned we
created an error component that you
should be able to reuse for those error
elements that you put on the routes so
pause now and work on this challenge
okay well let's get rid of our react
State here and this early return we
don't need those and actually this
should be pretty simple I'm just going
to check just to make sure but it looks
like I don't have any react state that
I'm maintaining here or any error
handling over in my host Pages we've got
host Vans yep it looks like we already
removed the error handling there and
host man detail same thing there okay so
we should just be able to go over to our
index page and honestly I'm just going
to take this error element of air and
start pasting it everywhere that needs
it this is our van detail page we want
it there we also want it see here we
have a loader that is grabbing some data
we'll put it there and with our host van
detail page okay let's hit save we're
going to log out just to make sure that
we're logged out we'll go to the host
page you must log in first if I try to
go to slash host slash Vans okay we get
the same thing
login
okay that loads just fine and then we
can really test this by going to the
server and here on the Vans page I have
this commented out just in case I needed
it again we're just going to hard code a
400 level response from the server and
I'll go to Vans and okay it's not super
pretty we could probably make some
improvements here but at least our app
is not completely crashing because we
have this error boundary let's undo this
so that we aren't hard coding an error
and we'll refresh just to get our vans
back you have been doing an amazing job
following so far so you should
definitely take the time to congratulate
yourself and if you've been sitting down
for a while maybe it would be a good
time to get up stretch take a breather
walk around outside if the weather
permits and really soak in that good
feeling of everything that you've
learned and accomplished in this course
while we're on the topic of dotting our
eyes and crossing our T's I do have a
little present for you so I'll reveal it
to you in the next scrim
now we have been staring at these
default dashboard goes here income page
goes here Pages for far too long and so
my surprise to you is that I have
completed them for you however to be
honest I've taken some pretty serious
shortcuts here just for the sake of
getting the design up if we come to the
income page we can see this graph well
it turns out this graph is just an image
and the image is completely static it's
not pulling data from anywhere I've done
the same thing over in the reviews page
we have this reviews bar chart and this
is just an image that's being rendered
here if we go to those pages the income
I just created uh transactions data
array That We're looping over and
displaying same with reviews we just
have some reviews data hard coded right
here inside of our component of course
if we were doing this for real and we
actually had a server where we could get
this data from we would be pulling this
in inside of our loader instead of doing
it in any kind of use effect here inside
of our component at this point in the
course we have covered all of the topics
that pertain directly to react router
that we planned to cover I suspect you
have spent a fair amount of time on the
react router documentation as I have
sent you there a number of times
throughout the course so when you find
yourself working in react router in your
own projects hopefully you not only feel
really comfortable with the topics that
we have practiced and learned but also
feel comfortable going to the
documentation and learning what you need
to learn I also can personally recommend
that you check out the remix Discord
server since react router is a part of
remix if you have any questions about
react router there's a really great help
Channel there that some of the core
contributors to react router and remix
will oftentimes be able to answer
questions from in the last part of this
course we are going to be jumping into
using Firebase as our mode of storing
our data and grabbing data from a real
database online our mirage.js server has
served us really well throughout the
beginning parts of this course and as a
final way to tie the bow on this app
we're going to migrate our data to Cloud
firestore which is a part of Firebase
and refactor our app so that we are
pulling data from a real database
as I mentioned mirage.js has been an
awesome server for us thus far however
it's time for us to move on to a real
online database so that we can really
round out this project piece and if
you're someone who's searching for a job
especially if you're just learning web
development for the first time using a
service like Firebase can be a great way
to get real data real API endpoints that
you can reach out to without necessarily
having to build and maintain your own
server and database so for this lesson
we are going to walk through how you can
set up Firebase and specifically we're
going to be using firestore which is one
of firebase's databases so that we can
migrate our data over to Firebase and if
you are following along here on
skrimba.com then this would actually be
a great time to stop following along
here on scrimba and actually download
this code to your local machine and
follow along on your local machine
instead in order to do that you can go
down to the little gear icon in the
lower right now at some point in the
future scrimba's design is going to
change so it's possible that this gear
icon may not be exactly here in fact
everything my might look completely
different but either way you can search
the app for this option that says to
download as zip or at least worded
something similar to that once you
download this project to your local
machine and unzip it you should have
access to a folder now I'm going to be
using vs code for my editor you can open
that folder in whatever editor you
prefer and then you need to install the
dependencies now I've done that here all
in one line with this double Ampersand
so what I did is I ran npm install or
npmi for short and as soon as that
finishes I'm going to run the
development server by using npm run Dev
you can see that under the hood we're
using Veet in order to package and
bundle everything up and it should be
really quick when you do this once
that's all set up you should have a new
folder called node modules in your
project and it should tell you that you
have a local environment the default I
think is at Port 5173 where you can open
up this project locally okay at that
point we can head over to the Firebase
home page you can click the screenshot
here to head directly there and once you
are there on that site you can click the
button to get started that'll take us to
a screen where we can create our first
project so we'll click the button create
a project we'll enter a project name I'm
just going to call it van life and we
can hit continue at that point we'll be
given the option to include Google
analytics in our Firebase project if you
would really want to this will take a
bit of extra setup so for now I'm just
going to uncheck that and then click
create project we're then sent to a
loading screen and when it's ready we
can click continue and that will drop us
into this project overview page which is
sort of a dashboard for this van life
project Firebase projects can consist of
multiple different applications like for
example if you had an IOS app that was a
dedicated IOS app and a dedicated web
app for now we are only concerned with
the web so I'm going to click this
little angle brackets web icon here in
order for us to register our web app we
need to give it a name so I'm going to
just put in Van life here or if you knew
ahead of time that you were going to
have other apps you might call this
something like van life web and then
I'll click the button for Register App
and this will give us some important
installation information that we are
going to need so this would be a great
time to click the little copy button or
of course you can highlight it and copy
it if for some reason that gets lost
after you copy it that's okay it's
pretty easy to get back here and I'm
going to show you how to do that once
you have that you can click continue to
console and this will drop us into the
web app that we just created for Van
life and the next step is to tell our
van life project that we want to use
firestore as our database so probably
the most accessible thing is just to
click the Big Orange rectangle here that
says cloud firestore or over on the left
you can drop down the build option and
click the firestore database there
clicking either one of those will take
you over to the cloud firestore homepage
where we can click this create database
button it's going to ask us if we want
to start in production mode or test mode
and this is kind of an important thing
to understand about Firebase you might
have noticed that a couple slides back I
was completely okay exposing this API
key and if you are familiar with the
concept of API Keys usually you want
these to remain secret for most API keys
that I've used at least they expect that
you keep the API key hidden you don't
commit it to your GitHub repository and
you only make requests using that API
key from a server of some sort however
Firebase is a little bit different and
that's because they use something that
they call security rules in order to
secure your data so you can see here in
production mode if you look closely it
says allow read write if false which
means that nobody not even yourself
could read and write data to your
database this is their way of forcing
you to take the time to learn about
security rules and actually Implement
what makes the most sense for your needs
but for us we're going to be okay just
starting in test mode which basically
says you are allowed to read and write
for about the next month from when you
created this database for now that's
going to work okay for us you will need
to make sure that you look up a little
bit about how to create security rules
with Firebase but for now this is going
to work okay for us so I'll go ahead and
click next it's going to ask us to set
our location you can click the drop down
and just choose the location that is
closest to you geographically and then
click enable that will drop you into the
cloud firestore database view where once
you have some data in here you'll be
able to actually peruse the data and see
all of the data that you have in your
database what I did on my instance of
this database is I actually just copy
and pasted the data that we have from
our six van objects and put it here in
Cloud firestore for us so that as we
start doing our refactoring we are
primed to grab that data from firestore
and that is it we have set up our
Firebase firestore for us to start
making changes to our code and even
though that may have seemed like a lot
of different steps to take if you think
of the alternative which would be to
spin up your own server and connect the
database and have database structures
and everything set up this truly was
like a walk in the park so let's jump
into our code and we will start making
refactors so that we can pull data from
our Firebase firestore instead of using
our fake mirage.js server
one really nice side effect of us having
put all of our fetching code here inside
of our api.js file is I won't have to go
to all of my components in order to
change where I'm getting this data from
right now we're doing a fetch request to
this local API which is handled by
mirage.js and all we need to do is
change where that data is getting
fetched from so that's what we're
primarily going to be working on but
first we need to set Firebase up in our
code so that we have the ability to
access our data from firestore you might
remember me asking you to copy down that
configuration object if you did great we
are about to use it if not it's pretty
easy to get back to from your Firebase
console you can click on the gear icon
in the upper left and choose project
settings that will take you to the
project settings page and on this
General tab if you scroll down to the
bottom you'll see that configuration
object again and you can click the
rectangle to copy that so that we can
use it then back in our api.js file I'm
just going to paste that in and we can
just clean up some of the these comments
for now and I'll give a little bit of
space before our actual API functions
just so we can clearly see what is
Firebase related now Firebase is a whole
Suite of different tools and firestore
is just one of those tools here we have
initialized an application which will
allow us to connect to our van Life
Application in Firebase we also need to
write code that is specific to firestore
so I'm going to import a function called
get firestore
which will come from Firebase
slash firestore now one of the major
benefits of firestore that we actually
aren't going to be using very much is
its ability to have real-time data in
other words I can create a connection
between my application and the database
and if that data ever changes in the
database my application can listen for
those changes and without any prompting
on my end refresh my user's view so that
the data can be real time this is
perfect for applications like a chat
interface where you want a new chat
message that gets pushed to the database
to also immediately display on your
front end without the user having to do
any kind of refreshing of the page
however in our case we are not going to
be using any of those real-time features
from firestore and so I found there is
actually a subset of this package
Firebase firestore called slash Lite
which is a lighter weight version as the
name would imply of the full firestore
library that allows you still to do
reads rights updates and deletes but
without including any of those real-time
features so because I don't need the
real-time feature I'm going to go ahead
and use the slash Lite version of this
library but if you do feel like you want
to play around with the awesomeness of
firestore's real-time data then you can
just delete this slash light at the end
now that we have access to this function
called get firestore I'm going to create
a database object which I'll be using
anytime I need to interface with my apps
firestore database and so I will set
that equal to get firestore and I need
to pass in the app that we just created
when I was initializing the app and with
that we should be set to start
refactoring the fetching functions that
are currently reaching out to mirage.js
so that it will instead be reaching out
to Firebase so that's what we'll be
starting on next
right from the start I'm going to show
you the documentation for firestore you
can click the screenshot to go over to
the documentation one thing that I
noticed as we are using this web version
9 which is more modular is that it
includes a lot of nested function calls
for example when we want to get
documents from a certain collection most
of the documentation shows calling this
function called git docs and inside of
that you pass a call to the collection
function and inside of that you pass
your database like the one that we
created and the name of the collection
that you're trying to get this might be
completely fine to you maybe this makes
perfect sense it makes sense to me but
it's still a little bit confusing it
also requires a lot of duplicated code
where I'm going to be writing collection
DB and in our case Vans multiple times
so I'm going to do it a slightly
different way I'm going to reference my
collection in a separate variable so
I'll call it maybe Vans collection ref
and set that equal to a call to the
collection function I'll pass in my DB
that that I created and pass in the
string Vans before anything else I need
to make sure that I pull in the
collection function because this is
something that comes from Firebase and
if you're wondering why this string Vans
is here if you remember back a little
ways when I was creating the data I had
created a collection that I called Vans
if I had named it something different I
would need to put that different name
here now first things first before we
move on I lost a lot of hours trying to
figure out when I was practicing this
why my requests out to Firebase weren't
making it all the way to Firebase in
fact they weren't even making it to my
network tab in my developer tools and
the reason as it turns out is because
mirage.js was intercepting every request
that goes out this makes a ton of sense
when you're using Mirage because you can
make a regular fetch request in your
code and not have to worry about it
trying to reach out to a real resource
or anything however it did cause me to
pull my hair out quite a bit as I was
trying to figure out why I couldn't get
any data from Firebase but fortunately
mirage.js has a really easy function
that we can include called this Dot
passthrough and we can put any URLs that
we want mirage.js to allow outgoing
requests to so if you're following along
suppose one thing you could do is just
delete this import server from your
index file or I think maybe a better
solution would be to use the this dot
passthrough function and just make sure
that you include this URL so that any
requests out to firestore will make it
past the sort of net or sieve that
mirage.js puts up okay let's go back to
our api.js file and start working on our
get Vans function I think what I
actually might do here is comment this
out as I start working on them and
create a new version of it so I'll just
export async function get Vans and maybe
I'll worry about this ID thing later if
I need to something that can be really
helpful to understand about Firebase
because of those features where it can
have a real-time component to it anytime
we go to get data from Firebase it calls
it a snapshot the reason is if we were
to make a request to get the list of our
vans and then after we got the data back
let's say a tenth of a second later that
data were to update somehow the data
that we just got from Firebase would
technically be outdated so the
terminology of snapshot starts to make a
lot of sense because it's sort of like a
snapshot of the data at that given point
in time but with the understanding that
it could have changed even perhaps
immediately after we finished making our
get request to the firestore database so
that's just a preference as to why I'm
about to name this variable a snapshot
so we'll call it query snapshot and that
is going to come from a call we'll use
the await keyword it's going to come
from a call to the function called get
docs I need to pass the collection
reference that I want to get the
documents from and that's going to be
our vans collection ref and what we'll
come back will not just be an array of
documents but instead will be this
snapshot of the query of the documents
really that just means that it's going
to have a bunch of additional metadata
about the docs that come back when we
take the snapshot so what I'm going to
do is take that query snapshot and turn
it into a data array that hopefully we
can make it so that it mirrors the same
data structure that we're already
expecting in our component files so that
we don't have to go make a bunch of
changes to our components so I can do
that by mapping over the documents that
come back in the query snapshot I can
access those by saying I need my equals
so we'll say equals query snapshot dot
docs and this one is an array of those
documents and I can map over that array
I'm going to look at each one of the
documents in that array and I'm going to
return an object and I can just do that
in line by surrounding my object in a
set of parentheses just so that it
doesn't confuse it with me opening the
body of this function and I want to
include all of the data from the
document so I can get that data by
saying doc dot data and then calling
that as a function and as it turns out
this data does not not include the ID of
the doc and so I also want to include
that as a property here that I specify
with doc.id this ID could be something
that is generated by firestore when you
create your documents or in our case I
created this manually so that I could
just have the simple IDs of one two
three four five and six okay we went
through that blazingly fast I guess as a
side note it's important to know that
I'm going through this Firebase
information more as a reference instead
of actually teaching it and that's
because in the scrimba front-end
developer career path we introduce our
students to Firebase pretty early on in
the career path and much of this has
already been taught so I just want to
preface why it seems like suddenly Bob
is going really fast through this
information instead of making me sit and
practice it so let's go ahead and
console log our data array and then we
need to make sure that we also return
the data array so that it can be used by
any loaders that are calling get Vans
now if I try to load up one of my van
detail Pages it will probably be broken
because the old version of get Vans was
able to take an ID and those van detail
Pages need to pass in an ID so let's
just avoid doing that for now I'm going
to go back to my home page and then
we'll click the Vans page oh okay well
actually this error boundary has been
really helpful I called get docs and
let's see where was that right here and
I forgot to import it so sorry for
anybody that was screaming at me to
remind me to import that okay let's try
saving okay so our vans came in we have
our console which is displaying all of
the information that we have saved in
firestore what's really nice about the
way that we have this setup is I didn't
have to make any changes to my
components or my pages because we had a
nice separation of concerns where we had
these API functions that are in charge
of getting the data that is needed by
the pages we can just make changes to
those functions and get the data from a
different place as long as that data is
in the same shape you could say as what
we had before everything should just
kind of work out the component shouldn't
really care how how or where the data is
getting fetched from you really should
just be taking that data and displaying
what it needs to display accordingly
okay we still have a bit of work to do
because right now if we click into one
of these we can see that a bunch of
information is missing and that's
because we have altered our get fans
function it no longer has the ability to
take an ID so next we will start working
on being able to fetch data on a single
document so that we can fix this page
in the earlier iteration of our get Vans
function we had this one that was a bit
overloaded it was able to take an ID and
if it had an ID then it would call out
to this endpoint and if it didn't have
an ID it would call out to this endpoint
I'm going to just make an executive
decision to split these functions into
two separate functions one really good
approach when you're creating these
functions is to make sure that your
function can do one thing and it does
that thing really well this will also
help with unit testing if we were ever
to add unit testing to this project so
I'm going to create a new function we'll
export the async function we'll call it
get van just singular and that will take
an ID this does mean that we'll have to
go into any files that originally was
calling it Vans and passing an ID and
instead just update it to say get van
and we'll have to import it as well when
we have access to an ID and we're
reaching out to firestore we really only
want to get a single document before we
created this Vans collection reference
using a collection function that comes
from firestore this time we only need to
get a single document reference not a
whole collection reference so right
inside of our get van function I'm going
to access that document by using a new
function called doc just like how
collection was a way for us to get a
reference to a collection Doc is a way
for us to get reference to a single
document so I'll need to import that
we'll bring that in right after
collection and I will save this as we'll
just call it maybe doc ref it's going to
be Doc and the dock is going to take
three parameters where the collection
took two it took the database instance
and then the string of the collection
that we're trying to get from that
database we're still going to take the
database we also need the string name of
the collection that we're reaching into
but then even one level deeper we need
to pass the ID of the document that we
are trying to get and that's the ID
that's coming from our function right
here now that we have a document
reference we can get a document snapshot
maybe I'll call it van snapshot and
that's going to come in by calling a
function called get doc just like we had
get docs in order to get an array of
docs I can use get Doc in order to get a
single document then just like we did
before where I passed the collection
reference to get docs I'm going to pass
the document reference to get Doc and at
this point I think it actually would be
helpful for us to do just a little mini
challenge so I'll go ahead and type that
out
okay we have access to our van snapshot
and in this case unlike what we were
doing with get fans we aren't going to
be iterating over an array of documents
because we already have access to the
one document that we're trying to get so
I haven't necessarily taught how to do
this but I'm hoping that through some
inference looking at our function up
here or if you would really like to you
can go to the Firebase documentation to
solve this Challenge and figure out what
we need to return from the getvan
function and as a part of that you'll
have to go over to the van detail page
and switch it so that it uses this get
van function instead of the other get
vans that it's currently using okay so
pause now and work on this challenge
what we had to do before was iterate
over the array of documents and take
each one of them and return this object
here which has all of the data from the
document and then it separately gathered
the ID from it as well since for some
reason the ID property of the document
is not included in the data of the
document well in our case we don't need
to iterate over an array we can simply
return the object that has all of the
values from the van snapshot and rather
I should say all of the values of the
data portion of the van snapshot and
then we will also create an ID for it
which will be van snapshot dot ID this
should put it in so to speak the same
shape as what the original get Vance was
doing before at least we'll hope so so
let's go over to our let's see where is
it van detail we're going to pull in in
this case we don't need the get Vans
anymore we're just going to do get van
and then we'll need to make sure to
change it in our loader and actually I
think that might be it let's see we're
already on the vanity tail page Let's
cross our fingers and hit refresh
and hmm then snapshot.data is not a
function I bet someone else has already
seen what I did wrong here we need to
use await get doc okay let's try again
super close awesome there we go I should
be able to go back to all Vans and go
into a different one perfect
I guess while we're at it let's get rid
of this console log up here we'll clean
up the challenge and we can actually get
rid of our old function as well
okay now let's go back to our host pages
and we will change our functions so that
we're getting vans from Firebase instead
of from our fake server
let's switch over our get host demands
to pull from Firebase instead of from
our mirage.js server now you might
remember over in server.js our get fans
or our host fans is just hard coding the
host ID of one two three since we're not
dealing with authentication right now
I'm going to do essentially the same
thing but this time we'll be pulling it
from Firebase instead of from mirage.js
so in our api.js file what we are going
to write will be very very similar to
what we have in get vans so I'm going to
copy that function and bring it down
here and then I'll rename it get host
Vans and comment out the code we have in
the existing get host Vans and for now
we also are not going to overload this
the way we were before where it was
taking an ID so we'll just forego
putting an ID here in the parameter list
now one thing to know about grabbing
data from Firebase if you are trying to
get the entirety of a collection then
you can just pass the Vans collection
reference that we created up above right
here you can pass that to the get docs
function and it will just get all of the
documents from that collection however
if I only want to grab certain of the
documents from that collection then I
need to create something that's called a
query don't let that be confused with
the query snapshot that we had before in
fact we might be better off calling this
something like van collection snapshot
but just for legacy Reasons I'm going to
leave it as query snapshot and maybe for
now I'll just call it Q to mean my query
and we can call a new function that's
called query so we'll go up to the top
here I'm going to put these on their own
lines
and bring in query and query is going to
take let's see where are we down here
query this function is going to take
first The Collection reference that we
want to filter through and secondly some
kind of filtering operation and this
filtering operation is going to come
from yet another function that we pull
from Firebase called where so let's go
ahead and pull in where and you'll see
why it's called where in just a second
because when we're calling it we are
going to provide three different
parameters the first parameter will be
one of the properties of our documents
in our case we have a property called
host ID and so it's saying where the
host ID and then the second parameter is
going to be some kind of equality
operation in my case I want to say that
the host ID is equal to and in Firebase
we'll just use a double equals I don't
know that they have the same conventions
that JavaScript has with the triple
equals so in the docs they talk about
using a double equals so where the host
ID is equal to and then we provide some
kind of value in our case like I
mentioned we're going to hard code this
to the host ID of one two three so you
can see why it's called where it's kind
of like an English sentence where the
host ID is equal to one two three I know
that the Syntax for this is admittedly a
bit strange but that's just how it is in
Firebase and what we've been
constructing here is a query object that
we called q and that will allow us to
filter documents out of the van
collection so instead of getting the
entire van collection we're going to
pass our new Q variable or our query
that we just constructed to get docs at
that point everything else should
essentially be the same we're going to
receive an array of data we're going to
Loop over it change the shape of that
data so that it fits the way that we
need it to fit and I think we should
just be able to hit save and see
everything kind of just work the way it
was before in fact it's a little bit
difficult to tell that it's working at
all let's just make sure this is the
code that's running we'll just you know
Firebase at it in our console okay well
that's running so great we can go ahead
and get rid of this this old version of
the function and because we have the
same name it should just work however
the function that we just deleted that
we had commented out is what is
controlling the detail page so this is
what we're going to fix next
just for the sake of completion we're
just going to take a look at the
instance where the host wants to get a
single van now because we're not using
real authentication we're not actually
going to be able to make it so that only
the logged in user can access their Vans
remember we're currently hard coding
that the get host fans is coming from
one two three if I were to change this
for example to 456 and hit refresh our
host fans will show reliable red because
in the database reliable red has the
host ID of 456 and apparently no other
Vans do because we're also pulling from
get host fans on our dashboard by
changing it here in our api.js file it
also updates our dashboard at the bottom
when we have your list advance but the
problem is when we go to the detail page
of these vans so I think if I click view
we can see that the van information is
not coming in currently originally git
host Vans had the ability to take an ID
but with Firebase if we are trying to
get a single document that also is
ensuring that the currently logged in
user is the only one that's able to see
it then we would have to set up some
security rules inside of the Firebase
console in order to ensure that we were
only getting Vans at the currently
logged in user was allowed to see since
we're not dealing with authentication
and really not bothering with some
really stringent security rules what I'm
going to do is simply go to my host van
detail page and instead of pulling in
get host Vans I'm just going to pull in
get van as this will allow us to pass
the ID and I guess I'll need to change
it down here as well that way this page
will get fixed again of course the
problem is that anybody could go to this
page and see this information because
we're using a more public version of
this get van function that doesn't
really care what the currently logged in
user is for us right now this isn't a
big deal because we don't actually have
any edit functionality in our app at
this point anyway so it doesn't really
matter somebody could just come up here
and change the url to instead of host
fans 3 they could maybe say host fans
five and come to that page but again
there's no edit access so it's not that
big of a deal
and that does it folks we are here at
the end of the react router course
congratulations great job on all of the
challenges that you did all the quiz
questions that you answered and in the
end this amazing app that you had a
chance to build by following this
curriculum hopefully this gives you a
really great appreciation for react
router and just the concept of
client-side routing in general there's a
ton more that you could be learning but
I think this would be a perfect time to
head over to the scrimba Discord server
and post something in the today I did
Channel you can click the link to the
screenshot here that will take you over
to the Discord server and just let
people know that you completed the react
router 6 course and that you completed
all of the challenges along the way so
what comes next well as I mentioned
multiple times we don't have real
authentication in this app the main
reason is because that would have taken
us on quite a bit of a detour that I
wasn't quite ready to do as a part of
this curriculum but that would be a
great thing for you to spend some time
on just learning how to add real
authentication another thing you could
do is just to figure out a project that
you are intrinsically interested in and
build something completely unique now
that you have the knowledge that you
need to do client-side routing inside of
an app the world is completely open to
you another idea and this is a little
bit far-fetched but you could try to
build this van Life app again completely
from scratch entirely on your own it
might sound mundane when I say it like
that but the truth is that would be one
of the best things you could do to
solidify all of the information that we
just learned even if you ended up
building it in a fairly different way
than what we did together that's
completely okay it would be a great
learning experience nonetheless another
idea and this is a bit of Shameless
self-promotion but since you have made
it here to the very end of this course I
assume that you enjoy to some degree my
teaching style and I apply all of my
same pedagogy including tons of
practices quizzes and project building
over in my Advanced react course on
scrimba the advanced react course does
require a scrimba pro membership and it
is part of the front-end developer
career path which is tailored to helping
people go from knowing absolutely
nothing in web development all the way
to being prepared for interviewing for
their very first jobs and lastly you've
heard me make the parallels a lot
between react router and the remix
framework I can highly recommend the
remix framework it's a great way to dip
your toes into full stack web
development one of the greatest things I
think about the remix framework is that
their Mantra is to rely on the native
web platform and so for me personally as
I have been learning remix I have
learned so many new things just about
Native web that I feel like I probably
should have known at this point in my
career so feel free to check out the
remix framework if you'd like to dive
into a full stack framework I have been
your instructor Bob zarol I'm most
active these days on Twitter if you want
to tweet at me or DM me you're more than
welcome to you can click on the at Bob's
role link here or on the Twitter icon to
take you to my Twitter profile and with
all of that said congratulations on
finishing this course